imagine you're the owner of a small
software development firm and you want
to scale your business up
however a small team size the
unpredictability of demand and limited
resources are roadblocks for this
expansion
that's when you hear about cloud
computing but before investing money
into it you decide to draw up the
differences between on-premise and
cloud-based computing to make a better
decision
when it comes to scalability you pay
more for an on-premise setup and get
lesser options too
once you've scaled up it is difficult to
scale down
and often leads to heavy losses in terms
of infrastructure and maintenance costs
cloud computing on the other hand allows
you to pay only for how much you use
with much easier and faster provisions
for scaling up or down
next let's talk about server storage
on-premise systems need a lot of space
for their servers notwithstanding the
power and maintenance hassles that come
with them
on the other hand cloud computing
solutions are offered by cloud service
providers who manage and maintain the
servers saving you both money and space
then we have data security on-premise
systems offer less data security thanks
to a complicated combination of physical
and traditional i.t security measures
whereas cloud computing systems offer
much better security and lets you avoid
having to constantly monitor and manage
security protocols
in the event that a data loss does occur
the chance for data recovery with
on-premise setups are very small
in contrast cloud computing systems have
robust disaster recovery measures in
place to ensure faster and easier data
recovery
finally we have maintenance
on-premises systems also require
additional teams for hardware and
software maintenance loading up the
costs by a considerable degree
cloud computing systems on the other
hand are maintained by the cloud service
providers reducing your costs and
resource allocation substantially
so now thinking that cloud computing is
a better option you decide to take a
closer look at what exactly cloud
computing is
cloud computing refers to the delivery
of on-demand computing services over the
internet on a pay-as-you-go basis
in simpler words rather than managing
files and services on a local storage
device you'll be doing the same over the
internet in a cost efficient manner
cloud computing has two types of models
deployment model and service model
there are three types of deployment
models public private and hybrid cloud
imagine you're traveling to work you've
got three options to choose from
one you have buses which represent
public clouds in this case the cloud
infrastructure is available to the
public over the internet
these are owned by cloud service
providers
two then you have the option of using
your own car
this represents the private cloud with
the private cloud the cloud
infrastructure is exclusively operated
by a single organization this can be
managed by the organization or a third
party and finally you have the option to
hail a cab
this represents the hybrid cloud
a hybrid cloud is a combination of the
functionalities of both public and
private clouds
next let's have a look at the service
models
there are three major service models
available es pass and sas
compared to on-premise models where
you'll need to manage and maintain every
component including applications data
virtualization and middleware cloud
computing service models are hassle-free
is refers to infrastructure as a service
it is a cloud service model where users
get access to basic computing
infrastructure they are commonly used by
it administrators
if your organization requires resources
like storage or virtual machines is is
the model for you you only have to
manage the data runtime middleware
applications and the os while the rest
is handled by the cloud providers
next we have pass
pass or platform as a service provides
cloud platforms and runtime environments
for developing testing and managing
applications
this service model enables users to
deploy applications without the need to
acquire manage and maintain the related
architecture
if your organization is in need of a
platform for creating software
applications pass is the model for you
pass only requires you to handle the
applications and the data the rest of
the components like runtime middleware
operating systems servers storage and
others are handled by the cloud service
providers and finally we have sas
sas or software as a service involves
cloud services for hosting and managing
your software applications
software and hardware requirements are
satisfied by the vendors so you don't
have to manage any of those aspects of
the solution
if you'd rather not worry about the
hassles of owning any it equipment the
sas model would be the one to go with
with sas the cloud service provider
handles all components of the solution
required by the organization
time for a quiz now
in which of the following deployment
models are you as the business
responsible for the application data and
operating system
one is
two
pass
3. sass
4. i ass and pass
let us know your answer in the comment
section below
[Music]
hello everyone
today we're going to talk about aws in
10 minutes
let's look at the agenda here
let's talk about what aws is
why it's such a big hit
we'll have a look at the overview of the
services we'll see how much it costs
how big it is
and what the future of aws is
so
what is aws
everyone is talking about amazon web
services but let's have a look at what
it is
it's basically a global cloud platform
which allows you to host and manage
services on the internet
it's used by almost eighty percent of
fortune 500 companies to host their
infrastructure
and it has a lot of services which it
provides to its customers
there's infrastructure service which
means they provide bare servers as a
service so you don't need to manage the
backup and the power supply of the
service they provide platform of the
service
you can get java ruby php as a service
so that you don't have to manage the
binaries of these applications
you get software as a service wherein
you get email sending capabilities like
ses
you get queuing services like sqs and
it's a cloud storage platform wherein
you have a lot of storage options
including ebs and s3 so all in all aws
is a hosting provider which gives you a
lot of services wherein you can run your
applications on the cloud
now let's take a look at why it's such a
big hit
so everyone is trying to use aws
everyone is trying to put their
applications on the cloud
so what's the reason that aws is the top
provider and the top choice for doing
anything on the cloud
one of the biggest reasons is the
billing
so the billing is very clear you get a
per hour billing
every instance or every service has a
micro billing so be it instances on ec2
you get per hour billing rate which is
very transparent even s3 buckets are
charged on a per gb basis although it is
a storage service but still there is
micro billing available there
the sign up process is easy you don't
need to sign any agreement nothing you
just go
sign up with an email id add a credit
card and you're good to go
you can go from zero to one hundred in
just two minutes
you can launch your servers big machines
without buying hardware without
procuring any hardware you can just be
up and running in minutes
so their billing dashboard is also very
simple
they give you an integrated billing
dashboard which gives you reports
you can pull out reports every month
you can pull out reports based on
services based on various parameters
[Music]
for the cloud provider to be a hit you
need it to be stable it has to be a
trusted thing
so their services are quite stable
in the last seven or eight years they
have seen some three or four major
outages but those have been only region
specific
so that means out of the 12 or 13
regions in which they operate the
outages have been region specific in a
particular country or continent and
those also have not been more than two
or three hours and have not affected all
of their customers
it's a trusted vendor so when we talk
about aws it comes up as something which
is used by everyone in the industry
from small startups to big enterprises
everyone sees amazon as a trusted
advisor
now let's have an overview of the most
commonly used services
so the first and the most commonly used
service is ec2 which is elastic compute
cloud
this is the service which gives you bare
servers
so this service will give you a machine
which you can launch and you can run
your software on those
you can get small or big machines based
on your requirements
the second choice is vpc
so amazon will not allow you full
control of their cloud instead they give
you chunks of their cloud which is vpc
or the virtual private cloud
so vpc lets you create networks in the
cloud and then run your servers in those
networks
the next one is s3 which is simple
storage service
so s3 gives you the opportunity to
upload and share files so it is mostly a
file storage and sharing service
then you've got rds which is relational
database service
so this rds allows you to run and manage
databases on the cloud so they've got
almost all the major flavors of
databases right from sql server to
oracle and mysql postgresql
they've recently launched another one
which is called aurora which claims to
be a very high performance database then
route 53 is there for dns
so they've got a managed dns service
wherein you can point your dns to amazon
and they take care of the stuff
so it's a global dns service it's a
scalable dns service so it scales
according to demand
there's also elastic load balancer the
elb is a service which gives you the
opportunity to load balance incoming
traffic to multiple machines so this way
you can skill up your web applications
to any number of users
you've got auto scaling which adds
capacity on the fly to elastic load
balancers so that your website or your
application is never down due to a load
how much does it cost
this per our billing is already
mentioned for everything if it's
something like a storage thing again
there's a per hour or per gb month
storage
so i think there is region specific
pricing so virginia is the cheapest
region out of all of them
so the region specific pricing is
because they have got some regions which
they have got good hold of and they are
the headquarters so oregon and virginia
are the cheapest actually
they also give you services based on the
term so if you sign up for something for
a year it would be cheaper for you
rather than signing up for something on
an on-demand basis so they've got
reserved instances which are very cheap
as compared to the on-demand ones you
can get discounts from 20 percent to
almost 60 percent if you sign up for a
three-year term
they are spot resources examples of
these are spot instances
so this is like a bidding market base
where you can bid for a price
the only downside of this kind of
pricing is that your machine might be
terminated or your resources might be
terminated if someone bids higher
people use these kind of things for
doing some ad hoc in search or some ad
hoc tasks which are really not critical
how big is it
they have got 15 regions across major
countries of the world
they've got regions in the us europe
asia pacific
they've got a global footprint so in
today's world if you are anywhere in the
world you would have a region within 1
000 miles of your location they've got
massive data centers so each of the
region has got multiple availability
zones so one availability zone can be
thought of as a big data center the data
centers have anywhere from three hundred
thousand to five hundred thousand
servers
what is the future of aws
so they currently have 64 services which
span across infrastructural service
software as a service platform as a
service
they're launching new services in all
demands every day
right now they're focusing on machine
learning
so recently they've launched a couple of
services which focus exclusively on
machine learning and they're focusing on
software as a service product wherein
they want to take control of the service
you want to utilize
they don't want you to do it they want
you to upload it to them
and every now and then they keep on
reducing the costs so you would hear it
in the blog that okay the price of ec2
machines has been reduced
and this is because of their scale so
they scale up and they give the cost
benefit to the customer
today we will be discussing all about
aws and its impact in 2021 so let's get
started
according to o'reilly more than 90 of
organizations are expected to increase
their cloud infrastructure in 2021 the
upshot is that the majority of cloud
users plan to scale their business and
cloud rather than reducing their cloud
usage share the code 19 pandemic led
organizations to increasingly shift to
the cloud which helped them improve
business continuity official meetings
like video conferencing were done on the
cloud using apps as google meet zoom etc
now let me give you a brief description
on what cloud computing is
cloud computing helps users to store
access and manage data by logging in
from their devices via the internet
instead of storing data on their hard
drives cloud computing gives the ability
to manage applications and services
through the internet
let's see what gartner says about cloud
infrastructure and platform services
for your information gartner is the
famous it service management company
across the world
gartner's magic quadrant report for
cloud infrastructure and platform
services noted that the capability gap
between hyperscale cloud providers has
begun to narrow however fierce
competition for enterprise workloads
extends to secondary markets worldwide
the famous cloud providers in the market
are aws microsoft azure and google cloud
all of which have been strong
aws or amazon web services has been
known for its rapid pace of innovation
in cloud computing and this year is no
different
aws is the leader in public cloud
providers and has a more significant
impact on modern technologies like
machine learning robotics and iot amazon
web services is an online service
provider that offers various services
such as compute power storage database
content delivery and other resources to
help businesses scale and grow
these services are provided based on a
subscription basis
talking about the general features
amazon web services was found in the
year 2006 and apparently it holds a
market share of 31.7 percent
aws provides approximately 175 fully
featured services
it consists of significant benefits like
compute storage databases networking
analytics robotics machine learning
artificial intelligence etc
now let us know the five primary reasons
why aws is essential and how it can
influence your business amazon web
services has various benefits that make
users rely on them
firstly it allows you to set up a
virtual office which will reduce the
cost of maintaining and monitoring your
infrastructure secondly compared to the
on-premises environment aws provides a
high level of data protection and a
lower cost to its users
thirdly based on the requirement you
receive you can scale up or scale down
your resources
fourthly in case you face a power
failure or any crisis having your file
stored in the cloud ensures it is backed
up and secured in a safe location
and lastly in short aws offers high
scalable services for database data
warehousing transcoding storage backup
infrastructure management application
management etc which helps in reducing
the overall time and effort spent in
setting up and managing the
infrastructure
now let's take a step back and look at
the history of aws
amazon web services was the first online
service provider to introduce a psu go
pricing model in cloud computing
aws was launched in 2006 with three
services amazon ec2 aws s3 cloud storage
and sqs
now let us discuss how much the
companies have saved with the help of
aws
this shows a tremendous benefit of using
aws
aws continues to lower the cost of the
cloud for its customers
compared to on-premise infrastructure
when a web application is deployed on
aws companies save 76 of the total
expense
companies save over 50 by running
business applications by consuming aws
resources
aws is the world's most broadly adopted
cloud platform many companies like espn
adobe twitter netflix facebook bbc etc
use aws
adobe quickly creates and updates
software without depending upon the it
teams it utilizes its services by
offering multi-terabyte operating
environments for its clients
by deploying its services with amazon
adobe integrated and operated its
software in a simple manner
a lot of people don't know the reason
for aws being so popular to understand
the popularity of aws you need to look
at these numbers first
first is cost
aws costs keep declining aws has
decreased its service price as many as
60 times since its launch
aws saves 76 of the expenditure of
running a standard web application and
reduces the processing cost by 50
percent
one-third of people who visit websites
on daily basis access sites powered by
aws
aws has customers over 190 countries
worldwide including 5000 edtech
institutions and 2000 government
organizations
31 of cloud infrastructure as a market
share service belongs to aws while 10
belongs to microsoft and 7 to ibm
aws has more than 1 million users in 190
countries
now let's discuss the revenue growth of
aws
according to gartner amazon retained the
number one position in the ias market in
2019 followed by microsoft and google
amazon continued to stay on top of the
ias market worldwide with an estimated
20 billion dollars of revenue in 2019
and 96.1 billion in 2020.
as a february report canalis confirms
aws has a total market share of 31
percent whereas microsoft holds a share
up to 20 percent
microsoft maintained number two position
in the ias platform with more than half
of its nearly eight billion dollars in
revenue
according to the canalis diagram shown
on your screen amazon leveraged its
number one position in the cloud market
continuously from 2019 to 2020 by
offering complete and unique services in
the cloud stack
in q2 2020 a prediction of profit in aws
was expected to reach 88.9 billion
dollars but surprisingly due to covet 19
the company saw quarterly sales
increased to 88.9 billion dollars
the net income of 5.2 billion dollars
was the highest in a single quarter
while microsoft azure has seen revenue
growth of 47 over the previous quarter
the report has a revenue growth number
of various cloud providers
aws is continuously adding new features
to utilize the updated services to
improve the productivity of work more
quickly
let's discuss each service one by one
at number one amazon cloudfront supports
origin shield amazon has updated its
cloudfront service with the shield
feature that increases cache capacity
and decreases the load on your origin
next aws im supports aws private link
which means it can invoke lambda
functions into a virtual private cloud
by eliminating network traffic to the
public internet
thirdly amazon sns supports fifo in
sequence
amazon sns introduces first in first out
topics intended for customers to process
messages across multiple services in a
sequenced manner
amazon sns fifo is available in 22 aws
regions
next aws dms functionality supports
amazon document db
amazon documentdb has the responsibility
of storing querying and indexing data
with aws database migration service
support
dms helps in migrating databases to aws
environments quickly
next amazon chime sdk now supports
health monitoring and troubleshooting
developers can now collect client
metrics from meeting events available
from the amazon chime sdk for javascript
finally aws server migration service now
adds support for application monitoring
using amazon cloudwatch application
insights
you can start monitoring applications in
amazon cloudwatch as soon as the
application migration is complete in aws
sms
there are plenty of cloud jobs that can
help you grow in your career
tech republic says in the past few
months job seekers are hunting for cloud
computing roles on indeed website
cloud computing job roles such as cloud
infrastructure cloud security cloud
architect and cloud engineer had risen
nearly by 108
employer interest for candidates with
cloud computing skills rose by 33
percent
now let's look at who an aws solutions
architect is and what they do
an aws solutions architect is
responsible for deploying your
applications on the aws platform
ever since cloud computing has come into
the limelight companies and
organizations worldwide have started to
migrate their physical infrastructure to
the cloud this is where aws solutions
architects come in
they help in relocating the physical
infrastructure to the aws cloud
aws solutions architect is responsible
for creating a design with the detailed
blueprint of the cloud infrastructure
they plan to set up
they are required to focus on
non-functional requirements such as
usability reliability scalability and
cloud infrastructure performance
aws solutions architects are responsible
for minimizing business risks such as
security leaks calculation mistakes and
even application downtime risks
every aws solutions architect must
ensure that none of these problems
happen
a lot of people must be wondering how
much a solution architect and a cloud
engineer earns
the average salary of a solution
architect in india is rupees 18 lakhs 36
996 per year and in the united states
they earn 128 000 dollars per annum
whereas a cloud engineer in india earns
12 lakh 41 000 rupees per annum and in
the united states they earn 139 000 for
440 dollars per annum
now that you know about aws and its
important concepts time for a small quiz
which of the following is an online
backup and storage system
option a amazon simple storage system
aws s3 option b aws cloud formation
option c amazon elastic compute cloud
aws ec2 and option d both a and c
let us know what you think is a right
answer in the comments below in cloud
computing the competition for leadership
is a quite tough three-way race
amazon web services
microsoft azure and google cloud
platform clearly are the top cloud
companies hold a commanding lead in the
infrastructure as a service and platform
as service markets
in this video we will compare and
contrast aws azure and gcp based on a
few related concepts around these cloud
computing platforms
it will help us understand the
functioning of these top cloud platforms
and will also let us figure out the
individuality of each one of them
but before starting with the comparison
let's have a quick introduction of aws
versus assured versus gcp
so let's get started
amazon web services or aws is a cloud
computing platform
that manages and maintains hardware and
infrastructure reducing the expense and
complexity of purchasing and running
resources on site for businesses and
individuals
these resources are available for free
or for a fee per usage
microsoft azure is a cloud computing
service that offers a collection of
cloud computing services for building
testing deploying and managing
application in the cloud including
remotely hosted and managed versions of
microsoft technology
google cloud platform offers a variety
of cloud computing services for building
deploying scaling monitoring and
operating a cloud
the services are identical to those that
power google products such as google
search gmail youtube
and google drive
now let's move on to the comparison
between aws assure and gcp
we will be comparing them based on few
major parameters like
origin
service integration
availability zone
cloud tools like compute
storage
networking
market share
pricing
and at last who uses them
now
let's move ahead and start with the
first comparison origin
in the year 2006 amazon web services aws
was introduced to the market
and in the year 2010 azure launched its
services
whereas on the other hand gcp was
established in the year 2008.
from the start aws has been supportive
of the open source concept but the open
source community has a tense
relationship with azure
on the other hand gcp similar to aws
provides google cloud with managed open
source services that are tightly linked
aws offers services on a large and
complex scale that can be manipulated
but azure support is comparatively low
quality
whereas gcp's monthly support price is
almost 150 dollars for the silver class
which is the most basic of services and
is quite expensive
now let's move on to the service
integration of these cloud platforms
service integration is a set of tools
and technology that connects different
applications
systems
repositories and data and process
interchange in real time
aws makes it simple for users to combine
services such as amazon ec2 amazon s3
beanstalk and others
on the other hand azure allows customers
to effortlessly combine azure vms
as your app service sql databases and
other services
whereas users can utilize gcp to combine
services such as compute engine cloud
storage and cloud sql
now that we know briefly about all these
cloud platforms let's have a look at the
availability zones of these platforms
because aws was the first in the cloud
domain they have had more time to build
and extend their network
but
azure and gcp both have various
locations around the world
but the distinction is in the amount of
availability zones they have
aws now offers 66 availability zones
with an additional 12 on the pipeline
close to it azure is available in 140
countries and is available in 54 regions
throughout the world
but google cloud platform is now
available in 20 global areas with three
more on the way
now let's move on to the next important
factor which is tools
now let's move ahead and have have a
look at the first feature
which is compute
elastic compute cloud or ec2 is aws
compute service which offers a wide
range of features including a large
number of instances
support for both windows and linux high
performance computing and more
as sure on the other hand
virtual machines is microsoft azure's
core cloud-based compute solution
it includes linux windows server and
other operating systems as well as
better security and microsoft program
integration
in comparison to its competitors
google's computing services catalog is
somewhat smaller
compute engine that companies principal
service offers custom and pre-defined
machine types per second invoicing linux
and windows support and carbon neutral
infrastructure that uses half the energy
of traditional data centers
within the compute category amazon's
different containers services are
gaining prominence it has docker
kubernetes and it's also far gate
service
which automates server and cluster
management when using containers as well
as other alternatives
azure unlike aws uses virtual machine
scale sets of two container services
azure container service is based on
kubernetes and container service
uses docker hub and azure container
registry for management
for enterprises interested in deploying
containers google offers the kubernetes
engine
it's also worth noting that google was
significantly involved in the kubernetes
project
providing it extensive knowledge in this
field
now let's move on to the next parameter
of comparison which is storage
simple storage service
for object storage elastic block storage
for persistent block storage and elastic
file system for file storage among aws
storage offerings
block storage for rest based object
storage of unstructured data queue
storage for a large volume workloads
file storage and disk storage are among
microsoft azure core storage services
gcp offers an increasing number of
storage options its unified object
storage service cloud storage also has a
persistent disk option
relational database service or rds
dynamodb nosql database
elastic cache in memory data store
redshift data warehouse neptune graph
database and database migration service
are all sql compatible databases
offered by amazon
the database choices in azure are
specially wide sql database mysql
database and postgre sql database are
the three sql based choices
when it comes to databases gcp offers
the sql based cloud sql and cloud
spanner a relational database built for
mission critical workloads
now the next parameter is networking
aws uses amazon virtual private cloud or
vpc
on the other hand azure uses
azure virtual network we net
and gcp uses cloud virtual network
now let's move on to the another factor
which is market share and pricing
all these cloud services are based on
comparative pricing strategy which means
you need to pay on the basis of its
usage
according to canalis the worldwide cloud
market rose 35
to 41.8 billion in the first quarter of
2021.
aws accounts for 32 of the market
with azure accounting for 19
and google accounting for 7
on one hand amazon charges on a yearly
basis and on the other hand microsoft
azure and google services charge on a
minute basis and also of them provide
you a standard price for you to access
these services
aws charges roughly 69 per month for a
very basic instance with two virtual
cpus and 8gb of ram
and aws largest instance with 3.84 tb of
ram and 128 vcpus
will set you back roughly 3.97
per hour
but in azure the same type of instance
one with two vcpus and 8gb of ram cost
roughly 70
us per month
and asia's largest instance has 3.89 tb
of ram
and 128 virtual cpus
it costs about 6.79 per hour
compared to aws gcp will supply you with
the most basic instance which includes
two virtual cpus and eight gigabytes of
ram for 25 percent less as a result it
will set you back roughly to 52 dollar
every month and the largest instance
that include
is 3.75 db of ram and 160v cpus it will
cost you around 5.32 dollar per hour
amazon other than this also provides
spot instances reserved instances and
dedicated host where you can look for
multiple offers and discounts
but for ensure it provides special
prices to developers based on situations
or even ensure hybrid benefit which
benefits your organization up to forty
percent if it uses microsoft software in
their data centers
whereas google offers quite a sorted
pricing to its customer compared to
other two
it gives you sustained use discounts
which activate if you use the same
instance for a month
the printable instance which is very
similar to amazon spot instances
but one thing is common in all three
cloud services which is they all offer
long-term discount
now let's have a look at the last
comparison which is companies using them
because aws is the oldest player in the
cloud business
it has a largest user base and community
support as a result aws has a largest
number of high-profile and well-known
clients including netflix airbnb
unilever bmw samsung mi senga and others
with time azure is getting a large
number of high-profile customers
azure currently boasts around 80 percent
of fortune
500 firms as customers johnson controls
polycom fujifilm hp honeywell apple and
others are among its key clients
google cloud on the other hand uses the
same infrastructure as google search and
youtube and as a result many high in
enterprises
trust google cloud hsbc paper
20th century fox bloomberg domino's and
other among google clouds many clients
so
this was all about aws versus assure
versus gcp
hi there welcome to this brand new
learning video called cloud computing
tutorial i'm samuel a multi-platform
cloud architect and trainer working for
simply learn let's dive deep into the
topics we're going to discuss here why
we needed cloud computing to begin with
and what is cloud computing and
different types of cloud computings
available at the moment and we also are
going to talk about a dominant cloud
providers available in the market at the
moment and we will touch a few topics or
scenarios on life cycle of a cloud
computing solution and we will be
talking about how cloud computing is
implemented in aws and there is nothing
like visually seeing how things work in
the cloud right so we're going to end it
with a demo and we're going to talk
about products or we're actually going
to use products like ec2 and s3 ec2
being a virtual computer in the cloud
and s3 being an object storage in the
cloud let's understand about why cloud
computing was needed what was the
problem that we had that cloud computing
solved and since then it took over the
market let's add a lot of unanswered
questions about cloud computing or
services that you might have here on the
left we have an owner of a business and
he wants to set up an dc or have an i.t
infrastructure for his company so he
called paul an i.t educated person in
his company and consulted him about how
to go about setting up an id
infrastructure now paul is the kind of
guy who keeps himself updated about
what's happening in the iit industry and
he frequently goes through learnings
about the reason technology so with
benefiting i'm going to explain to you
now let's start with the expenditure or
the billing model expect that we pay
everything upfront and there is an
additional operating cost and it never
lets us to dynamically scale in on
premises a lot of space is required for
seating the servers but in the cloud not
such space requirement is needed for the
organization in on premises we also need
a dedicated team to manage the hardware
and software but in the cloud no such
dedicated team is needed for most of the
services they all get managed by the
provider and even if we need to manage
them the provider gives us options to
manage them through the console which is
lot lot simpler than managing directly
from the device in the on-premises we
need to admit the fact that data
security is poor due to the cost
involved in procuring the hardware and
software to provide the security but in
the cloud the security standards are
high due to the investments the
providers have done to secure the data
and to meet the compliance in
traditional dc there will generally be
less focus on data recovery and we kind
of settle for less when it comes to data
recovery due to the cost involved and
you know the effort involved in
replicating the data and even if we set
up a high performing data replication a
lot more can be done in the cloud for
the same cost the on-premises
environment lacks the flexibility needed
today like if i need to restructure the
it for the new age business needs then
the on-premises is not so friendly for
such changes but in the cloud i can
easily undo or tear down an environment
or migrate to the new environment and
tear down the old environment in few
button clicks now looking at the number
and the frequency of the releases that
happen scheduling updates would be an
full time job but with cloud the updates
happen automatically in on premises if
i'm working with the team that is spread
across the globe working with them in
unison and sharing the data is a tedious
work but with the cloud there are a lot
of tools and technologies put together
that makes it easy to share the data
with other members in the team or with
the new prospective customer in on
premises if i'm working with the team
that is spread across the globe working
with them in unison and sharing the data
is a tedious work but with a cloud there
are a lot of tools and technologies put
together that makes it easy to share the
data with other members in the team or
with a new prospect customer i will be
working with who is present across the
other side of the globe in on premises
the data will be present inside the dc
or inside the on-premises dc and even a
valid user trying to access the data
from outside the organization is a tough
task but with a cloud as long as someone
has internet providing the person access
is just a few mouse clicks away talk
about implementation building an
on-premises dc takes time i was working
on a project few years back and the goal
to make a dc go live at that time was
after two years from the date we were
speaking about it but with the cloud we
can bring our dc in the cloud within
weeks after all this explanation and
comparisons and talking about benefits
paul's manager was fully enlightened and
wants to have his iet environment in the
cloud but our paul is not done yet and
he took his manager through another
level of discussion about the cloud just
like i'm gonna take you now so let's
talk about what is cloud computing now
cloud computing is the ability to
deliver on-demand computing service over
the internet and that too on a
pay-as-you-go basis now you might think
well what does that mean let me explain
now with cloud rather than managing
files on local storage devices cloud
computing makes it possible to save them
over the internet and access them from
the internet so i can be a mobile person
and i'm moving from place to place but i
can access the storage from the internet
because it's in the internet and if i
want to give access to somebody else
again it's easy for me to give access to
them as long as they have internet
connection available with them now let's
move further and talk about or get
understanding on the types of cloud
computing we can categorize the
different types of cloud computing based
on two white categories one being a
deployment model and the other one being
service model let's talk about the
deployment model first deployment model
is categorized into three types first
one is public and then private and then
hybrid cloud in other words public cloud
private cloud and hybrid cloud it'll be
easy for me to explain and also it'll be
easy for you to understand if i walk you
through this example consider the
different types of vehicles we use to
commute from one place to another for
example if i want to travel i can pick a
bus which is accessible to anyone i get
in and i pay for the seat that i occupy
and i pay for the time that i will be
traveling in it i'm done cost is very
less here a similar kind of thing
happens in the public cloud i pay only
for the resource that i use and i pay
for how long i use it if i use less i
pay less if i use more i pay more for
that month simple on the other hand
private cloud is like buying your own
car and using it for commuting purpose
here i pay a huge amount upfront and it
is all owned only by me i do not pay for
it in an hourly fashion but completely
and all up front the cost here is very
huge and thirdly if i want the best of
both types like the comfort of the own
car and still don't want to pay all
upfront otherwise one only to pay for
the time that i use the service i can
rent a car similarly i can have it in a
hybrid environment meaning if i already
have a dc i can integrate it with the
cloud and use both the dc's and that
would become an hybrid environment all
right so that was good often uh learning
let's summarize the types of cloud based
on deployment models and as we know now
about the public cloud public cloud is
an cloud infrastructure that's made
available to the general public over the
internet and it is owned by the cloud
provider some of the major players as
cloud providers are aws microsoft azure
ibm's blue cloud and suncloud and
private cloud now this cloud
infrastructure is exclusively operated
by a single organization it can be
managed by organizations or third party
and may exist on premises or
off-premises doesn't matter but the
point here is this is exclusively
operated for a single organization and
some companies that provide private
cloud are aws and vmware and hybrid
cloud gives the best of both public and
the private cloud for example the
federal agencies they opt for private
clouds for storing and developing
personal data and they use public cloud
to share the non-sensitive data with the
general public or with other government
departments now let's talk about
different clouds based on the service
model if we need to categorize them
broadly we can categorize them as
infrastructure as a service ias or
platform as a service pas or software as
a service sas they sometimes are
referred to as i as pass and says now at
this moment you could be like this guy
thinking sam i thought you're done
categorizing the cloud now we are going
to talk about three more categories
which one should i pick well let me
explain if all that you want is just in
vm and you have all the expertise to
install the software on top of it and
make it work then go for is if you only
want a platform or an interface to
program or an interface to upload a
program and make it run then pick pass
or if all that you want is a finished
product hosted in the cloud and be able
to access it through the internet then
go for sas here you get a username and
password for an application and you can
begin to customize the application based
on your needs all right let's talk about
is in a bit more detail is it gives
basic computing infra it's based on pay
for what you use model and some of the
cloud providers who are big players are
aws azure and google and here the users
generally will be id admins in pass the
provider gives you a platform or a
runtime environment for developing
testing and managing application it's
platform ready you buy the platform you
upload your code and you start working
on it and it allows the software
developers to deploy applications
without running the underlying
infrastructure and as you might have
guessed by now the interesting
candidates who would use paz is software
developers and in sas everything is
managed by the vendor be it the hardware
or the software it's managed by the
vendor and we pay for the service and we
pay for it through a pay as you go
subscription model and as you might have
guessed the end users here would be end
customer itself all right let's put
together everything in the same page and
compare and contrast the different types
of service models in this chart it
explains the difference between the four
models starting from on-premises to is
and then pass and says it is
self-explanatory that the resources
managed by us are huge in on premises
and little less in is and further less
or reduced in paths and nothing to
manage when it comes to sas let me also
explain the different types of cloud
services through an example like this
let's say that you have a crush on cake
and you're planning to bake one yourself
now let's look at the options you can
have you can make all the ingredients
yourself be the floor butter and you
know put together and bake the whole
thing yourself using your own oven pan
you know the needed water and the rest
you get idea right everything is yours
and that's on premises all that you use
is owned by you and nothing is managed
by the vendor the other options you can
have is buy the ingredients and
mix and bake the cake yourself now this
would be like is here the infra is
managed by the provider and we get to
use it and customize it the way we want
it here the cloud service is then shared
responsibility the other options you
still have on hand is simply pick a
phone and order a cake now this is a lot
simpler than the rest we discussed so
far you know it's simply picking the
phone and ordering the cake and pay for
it when it arrives simple and when it
reaches home you will have to arrange
the table garnish the cake if that's
needed and then enjoy the cake it's the
same way with pass just get the platform
in which you would run your code and
upload your code and start running your
application here you and the vendor
still share the responsibility you still
have one more option left that is simply
go out and dine this is a lot lot
simpler that it requires no effort from
us at all you buy the fully finished and
garnished cake and pay for it and walk
out no responsibility on making the cake
it's the same way with sas we buy the
finished product and pay for the
finished application as next thing let's
talk about the different cloud providers
amazon web services aws is a cloud
computing service provided by amazon it
provides a mix of infrastructure as a
service is platform as a service pass
and package software as a service called
sas offerings microsoft azure formerly
known as windows assure is a cloud
computing service by microsoft and it
sort of specializes in using cloud for
building testing deploying and managing
the applications through the servers
throughout the global network that
microsoft manages it also provides
software as a service platform as a
service infrastructure as a service and
it supports lots of different
programming languages and tools and
frameworks including both microsoft and
third-party software and systems ibm
cloud is a cloud computing service
offered by ibm ibm cloud includes
infrastructure as a service software as
a service platform as a service now the
difference is here it offers through
public private and hybrid cloud delivery
models vmware on the other hand is an
subsidiary of dell technologies and
provides cloud computing and platform
virtualization software and services it
was the first commercially successful
company to virtualize the x86
architecture google cloud platform on
the other hand is offered by google it's
a suit of cloud computing services that
run on the same infrastructure that
google uses internally for its end user
products such as the google search and
the youtube you're familiar with
alongside a set of managed tools it also
provides cloud services including
computing services data storage services
data analytics and machine learning
services digitalocean on the other hand
is headquartered in new york city with
data centers worldwide digitalocean
provides developers cloud services that
help to deploy and scale applications
that run simultaneously on multiple
computers as of january 2018
digitalocean was the third largest
hosting company in the world in terms of
web phasing computers let's talk about
cloud computing in aws amazon web
services aws is an cloud computing
service provided by amazon and these
services are accessible over the
internet and because aws provides
infrastructure as a service it's a
flagship offering we can create and
deploy any type of application in the
cloud on top of the is that amazon
provides and you know the best part here
is the subscriptions are pay as you go
type you use less and pay less and only
for what you have used you use more pay
more but still less per unit for the
service used attractive isn't it now
let's talk about the life cycle of the
cloud computing solution the very first
thing in the life cycle of a solution or
a cloud solution is to get a proper
understanding of the requirement i
didn't say get the requirement but said
get a proper understanding of the
requirement it is very vital because
only then we will be able to properly
pick the right service offered by the
provider getting a sound understanding
the next thing would be to define the
hardware meaning choose the compute
servers that will provide the right
support where you can resize the compute
capacity in the cloud to run application
programs getting a sound understanding
of the requirement helps in picking the
right hardware one size does not fit all
there are different services and
hardwares for different needs you might
have like ec2 if you're looking for is
and lambda if you're looking for
serverless computing and ecs that
provides containerized service so there
are a lot of hardwares available pick
the right hardware that suits your
requirement the third thing is to define
the storage choose the appropriate
storage service where you can backup
your data and a separate storage service
where you can archive your data locally
within the cloud or from the internet
and choose the appropriate storage that
is one separately for backup called s3
and there is one separately for archival
that's for glaciers so you know you
knowing the difference between them
really helps in picking the right
service for the right kind of need
define the network define the network
that securely delivers data video and
applications define and identify the
network services properly for example
vpc for network route 53 for dns and
direct connection for private p2p line
from your office to the aws data center
set up the right security services im
for authentication and authorization and
kms for data encryption at rest so there
are variety of security products
available we got to pick the right one
that suits our need and there are a
variety of deployment and automation and
monitoring tools that you can pick from
for example cloud watch is for
monitoring auto scaling is for being
elastic and cloud formation is define
the management process and tools you can
have complete control of your cloud
environment if you define the management
tools which monitors your aws resources
and or the custom applications running
on aws platform there are variety of
deployment automation and monitoring
tools you can pick from like cloud watch
for monitoring auto scaling for
automation and the cloud formation for a
deployment so knowing them will help you
in defining the life cycle of the cloud
computing solution properly and
similarly there are a lot of tools for
testing a process like code star and
code build and code pipeline these are
tools with which you can build test and
deploy your code quickly and finally
once everything is set and done click
the analytic service for analyzing and
visualizing the data using the analytics
services where we can start querying the
data instantly and get a result now if
you want to visually view the happenings
in your environment you can pick athena
and other tools for analytics are emr
and which is elastic mapreduce and cloud
search all right enough of theory and
let's have a quick look at how two
services in aws ec2 and s3 work together
and benefits us here are two id
professionals talking to each other one
says i have an application which takes a
lot of storage and works only on linux
system which i do not have at the moment
and the other one is a smart guy and he
immediately replies that he could use s3
to store data and the tribe data and use
ec2 for all his compute needs and then
the curious conversation builds up and
the first person wants to know what is
easy to ns3 and the second guy starts to
explain that aws ec2 is a web service
that provides a secure and resizable
compute capacity in the cloud and ec2 it
can also be used to launch as many
virtual servers as we need and about s3
he explains aws s3 is a simple storage
service provided by aws and about s3 he
explains further saying that using
amazon s3 we can store android drive any
amount of data at any time on the web
alright so the very first thing is to
have an aws account so create an aws
account and second thing is to create an
aws s3 bucket and upload the files there
you know the files that ec2 server is
going to pull from will get stored in s3
as first thing all right so the first
thing is to create an s3 bucket so let's
create an s3 bucket and let's call it as
a website bucket and these names will
have to be unique so let's see if this
bucket name is available it says bucket
name already taken or already exist so
let me top it up with sl meaning simply
learn all right so we were able to
create a bucket and in that bucket let
me upload a content that basically is
going to be my index file that's going
to go and sit in my web server so let me
also make it public and view it all
right so this is the content that i have
stored in my s3 and this is the content
i'm going to push to my ec2 server right
second step create an aws s3 bucket and
upload files we're done with that third
is to create an ec2 instance
that's in other words create an virtual
machine in the cloud let's go and create
it all right the third thing is to
create an ec2 instance so let's create
an ec2 instance it's plain and it's very
simple i'm going to keep everything as
defaults here all right so i've launched
an ec2 instance as you see it's running
i also have an ip address public ip
address here with that i have logged
into this ec2 instance and i'm in the
folder slash war slash
www.html and as you see there is nothing
in there at the moment and this server
also has apache installed in it as you
can see you know i browse to the ip
address of the ec2 instance and it's
showing a page which is the default
apache page all right if i had any files
in this folder that would get shown as
the web page inside of the default page
our task is to save files in s3 and move
them to the ec2 instance so s3 is going
to act as a storage or a repository or a
source code control in this example all
right so let's do that all right the
third step is to create your ec2
instance and that's what we have done
and the ec2 instance has no files in it
and the fourth step is to synchronize
the source code bucket with the ec2
instance let's do that the actual
command to do that would be aws s3 sync
and then the name of the bucket from
which we're going to pull the code and
the folder in which we're going to put
the code or the data all right so it has
downloaded something look at that and
now if we go back to the test page and
to refresh there you go it's showing the
page that it pulled from s3 so here i
can use s3 as the source code control
bucket and any information that i put in
there will get reflected in ec2 instance
once i do a sync every day and that's
how i use s3 as my storage for ec2 all
right finally we were able to
synchronize s3 bucket and the ec2
instance let me start the session with
this scenario let's imagine how life
would have been without spotify for
those who are hearing about spotify for
the first time spotify is an online
music service offering and it offers
instant access to over 16 million
licensed songs spotify now uses aws
cloud to store the data and share it
with their customers but prior to aws
they had some issues imagine using
spotify before aws let's talk about that
back then users were often getting
errors because spotify could not keep up
with the increased demand for storage
every new day and that led to users
getting upset and users cancelling the
subscription the problem spotify was
facing at that time was their users were
present globally and were accessing it
from everywhere and they had different
latency in their applications and
spotify had a demanding situation where
they need to frequently catalog the
songs released yesterday today and in
the future and this was changing every
new day and the songs coming in rate was
about 20 000 a day and back then they
could not keep up with this requirement
and needless to say they were badly
looking for a way to solve this problem
and that's when they got introduced to
aws and it was a perfect fit and match
for their problem aws offered at
dynamically increasing storage and
that's what they needed aws also offered
tools and techniques like storage
lifecycle management and trusted advisor
to properly utilize the resource so we
always get the best out of the resource
used aws addressed their concerns about
easily being able to scale yes you can
scale the aws environment very easily
how easily one might ask it's just a few
button clicks and aws solved spotify's
problem let's talk about how it can help
you with your organization's problem
let's talk about what is aws first and
then let's bleed into how aws became so
successful and the different types of
services that aws provides and what's
the future of cloud and aws in specific
let's talk about that and finally we'll
talk about a use case where you will see
how easy it is to create a web
application with aws all right let's
talk about what is aws aws or amazon web
services is a secure cloud service
platform it is also pay as you go type
billing model where there is no upfront
or capital cost we'll talk about how
soon the service will be available well
the service will be available in a
matter of seconds with aws you can also
do identity and access management that
is authenticating and authorizing a user
or a program on the fly and almost all
the services are available on demand and
most of them are available
instantaneously and as we speak amazon
offers 100 plus services and this list
is growing every new week now that would
make you wonder how aws became so
successful of course it's their
customers let's talk about the list of
well-known companies that has their id
environment in aws adobe adobe uses aws
to provide multi-terabyte operating
environments for its customers by
integrating its system with aws cloud
adobe can focus on deploying and
operating its own software instead of
trying to you know deploy and manage the
infrastructure airbnb is another company
it's an community marketplace that
allows property owners and travelers to
connect each other for the purpose of
renting unique vacation spaces around
the world and the airbnb community users
activities are conducted on the website
and through iphones and android
applications airbnb has a huge
infrastructure in aws and they're almost
using all the services in aws and are
getting benefited from it another
example would be autodesk autodesk
develops software for engineering
designing and entertainment industries
using services like amazon rds or
rational database servers and amazon s3
or amazon simple storage service
autodesk can focus on deploying or
developing its machine learning tools
instead of spending that time on
managing the infrastructure aol or
american online uses aws and using aws
they have been able to close data
centers and decommission about 14 000
in-house and co-located servers and move
mission critical workload to the cloud
and extend its global reach and save
millions of dollars on energy resources
bitdefender is an internet security
software firm and their portfolio of
software's include antivirus and
anti-spyware products bitdefender uses
ec2 and they're currently running few
hundred instances that handle about five
terabytes of data and they also use
elastic load balancer to load balance
the connection coming in to those
instances across availability zones and
they provide seamless global delivery of
servers because of that the bmw group it
uses aws for its new connected car
application that collects sensor data
from bmw 7 series cars to give drivers
dynamically updated map information
canon's office imaging products division
benefits from faster deployment times
lower cost and global reach by using aws
to deliver cloud-based services such as
mobile print the office imaging products
division uses aws such as amazon s3 and
amazon route 53 amazon cloudfront and
amazon im for their testing development
and production services comcast it's the
world's largest cable company and the
leading provider of internet service in
the united states comcast uses aws in a
hybrid environment out of all the other
cloud providers comcast chose aws for
its flexibility and scalable hybrid
infrastructure docker is a company
that's helping redefine the way
developers build ship and run
applications this company focuses on
making use of containers for this
purpose and in aws the service called
the amazon ec2 container service is
helping them achieve it the esa or
european space agency although much of
esa's work is done by satellites some of
the programs data storage and computing
infrastructure is built on amazon web
services esa chose aws because of its
economical pay-as-you-go system as well
as its quick startup time the guardian
newspaper uses aws and it uses a wide
range of aws services including amazon
kinesis amazon redshift that power an
analytic dashboard which editors used to
see how stories are trending in real
time financial times ft is one of the
world's largest leading business news
organization and they used amazon
redshift to perform their analysis a
funny thing happened amazon redshirt
performed so quickly that some analysis
thought it was malfunctioning they were
used to running queries overnight and
they found that the results were indeed
correct just as much faster by using
amazon redshift ft is supporting the
same business functions with costs that
are 80 percentage lower than what was
before general electric
ge is at the moment as we speak
migrating more than 9000 workloads
including 300 desperate erp systems to
aws while reducing its data center
footprint from 34 to 4 over the next
three years similarly howard medical
school htc imdb mcdonald's nasa
kellogg's and lot more are using the
services amazon provides and are getting
benefited from it and this huge success
and customer portfolio is just the tip
of the iceberg and if we think why so
many adapt aws and if we let aws answer
that question this is what aws would say
people are adapting aws because of the
security and durability of the data an
end-to-end privacy and encryption of the
data and storage experience we can also
rely on aws way of doing things by using
the aws tools and techniques and
suggested best practices built upon the
years of experience it has gained
flexibility there is a greater
flexibility in aws that allows us to
select the os language and database easy
to use swiftness in deploying we can
host our applications quickly in aws
beat a new application or migrating an
existing application into aws
scalability the application can be
easily scaled up or scaled down
depending on the user requirement cost
saving we only pay for the compute power
storage and other resources you use and
that too without any long-term
commitments now let's talk about the
different types of services that aws
provides the services that we talk about
fall in any of the following categories
you see like you know compute storage
database security customer engagement
desktop and streaming machine learning
developers tools stuff like that and if
you do not see the service that you're
looking for it's probably is because aws
is creating it as we speak now let's
look at some of them that are very
commonly used within computer services
we have amazon ec2 amazon elastic bean
stock amazon light sale and amazon
lambda amazon ec2 provides compute
capacity in the cloud now this capacity
is secure and it is resizable based on
the user's requirement now look at this
the requirement for the web traffic
keeps changing and behind the scenes in
the cloud ec2 can expand its environment
to three instances and during no load it
can shrink its environment to just one
resource elastic beanstalk it helps us
to scale and deploy web applications and
it's made with a number of programming
languages elastic beanstalk is also an
easy to use service for deploying and
scaling web applications and services
deployed a beaten java.net php nodejs
python ruby docker and lot other
familiar services such as apache
passenger and iis we can simply upload
our code and elastic bean stock
automatically handles the deployment
from capacity provisioning to load
balancing to auto scaling to application
health monitoring and amazon light sale
is a virtual private server which is
easy to launch and easy to manage amazon
light sale is the easiest way to get
started with aws for developers who just
need a virtual private server lightsail
includes everything you need to launch
your project quickly on a virtual
machine like ssd based storage a virtual
machine tools for data transfer dns
management and a static ip and that too
for a very low and predictable price aws
lambda has taken cloud computing
services to a whole new level it allows
us to pay only for the compute time no
need for provisioning and managing
servers and aws lambda is a compute
service that lets us run code without
provisioning or managing servers lambda
executes your code only when needed and
scales automatically from few requests
per day to thousands per second you pay
only for the compute time you consume
there is no charge when your code is not
running let's look at some storage
services that amazon provides like
amazon s3 amazon glacier amazon abs and
amazon elastic file system amazon s3 is
an object storage that can store and
retrieve data from anywhere websites
mobile apps iot sensors and so on can
easily use amazon x3 to store and
retrieve data it's an object storage
built to store and detroit any amount of
data from anywhere with its features
like flexibility in managing data and
the durability it provides and the
security that it provides amazon simple
storage service or s3 is a storage for
the internet and glacier glacier is a
cloud storage service that's used for
archiving data and long term backups and
this glacier is an secure durable and
extremely low cost cloud storage service
for data archiving and long term backups
amazon ebs amazon elastic block store
provides block store volumes for the
instances of ec2 and this elastic block
store is highly available and a reliable
storage volume that can be attached to
any running instance that is in the same
availability zone abs volumes that are
attached to the ec2 instances are
exposed as storage volumes that
persistent independently from the
lifetime of the instance an amazon
elastic file system or efs provides an
elastic file storage which can be used
with aws cloud service and resources
that are on premises an amazon elastic
file system it's an simple it's scalable
it's an elastic file storage for use
with amazon cloud services and for
on-premises resources it's easy to use
and offers a simple interface that
allows you to create and configure file
systems quickly and easily amazon file
system is built to elastically scale on
demand without disturbing the
application growing and shrinking
automatically as you add and remove
files your application have the storage
they need and when they need it now
let's talk about databases the two major
database flavors are amazon rds and
amazon redshift amazon rds it really
eases the process involved in setting up
operating and scaling a relational
database in the cloud amazon rds
provides cost efficient and resizable
capacity while automating time-consuming
administrative tasks such as hardware
provisioning database setup patching and
backups it sort of frees us from
managing the hardware and sort of helps
us to focus on the application it's also
cost effective and resizable and it's
also optimized for memory performance
and input and output operations not only
that it also automates most of the
services like taking backups you know
monitoring stuff like that it automates
most of those services amazon redshift
amazon redshift is a data warehousing
service that enables users to analyze
the data using sql and other business
intelligent tools amazon reshift is an
fast and fully managed data warehouse
that makes it simple and cost effective
and lays all your data using standard
sql and your existing business
intelligent tools it also allows you to
run complex analytic queries against
petabyte of structured data using
sophisticated query optimizations and
most of the results they generally come
back in seconds all right let's quickly
talk about some more services that aws
offers there are a lot more services
that aws provides but we're going to
look at some more services that are
widely used aws application discovery
services help enterprise customers plan
migration projects by gathering
information about their on-premises data
centers in a planning a data center
migration can involve thousands of
workloads they are often deeply
interdependent server utilization data
and dependency mapping or important
early first step in migration process
and this aws application discovery
service collects and presents
configuration usage and behavior data
from your servers to help you better
understand your workloads route 53 it's
a network and content delivery service
it's an highly available and scalable
cloud domain name system or dns service
and amazon route 53 is fully compliant
with ipv6 as well elastic load balancing
it's also a network and content delivery
service elastic load balancing
automatically distributes incoming
application traffic across multiple
targets such as amazon ec2 instance
containers and ip addresses it can
handle the varying load of your
application traffic in a single
available zones and also across
availability zones aws auto scaling it
monitors your application and
automatically adjusts the capacity to
maintain steady and predictable
performance at a lowest possible cost
using aws auto scaling it's easy to set
up application scaling for multiple
resources across multiple services in
minutes auto scaling can be applied to
web services and also for db services
aws identity and access management it
enables you to manage access to aws
services and resources securely using
iam you can create and manage aws users
and groups and use permissions to allow
and deny their access to aws resources
and moreover it's a free service now
let's talk about the future of aws well
let me tell you something cloud is here
to stay here's what in store for aws in
the future as years passed by we're
gonna have a variety of cloud
applications bond like iot artificial
intelligence business intelligence
serverless computing and so on cloud
will also expand into other markets like
healthcare banking space automated cars
and so on as i was mentioning some time
back a lot or greater focus will be
given to artificial intelligence and
eventually because of the flexibility
and advantage that cloud provides we're
going to see a lot of companies moving
into the cloud all right let's now talk
about how easy it is to deploy and web
application
in the cloud so the scenario here is
that our users like a product and we
need to have a mechanism to receive
input from them about their likes and
dislikes and you know give them the
appropriate product as per their need
all right though the setup and the
environment it sort of looks complicated
we don't have to worry because aws has
tools and technologies which can help us
to achieve it now we're going to use
services like route 53 services like
cloudwatch ec2 s3 and lot more and all
these put together are going to give an
application that's fully functionable
and an application that's going to
receive the information like using the
services like route 53 cloudwatch ec2
and s3 we're going to create an
application and that's going to meet our
need so back to our original requirement
all i want is to deploy a web
application for a product that keeps our
users updated about the happenings and
the new comings in the market and to
fulfill this requirement here is all the
services we would need ec2 here is used
for provisioning the computational power
needed for this application and ec2 has
a vast variety of family and types that
we can pick from for the types of
workloads and also for the intents of
the workloads we're also going to use s3
for storage and s3 provides any
additional storage requirement for the
resources or any additional storage
requirement for the web applications and
we are also going to use cloudwatch for
monitoring the environment and
cloudwatch monitors the application and
the environment and it provides trigger
for scaling in and scaling out the
infrastructure and we're also going to
use route 53 for dns and route 53 helps
us to register the domain name for our
web application and with all the tools
and technologies together all of them
put together we're gonna make an
application a perfect application that
caters our need all right so i'm gonna
use elastic beanstalk for this project
and the name of the application is going
to be as you see gsg sign up and the
environment name is gsg signup
environment one let me also pick a name
let me see if this name is available yes
that's available that's the domain name
so let me pick that and the application
that i have is going to run on node.js
so let me pick that platform and launch
now as you see elastic beanstalk this is
going to launch an instance it's going
to launch the monitoring setup or the
monitoring environment it's going to
create a load balancer as well and it's
going to take care of all the security
features needed for this application
all right look at that i was able to go
to that url which is what we gave and
it's now having an default page shown up
meaning all the dependencies for the
software is installed and it's just
waiting for me to upload the code or
specific the page required so let's do
that
let me upload the code i already have
the code saved here
that's my code
and that's going to take some time all
right it has done its thing and now if i
go to the same url look at that i'm
being thrown an advertisement page all
right so if i sign up with my name email
and stuff like that you know it's gonna
receive the information and it's gonna
send an email to the owner saying that
somebody had subscribed to your service
that's the default feature of this app
look at that email to the owner saying
that somebody had subscribed to your app
and this is their email address stuff
like that not only that it's also going
to create an entry in the database and
dynamodb is the service that this
application uses to store data there's
my dynamodb and if i go to tables
right and go to items i'm going to see
that a user with name samuel and email
address so and so has said okay or has
shown interest in the preview of my site
or product so this is where this is how
i collect those information right
and some more things about the
infrastructure itself is
it is running behind and load balancer
look at that it had created a load
balancer it had also created an auto
scaling group now that's the feature of
elastic load balancer that we have
chosen it has created an auto scaling
group and now let's put this url you see
this it's not a fancy url right it's an
amazon given url a dynamic url so let's
put this url behind our dns let's do
that
so go to services go to route 53
go to hosted zone and there we can find
the
dns name right so that's a dns name all
right
all right let's create an entry
and map that url
to our load balancer right
and create now technically if i
go to this url it should take me
to that application all right look at
that i went to my custom url and now
that's pointed to my application
previously my application was having a
random url and now it's having a custom
url and let me help you understand about
aws ec2 a compute servers in the cloud
through this video somewhere far in the
country a scientist has a lab far in the
woods and at one day he stumbled on a
calculation that he had trouble solving
and he was very certain that his
computer can handle it and he asked his
computer to do the math or the
calculation for him and the computer
thought about it for a while then took
couple of hours in trying to process the
data and eventually at one point it gave
up and died due to low memory and this
old scientist is now clueless about how
he was going to finish the task and
complete his invention and let the whole
world know about it and that's when he
was introduced to this new friend aws as
you see on the screen aws was very handy
in replacing his old machines and it was
able to give him the service that he
wanted at that moment aws has been
around for a while helping people with
their computer needs and now this new
scientist friend in need is welcomed by
the new and trendy id technology
aws and sure enough his new aws friend
welcomed and walked him through the new
way of computing and this new
happy-faced aws friend talked to this
scientist about aws ec2 in specific and
walked him through about all the new
innovations in it and in cloud that he
had been missing all these days so his
new friend aws started the conversation
about explaining how there is no need
for any hardware units no managing
hardware or provisioning in aws and
secondly it explained increasing and
decreasing the capacity as per the
demand is just a click away and the best
part here is that there's no upfront
commitment and we only pay for what we
have used just like we pay electricity
and water bills and all this comes with
complete control from our side other
words the whole key for this
infrastructure is with us and as if this
was not enough all this comes with
enterprise great security that's beyond
imagination in on premises and if this
still does not excite you then this
definitely would you can work from
anywhere in the world now this really
made the scientist to get excited
especially when he thought about working
from home working from home there is
nothing like it isn't it now this person
this scientist is not tied up to a
particular environment he can work from
home work on the fly work from anywhere
still the data and everything else in
his id environment is secure and safe
now let's move to the next level of
discussion let's talk about what is ec2
and some of the use cases of ec2 and
this use case we're going to talk about
are this architecture we're going to
talk about it notifies a group of users
about a new letter and the components or
resources this architecture would need
the first ec2 instance then sns a simple
notification service and
coupling ec2 and s3 servers together
that's all it would require to get an
architecture that notifies a group of
users about a new newsletter and now i
think it would be a good time to talk
about what ec2 is aws offers plenty of
services offered under different domains
like you know compute storage database
migration network management tools media
services security business productivity
application integration machine learning
game development and lot more coming up
out of which ec2 falls under the compute
capacity so what is ec2 ec2 is a web
service which aims to make life easier
for developers for providing secure and
recessable compute capacity in the cloud
with ec2 it is very easy to scale up or
scale down our infrastructure based on
the demand and not only that this ec2
service can be integrated well with
almost all the services in amazon and
out of all this the best part could be
we only pay for what we use all right
let's talk about this use case a use
case here is that a successful business
owner has a bunch of users and a
successful product that's running and
now he has developed few more products
that he thinks will be very successful
that he thinks his customers are going
to like now how can he advertise his
product to his new and prospective
customers or the solution for this
question can be addressed by aws in aws
we can use services like simple
notification service sns and ec2 for
compute and s3 for storage we can in a
way integrate them all and achieve this
business use case and that sort of got
this business owner very cheered up and
now he wants to use the service and he
wants to get benefited from the service
he wants to advertise or he wants to
notify his users every time the company
creates a newsletter all right so let's
talk about what it would take to get
this environment up and running or what
it would take to connect the environment
and put the applications on top of it
firstly we would require an aws account
and then for compute capacity we would
require an ec2 instance and here's how
we go about doing it the first thing is
to create an ami which is amazon mission
image that's really the softwares and
the application packages we would need
to run our application and the second is
to choose the hardware in here it's the
instance type depending on the workload
we would be choosing the hardware and
depending on the intents of the workload
we will be choosing the size of the
hardware and finally we would configure
the instances and how many instance do i
want you know which subnet do i want
them in and what's going to be the in a
stop or terminate
behavior of the instance and do i want
to update any patches when the instance
starts running all those pieces of
information go in here when we configure
the instance
and then the first three steps is really
about the os volume and the basic
hardware now it's time to add additional
storage to the ec2 instance that would
be step four here we add additional
storage to the ec2 instance and then
tags we use tags or we would configure
tags to easily identify an ec2 instance
at a later point you know we give it
some meaningful names so we can identify
like you know which team it belongs to
which billing department it belongs to
what's the purpose behind launching this
instance stuff like that in an
environment where we run 700 to 800 or
even more instances identifying an
instance and trying to understand you
know who owns the resource for what
purpose we created it could be an
full-time work so tagging comes to a
rescue at that time after tagging as
step 6 we would configure the firewall
which is also called security group for
the ec2 instance and this is where we
would allow or deny connection from
external world to this particular ec2
instance well it works both ways from
outside and from inside out this
firewall blocks the connection based on
port number and ip address and finally
as step 7 we review all the
configurations that you have done and we
make sure that the configurations is
what we wanted and finally click on
submit that's going to launch an ec2
instance all right this was just an
overview of how to create an ec2
instance now let's talk about each and
every step in detail so to begin with
let's talk about how to create an ami
well the ami is just a template a
template that's used to create a new
instance or an new computer or a new vm
or a new machine based on the user
requirement the things that go into an
ami are the software the operating
system the additional applications that
get installed in it stuff like that the
ami will also contain software
information you know information about
operating system information about
access permission information about
volumes they all compact in the ami
again the ami is of two types one is
predefined amis are called amazon
provided amis the other one would be
custom amis the amis that we create and
if you're looking at a particular ami
that you don't want to create but still
want to get it from amazon there is a
place or a portal called ami marketplace
there we get like thousands of amis in
there available for us to shop and use
them on a pay as you go business model
and use them as pay as you go billing so
there you can search ami that you're
looking for most probably you'll be able
to get it there now let's talk about
choosing the instance type the instance
type is basically the hardware
specification that's required for a
machine that we're trying to build and
the instant types is categorized into
five main families they are to begin
with it's compute optimized now compute
optimize gives us lots of compute power
or lots of processing power so if my
application is going to require a lot of
processing power i should be picking
compute optimized instance and the
second one is memory optimized now this
is very good for application that
require in-memory caching you know there
are some applications that performs well
with cash or through cash or the
application would create a lot of data
that it wants to keep in cash for
re-reading or for processing you know
for lengthy processing stuff like that
for those type of application this
memory optimized instance that comes
with in memory cache is a very good use
case and the third one is the instant
that comes with the gpu otherwise called
gpu optimized gpu stands for graphical
process unit and this is very good for
application that deals with gaming this
is very good for application that's
going to require large graphical
requirements and storage optimize is the
fourth option just like the name says
this is a very good use case for storage
servers and the fifth family type is
general purpose just like the name says
it's for general purpose if you're not
particular about the family then you
generally would end up picking the
general purpose because here the
services are sort of equally balanced
you know you'll find a balance between
the virtual cpu and the memory and the
storage and the network performance it's
sort of balanced all the components all
the features that needs to go in a
computer are sort of balanced in general
purpose now these instant types are
fixed and they cannot be altered because
it's hardware based we buy hardware we
do not have much control on the hardware
that's being used well we have options
but we do not have control on the
hardware and these instant types are
divided into five main families they are
compute optimized memory optimized gpu
enabled storage optimized and general
purpose then as third thing we have to
configure the instance now here is where
i have a lot of options about
purchasing you know what type of
purchasing do i want to do do i want to
go for a spot instance do i want to go
for a reserved instance do i want to go
for an on-demand instance these are
different billing options available and
that's available under configure
instance not only that here's where i'm
going to put the ec2 instance do i want
and public ipads assigned to it do i
want an iam role attached to it im role
is authentication what kind of
authentication am i going to provide and
the shutdown behavior the shutdown
behaviors include do i want to stop the
instance when the user shuts down the
machine from the desktop or do i want to
simply terminate the instance when the
user shuts down the instance from the
desktop so those things go in here just
like the name says configure instance a
lot of instance configuration options
comes in here that's the third step and
not only that under the advanced details
or advanced tab under configure instance
i can bootstrap the instance with some
scripts now bootstrap is nothing but the
scripts that you want to be run in the
instance before it actually comes online
let's say you're provisioning the
instance for somebody else you know
instead of you launching the instance
and then logging in and running some
commands and then handing it over to the
other person you can create bootstrap
shell scripts and you know paste it in a
console option available under configure
instance and amazon is going to take
those commands run it on the instance
before it hands over to the user that
initially requested for that instance
now it could be a different user or just
you it sort of automates you know
software installation procedures in the
instance that we will be launching and
not only that there are multiple payment
options available under configure
instance the user can pick an instance
under normal price and that instance
would apply normal rates applied to it
and there are also options like reserved
instance where the user can pay for an
instance upfront before a year or before
months you know for a span of year or a
span of months and that way they can pay
less per hour for using that instance
not only that you can also go for spot
instance like bidding for those
instances whoever bids more they get the
instance for that particular time well
these instances are a lot cheaper than
on-demand instances and through bidding
and buying you can keep the instance as
long as your bid price doesn't exceed
the price that amazon is proposing and
as the fourth step we will have to add
storage to the instance that we are
about to launch and here we have bunch
of storage options i can go for a
permeable storage which is free or i can
go for an external elastic block storage
also called ebs which is paid and it's a
permanent storage or else i can
integrate my ec2 instance with s3 for
its storage needs and the best part
about storage is free subscription users
they get to use 30 gigabit of ssd
storage or magnetic storage for the
whole year in this page where we are
ready to add storage we will have to
mention or provide the size in gigabit
and the volume type is it going to be an
uh provisioned volume is it going to be
and general purpose volume is it going
to be a magnetic volume stuff like that
there are volume types and we also need
to give inputs about where the disk will
be mounted and whether this volume needs
to be encrypted or not so all these
options are all these inputs are
received from us under the adding
storage section and then the fifth
option would be adding tags like we
discussed some time back tags are very
helpful to identify a machine in an
environment where we have 700 or 1000
vms running and security groups are the
actual firewall that sits in front of
ec2 instance and it protects that ec2
instance from unintended inbound and
outbound traffic now here is where i can
fine tune the access to my ec2 instance
based on port numbers and based on ip
address from which it can be accessed
and finally we get to review the whole
changes or the whole configurations that
we have made to find out whether they
are intact with the requirement and then
click on submit that's going to launch
an ec2 instance but hold on we're not
done yet when we're about to launch or
before the amazon console actually
launches the ec2 instance it's going to
give us an option to create a keypad
remember i said it's key pair you know
key pair is two things one is public and
private the private key is downloaded by
the user and is kept with the user and
the public key is used by amazon to
confirm the identity of the user so just
go ahead and download the private key
and keep it for yourself and this
private key gets downloaded as a dot pem
file it's a format of the file and it
gets downloaded as dot pen file and our
next step is to access the ec2 instance
and
because the instance that we have
launched in this example let's assume
it's linux instance and that's going to
require a tool called putty to be able
to access it and this putty tool is
really needed when we're trying to
access and linux instance from windows
instance most of the time windows
instance will have putty installed in
them but in some rare cases they do not
come with putty in those cases we can go
ahead and download putty and put the
generator and we can start using it to
access the linux instance now you might
ask well i understand putty what's putty
generator now the file that we have
downloaded is in dot pem format but
unfortunately putty does not accept dot
pem format as input you know it has to
be converted into a different format
called ppk and puttygen is a tool that
helps us to convert the dot pem file
into ppk file so the quick way to do it
is download generator open it up click
on conversion and insert the dot pem key
that we have downloaded and save the
private key and this when we save the
private key it gets saved as a dot ppk
type private key and when that's done
the next very step is to open putty and
try to log in and the way to login is to
open putty put that ip address here and
then click on auth
you know this is where we would input
the file that we have created so click
on alt and then click on browse and find
the dot ppk file that we have converted
and stored browse it and upload it and
then click on open now that's going to
open up a login screen for us and the
amis comes with a default username
depending on the ami that we have picked
the username might differ in our case we
have picked an ami for which the
username is ec2 hyphen user and this is
the default by the way let's put the
username ec2hyphen user and hit enter
and that's going to open up the linux
instance using cli there are a few other
things that we can do with the terminal
that we'll explain it a little later
alright so we have successfully launched
an ec2 instance and
yeah give yourself a pat on your back
launching an instance was just one part
of the solution so let's actually talk
about how we can notify our customers
sns or simple notification service is a
service or a product
in amazon that helps us to notify
customers through email so navigate to
sns in your account and create a topic
and we're going to use this topic for
public notification so let's make it
public and then add subscribers to it
now these subscribers these subscribers
are the people who you want to be
notified about the newsletter so we
already have the email database in there
add them to the subscribers list and
then they will start getting new
newsletters as in when we post them to
the topic and as next step create a
bucket in s3 where you can store content
and in that bucket create an event that
triggers a notification to simple
notification service so this is how it
will be set up and notification will be
sent to our subscribers anytime we put
something in our s3 bucket so s3 bucket
is going to create an event for the
notification and the notification is
going to make sure that it's delivered
to your end customer because they're
already subscribed to the topic as
subscribers and finally let's connect
the s3 with ec2 so the bucket and the
aws instance are in sync so we put some
content in the s3 bucket our email
system notifies our customers and the
customers can go online to a website
that's hosted in ec2 and because s3 and
ec2 are in sync the items that we put in
s3 will also show up in ec2 see how this
is all connected and it's working
together and once this is all connected
our subscribers will regularly be
informed anytime we put new content in
the s3 bucket and the same content will
be made available in ec2 instance
through the website let me welcome you
to this new video learning where we're
going to learn about lambda and i'm very
glad that you're watching this aws
lambda tutorial now one day at office in
a growing company there was discussion
going on between two it personal it was
about the new role that his colleague
jessica has taken benjamin the guy
standing here wants to know about it and
jessica's job is new different and
dynamic and interesting too she scale
and manage servers and operating systems
and apply security patches onto them and
monitor all of these at the same time to
ensure the best quality for application
is given to the users and benjamin was
awestruck with the amount of work
jessica is doing and with the time it
would take to complete all of them but
jessica being a very dynamic person very
suitable for the job said it was easy
for her to handle all of it and even
more but that easiness on the job did
not last longer as the environment grew
more and more it being a startup company
jessica was getting drained and was not
really happy about all her job as she
used to be jessica's manual way of
scaling and environment did not last
long and she was also finding out that
she missed to scale down some of the
resources and it's costing her a lot she
needs to pay for the service that she
was not at all using she sort of felt
that she was at the end of the road and
there was no way out from this manual
task she was very desperate and that's
when benjamin suggested something and
that brought back the peace and joy
jessica initially had benjamin suggested
about a service called lambda that can
ease the work that jessica is doing at
the moment and lambda as happy as it
looks like it's a solution that solves
the manual repetitive work and lot more
and lambda introduced itself as the
problem solver and started to explain
the following things the very same thing
that we're going to learn about in this
series so in this section we're going to
learn about the features of aws lambda
and we're going to talk about what
lambda is and then we're going to talk
about where lambda is being used in the
it or in the cloud environment as we
speak and then we're going to talk about
how lambda works and some use cases of
lambda and we're going to be
particularly discussing about the use
case about automatically backing up the
data that's put in the cloud storage
let's talk about lambda in detail lambda
automatically runs our code without
requiring us to provision or manage
servers just write the code and upload
it to lambda and lambda will take care
of it that means that we don't require
any server to run or to manage and all
you need to do is write the code and
upload it to lambda and lambda will take
care of it which also means that we can
stop worrying about provisioning and
managing service the only thing lambda
expects from you is a code that's
working aws lambda also automatically
scales our application by running code
in response to each trigger our code
runs in parallel and processes each
triggers individually scaling precisely
with the size of the workload scaling
here is done automatically based on the
size of the workload lambda can scale
the application running the code in
response to each and every trigger that
it receives billing in lambda is metered
on the seconds we only pay for the
amount of time that our code is running
which means that we're not charged for
any of the servers the only payment
required is for the amount of time the
code is computed with aws lambda we are
charged for every 100 milliseconds we
are actually charged for 100
milliseconds our code executes and the
number of times our code is triggered
and we don't pay anything when the code
is not running let's talk about what is
aws lambda now lambda is one of the
servers that falls under the compute
section or the compute domain of
services that aws provides along with
ec2 ebs elastic load balancer lambda is
also a service that comes under the
bigger umbrella of compute services in
aws and lambda allows us to execute code
or any type of application with aws
lambda we can run code for virtually any
type of application or backend services
all we need to do is supply our code in
one of the languages that aws lamda
supports as we speak the languages that
are supported by aws lambda are node.js
java c-sharp go and python and lambda
can be used to run code in response to
certain events from other services and
based on the event it can run functions
and those functions can be of node.js
java c-sharp etc now let's talk about
where is lambda used there are huge
number of use cases for lambda and there
are many ways aws lambda is used
specifically in the business world let's
talk about some of them one use case is
aws lambda is used to process images
when it is uploaded in an s3 bucket
let's say the object gets uploaded in an
estate bucket in a format that we don't
expect it to be which means the file
needs to be formatted so it gets
uploaded in a raw format and aws lambda
is triggered anytime a new object is
added to the bucket and the images are
processed and converted into thumbnails
based on the devices the other end
device that would be reading the data it
could be an pc it could be an apple
machine it could be an android phone it
could be an apple phone it could be a
tablet what not so based on the devices
different formats lambda can get
triggered and convert the video or
convert the picture into the different
format that it requires another use case
for lambda is to analyze the social
media data let's say let's say we're
collecting the hashtag trending data and
the data is received and it's uh added
into the kinesis stream to feed into the
amazon environment and lambda action get
triggered and it receives the data and
then the data is stored into the
database which can be used by
businesses for later analysis and some
of the companies that have gotten
tremendous benefit using lambda or
thomson routers bench links
not storm coca-cola robot are some of
the companies to name at the moment that
have received tremendous amount of
benefit by using lambda let's look at
how lambda works in other words let's
look at how the complicated function
behind the scenes work in a simple and
in a seamless way so here clients send
data now clients send data to lambda and
clients could be anyone who's sending
requests to aws lambda it could be an
application or other amazon web services
that's sending data to the lambda and
lambda receives the request and
depending on the size of the data or
depending on the amount or volume of the
data it runs on the defined number of
containers if it is a single request or
if it is less request it runs on a
single container so the requests are
given to the container to handle and the
container which contains the code the
user has provided to satisfy the query
would run and if you're sort of new to
containers then let me pause here for a
while and explain to you what container
is now container image is a lightweight
standalone executable package of a piece
of software that includes everything
needs to run it like the codes the
runtimes the system tools the system
libraries and any other settings needed
and it is at the moment available both
on linux and windows based application
and containerized software will always
run the same regardless of the
environment it's running on and
containers isolate software from its
surrounding for example there could be
difference between a development and
staging environment so that's sort of
isolated and this helps in reducing the
conflict between the teams running
different software on the same
infrastructure all right now that we
know containers needed to understand
lambda so if there are few requests it
sends to a single container but as and
when the request grows it actually
creates multiple containers shares the
multiple requests to the different
containers there and depending on the
volume depending on the size depending
on the number of sessions the more
number of containers are provisioned so
to handle those requests and when the
requests reduce the number of containers
reduce as well and that helps in saving
costs we're not running any resources
and paying for it when we're not using
them and in fact we're not at all paying
for the resources we're only charged for
the amount of time a function is running
inside these containers now consider a
situation where you have to set up a
temporary storage and as a system to
backup the data as soon as the data is
uploaded which is a near real time
backup now a near real time manual
backups are nearly impossible and
they're not that efficient too and near
real real-time manual backups that's
what the business demands but that's not
near real-time backup that to a manual
one that's not at all efficient even if
we come up with a solution of manually
backing up close to near real time
that's not going to be efficient looking
at the amount of data that will be put
in and looking at the random times the
data will be put into the source bucket
and there is no way we can do a manual
backup and they keep it as real as
possible but if that's still your
requirement we can use aws lambda and
set things up so aws lambda manually
handles the backup in other words for an
impossible or a difficult situation like
that aws lambda comes for the rescue and
this is what we do create a 2s3 bucket
one would be the source bucket where the
data will be uploaded and the other one
is and destination bucket where the data
will be backed up from the source bucket
and for these buckets to talk to
themselves it's going to require an iem
rule and then for the automatic copy
it's going to require an lambda function
to copy the files from the source bucket
to the destination bucket and what
triggers the lambda function the lambda
function is triggered every time there's
a change in the metadata for the bucket
and this data is then uploaded into the
destination bucket and after setting all
this up we can literally test it by
putting a data in the source bucket
that's going to automatically replicate
or that's going to automatically copy
the data from the source bucket to the
destination bucket all right let's see
how we can replicate data between two
buckets well we have a feature to cross
region replicate in s3 that's a feature
that comes along with s3 what if you
want to replicate between two different
buckets in two different accounts in
those cases we can use lambda to
replicate the data between the buckets
so you put one data or you put data in
the source bucket and that data gets
replicated to the destination bucket and
let's see how that's done the procedure
here would be to have two buckets to
begin with and then create an im role
that lets you access to pull data from
the source bucket and put data on the
destination bucket and then create
lambda files or lambda event or triggers
to actually look for event in the source
bucket and anytime a new data gets added
lambda gets triggered copies the data
from the source bucket and moves the
data to the destination bucket and it
uses the iam role and policy for the
needed permissions and in just a couple
of clicks we have set up a temporary
backup system that can run seamlessly
without any manual intervention and that
can be as near real time as possible all
right that's the concept and let's see
how it is done real time through this
lab so to begin with we need two buckets
so i have here a source bucket and a
destination bucket and the source bucket
as of now do not have any data in it so
as the destination bucket all right so
that's one down the second would be to
create an im role right so let me create
an im role and the role is going to have
this policy in it a policy that's
allowing get object on the source bucket
and a policy that's allowing put object
on the destination bucket and here i'm
gonna use or i'm gonna paste my source
and destination buckets arn all right go
to services go to s3
source bucket
all right click on the source bucket and
copy the bucket drn
so that would be the source bucket arn
right on on the destination bucket copy
the destination bucket arn
and this is going to be my destination
bucket arn so with this i'm going to
create a policy
all right
go to im
and create a policy
now i i have already created a policy
with the same information all right
destination bucket arn and a policy is
available with the name s3 bucket copy
lambda attach the policy to the role
right go to roles create a role lambda
is the service that's going to use it in
here attach the policy that we have
created
right give it a name
and then create a role now i have a role
created as well
right copy lambda and that's having the
policy that we have created sometime
back now create a lambda function right
so go to lambda
create a function give it a name like s3
bucket copy all right choose the role
that we want to use
all right that's the row that we want to
use copy one two create a function
all right
and in here
we're going to use node.js code right i
have a sample code
this can be used as template here
replace the source bucket with the name
of the source bucket and the destination
bucket with the name of the destination
bucket this is a node.js code that gets
run when an event get triggered now
what's an event anytime there is a new
object placed in the s3 bucket it
creates an event and the even triggers
lambda and lambda checks the source s3
bucket picks the data puts it in the
destination bucket all right paste it
here
paste it here
and click on save
right now before you click on save just
ensure that you have the appropriate
roles defined that's all you got to do
click on save all right now i already
have created
a lambda function
right
which is the same thing same code and
the rule is attached to it
now it's running it's active now let's
put this to test go to s3
pick the source bucket
put some data in it
all right and
in theory those data should be present
in the destination bucket as well
there you go it's all done by lambda and
i'm going to be touring you with
different s3 features and technical
details in this section so what are we
going to learn we're going to learn
about what is cloud storage in general
and then the types of storage available
in general in the cloud and how things
were before anybody adopted using s3
that's something we're going to learn
and then we're going to immediately dive
into what is s3 and then the benefits of
using s3 over other storage and then
we're going to do a couple of
labs or
console walk-throughs about what is
object and how to add an object what is
bucket how to create a bucket stuff like
that and then we're going to talk about
how amazon s3 generally works now it
comes with a lot of features it comes
with a lot of promise um how does this
all work how does amazon able to keep up
with the promise we're going to talk
about that and then we will talk about
some features add-on features that comes
along with the amazon s3 so what is
cloud storage in general cloud storage
is a service that provides web services
where we can store our data and not only
that the data can be easily accessed and
the data can be easily backed up
everything over the internet in short if
you could store your data if you could
access the data if you could back your
your data everything you do through the
internet then that's a good definition
for cloud storage and the additional
definitions are in cloud storage we only
pay for what we use you know no
commitment no pre-provisioning is you
know pay-as-you-go type subscription and
the best part is we pay on a monthly
basis you know we don't rent a hardware
for the year or we don't give commitment
for the whole year it's pay as you go
and pay on a monthly basis and these
cloud storages are very reliable meaning
once you put the data in it it's never
going to get lost and these cloud
storages are scalable assuming i have a
requirement to store 100 times of what
my actual data sizes and i want it now
it's available in the cloud and these
storages are secure as well because
we're talking about data data virginity
they need to be secure and amazon
provides tools and technologies through
which we can secure our data and these
are generally not found in the
on-premises storage system so let's talk
about the different types of storage in
general so s3 is a cloud storage in aws
and then we have a elastic block store
now elastic block store is actually the
ssd hard drives that gets attached to
our ec2 instance you know it's like the
c drive it's like the d drive it's like
the e drive that gets attached to our
instances now efs is elastic file system
the underlying technology is kind of the
same but it differs from ebs in a way
that ebs can be accessed only by the
system that's attached to it meaning the
e volumes and the d volumes we spoke
about they can be accessed only if there
is an instance connected to it but these
efs are actually shared file systems
elastic file system all right they're
shared systems they can be accessed by
multiple systems they can be accessed
from inside the amazon environment it
can be accessed from on-premises
equipment as well glacier is actually
the archiving solution in the cloud if
you want to dump a data and try to keep
them in
the low cost as possible then glacier is
the product we should be using and then
we have storage gateway if i want to
safely move my data from my local
environment to the cloud environment and
also want to keep a copy of the data
locally so users locally can access them
and in a cloud users or internet users
can access the data from the cloud if
that's your requirement then storage
gateway is the one we would be choosing
and then we have snowball snowball is
really an
data import and export system but
it is actually an hardware that gets
shipped to our premises where we can
copy a data into it and then ship it
back to amazon and amazon would copy the
data into whatever destination we give
them in our account and if the data is
really huge then i can call for a
snowmobile which is actually a data
center on a truck where amazon would
send me and truck loaded with the data
center as you see that has compute
capacity lots and lots of storage
capacity and electricity
ac and lot more so they get come parked
near our data center and cables run into
our data center we can copy data into it
send it back to amazon and they would
copy it to our account in whatever
storage that we advise them so if the
data is really really huge then i would
be calling snowmobile snowmobile is not
available in all the regions all right
let's take this example how things were
before s3 was introduced you know two
professionals are having a conversation
and one of them is finding it very
difficult to sort of manage all the data
in the organization well if the data is
small it can be easily managed but as
companies grow and we are living in an
era where data is everything we want
data to back up every idea we want data
to back up every proof of concept that
we provide so data is everything so in
this era it's all about uh collecting
data analyzing them and saving you know
not losing logs you know saving them
analyzing stuff like that so coming back
to our discussion here one person finds
it very difficult to store and manage
all the data that they have so some of
the data that this person is having
problem storing is data that application
used to running and then data that gets
sent to the customers and data's that
the websites require the data that are
because of the email backups and a lot
more other storages that an enterprise
can have and this person is having
problem backing up all those data and
even if
we think of increasing the local storage
capacity that's going to cost the
fortune and few things that
make it sometimes impossible to increase
the storage capacity in-house is uh you
know we will have to go and pay heavy to
buy hardware and software to run these
storages and we need to hire a team of
experts for maintaining them the
hardware and the software and anytime if
there is a dynamic increase in the
storage capacity the on-premises or
in-house hardwares won't be able to
scale and data security data security is
very costly when it comes to building
our own storage environment in-house and
adding data security on top of it so the
other guy in the conversation was sort
of quietly listening everything the
manager was saying and then he slowly
introduced him to s3 because he knew
that all the problem that this manager
was worried about can be solved to
estimate in other words all the
scalability all the
data security all the
not being able to provision hardware and
software components are all available
with s3 so that actually brings us to
the discussion about what s3 is s3 is
simple storage service it actually
provides an object storage service let
me talk to you about object and block
storage object storage is where you can
store things into drive alright you
can't install anything in it and this
object storage can be accessed directly
from the internet whereas block storage
is something that needs to be attached
to an instance and
we can't directly access it but we can
install software in it so that's a high
level difference between object storage
and block storage and s3 is an object
storage what does that mean we can store
data from the internet we can retry from
the internet but uh we can't install
anything in s3 all right so so s3 is an
object based storage and it's it's
really built for storing and recovering
or retrieving any amount of data or
information from anywhere in the
internet few other things you need to
know about s3 is that this s3 is
accessible through the web interface the
storage one type of accessing or one way
of accessing s3 is by dragging dropping
content into it and another way of
retrieving data from s3 is go to a
browser click on download that's going
to let you download any content and the
data can be 5 terabytes in size now
we're talking about one file you know
you can have hundreds or thousands of
files like that one file can be as big
as five terabytes in size and s3 is
basically designed for developers where
they can push logs into s3 or drive logs
anytime they want instead of storing
locally in the server they can use s3 as
code repositories you know where they
can save the code and have the
applications read the code from there
and a lot more if they want to safely
share the code with another person with
a lot of encryption and security added
on top of it that's possible as well so
there are a few things about s3 and on
top of all these s3 provides 11 9
durability and four nine availability
meaning durability is if i store the
data will it get lost amazon is like no
it's not gonna get lost you're gonna
have the data because we provide 11.9
durability for the data and availability
is if you want the data now will you be
able to show it amazon is like yes we
will be able to show it we have 99.99
availability and when you request the
data we will be able to show the data to
you all right so let's talk about the
benefits of s3 s3 is durable as we saw
it provides 11 9 durability s3 is low
cost out of all the storage options in
amazon s3 is the cheapest and s3 is very
scalable like we were saying that
there's no required to pre-provision a
storage capacity you know if you need
more go ahead and use more if you need
even more go ahead and use even more and
once you're done some data needs to be
removed just remove the data so that
particular month you would be paying
less so it's very scalable in nature and
it's very available as well s3 isn't
regional service you know it's not based
on one availability zone so one
availability is on going down within
amazon the whole availability going down
it's not going to affect your ability to
access s3 storage ns3 is secure a lot of
security features like bucket policy a
lot of security features like encryption
and then mfa authentication are possible
with the s3 that actually adds a very
good security layer on top of the data
that we have stored in s3 and not only
that this s3 is very flexible in terms
of cost flexible in terms of where i
want to store the data in terms of cost
there are a lot of pricing tiers within
s3
s3 itself is a cheap service now within
that we have a lot of pricing tiers
depending on the durability so i can
always choose to put data on a different
storage tier or storage option in s3
we're going to talk about it as you
stick along and in terms of flexibility
in the region i can always choose any of
the region available in the console or
in the s3 console to put my data to
there is no restrictions on where i can
or cannot put the data in the cloud as
long as there are regions available for
me to move the data to and data
transferring with s3 is very simple all
i have to do is browse to the bucket
upload the data and the data gets
uploaded and we can also upload data
using cli commands are very similar to
linux commands are very similar to what
we would use in the run command prompt
in windows and what we would use in the
run command prompt in the powershell all
right let's talk about
a basic building block of s3 which is
bucket and objects now what's a bucket
what's an object object is the actual
data
and bucket is the folder where the
objects get stored let me give you a new
definition for objects so object is the
actual data plus some information that
reference the data like is it a jpeg
file the name of the file and at what
time it was added to so they're called
metadata all right so object is actually
data plus metadata and bucket is
actually a container that receives the
data and safely stores in it and when we
add a data in a bucket amazon s3 creates
an unique version id and allocates it to
the object so we can easily identify it
at a later point let me show you a quick
lab on s3
all right i'm in the s3 console if
you're wondering how i reached here
go to services under storage and s3 is
right here
and let's create a bucket called simply
learn
now the bucket names will have to be
unique
so i really doubt if simply learn
will be available let's
let's check it anyway
all right it's doesn't seem to be
available so
um
let me pick another name or let's call
it simplylearn.samuel.com
and i'm going to put this in
mumbai or i can choose oregon
let me choose oregon
oregon
yes
let me choose oregon
and let me create a bucket
sure enough a bucket got created let me
upload an object into the bucket
and
you know these objects can be as big as
five terabytes we talked about it right
all right let me upload an object
all right so that's my object so you get
the relation right
here is a bucket
right here is my bucket and within that
is my object now object is the actual
file plus what type of file it is
and then
and then the size of the file the date
in which it got added and the storage
class it is in at the moment
so if i have to access it
i can simply access it through the
internet
so let's talk about how does this s3
bucket work anyway all right so how does
it work a user creates a bucket they
will specify the region in which the
bucket should be deployed we had an
option we could have chosen to deploy in
all the regions amazon provides s3
service you know beat north virginia
beat mumbai beat tokyo beat sydney
beat
argon and we chose aragon to be the
destination region where we want to
create bucket and save our data there
and when we upload data into the bucket
we can specify three types of storage
classes in our case we picked the
default which was a s3 standard as we
saw on the object data it was on s3
standard so that's the basic thing later
once the object gets added we can always
add a bucket policies you know policies
define who accesses it and who should
not access it what can they access are
we going to allow users only to read or
to read write as well stuff like that so
that's bucket policy we're defining the
live cycle or the life span of the data
in the s3 bucket now over the time do
you want the data to automatically move
to a different storage tier and at any
point do you want to sort of expire the
data you know get the data flushed out
of your account automatically and those
things can be configured in life cycle
policies and version control is creating
multiple versions if you're going to use
s3 for a code repository creating
multiple versions let's say if you want
to roll back to whatever you had before
a month how are you going to do it if
you kept updating the file and never
took a version of it so version control
helps us to keep different versions and
it helps us to roll back to the older
version anytime there is a need so let's
talk about the different storage classes
in s3 the different storage classes in
s3 begins with s3 standard now this is
the default and it's very suitable for
use cases where you need less or low
latency for example if you want to
access the data of students attendance
you would retrieve them very quickly as
much as possible so that's a good use
case to store data in s3 let's
understand the different storage classes
in amazon s3 now let's take
a school for example and
the the different datas present in a
school
and the features of those data the
validity of the data all right so let's
take this example and there are
different storage options in s3 let's
take s3 standard for example and what
would be the actual candidate data that
can be stored in s3 standard let's talk
about that so s3 standard in general is
suitable for use cases where the latency
should be very low and in here the good
example or the good candidate file that
can be stored in s3 is a data that
needs to be frequently accessed and that
needs to be retrieved quickly something
like students attendance report or
students attendance sheet which we
access daily and then it needs to be
retrieved immediately as in when we need
it the other type of storage chair in s3
is infrequent access or infrequent data
access just like the name says the use
case for that is less frequently
accessed data i mean the candidate data
that should go in infrequent access data
is a student's academic record you know
which we don't need to access on a daily
basis but if there is a requirement we
might want to go and look at it and
that's going to be quick so it's not a
data that we would access on a daily
basis but it's data that needs to show
up on your screen real quick and the
third option is amazon glacier now
glacier is really an archival solution
in the cloud so for archives high
performance is not a requirement so
let's talk about some candidate data
that can go into archives something like
uh students admission fee and it's not
critical also now anytime if you want to
look at the data you can always wait to
retrieve the data so in other words you
know put it in the archive and the
driving from the archival takes time so
uh students old record are a good
candidate to be put in the archives the
other options are one zone ia storage
class where the data is infrequently
accessed and the data is stored in a
single availability zone for example now
by default amazon stores data in
multiple availability zones and there is
a charge for that now it's not an option
but the charge includes storing data in
multiple availability zones but if your
data requirement is you want to keep the
charges in a low even further you can
choose a one zone ia storage class where
it stores data in one availability zone
and the candidate data that can go in
one zone in frequent access is students
report card and the other option with
amazon s3 is standard reduced redundancy
storage it is suitable for cases where
the data is not critical and the data
can be reproduced quickly for example
you know take
a copy of the library book take a copy
of the pdf library book for example now
we would have a source pdf and we would
make copies of it and then we make it
available for the readers to read the
other option in s3 is reduced redundancy
storage uh here the use case is data
that's not critical and the data can be
reproduced quickly welcome to this new
learning
series called i am a service in aws for
security here in this section we're
going to talk about what is security in
aws and then we're going to slowly or
gradually move on to the other topics
like types of security available in aws
out of all the services why im is the
most preferred one and then we're going
to talk about what is im in general how
it works the building blocks are
components in im and the features it the
the attractive features that it provides
that makes iam stand out from the rest
of the services available we're gonna
talk about that and then we're gonna end
today's session with a demo about how
iam gets well interacted with the other
services in amazon and help create a
secure environment in the cloud let's
talk about aws security now cloud
security is the highest priority in aws
and when we host our environment in the
cloud we can be rest assured that we are
hosting our environment in a data center
or in a network architecture that's
really built to meet the requirement of
the most security sensitive organization
and this high level of security is
available to us on a pay-as-you-go type
meaning there is really no upfront cost
that we need to pay and the cost for
using the service is lot lot cheaper
than what it is in an on-premises
environment so aws cloud provides and a
secure virtual platform where we can
deploy our application now compared to
the on premises when using or attaching
that type of security to our application
is very low compared to on premises
there's really no upfront cost and the
cost is very lower whatever cost that we
pay is very lower than what it would be
in on premises and all this contributes
to the secure environment we can get
through im in aws cloud there are really
many types of security services
available in aws to name a few are to
name the familiar ones im stands first
followed by a key management system kms
and then we have cognito that's another
service and web access firewall vaf is
another security service in aws now
let's start our discussion by talking
about im and that's what this whole
series is about now im or identity and
access management it really enables us
to
manage access to aws services and aws
resources in a very secure manner with
im we can create groups we can actually
allow those users or groups to access
some service or we can sort of deny them
uh to access the servers whichever we
want that's all possible through
identity and access management and this
feature comes with no additional charge
now let's talk about how things were
before aws before aws or before i am
in general it was not that safe in a
copyright to share the password over the
phone or through the email that was the
practice that was existed at that time
now we all can remember the days when we
need to switch to a different account or
we had just one admin password commonly
stored in a location or one person would
reset it and maintain it and anytime or
we need to log in we call the person ask
for the admin password or the phone and
then we try logging in now that was not
secure at all back then you know
somebody could walk by and sort of
eavesdrop you know get the password now
they walk away with the password with
them so they're all possible when we
share the password over the phone and
through the internet or email now with
aws a lot of options are available that
i'm not sharing password over the
unsecure medium now a slack is a
third-party product available with aws
it's not an aws product but slack is in
third-party application that's hosted on
aws and it's really a communication tool
that helps people to share documents so
now we're not sharing the password over
the phone rather through the
applications and no eavesdrop person can
really catch the password and you know
try it in their system to access our
environment that's not possible so you
see the difference now back then sharing
password was only through phone and
email and you would write it on a paper
and you give it to somebody but now
technology is providing provisions
enough for us to share the password in a
secure way we're still talking about i
am im as an web service for securely
controlling access to the aws resource
now it really helps us to authenticate
or sort of limit access to a certain set
of users accessing the aws account or
certain set of users accessing a certain
set of resources in aws account now you
see this picture we have an im
administrator who is trying to allocate
permissions to different group of people
so we have group one on the top and
group two in the middle and group three
towards the end the administrator using
iam or iam empowers the administrator
allow access to certain group to certain
resources that's what i am is all about
now let's talk about the building blocks
or let's talk about the elements that
make and complete i am so the elements
are categorized into six
different elements we have the principle
in iam the authentication the request
the actual request coming in the
authorization allowing denying access
actions what are the scope of actions
can be taken and on what resource is it
easy too is it rds is it s3 bucket so
what resource these actions are applied
to so they are the basic elements of an
iem workflow let's talk about principle
for example an action on aws resource
can only be performed by a principal an
individual user they can be a principal
a role in aws im it can be a principle
as well in other words a principal is an
entity that can take an action on an aws
resource you know a principle can be an
user a principle can be a role a
principle can be an application that's
trying to access the aws environment
secondly authentication now
authentication is a process of
confirming the identity of the principle
trying to access the aws environment now
how do we get authenticated or how does
the user get authenticated by providing
credentials or the required keys to
validate that this is what he or she is
as per what's in the record so all
principle must be authenticated and we
get authenticated using the username and
password to log into the console if it
is cli or we get authenticated using the
access key and the secret access key
the other component that makes up im is
request when a principal tries to use
the aws management console what the
principal is doing or what the user is
doing is sending a request to the aws
environment and the request will have
the principal actually wants to perform
is it a put request or is it a get
request or is the delete request stuff
like that and it's also going to carry
information about on which resource the
action needs to be done is it done easy
to one is it on s3bucketsimplylearn.com
stuff like that so it has a specific
action that it wants to perform and the
resource on which it wants to perform
and also some information about from
where the request is originating from is
it within an aws environment or is it
with another cloud service provider or
is it with on-premises stuff like that
so these information will be present in
the request authorization now this iam
uses information from the request
context to check for matching policies
and it determines it takes a decision
whether to allow or to deny the request
now here it has a logic by default all
the resources are denied and im
authorizes your request only if every
part of the request is allowed by a
matching policy so there is an
evaluation logic that says by default
all requests are denied and if there is
an explicit allow
then it overrides the default deny and
if you are explicitly denying a service
then all the allow statements gets
overridden and all the other statements
gets overwritten and this explicit deny
stands by default only the aws account
root user has access to all the
resources in that account so if you're
not signed in as a root user then we
must be specifically granted permission
uh through a policy in other words we
need to be authorized through the policy
now let's talk about action now after
authenticating and authorizing the
request aws approves the action that we
are about to take now using action we
can view the content we can create a
content or create a bucket or create an
ec2 instance i can edit content or even
i can delete a resource that's all based
on the action that i'm allowed to do now
that was about actions now where is the
action performed the action is performed
on the resources a set of actions can be
performed on a resource and anything
that's not mentioned in the action or
anything that's not tagged with the
action and the resource they don't get
to complete for example let's say if you
attempt to delete an im role and you
also request to access the ec2 instance
for that role then the request gets
denied now let's talk about some of the
other components of im so the other
components are im are the basic building
block is an user and then many users
together they form a group and then
policies are the engines that allows or
denies a connection
based on policy one gets to access or
gets no access to a resource and then
roles roles are another component rules
are temporary credentials i would say
that can get assumed to an instance as
and when needed right let's talk about
this component called user in an im with
im we can securely manage access to aws
services and
we can create an im user anytime there
is a new employee joining our corporate
so it's a one-to-one mapping you know
one user or one employee get a username
directly attached to them and a username
or a user is an account specific thing
you know it's very local to that aws
account that we are using so for in
detail an imuser is an entity that
we create in an aws environment to
represent a person or a service that
interacts with aws environment and this
user is going to have some credentials
attached to them and by default they do
not have
a password and they do not have any
access key or secret access key attached
to them in fact literally no credentials
of any kind now we must create an user
and we must create the type of
credential that gets attached to the
user do they want to access a cli so
based on that we would be adding
credentials to them a user by default is
not authorized to perform any action in
aws and the advantage of having
one-to-one user is that we can assign
permissions individually to that user
for example we might want to assign
administrative permissions to few users
who can administer our aws environment
and users are entity within an aws
account users don't have to pay
separately you know they start using
their servers and that get bills under
the account they are attached to so
separate users doesn't mean that
separate payment for those users they
are just users in our account and
you know the whole account gets to pay
for the resources that they provision
again the im user does not always
represent a person an iem user is really
just an identity with associated
credential and permissions attached to
it it could be an actual person who is a
user and it could be an application also
who is a user next we'll talk about
groups talking about groups or
understanding group is very easy a
collection of user forms an iem group
and we can use iam group to specify
permission for multiple users so that
any permission that's applied to the
group is also applied to the users who
are at add to that group now there are a
few things you might want to know about
group a group can have
many users and a user they can belong to
many groups but groups can't be nested
meaning group can only have users
a group cannot have a group inside a
group that's not possible and there's
nothing called a default group that sort
of automatically includes all users in
the aws account
if you want to have a group then we will
have to create a group now let's take
this diagram for example now this is a
diagram of an small company now the
company owner creates an admin group for
users to create and manage other users
as the company expands every day and the
admin group creates a developer group
and a test group each of these group
consists of users users who are
people users who are application that
interact with aws environment so the
different types of users we have are
jim is a user brad is an user and dev
app one is a user and and so on so each
users have an individual set of security
credential like i said it's one to one
and the uh
10 users that we see on screen are
shared between or they belong to
multiple groups in the account and
managing group is quite easy we set
permission to the group and that
permission gets applied to all the users
automatically in the group and after we
applied the policy if i add another user
to the group the new user will
automatically inherit all the policies
all the permissions that's already
mentioned in that group so
administrative burden is sort of taken
away administrative burden about user a
privilege or user permission management
is sort of taken out with iam all right
the next thing we will want to discuss
is policy a policy sets permission and
controls the access to aws resource and
the policies this permissions and
controls are stored in json format a
policy is a very clear document it
defines who has access to a resource and
what are all the actions they can
perform so in other words policy is an
entity in aws that when a policy gets
attached to an identity or a resource
you know it really defines the
permission what they can and cannot do
and aws it evaluates these policies when
a principal such as a user makes a
request and the permission statement and
the policy it really defines whether the
user is allowed to access a service or
is he denied to access a service all
right let's take this example now we
have a task the task is to give paul
who's a developer access to amazon s3
environment and what you're looking at
is a snippet of what a policy would look
like so these are some questions we will
have to answer or these are some
questions the policy twice to answer and
once it found an answer then it becomes
a complete policy so who wants access to
the service it's paul who wants access
to the service and what action do paul
want now paul wants to
download or paul wants to upload objects
in s3 in json language it's otherwise
called paul wants to get information
paul wants to put information otherwise
paul wants to get object paul wants to
put object in s3 and which resource does
he want now in this case every bucket
the star symbol represents all buckets
in history so which resource it's all
bucket in s3 so we can start reading
already from the data present here so
who wants access paul wants access what
action does he want he wants to get he
wants to put and what's the resource
that he's trying to access or you want
to give him access it's all the bucket
in aws and when does he want these
additional statement that goes in a
policy so since when does he want that
access he wants access till march 2nd
2019 so all this who all this action all
this resource you know till the time all
this gets allowed so this is the
statement that really defines now does
this all refer to an allow statement or
does this all refer to a deny statement
if we had deny here it's the direct
opposite of what we discussed but we
have allow that means paul is allowed to
get and put access in an s3 bucket and
all the buckets in s3 till march 2nd
2019 he's allowed to access the
resources so if we put together put all
the information that we have gathered or
all the answers that we have so far if
we put together in a json format this is
how it's going to look like so
the effect is
allow or deny here it's allowing and the
principle
is any now who can access it it's any an
action it's any bucket in s3 any action
in s3 put get request and the resource
is any bucket in s3 so that's how a
basic policy would look like or that's
how a basic policy is formed by
answering those basic questions so let's
talk about the types of policies so we
have two broad categories managed policy
and inline policy the manage policy it's
the default policy that we attach to
multiple entries be users beat groups
and beat roles in our aws account on the
other hand inline policy are the
policies that we create and manage them
and these policies are embedded directly
into a single user group or a role so if
i need to brief it a little bit more
then a managed policies are standalone
identity based policies that we can
attach to multiple users groups and
roles in our aws account we can use two
types of managed policies in other words
managed policies they themselves have
two categories one is aws managed
policies which is created and managed by
aws and the other one is customer
managed policies just like the name says
it's managed by the customer now we can
create and edit an im policy in visual
editor or simply create a json policy
document directly and upload it in the
console and start using them so that's
manage policy on the other hand inline
policies are policies that we create and
manage and that are embedded directly
into a single user group or role let's
talk about this next component called
role now this role is very similar to
everything that we discussed so far it's
a set of permission that defines what
actions are allowed and denied by an
entity in an aws console the role is
very similar to an user i said very
similar i didn't say it's the same as
the user but i said it's very similar to
the user and the difference is that user
is hard coded user permissions are hard
coded but the role permissions are
accessed by any entity you know be it a
user or a beat and aws service and
moreover the role permissions are
temporary on the other hand user
permissions are permanent and the role
permissions are temporary
so in detail a role is very similar to a
user in that it's an aws entity with
permission policies that determines what
the identity can and cannot do in aws
now instead of it being uniquely
associated with one person a role is
intended to be assumable by anyone who
needs it roles generally do not have an
long term credential you know password
or access keys associated with it you
know it does not have
long term credentials it only has
temporary credentials created
dynamically and provided to the user as
in when the user assumes a role and
wants to access any service roles can be
assumed by users roles can be assumed by
applications roles can be assumed by
services that normally you don't have
access to aws resources for example you
might want to grant a user in your aws
account access to your resource that
they do not normally have or grant users
in one aws account access to resource in
another aws account now this is
something that we don't have by default
and this is something we may not need
all the time or you might want to allow
a mobile app to use aws resource but you
do not want to save the key or save the
credential or save the passwords in the
mobile app or sometimes you might want
to give access to resources who already
have identities defined outside of aws
like a user who's already and google or
facebook authenticator if you want to
give them some service or if you want to
let them to access some of the resources
in your account we can use roles for
that purpose or you also might want to
grant access to your account to a third
party a consultant or an auditor so they
can for some time get some temporary
access to audit our aws resources
remember they're not permanent users
just templar users they want some
temporary access to our environmental
the audit is over so for those cases
roles are a very good use case so let's
take this um
example let's see where role sits and
let's see how roles give permission to
other services so here is a scenario
where where an ec2 instance
wants access to an s3 bucket by default
though both of them were created by the
same username or the same admin they do
not have access by default so by default
they don't have access and i also do not
want to give permanent access you know
one-on-one hard-coded permanent access
instead i would like to create and share
access so that's possible to roll so
coming back to the discussion uh the
scenario here is that an ac2 instance
wants to access data in an s3 bucket so
the first thing is to create a role or a
permission we saw how that's done right
using policies roles use policies policy
is the actual working engine for any
permission related actions right so
create a role with an appropriate policy
that gives access to s3's bucket and
then launch an ec2 instance with the
role attached to it we said rules are
assumed by any entity right it could be
user it could be an application it could
be a service it could be another
resource in aws account so here it's
another resource in aws account right so
we create a role and we attach it to an
ec2 instance so now the ec2 instance can
assume the role now the same role can be
attached to another ec2 instance the
same role can be attached to
another user the same role can be
attached to another database service we
get the idea right roles can be assumed
by anyone so when the ec2 instance wants
to communicate with s3 it contacts the
role and then the role gives this ec2
instance some temporary username and
password that expires after one hour
let's say so it's a temporary username
and password now with that temporary
username and password the ec2 instance
can access the
s3 bucket and access the file
with the credential that it already has
and that credential is a temporary one
and the credential will expire after one
hour or how much ever time the admin
sets it to be and then the next time
whereas when an ec2 instance wants to
contact s3 it will have to contact the
role and the role will propose a new
access key and secret access key in
other words a new credential with that
new credential the second time the ec2
instance will be able to contact the s3
bucket and get the information so the
password is not a permanent or a
one-time or a hard-coded password it
keeps rotating it's a token it's a
secure token that an ec2 instance or any
application that uses the role gets to
access the resources on the other end so
let's talk about the features of iam the
main feature of im is that i can create
separate username and password for
individual users or resources and i can
delegate access now those days where we
had just one username and password for
admin and we need to call the other
person to get the username and password
over the phone
if it gets compromised you know the
whole account gets compromised stuff
like that those issues are gone i can
create separate username and password
for all thousand users in my account no
more username and password sharing i can
manage access to all those thousand
accounts in a very simple and an easy
way so im provides shared access for all
the thousand users in my account it
provides share access to the aws
environment and the permissions that can
be given through im are very granular
now we saw how restrictions can be put
on get request you know we can allow a
user to download information and not
update an information so that's possible
through the iem policies that we looked
at some time back and with the use of
roles you know we're authenticating an
ec2 instance instead of the application
running on top of it so if there are
like 10 or 20 applications running on
top of an ec2 instance instead of
creating a separate username and
password for all those 20 instances i
can create a role and assign that role
to the
ec2 instance and all the applications
running on the ec2 instance get a secure
access to the other resources use the
role credential that's provided to that
ec2 instance now besides username and
password im also supports multi-factor
authentication where we provide our
credential the username and password
plus an otp from our phone or an
randomly generated
number that gets displayed in our phone
before amazon console or before amazon
cli would authenticate and
lets us access some of the servers in
the account so it's called multi-factor
authentication its username and password
plus something else from what you have
im also provides identity federation if
a user is already authenticated with a
corporate ad or
facebook or google you know im can be
made to trust that authentication method
and then allow access based on that
authentication now without federation
what would happen is the users will have
to remember two passwords you know one
for on premises and one for cloud
anytime they work on on-premises they'll
have to use one set of password and
anytime they switch to the cloud which
is going to be very frequent in a every
day so anytime they switch to the cloud
they will have to again type in the
cloud username and password now with
identity federation we can sort of
federate or we can connect both the
authentication systems both on premises
and im so users can just use one
username and password for both
on-premises and cloud environments and
all that we saw so far it's free to use
there's no additional charge for im
security there is no additional charge
for creating additional users groups or
policies it's a free service comes along
with any account im is an pci dss
compliant product now im comes with
password policy where we can reset the
password remotely or rotate the
passwords remotely
and we can set rules like how a user
should pick an password it should not be
the one that was used in the past any of
the past three times stuff like that so
uh you get the idea right how the
features of im help us to build and
secure authentication and authorization
system in or for our aws account
all right it's time to do a quick lab
let's let's put all the knowledge that
we have earned so far together and apply
it and try a lab and solve the problem
so here's a problem statement
we need to create an s3 bucket for a
company where users can read or write
the data only if they are multi-factor
authenticated so there could be like 20
users in an account but a user is
allowed to read or write a data in an sd
bucket only if the user is multi-factor
authenticated you know this is a very
good use case if we have a sensitive
data in an s3 bucket and you only want
privileged or mfa authenticated users to
do changes to those buckets and for
those privileged users you would enable
multi-factor authentication so let's see
how that's done before that let me talk
to you a bit more about multi-factor
authentication a multi-factor
authentication is that additional level
of security process it's provided by aws
here the user's identity is confirmed
only after the user proposes or the user
passes to level of verification now one
being the username and password and
another being an otp that gets generated
in this case it's the mobile phone it
could also be an rsa token key that
generates the one-time password that's
possible as well but in this case it's
the mobile phone now that's going to be
very similar to how we log in to our
gmail account sometimes when we log into
a gmail account and
i mean if you have the proper setting
enabled it's going to send an one-time
password to the mobile phone and only
after we put that information it's going
to let us log in let's see how all this
is done in an aws account so the first
thing is to log in to the aws account
create a user and attach the user to the
virtual mfa device now we're going to
use google authenticator here and we're
going to attach the user to
google authenticator and make the user
use the google authenticator one time
password every time he logs in to the
account now this is an addition to the
username and password that
he or she already has right so the first
thing is to log into the account connect
or sync the virtual appliance with the
aws username and password now when we
sync there will be an one-time password
that gets shown in the phone type in the
password in the aws console and then the
phone and the username comes to sync and
from that point onwards the user anytime
they log in they will have to propose
their username and password which is the
first step of security and then once
they typed in the username and password
type in the mfx code that gets generated
on the phone that would be the second
step or security or the last step of
security once that is done the account
is going to let them log in and access
the aws resources
all right so in order to test im mfa s3
together this is what we are going to do
so we are we're gonna create
a bucket and we're gonna have two users
and we're gonna allow or deny access to
the s3 bucket to those two users based
on whether they are mfa authenticated or
not and on purpose uh we gonna assign
mfa to one user and
no mfa to the other user like you might
have guessed by now the user with mfa
will have access to the bucket and the
user with no mfa attached will not have
access to the bucket both of them are
going to have full s3 services but mfa
like i said is one layer above the other
permissions mfa stands at all time so
irrespective of whether the underlying
policy says but they have full access to
the s3 bucket they're not going to
because mfa stands on top of it let's
see how that's done to begin with
firstly we need a bucket so let's create
a bucket
so i'm in my
aws console so let me go to s3
and in here create a bucket call that
bucket as simply learn mfa bucket and
let me put it in north virginia and
create
all right so that's done
now i'm going to put a separate folder
in here
i'm going to create another folder in
here and the name of the folder is tax
documents now this is where i'm planning
to keep my tax files
and i only want my privileged users to
be able to upload and download
information from the tax document so on
the bucket side it's partially done or
on the s3 side it's partially done so
let's go back to iam
and here we're going to create two users
one a junior employee and another one
and senior employee the senior employee
is the one who is going to have mfa
access and
more access to the s3 bucket and the
junior employee is the one who's not
going to have access to that particular
bucket so let's get started let's create
an user under iam
click on users
and let's create a user called as user
junior
right so he's a junior user
and for the password
set a password
the user does not need to create a new
password at sign in because it's a test
environment and
the user who creates the username and
the user are the same person so let's
keep it simple username password
management console access
and this user is going to have
full s3 bucket access all right this is
really the policy
and we should be familiar
with this json document by now it says
effect is allowed and what action any
action an s3 and
what resource anybody who's attached to
it review
and create a user
so this user is having
s3 full access now let's create another
user call them as senior employee
all right attach
a policy to the user
you know from the surface level both of
them have the same permissions both of
them have s3 full access
all right so
both of them have s3 full access as we
see
there's one thing different we're going
to do to this senior employee now we're
going to attach
mfa to this employee so the way we would
do it is under the summary section of
that particular user click on security
credential and see here is a place we
can attach an mfa to this user so let's
attach mfa to this user
for mfa i can use both virtual mfa or
hardware mfa this being in lab
environment we're going to use virtual
mfa now that is an application there are
a lot of applications available but
there is one application that i'm using
at the moment called google
authenticator
so once we have installed the
application and once it is running
so i can go to virtual mfa device and
once it is running i can scan the code
using the google authenticator in my
mobile phone once you turn on the
application and once you do scan the
barcode that is showing right here now
that's going to give us codes that we
can use and we will have to put in those
codes here twice we'll have to wait for
some time and it would generate a second
set of key that we can put
so my first set of key is 4 0 2 three
five one right i'll have to wait for
some time and then it would throw me a
second set of key it's like validating
twice right here so let me put in my
second set of key
so this user is now mfa authenticated
user so anytime this user logs in it's
going to ask for mfa anytime this user
proposes something it's going to attach
the mfa key along with it all right so
we're done with iam what have we done
with im we have created two users both
of them have actually full access but
one of them have
mfa access and the other one does not
have mfa access and based on whether the
user is having mfa or not you know we
are identifying privileged users by this
mfa all right so based on whether the
user has mfa or not are we going to
allow deny access in the s3 bucket
so we already have a bucket we already
have a folder and this is a very
privileged
folder part here i would like to
restrict access based on whether the
user is having mfa or not
so let me create a bucket policy here
now here is a policy that i have written
the policy
says that you know under tax document
folder give access only if the user is
mfa authenticated right if the user is
not mfa authenticated simply deny the
access to that user so as you might
guess right now the user one will not
have access or the
junior employee will not have access
because it's a privilege then you know
junior employee might tend to delete
them unknowingly and only privileged
users get access to the tax document
because it's confidential because it's
privileged because if it gets deleted we
won't be able to get it back for those
reasons right so apply the bucket policy
now try logging in as
the different users and see how the
permissions are applied on both the
users all right so let's make a note of
the im url
and then the two usernames and password
let's login
so let me login as the privileged user
sure enough i'm being asked for an mfa
code let me put my mfi code
so let's directly navigate to the s3
bucket
right here's my privileged path let me
try uploading some content
claim forms
sure enough i'm able to upload content
into it will i be able to delete
yes i'm able to delete as well now let's
see what's the situation for the other
user
so let's login
as the other user
navigate to the sd bucket
if you noticed when logging in it did
not ask for an mfa code because the user
is not set up for mfa
so navigate to the folder
which we want to test
now try adding some files
as you see it's failing
to add content to this bucket it shows
error because the bucket policy is
requiring mfa and this user is not mfa
and we did that in iam or under iam
but still as you see you know they will
be able to view the content in the
bucket they can do all that we have
specifically restricted access to upload
and download content from the bucket and
that's exactly this user is now denied
with welcome to this new video lesson
where we're going to learn about plot
formation in this section we're going to
learn about why we need a solution
called cloud formation or why we need a
product called cloud formation and we're
going to talk in detail about what is
cloud formation and then how cloud
formation works and the concepts
involved in cloud formation like i know
templates and stacks there are some
concepts involved in cloud formation
we're going to talk about that and how
do we maintain access control over the
cloud formation we're going to talk
about that as well in this video and
then we're going to go through a demo or
a lab where we create an lamp stack
environment from a template through
cloud formation and then we're going to
talk about some use cases one of which
include being able to create an
redeployable template using cloud
formation that's a very good use case
we're going to talk about that in this
video so let's talk about why cloud
formation so when the number of products
and services grow more and managing them
and
maintaining them
becomes and tedious work and cloud
formation it sort of eases that
environment now cloud formation is
really an infrastructure as a code and
it sort of solves all the problem that
we discussed some time back and with
cloud formation we can actually create a
perfect clone of the server
configuration at any point in time and
we can also manage the configuration
changes and configuration changes with
cloud formation we can manage the
configuration changes across the
environment and not only that we can
easily ember in the ad hoc changes to
our existing environment so one might
ask why use cloud formation let's look
at the current problem that we have
creating and managing multiple aws
resource in the portal is a big task
especially when you need to replace some
services it becomes a bigger task now
cloud formation eases that work let me
explain it in detail now at the moment
without the cloud formation or
environments that don't use cloud
formation have this problem that is a
lot of time is being spent on building
the infrastructure and less focus and
less time at the moment is being given
on developing that application that runs
on that environment that's because
majority of the time is consumed by
building the environment and if we need
to redeploy the same environment again
and again the same happens in a cycle
again a new environment we start from
the scratch build environment and then
put application on top of it now that
can be avoided using cloud formation now
without cloud formation still is a
problem because the the resource or the
bandwidth that is needed for the
application development is not provided
because that's taken by developing the
infrastructure and to solve that problem
we can use cloud formation now that
leads to a discussion about what is
cloud formation so let's talk about or
let's try understanding what cloud
formation is cloud formation is a
service that provides users a simple way
to create and manage collection of aws
resources by provisioning and updating
them in a very orderly and in a
predictable way if i need to expand
explanation of cloud formation
cloudformation is an server that really
helps us to model and set up our amazon
web services or resources so we can
spend less time on managing the
resources and show more focus on the
application that runs on top of it we
can simply create a template for an ec2
instance or for an rds instance and
upload it in the cloud formation portal
and cloud formation will provision and
configure those resources based on the
template that we define we really don't
have to sort out the complexities in
dependency between those applications
once the template is vetted and
validated cloud formation takes the
responsibility of handling the
dependencies between the application in
an orderly and a predictable way it
creates those services and makes it
available for us once the template is
fully run so in short at the cloud
formation it allows us to create and
model our infrastructure and
applications without we having to
perform the manual action for example
the well-known company called expedia is
able to easily manage and run its entire
front and back end resources they run on
aws in cloudfront what does that mean
they are spending less time on managing
infrastructure and more time on the core
business and the application that runs
on top of it and we're still talking
about what cloud formation is with
cloudformation it enables us to manage
our complete infrastructure or aws
resource in a text file now we're going
to see that in a moment you know it's
either a json or an yml file and that
file is called as the template to begin
with the resources the template
provision is called the stack all right
so the abstract of the code is called
the template and the resource that it
provisions is called the stack and this
stack can be i mean it's going to run
resources obviously and those resources
can be updated as well it's not like
once you create a stack it's done if you
need a change you need to go create
another resource that's not needed this
stack is an updatable stack let's say if
i'm including two more servers if i'm
sort of extending my environment it's
branching out to another application now
i'm including another functionality in
my environment all those can be embedded
in the update and can be updated so like
i said the stack is an updatable one now
let's talk about what the template can
do or some features and functionality of
the template now using a template we can
almost include all the application and
resources that a user might require
let's say you know after the easy to
instance is provision running an
application on top of it and you want to
templatize that and include that in the
template that's possible as well and
these templates are portable ones
meaning i can use the template in one
region and i can use the same template
in another region and that's going to
build a very similar environment in
another region i can also share that
with the customer and when they run it
it's going to run an environment from
the portable template in their account
in their environment of course all the
security is taken care i'm just saying
that if we need to build a resource if
you need to build an architecture if you
need to build an environment which looks
very similar to the other environment
that is possible and and these templates
are usable by the use of some sections
in the template like the parameter
section the mapping section the
condition section within the template is
what makes the templates reusable and we
will talk about parameters mapping and
conditions down the line we're still
talking about aws how aws cloud
formation works and we're going to talk
about how a template becomes an
infrastructure right so to begin with
one requires a template and the template
would be in json or yml format so one
would develop a template based on the
requirement based on number of ec2
instances based on whether they want a
load balancer based on what they want
and a windows server based on whether
they want an database server in that
environment and then based on the
applications that will be running on top
of it that can be templatized in the
code itself so one creates a code and
then the code is saved locally or they
can be put in an s3 bucket from which
the cloud formation will call the
template and provision the resource
right so we use cloud formation uh to
create a stack or create the resource
defined in the template and cloud
formation analyzes the template first
the validates template and then it
identifies the
dependencies between them and then it
starts provisioning the resource one
after the other for example if you need
a five servers in a new vpc obviously
it's going to create the vpc first and
servers second and stack all right let's
understand the two major components in
cloud formation by now you might have
guessed it the two major components are
the template and the stack together the
aid or the complement cloud formation
and that's how the resource of provision
that's how the resource are managed and
that eases the job of the administrator
who's managing the environment so let's
talk about template first a template in
cloudformation is an text file or a
formatted text file in json or yml
language and that the code or the
template or the text file that actually
describes how your infrastructure looks
like or will look like once provision
and for us to create the template or for
us to you know modify an existing
template we can use a tool available
called cloud formation designer from the
console or any text editing tool that's
available but i would recommend the
cloud formation designer though that has
rich graphics in it and these templates
are built off or they consist of nine
main objects the first of which is the
format version and this really
identifies the capabilities of the
template based on the version number and
then the second object in a template
would be description and this helps us
to include any arbitrary comments about
the template for what reason are we
building this template what's the
purpose of it stuff like that
and then we have the object called
metadata in a template and that includes
a details about the template details of
the resources in the template and then
we have the optional parameters section
this really helps us to customize our
template now parameters enable us to
input custom values to our template each
time we create or update and stack and
the mapping object it helps us to match
a key to a corresponding set of named
values for example if you want to set a
value based on region then we get to
create a mapping that uses region name
as the key and then the value that we
want to specify for each specific
regions and then we have conditions
object this is again an optional object
with this we can include statements that
define when a resource is created or
when a property is defined for example
we can compare whether a value is equal
to another value and based on the result
of that condition we can conditionally
create additional resources and then the
object called transform it's it's an
optional object as well and this
transform section specifies one or more
transforms that we can use in our cloud
formation template for example uh aws
cloud formation transforms helps
simplify template authoring by
condensing the expression of the aws
infrastructure as a code or the cloud
formation template and it enables reuse
of template components for example we
can condense multiple line resources
declaring it into a single line in our
template now we will talk about all
these examples in the upcoming slides
and then we have the required
section called resource that declares
the aws resource that you want to
include in the stack for example if you
want to include an ec2 instance if you
want to include a necessary bucket we
would be using the resource object in
our stack and then we have object called
output this output object it's an
optional object in the template and it
helps us to sort of
declare the outputs that we can import
into other stacks or
we can actually show it on the cloud
formation console for example if you
want the output of the or the name of
the s3 bucket that got created in
response to a cloudformation template
now we can have that outputted into an
output section in the cloud formation
console itself so it's sort of easy for
us to identify the resources that the
template provisioned so with all of
those objects put together this is how a
full-blown clot formation template with
all the objects included is going to
look like now this includes optional and
mandatory object let's talk about those
objects in detail in the upcoming
section all right let's now discuss each
and every object of this template
structure and let's begin our discussion
with the format version the format
version it really defines the
capabilities of the template the latest
version format version as of now is the
one that was updated on 2010. now the
value of the template format version it
has to be and
string and if you really don't specify
the format version cloudformation
automatically assumes the latest version
talking about description descriptions
are really any comments that help
ourselves that we want to embed in the
template itself that can be a
description and this description in a
template it has to be an string length
of the string can be between
0 to 124 bytes in length the metadatas
are really used in the template to
provide any additional information
using the json and
yaml objects and metadata holds some
implementation details of a specific
resource and parameters are really a way
to customize the template each time we
create or update our stack these
parameters are the ones that helps us to
give some custom value to the template
during run time in the example shown
below the parameter named instance type
parameter it lets us to specify the ec2
instance type for the stacks to use when
creating or updating the stack by
default as we see uh it's picking t2
micro and this is the value that will
get picked if we don't provision
another value to it and mapping mapping
really enables us to map a key to a
corresponding named value that we
specify in a conditional parameter and
also we can retrieve the map or to try
the values in the map using the function
find in map instrict function let's take
this example let's say based on a region
if you want to set values in a template
we can create a mapping that uses a key
and holds the value that you want to
specify for each region and the object
conditions can be used when we want to
reuse the templates by creating
resources in a totally different context
for example in a template during stack
creation all the conditions that we
mentioned in the template are evaluated
and any resources that are associated
and that come up to be true are created
and any condition that fails or invalid
are kind of ignored automatically and
the check moves forward to the next
condition and conditional is an optional
object and it includes statement that
define when a resource is created or
when a property is actually defined for
example you can
create whether for example you can
compare whether a value is equal to
another value and based on the result of
that condition we can conditionally
create resources if you have multiple
conditions then they are generally
separated with commands sometimes
conditions are very helpful when we want
to create templates and we want to reuse
those templates which was created for
one environment to another environment
for example if you want to use a
template that was created in a test
environment in a dev environment
conditions would be helpful for example
in a production environment we might
want to include instances with certain
uh capabilities and in a test
environment we might want to include
instances with some reduced capability
in them for saving money and condition
helps us to sort of create resources
based on the environment it will be used
in we can also use intrinsic functions
to define conditions like equals we can
also use r conditions we can use not
functions intrinsic functions in a
condition and when put together the
syntax is going to look like the one
that you see on the screen now the
optional object called transform it
specifies one or more transforms that
the cloud formation uses to process our
template now these transform sections
are built on a simple
declarative language of aws cloud
formation with a powerful macro system
that helps us to reuse the templates or
the template components and they really
help us to condense or simplify our
codes by enabling reuse of the template
components for example condense a
multiple line resource declaration into
a single line in our template the
resource section it really declares the
aws resource that you want to include in
the stack such as ec2 instance such as
s3 bucket and some of the resource
fields are the logical id the resource
type and the properties let's talk about
them in brief the logical id is unique
within the template and the logical id
name it actually reference the resource
in other parts of the template in this
case it's my bucket for example i know
if we want to map an elastic block store
volume or if you want to map and
name of the bucket in another place in
the template not then we would use the
logical id and again in this case it is
my bucket a logical name has the
physical id uh with which we actually
assign the resource for example in this
case my s3 bucket was named as my bucket
to begin with and the resource type in
the template it identifies that the type
of the resource is an s3 bucket and the
properties are the additional
optional information that we can specify
to our resource for example if it is an
ec2 instance let's say we would like to
know which ami it used then property
section really defines the ami that was
used or ami as the property of the
instance so this section describes the
output value that needs to be imported
to other stacks or the output value that
needs to be shown in the console for the
user to easily navigate to the resource
that are being created for example for a
s3 bucket name we can declare an output
and once the bucket is created we can
actually declare the output and sort of
import the name of the bucket in a
different place in the console so it's
it's easy to view instead of you know
the user getting confused and
going to s3 and searching for the bucket
name this can be made available in the
cloud formation console itself and the
output fields it can include some of
these followings like the logical id
it's actually the identifier of the
current output and it's very unique
within the template and it can also
include a description description is
really a string type that describes the
output value and it can also include
value and value is the property that was
returned by the aws cloud formation
describe stacks command all right let's
talk about template
resource attribute in this section we're
going to
talk about
attributes that you can add to a
resource to control additional behavior
and relationships so let's talk there
are many resource attributes available
out of which we have i mean if we need
to name them we have a creation policy
and then we have deletion policy it
depends on metadata attribute update
policy attribute let's talk about each
of them separately when we associate the
create policy attribute with the
resource it actually delays the resource
configuration actions before proceeding
with the stack creation i mean the
attribute stack creation is delayed till
the time the cloud formation receives
some number of success signals back i
mean this is a very good use case when
we do auto scaling
and this creation policy can be used
only with a
limited number of services like auto
scaling and ec2 instances
some of the use cases would be if you
want to install and software application
on an ec2 instance you might want the
applications to be running before it
proceeds further so in this case we
would use the creation policy attribute
to the instance and then send the
success signal after the applications
are installed and configured then cloud
formation goes to the next step here in
the syntax that we're looking at the
auto scaling creation policy and the
minimum successful instance percentage
it's actually a number of signals that
it will have to reply back before it can
move forward using deletion policy it
preserves backing up of resources when
the stack is getting deleted and by
default if you don't have a deletion
policy the
data gets deleted just like that but if
we use an deletion policy we would be
able to preserve the data by taking a
snapshot of it or
just letting the resource and moving on
with deleting the other resources in the
stack and we specify the delete policy
attribute for each resource specifically
that we want to control and if there are
no deletion policy mentioned for a
particular resource the cloud formation
simply deletes their resources as that's
its default behavior and if you want to
keep the resource when the stack is
deleted we use we we mention retain in
the delete policy and that simply
retains the resource from getting
deleted so in this example we are
actually retaining a dynamodb table rest
of the resources in the stack will get
deleted and using the depends on
attribute
we actually
create a an order in which the resource
gets deleted for example if i map one
resource to another resource and say
that this resource depends on the other
resource the other resource gets created
first then followed by this instance or
this resource so with the depends on
attribute we can specify that the
creation of specific resource is
actually followed by an another when we
add the depends on attribute to a
resource the resource is created only
after the creation of the resource
specified by the depends on attribute
let's take this example in this example
we're saying that the resource x
depends on y we've said that x depends
on y so in this case when cloud
formation is executing it's going to
deploy y first because it has some
resources that depends on it so it's
going to create y first and then it's
going to create the resource called x on
the same context let's say in the
template we say that an ec2 is going to
depend on s3 and when the cloud
formation is executing it's going to
create an s3 bucket first and then the
ec2 instant that's probably because the
codes needed for the ec2 instance are
stored in the s3 bucket and and what
we're looking at is the syntax of how
the depends on template resource
attribute will look like this is how it
actually will look like when we put it
in the cloud formation the instance
depends on the bucket the other template
resource attribute is metadata metadatas
are the one that really helps us to
associate our resources with the the
structured data and by including this
attribute in our template or by
including this attribute to a resource
we can specify the data in json or in
yaml language for example in this
section of the template we're creating a
vpc and the metadata explains or
metadata defines that the vpc is part of
the region us east one and the update
policy template resource attribute and
cloud formation we can manage and
replace the updates of the instance in
an auto scaling group for example you're
looking at this
sample where it says that the update
policy will it replace the instance in
an auto scaling group or not so
depending on what the value is for the
will replace section whether it's true
or false depending on that the update
policy will replace the instance or will
replace the auto scaling group itself
when it's doing enrolling deployment now
that we've discussed about templates
let's talk about aws stacks as well now
we know that aws stacks are the actual
resources that gets generated or that
gets created because we ran a template
right so stack is a collection of aws
resource that we can manage in a single
unit in other words you know we can
create a stack update a stack or delete
a stack and that would actually create
update delete the collection of
resources within the stack and all the
resources in the stack are really
defined by the cloud cloudformation
template and a stack for instance can
include all the resources required to
run a web application such as a web
server a database server and some
networking rules that come along with it
all that gets embedded in a stack and
let's say if we want to delete all the
resources that were created by template
that is in a separate stack we can
simply delete the stack and that would
sort of delete all the resources that is
in the stack so it sort of helps us to
manage all the resources in a single
unit or as a single unit so to summarize
stack is a collection of aws resource
and it can be managed as a single unit
and the cloud formations template
defines a stack in which the resource
can be created deleted or updated in a
very predictable way and a stack can
have all the resources like web server
database server vpc the network and the
security configurations in a vpc all
that is required to run a web or a
database application now stack could be
nested as well with cloud formation we
can actually
nest a stack with another stack and
that's going to create an hierarchy of
the stacks for example i mean this is a
very good picture that explains how the
stacks are nested in a hierarchical way
let's say stack p is the
root stack and that could be a parent
stack for the stack called r and the
stack called cube and the same way the
the stack called r is a parent stack for
the stack s and the stack s is the
parent stack for d and q you get that
right so stacks can always be nested
it's possible cloudformation allows us
to create a microsoft windows stack
based on amazon ec2 windows amis and
provide us with the ability to install
software and use remote desktop to
access our stack and update the
configuration of our stack and these
stacks can be run on windows server
instances there are a number of
pre-configured templates available and
it's directly available to use from the
aws website itself to name a few we have
templates available for sharepoint
running on an
windows server 2008 r2 we also have
templates that create a single server
installation of active directory running
on a windows server and in fact we have
templates available for elastic bean
stock and some sample applications that
runs from an windows server 2008 r2
let's talk about stack sets stack sets
actually has taken the stack level
implementation to the next level using
the aws cloud formation template we can
define a stack set that lets us to
create stack in aws account across the
globe by using just a single template
and after we create the stack or after
the stack set is defined creating
updating or deleting the stack in the
target account and the regions can also
be specified by us so the stack set it
really extends the functionality of the
stacks by allowing us to create update
and delete stack across multiple
accounts regions in just a single
operation and using an administrator
account we can define and manage an aws
cloud formation template and use the
template as the basis for provisioning
stacks into you know some selected
target accounts across a specified
region let's talk about cloud formation
access control with im i can specify the
list of users or list of privileged
users who would have access to the cloud
cloudformation template who can create
update and delete stacks so that's how
im helps me with having or putting a
layer of control over the cloudformation
service and we can also use service
roles service roles are the one that
allows aws cloud formation to make a
call to a resource in a stack on the
user's behalf and i can also have stack
policies and these stack policies are
applied to the users who already have
access to the cloud formation service
and these policies are the ones that
help the users who attempt to update the
stack all right let's do a quick lab on
creating and lamp stack on an ec2
instance with a local mysql database for
storage now we can do the other way as
well i can pick an ec2 instance and
install the servers one top of the other
that can be done as well but that's
going to take a lot of time now we
talking about automating it we're
talking about you know provisioning and
infrastructure using a code and cloud
formation helps us to do that so this is
what we're going to do we're going to
create or we have an cloudformation
template already and we're going to use
that template the provision web instance
and that is going to have look at that
that's going to have my sequel installed
in it that's going to have php that's
going to have http servers installed in
it and running and it's also going to
have and a php website running from it
so that's going to receive information
from the website and that's going to
store that information in the database
that's very local to it
this is the template that defines
that environment
all right this is a very simple
provisioning so let's provision
this environment let's create a stack
we're going to give a stack name
and a database password
right and
which region is it this is in
california is it
all right
now let me do one thing let me switch to
the mumbai region or let me switch to
north virginia region
north virginia and from here
actually let me switch to mumbai region
all right just to be sure it's the same
template that we're provisioning
right that's the same
template that we are provisioning
all right let's give this a name so it's
gonna be great this could be simply
learn
simply learn lamp stack and what could
be the db password
ndb root password
and what could be the db user
i'm going to keep the rest as defaults
and i'm going to launch
all right so there's an issue with the
password
[Music]
password should only have alpha
numeric characters
get that
so let's go back and create a new
password
right it also needs to have eight
characters
so what can be your password
look at that the template is actually
creating the resources
and here in the screen
we can see the template that we used to
deploy the environment
if you remember we have we discussed
about
instant
types in parameters right
the default instance type is t2 small
but these are also allowed
to run
right parameter section is the one that
was
used to receive information from us like
the db name
the db password the db root password db
user instance type keyname and ssh
locations
all right now this resource section is
is showing us the resource that it
actually uh created
right looks like it's rolling back
why would that be give me a moment
[Music]
all right this is one live example
anytime it could not provision or any if
there is an interruption
that it could not proceed it would
simply roll back and delete all the
resources that it had provision and
that's what it did
now let me fix this
all right as a fix i have switched
the regen because i had some issue with
the vpc that's going to take time for me
to analyze and fix it so here we're
going to understand
about cloud formation so i thought i'll
run the cloud formation from another vpc
that
i know is working fine that's in north
virginia all right let's provision this
lamp server which is running out of
linux which has apache installed in it
which has php and mysql already
installed in it so one server gonna act
as web and db server
all right so i'm going to create a stack
and from here i'm going to pick a sample
stack
if we look at if we look at it in the
designer
it's going to provision one lamp server
and a security attack security group
attached to it there you go right so
let's go ahead and create a stack
all right
parameters are used to receive
input from us
what could be the db password
and the db user
and
let's select the key name
but i'm going to keep the rest as
defaults
and i'm going to create
a stack
all right so our stack
that we run from the template
at the moment it's getting created it's
in progress
from here i can watch the events as to
what is getting created at the moment
like i said in a lot of these would have
already sorted out their dependencies
you know which one needs to get created
first which one needs to get created
second
all that is sorted out by cloud
formation itself
and parameters are the values that we
have inputted
and a resource
tab
is a section where we can find what
resources are being provisioned at the
moment so to begin with it created a
security group
at the moment it's creating an instance
and output
uh it's empty as of now we're gonna come
back and see it
now output is where
we can
get outputs of a finished job let's say
here i wanted an
url
of the
server that got created so instead of me
you know going to a couple of other
places within the console and
find the
output of the url
or
the the output of the resource that was
created i can simply get it from here
well this needs to be defined in the
templates first
once we define it in the template
it's going to be made available
like here
right so i can
open it up
and
there you go so it has it already has
a database locally installed and it's
connected to where if i launch an
application on top of it
that will get connected to the database
which is very local and
my single
server with web and database in it is
ready for production
now while we're talking about a lamp
server a single lamp server let's talk
about
uh creating an environment like this
which has elastic load balancer a vpc
a server running in an auto scaling
group
and putting some restrictions that
nobody will be able to access the ec2
instance directly but they should be
able to access
the ec2 instance or the data only
through the elastic load balance so this
is a bit complicated than the
environment that we've already created
let's see how this is done all right in
this lab we're going to create elastic
load balanced auto scaling group which
is going to create a load balancer and
an auto scaling group and that auto
scaling group receives
traffic only from the load balancer so
here's the template
and here's the architecture that we're
going to provision
let me call it
right and the key pair it's going to use
is
simply learn key pair
now this is where the problem was now
we were selecting few subnets
so now if i provision it
now this is going to take its
short time to provision the resources
so through parameters we can see the
values that we have inputted
and the events look good
no rollback no no deletes and
the resource section shows the resource
that
it is creating so previously created a
target group now it's creating the
application load balancer itself
all right so it created and
load balancer and then create a security
group it created a launch configuration
it at the moment it's creating and web
server group
and the events look good with all green
and yellow green ones are completed
yellow ones are in progress we don't
have any red delete or roll back errors
so it looks good
all right it took a while and
the resources have been created some of
them show that they are in progress but
the status of the stack is complete
all resources have been created and we
do have an output to access the url
there you go
thank you samuel for that wonderful
session i hope you guys found this
informative we now have rahul who will
take you through the various
certifications available for you in aws
and then he will also guide you how you
can become an aws certified solutions
architect
over to you rahul
in today's job environment being
certified marks the difference between
getting your dream job and losing it if
you're a fresher or just someone who's
starting up it's highly likely that
you're confused in choosing the right
certification i'm going to help you
figure it out i'm rahul from simply
learn and today we're going to talk
about aws certifications so what exactly
is an aws certification it represents a
degree of expertise in aws it is
obtained after passing one or more exams
provided by amazon and each different
role like thesis ops administrator
developer or solutions architect has a
different exam associated with it this
in turn helps employees demonstrate and
validate technical cloud knowledge which
means that the people who are certified
actually know what they're talking about
i have seen a common misconception among
people where they believe that just
because they're certified they're
entitled a job that's not true now
without proper practice or hands-on
experience the certification is wasted
on you so remember just because you're
certified does not mean you'll get a job
it only makes the job application
process slightly easier related to
someone who's not been certified now why
is aws given so much importance some of
the important reasons are an aws
certified individual gains credibility
for their skills in aws they also gain
access to free practice exams which help
them prepare for the next aws
certification there's an increase in
monetary compensations which only means
that they get paid more and you gain
recognition for your knowledge and
skills in aws right now we're in the aws
certification website whose link will be
in the description and now we're going
to talk about the types of aws
certification as you can see here there
are three levels of aw certification
there's the foundational level associate
level and professional level
certification now the foundational level
certification only requires you to have
a basic understanding of how the aws
cloud works the aws certified dot
practitioner is optional for the
architect path developer path and
operations path it is mandatory for the
specialty certifications like the
advanced networking big data and
security certifications now the
associate level certifications are
mid-level certifications for a technical
role now a professional certification is
the highest level of certification that
you can have for a technical role now
you have the solutions architect for the
architect path and the devops engineer
certification for both the developer and
operations path so how do you decide
which of these certifications is
suitable for you so you've seen here
that aws provides various certifications
for a number of job roles exisops
administrator solution architect
developer so you need to make the right
choice taking into consideration the
areas of your interest and the
experience level that you have now we're
going to talk about each of these
certifications in detail so first let's
talk about the aw certified cloud
practitioner now we all understand that
aws is a widely recognized product in
the market so this certification helps
you validate how well you know the aws
cloud so this is just the basic
understanding now it is optional for the
developer path and the operations path i
would suggest it's a good idea to start
here because it forms a solid bedrock on
all the other things that you're going
to learn soon now more importantly it
does not require any technical knowledge
of other roles such as development
architecture administration and so on so
it's a great place to start for
newcomers now you have the architect
role certifications now this is for you
if you are interested in becoming a
solutions architect or a solution design
engineer or someone who just works with
designing applications or systems on the
aws platform now first we have the aw
certified solutions architect associate
level certification now this
certification is for you if you want to
show off how well you can architect and
deploy applications on the aws platform
now it is recommended that you have at
least a year of experience working with
distributed systems on the aws platform
at the same time it's also required that
you understand the aws services and be
able to recommend a service based on
requirements you need to be able to use
architectural best practices and you
need to estimate the aws cost and how
you can reduce them next up you have the
aws certified solutions architect
professional level certification now you
will not get the certification unless
you're done with the aw certified
solutions architect associate level
certification this is the show of your
technical skills and experience in
designing distributed applications on
the aws platform now this does require
you to have two years of experience
working with cloud architecture on aws
at the same time it also requires you to
be able to evaluate requirements and
then make architectural recommendations
you also need to provide guidance on the
best practices on architectural design
across a number of different platforms
the developer level certifications are
for you if you're interested in becoming
a software developer now the awa
certified developer associate
certification is to test how well you
know how to develop and maintain
applications on the aws platform it does
require you to have a year or more of
hands-on experience to design and
maintain aws-based applications like any
software developer role it is necessary
that you know in-depth at least one
high-level programming language it's
also necessary that you understand the
core of aws services uses and basic
architectural best practices you need to
be able to design develop and deploy
cloud-based solutions on native place
platform and you need to understand how
applications can be created you need to
have experience in developing and
maintaining applications for a number of
aws services like amazon sns dynamodb
sqs and so on now for the aws certified
devops engineer professional level
certification note here that this
certification is exactly the same as the
one you have under the operations role
so both of them are the same thing so
here it tests your ability to create
operate and manage distributed
applications on the aws platform now it
is necessary or it is mandatory to have
the aw certified developer associate
certification or the aws certified
sysops administrator certification with
two or more years of hands-on experience
in doing the same in aws environments it
requires you to be able to develop code
in at least one high-level language you
need to be able to automate and test
applications via scripting and
programming and to understand agile or
other development processes the
operation certifications are for you if
you want to become a sysops
administrator systems administrator or
someone in devops role who wants to
deploy applications networks and systems
in an automatable and beatable way the
aw certified sysops administrator
associate certification tests your
knowledge in deployment management and
operations on the aws platform now you
need to have one or more years of
hands-on experience in aws based
applications you need to be able to
identify and gather requirements then
define a solution to be operated on aws
you need to be able to provide guidance
for the best practices through the life
cycle of a project as well now the
specialty certifications are for you if
you're well-versed in aws and want to
showcase your expertise in other
technical areas the aw certified big
data certification showcases your
ability to design and implement aws
services which can help derive value
from a large amount of complex data you
are however required to have completed
the foundational or associate level
certification before you can attempt
this you need a minimum of five years of
hands-on experience in the data
analytics field as well next we have the
aw certified advanced networking
certification this validates your
ability to design and implement aws
solutions as well as other hybrid id
network architectures at scale this also
requires you to have completed the
foundational or associate level
certification you need to have a minimum
of five years of hands-on experience
architecting and implementing network
solutions and lastly we have the awa
certified security certification it
helps showcase your ability to secure
the aws platform you're required to have
an associate or cloud practitioner level
of certification a minimum of five years
of it security experience and two years
of hands-on experience securing aws
workloads now say i wanted to schedule
an examination so for example i want to
do the solutions architect certification
so first i would go there now here i can
click on register now and the process
continues or i can click on learn more
by doing this again i can show you the
examination here i can also get access
to other data like the number of
questions available the cost of an
examination the portions i need to study
and so on now let's talk about solutions
architect certification with a little
more detail now this certification exam
cost 150 us dollars and the practice
exam cost 20 us dollars now here i can
schedule the examination or download the
exam guide i've already downloaded the
exam guide and here it is now this exam
guide tells you about what you need to
learn and what is expected from you here
they want you to define a solution based
on requirements and provide guidance in
its implementation it is also
recommended that you know about how the
aws services work 1 years of hands-on
experience with distributed systems on
aws to identify and define technical
requirements and so on the rest is
available in the exam guide and most
importantly they tell you the main
content domains and their weightages now
we have five domains first domain is to
design resilient architectures which
holds 34 percent of weightage at depend
2 you have to define performance
architectures three is to specify secure
applications and architectures cost
optimized architectures and five to
define operationally excellent
architectures now like you've seen here
you've selected one certification and
learned it in detail you can do the same
for any of these other certifications
and today i'm going to tell you how you
can become an aws solutions architect so
who is an aw solutions architect now the
main role of an aws solutions architect
is to help you deploy your applications
on the aws platform now this is nothing
but a cloud computing platform so it's
not to say that you can't deploy your
applications on the cloud computing
platform yourself it's just that when it
comes to organizations the applications
that you need to deploy become a whole
lot more complex that's where an aw
solutions architect can help ever since
cloud computing became a thing companies
around the world have started migrating
their physical infrastructure onto the
cloud that's what an aw solutions
architect does they help you migrate
your physical infrastructure onto the
aws cloud companies around the world
work on a budget an aws solutions
architect will help design a cloud
infrastructure based on the
organization's budget before that can be
done however an aw solutions architect
has to create a design with an intricate
and detailed blueprint of the cloud
infrastructure that they plan to set up
now aw solutions architects also have to
focus mainly on non-functional
requirements like usability reliability
scalability and performance of the cloud
infrastructure they're also responsible
when it comes to minimizing risks that
an organization can face when it comes
to cloud computing platforms now they
could face risks like security leaks
calculation mistakes and application
down times an aws solutions architect
has to ensure that these don't happen
before we can talk about how you can
become an aws solutions architect i have
some exciting news for you guys we've
launched our own youtube community
you'll get to see a lot of quizzes polls
offers and much more to make your
learning experience a whole lot more fun
you can find all of this on your
subscription feed or you can also click
on the top right corner right now to get
started and let's get back to how can
you become an aw solutions architect now
to become an ew certified solutions
architect you need to clear the aw
certified solutions architect associate
level examination now here's some
details about it the exam score ranges
from 100 to 1000 marks and the minimum
passing score is 720. however there's a
catch the passing marks are actually set
using statistical analysis so they can
be changed based on how difficult the
examination actually is the exam fee is
150
and you can also take a practice
examination which costs 20 dollars now
regardless of the examination you take
be it solutions architect sysops
administrator or developer any associate
level examination costs hundred and
fifty dollars for the professional level
examination it's three hundred dollars
now if you want to learn more about the
aws certifications i suggest you click
on the top right corner and watch our
video aws certifications in 10 minutes
to learn more now the exam duration is
of 130 minutes and you have two types of
questions multiple choice and multiple
answer now the multiple choice questions
have four options on which one of them
is right and you have multiple answer
where you have five options out of which
two of them are correct you can take the
examination in english japanese korean
and simplified chinese now let's talk
about how you can schedule an
examination
first let's go to google and search for
aws certifications
click on the first link
so on this page you can go to the bottom
and find the different certifications
aws provides
click on architect
and select the awa certified solutions
architect associate certification
click on register now
and here you need to click on the aws
certification account
you can sign in with your amazon account
or create a new one
i already have an amazon account that
i'll be using for signing in here in
case you don't you can click on the
create your amazon account button here
and create an account for yourself
now after that is done you can schedule
a new examination
and you can scroll down to the bottom
here aw certified solutions architect
associate level certification
click on schedule exam
press continue
and here you need to select your
language
which i'm assuming is english
i'm from india so i don't need to change
anything here but you can change your
country your time zone and other details
based on your requirement
and select your preferred month i want
to do it in october
now select search for exam center
select the one that's closest to you
i'm going to select this one
and here you can select the day that you
want to take your test and the time
available i want to do it on 15
select the time that i want
and press continue
now you can go through all the details
here
change them if you want to otherwise you
can press continue
after this is done
close
and here we have the final step which is
the fees
you can enter your details here
and pay now to finish the process
now let's look at an outline of the exam
content now what you're going to see in
the exam are five major domains and here
you have each of the domains with their
respective weightages first you have at
34
designing resilient architectures at 24
percent you have both defining
performant architectures and specifying
secure applications and architectures at
10 percent you have designing cost
optimized architectures and at six
percent you have defining operationally
excellent architectures now let's look
at each of these domains in detail now
the first domain or design resilient
architectures can be divided into four
parts firstly you need to know how you
can choose reliable or resilient storage
using services like aws s3 aws glacier
and aws ebs
then you have how you can design
decoupling mechanisms using aws services
now this is possible with the help of
aws sns now these aren't the only
services that enable this these are just
some of the services then how you can
design a multi-tier architecture
solution now this is important because
you need to know how you can create a
solution that involves several other
services then you need to know how you
can design highly available and fault
tolerant architectures now for the
second domain defining performance
architectures first you have how to
choose performance storages and
databases services that are used are aws
rds aws redshift and aws dynamodb the
second step is how you can apply caching
to improve performance a service that
can be used for this is aws elastic
cache third how you can design solutions
with elasticity and scalability you have
aws lambda aws cloudwatch and aws data
pipeline now for the third domain which
is specifying secure applications and
architectures you need to know how you
can secure applications using services
like aws inspector aws cloudtrail and
aws iam you need to know how to secure
data using cloud hsm and aws macy and
how you can define the networking
infrastructure using cloud front vpc and
elastic load balancer for the fourth
domain you have designing cost optimized
architectures firstly you need to know
how you can design cost optimized
compute solutions you can use aws ec2
elastic bean stock lambda and aws light
sale then you need to know how you can
design cost optimized storage solutions
using aws s3 glacier ebs and elastic
file system and the final domain to
define operationally excellent
architectures you need to set up design
features and solutions that enable
operational excellence now some of the
features are that you perform operations
as code you annotate documentation you
make frequent and small reversible
changes and anticipate and tackle
failures now let's have a look at the
job opportunities when it comes to aws
solutions architects now if you have a
look at this graph you can see that aws
has always provided a lot more job
postings as compared to the other two
giants in the cloud computing domain
which are microsoft azure and google
cloud platform now if you do a little
bit of research you'll find out that
there's a significant lacking of
experienced personnel when it comes to
aws so i would suggest this is the best
time for you to get certified in aws so
how can simply learn help you with your
aws certifications now we are on the
simply on homepage
and here we have the aws solutions
architect course
on this course which is the aws
solutions architect certification
training course we have 36 hours of
instructor-led training 20 hours of
self-paced learning 16 live demos three
simulation exams three hands-on practice
projects and so much more here our main
emphasis is on making sure that you have
enough hands-on experience with the
services that you crack the examination
at your first attempt
so here we also go through some of the
more important services that you need to
learn like iam vpc ec2 s3 and so much
more we'll also talk about databases
application services security practices
disaster recovery and so on we even have
practice examinations to help you
prepare for the real one thank you very
much rahul that was great we have now
reached the final segment of this
complete aws tutorial
we will now have samuel take you through
80 of the most important aws questions
that might just appear in your aws or
cloud interview i'm here to walk you
through some of the aws interview
questions which we find are important
and our hope is that you would use this
material in your interview preparation
and be able to crack that cloud
interview and step into your dream cloud
job by the way i'm and cloud technical
architect trainer and an interview
panelist for cloud network and devops so
as you progress in watching you're going
to see that these questions are
practical scenario based questions that
tests the depth of the knowledge of a
person in a particular aws product or in
a particular aws architecture so why
wait let's move on all right so in an
interview you would find yourself with a
question that might ask you define and
explain the three basic types of cloud
services and the aws products that are
built based on them see here it's a very
straightforward question just explain
three basic types of cloud service and
when we talk about basic type of cloud
service it's compute obviously that's a
very basic service storage obviously
because you need to store your data
somewhere and networking that actually
connects a couple of other services to
your application these basic will not
include monitoring these basic will not
include analytics because they are
considered as optional they are
considered as advanced services you
could choose a non-cloud service or a
product for monitoring of and for
analytics so they're not considered as
basic so when we talk about basics they
are compute storage and networking and
the second part of the questions is
explain some of the aws products that
are built based on them of course
compute ec2 is a major one that's that's
the major share of the compute resource
and then we have platform as a service
which is elastic bean stock and then
function as a service which is lambda
auto scaling and light cell are also
part of compute services
so the compute domain it really helps us
to run any application and the compute
service helps us in managing the scaling
and deployment of an application again
lambda is a compute server so the
compute service also helps in running
event initiated stateless applications
the next one was storage a lot of
emphasis is on storage these days
because if there's one thing that grows
in a network on a daily basis that
storage every new day we have new data
to store process manage so storage is
again a basic and an important cloud
service and the products that are built
based on the storage services are s3
object storage glacier for archiving ebs
elastic block storage as a drive
attachment for the ec2 instances and the
efs file share for the ec2 instances so
the storage domain helps in the
following aspects it holds all the
information that the application uses so
it's the application data and we can
also archive old data using storage
which would be glacier and any object
files and any requirement for block
storage can be met through elastic block
store and s3 which is again an object
storage talking about networks it's just
not important to answer the question
with the name of the services and the
name of the product it'll also be good
if you could go in depth and explain how
they can be used right so that actually
proves you to be a person knowledgeable
enough in that particular service or
product so talking about networking
domain vpc networking can't imagine
networking without vpc in in a cloud
environment especially in aws cloud
environment and then we have route 53
for domain resolution or
for dns and then we have cloudfront
which is an edge caching service that
helps customers get our customers to
read their application with low latency
so networking domain helps with some of
the following use cases it controls and
manages the connectivity of the aws
services within our account and we can
also pick an ip address range
if you're a network engineer or if you
are somebody who works in networks or
are planning to work the network you
will soon realize the importance of
choosing your own ip address for easy
remembering
so having an option to have your own ip
address in the cloud owned range of ip
address in the cloud it really helps
really really helps in cloud networking
the other question that gets asked would
be the difference between the
availability zone and the region
actually the question generally gets
asked
so to test how well you can actually
differentiate and also correlate the
availability zone and the region
relationship right so a region is a
separate geographic area like the us
west one i mean which represents uh
north california
or the ap south which represents mumbai
so regions are a separate geographic
area on the contrary availability zone
resides
inside the region you shouldn't stop
there you should go further and explain
about availability zones and
availability zones are isolated from
each other and some of the services will
replicate themselves within the
availability zone so availability zone
does replication within them but regents
they don't generally do replication
between them the other question you
could be asked is what is auto scaling
what do we achieve by auto scaling so in
short auto scaling it helps us to
automatically provision and launch new
instances whenever there is an demand it
not only helps us meeting the increasing
demand it also helps in reducing the
resource usage when there is low demand
so auto scaling also allows us to
decrease the resources or resource
capacity as per the need of that
particular r now this helps business in
not worrying about putting more effort
in managing or continuously monitoring
the server to see if they have the
needed resource or not because auto
scaling is going to handle it for us so
business does not need to worry about it
and auto scaling is one big reason why
people would want to go and pick a cloud
service especially an aws service the
ability to increase and shrink based on
the need of that art that's how powerful
is auto scaling
the other question you could get asked
is what's your targeting in cloud front
now we know that cloudfront is caching
and it caches content globally in the
amazon caching servers global wide the
whole point is to provide users
worldwide access to the data from a very
nearest server possible that's the whole
point in using or going for cloudfront
then what do you mean by geotargeting
geotargeting is showing customer and
specific content based on language we
can customize the content based on
what's popular in that place we can
actually customize the content the url
is the same but we could actually change
the content a little bit not the whole
content otherwise it would be dynamic
but we can change the content a little
bit a specific a file or a picture or a
particular link in a website and show
customized content to users who will be
in different parts of the globe so how
does it happen cloudfront will detect
the country where the viewers are
located and it will forward the country
code to the origin server and once the
origin server gets the specialized or
specific country code it will change the
content and it will send to the caching
server and it get cached there forever
and the user gets to view a content
which is personalized for them for the
country they are in the other question
you could get asked is the steps
involved in using cloud formation or
creating a cloud formation or backing up
an environment within cloud formation
template we all know that if there is a
template we can simply run it and it
provisions the environment but there is
a lot more going into it so the first
step in moving towards infrastructure as
a code is to create the cloud formation
template which as of now supports json
and yaml file format so first create the
cloud formation template and then save
the code in an x3 bucket s3 bucket
serves as the repository for our code
and then from the cloud formation call
the file in the s3 bucket and create a
stack and now cloudformation uses the
file reads the file understands services
that are being called understands the
order understands how they are connected
with each other cloud formation is
actually an intelligent service it
understands the relation based on the
code it would understand the
relationship between the different
services and it would set an order for
itself and then would provision the
services one after the other let's say a
service has a dependency and the
dependent service the other service
which this service let's say service a
and b service b is dependent on service
a let's say cloud formation is an
intelligent service it would provision
the resource a first and then would
provision resource b what happens if we
inverse the order if we inverse the
order resource b first gets provision
and because it does not have dependency
charges that the cloud formation's
default behavior is that if something is
not provisioned properly something is
not healthy it could roll back chances
that the environment provisioning will
roll back so to avoid that cloud
formation first provisions all the
services that has or that's dependent on
that's depended by another service so it
provisions those service first and then
provisions the services that has
dependencies
and if you are being hired for
a devops or you know if the interviewer
wanted to test your skill on
systems side this definitely would be a
question in his list how do you upgrade
or downgrade the system with near zero
downtime now everybody is moving towards
zero downtime or near zero downtime all
of them want their application to be
highly available so the question would
be how do you actually upgrade or
downgrade a system with near zero
downtime now we all know that i can
upgrade an ec2 instance to a better ec2
instance by changing the instance type
stopping and starting but stopping and
starting is going to cause a downtime
right so that's you should be answering
or you shouldn't be thinking in those
terms because that's the wrong answer
specifically the interviewer wants to
know how do you upgrade a system with
zero downtime so upgrading system with
zero downtime it includes launching
another system parallelly with the
bigger ec2 instance type over the bigger
capacity and install all that's needed
if you are going to use an ami of the
old machine well and good you don't have
to go through installing all the updates
and installing all the application from
the ami once you've launched it in a
bigger instance locally test the
application to see if it is working
don't put it on production yet test the
application to see if it is working and
if the application works we can actually
swap if your server is behind and
behind
route 53 let's say all that you could do
is go to rot 53 update the
information with the new ip address new
ip address of the new server and that's
going to send traffic to the new server
now so the cut over is handled or if
you're using static ip you can actually
remove the static ip from the old
machine and assign it to the new machine
that's one way of doing it or if you are
using elastic nick card you can actually
remove the knee card from the old
machine and attach the new card to the
new machine so that way we would get
near zero downtime if you're hired for
an architect level
you should be worrying about cost as
well along with the technology and this
question would test how well you manage
cost so what are the tools and
techniques we can use in aws to identify
and correct identify and know that we
are paying the correct amount for the
resources that we are using or how do
you get a visibility of your aws
resources running one way is to check
the billing there is a place where you
can check the top services that were
utilized it could be free and it could
be paid service as well top services
that can be utilized it's actually in
the dashboard of the cost management
console so that table here shows the top
five most used services so looking at it
you can get it all right so i'm using a
lot of storage i'm using a lot of ec2
why is storage high you can go and try
to justify that and you will find if you
are storing things that should be
storing and then clean it up why is
compute capacity so high why is data
transfer so high so if you start
thinking in those levels you'll be able
to dig in and clean up unnecessary and
be able to save your bill and there are
cost explorer services available which
will help you to view your usage pattern
or view your spending for the past 13
months or so and it will also forecast
for the next three months now how much
will you be using if your pattern is
like this that will actually help and
will give you a visibility on how much
you have spent how much you will be
spending if the trend continues budgets
are another excellent a way to control
cost you can actually set up budget
alright this is how much i am willing to
spend for this application for this team
or for this month for this particular
resource so you can actually put a
budget mark and any time it exceeds any
time it's nearing you would get an alarm
saying that well we're about to reach
the allocated budget amount stuff like
that that way you can go back and know
and you know that how much the bill is
going to be for that month or you can
take steps to control bill amount for
that particular month so aws budget is
another very good tool that you could
use cost allocation tags helps in
identifying which team or which resource
has spent more in that particular month
instead of looking at the bill as one
list with no specifications into it and
looking at it as an expenditure list you
can actually break it down and tag the
expenditure to the teams with cost
allocation tax the dev team has spent so
much the uh production team has spent so
much the training team has spent more
than the dev and the production team why
is that now you'll be able to you know
think in those levels only if you have
cost allocation tax now cost allocation
tags are nothing but the tags that you
would put when you create a resource so
for production services you would put as
a production tag you would create a
production tag and you would associate
that resources to it and at a later
point when you actually pull up your
bill that's going to show a detailed a
list of this is the owner this is the
group and this is how much they have
used in the last month and you can move
forward with your investigation and
encourage or stop users using more
services with the cost allocation tax
the other famous question is are there
any other tools or is there any other
way of accessing aws resource other than
the console console is gui right so in
other words other than gui how would you
use the aws resource and how familiar
are you with those tools and
technologies the other tools that are
available that we can leverage and
access the aws resource are of course
footy you can configure puri to access
the aws resources like log into an ec2
instance and ec2 instance does not
always have to be logged in through the
console you could use putty to log into
an ec2 instance and like the jump box
like the proxy machine and like the
gateway machine and from there you can
actually access the rest of the
resources so this is an alternative to
the console and of course we have the
aws cli in any of the linux machines or
windows machines we can install so
that's point two three and four we can
install aws cli for linux windows also
for mac so we can install them and from
there from your local machine we can
access run aws commands and access
provision monitor the aws resources the
other ones are we can access the aws
resource programmatically using aws sdk
and eclipse so these are a bunch of
options we have to use the aws resource
other than the console if you're
interviewed in a company or by a company
that focuses more on security and want
to use aws native services for their
security then you would come across this
question what services can be used to
create a centralized logging solution
the basic services we could use our
cloud watch logs store them in s3 and
then use elasticsearch to visualize them
and use kinesis to move the data from s3
to elasticsearch right so log management
it actually helps organizations to track
the relationship between operational and
security changes and the events that got
triggered based on those logs
instead of logging into an instance or
instead of logging into the environment
and checking the resources physically i
can come to a fair conclusion by just
looking at the logs every time there's a
change the system would scream and it
gets tracked in the cloud watch and then
cloud watch pushes it to s3 kinesis
pushes the data from s3 to elasticsearch
and i can do a time-based filter and i
would get an a fair understanding of
what was going on in the environment for
the past one or whatever the time window
that i wanted to look at so it helps in
getting a good understanding of the
infrastructure as a whole all the logs
are getting saved in one place so all
the infrastructure logs are getting
saved in one place so it's easy for me
to look at it in an infrastructure
perspective
so we know the services that can be used
and here are some of the services and
how they actually connect to each other
it could be logs that belongs to a one
account it could be logs that belongs to
multiple accounts it doesn't matter you
know those three services are gonna work
fairly good and they're gonna inject or
they're gonna like suck logs from the
other accounts put it in one place and
help us to monitor so as you see you
have cloud watch here that actually
tracks the metrics you can also use
cloud trail if you wanna log api calls
as well push them in an s3 bucket so
there are different types of blog flow
logs are getting captured in an instance
application logs are getting captured
from the same vpc from a different vpc
from the same account from a different
account and all of them are analyzed
using elasticsearch using the kibana
client
so step one is to deploy the ecs cluster
step two is to restrict access to the
ecs cluster because it's valid data you
don't want anybody to put their hands
and access their data so resting access
to the ecs dashboard and we could use
lambda also to push the uh data from
cloud watch to the elasticsearch domain
and then kibana is actually the
graphical tool that helps us to
visualize the logs instead of looking at
log as just statements or in a bunch of
characters a bunch of files kibana helps
us to analyze the logs in a graphical or
a chart or a bar diagram format again in
an interview the interview is more
concerned about testing your knowledge
on aw security products especially on
the logging monitoring even management
or incident management then you could
have a question like this what are the
native aws security logging capabilities
now most of the services have their own
logging in them like have their own
logging like s3 s3 has its own login and
cloudfront has its own logging ds has
its own login vpc has its own login in
additional there are account level
logins like a cloudtrail and aws config
services so there are variety of logging
options available in the aws like cloud
trail config cloudfront redshift logging
rds logging vpc flow logs s3 object
logging s3 access logging stuff like
that so we're going to look at two
servers in specific cloud trail now this
cloud trail the very first product in
that picture we just thought the cloud
trail provides an very high level
history of the api calls for all the
account and with that we can actually
perform a very good security analysis a
security analysis of our account and
these logs are actually delivered to you
can configure it they can be delivered
to s3 for long time archivals and based
on a particular event it can also send
an email notification to us saying hey
just got this error thought i'll let you
know stuff like that the other one is
config service a config service helps us
to understand the configuration changes
that happened in our environment and we
can also set up notifications based on
the configuration changes so it records
the cumulative changes that are made in
a short period of time so if you want to
go through the lifetime of a particular
resource what are the things that happen
what are the things it went through they
can be looked at using aws config
all right the other question you could
get asked is if uh you know your role
includes taking care of cloud security
as well then the other question you
could get asked is the native services
that amazon provides
to mitigate ddos which is denial of
service now not all companies would go
with amazon native services but there
are some companies which want to stick
with amazon native services just to save
them from the headache of managing the
other softwares or bringing in another
tool a third-party tool into managing
ddos they simply want to stick with
amazon proprietary amazon native
services and a lot of companies are
using amazon service to prevent ddos
denial of service now denial of service
is if you already know what denial of
service is well and good if you do not
know then let's know it now denial of
service is a user trying to or
maliciously making attempt to access a
website or an application the user would
actually create multiple sessions and he
would occupy all the sessions and he
would not let legitimate users access
the servers so he's in turn denying the
service for the user a quick picture
review of
what denial of services now look at it
these users instead of making one
connection they are making multiple
connections and there are cheap software
programs available that would actually
trigger connections from different
computers in the internet with different
mac addresses so everything kind of
looks legitimate for the server and it
would accept those connections and it
would keep the sessions open the actual
users won't be able to use them so
that's denying the service for the
actual users denial of service all right
and distributed denial of service is
generating attacks from multiple places
you know from a distributed environment
so that's distributed denial of service
so the tools the native tools that helps
us to prevent the denial of service
attacks in aws is cloud shield
and web access firewall aw swap now they
are the major ones they are designed to
mitigate a denial of service if your
website is often bothered by denial of
service then we should be using aw
shield or aws vaf and there are a couple
of other tools that also does when i say
that also does denial of service is not
their primary job but you could use them
for denial of service route 53's purpose
is to provide dns cloudfront is to
provide caching elastic load balancer
elbs work is to provide load balancing
vpc is to create and secure a virtual
private environment but they also
support mitigating denial of service but
not to the extent you would get in aws
shield and aws web so aws shield and
waff are the primary ones but the rest
can also be used to mitigate distributed
denial of service the other tricky
question is
this actually will test your familiarity
with the region and the services
available in the region so when you're
trying to provision a service in a
particular region you're not seeing the
service in that region how do we go
about fixing it or how do we go about
using the service in the cloud it's a
tricky question and if you have not gone
through such situation you can totally
blow it away you really need to have a
good understanding on regions the
services available in those regions and
what if a particular service is not
available how to go about doing it the
answer is not all services are available
in all regions anytime amazon announces
a new service they don't immediately
publish them on all regions they start
small and as in when the traffic
increases as and when it becomes more
likable to the customers they actually
move the service to different regions so
as you see in this picture within
america north virginia has more services
compared to ohio or compared to north
california so within not america itself
north virginia is the preferred one so
similarly there are preferred regions
within europe middle east and africa and
preferred regions within asia pacific so
anytime we don't see a service in a
particular region chances that the
service is not available in that region
yet we got to check the documentation
and find the nearest region that offers
that service and start using the service
from that region now you might think
well if i'm looking for a service in
asia let's say in mumbai and if it is
not available why not simply switch to
north virginia and start using it you
could but you know that's going to add
more latency to your application so
that's why we need to check for
application which is check for region
which is very near to the place where
you want to serve your customers and
find nearest region instead of always
going back to north virginia and
deploying an application in north
virginia again there's your place
there's a link in aws.com that you can
go and look for services available in
different region and that's exactly what
you're seeing here and if your service
is not available in a particular region
switch to the other region that provides
your service the nearest other region
that provides that service and start
using service from there
with the uh coming up of cloud a lot of
companies have turned down their
monitoring team instead they want to go
with the monitorings that cloud provides
you know nobody wants to or at least
many people don't want to go through the
hassle of at least new startups and new
companies that are thinking of having a
monitoring environment that they don't
want to go with traditional knock
monitoring instead they would like to
leverage aws monitorings available
because it monitors a lot of stuff not
just the availability but it monitors a
lot of stuff like failures errors it
also triggers emails stuff like that so
how do you actually set up a monitor to
website
how to set up a monitor to monitor the
website metrics in real time in aws the
simple way anytime you have a question
about monitoring cloud watch should
strike your mind because cloudwatch is
meant for monitoring is meant for
collecting metrics is meant for
providing graphical representation of
what's going on in a particular network
at a particular point of time so
cloudwatch cloudwatch helps us to
monitor applications and using
cloudwatch we can monitor the state
changes not only the state changes the
auto scaling life cycle events anytime
there are there are more services added
there is a reduction in the number of
servers because of less usage and very
informative messages can be received
through cloud watch any cloud watch can
now support scheduled events if you want
to schedule anything cloudwatch has an
event that would schedule an action
right schedule a trigger time based not
incident based you know anything
happening and then you get an action
happening that's incident based on the
other hand you can simply schedule a few
things on time based so that's possible
with cloud watch so this cloud watch
integrates very well with a lot of other
services like notifications for
notifying the user or for notifying the
administrator about it and it can
integrate well with lambda so to trigger
an action anytime you are designing an
auto healing environment this cloud
watch can actually monitor and send an
email if we are integrating it with sns
simple notification service or this
cloud watch can monitor and based on
what's happening it can trigger an event
in lambda and that would in turn run a
function till the environment comes back
to normal so cloudwatch integrates well
with a lot of other aw services
all right so cloudwatch has
three statuses green when everything is
going good yellow when the service is
degraded and red when the service is not
available green is good so we don't have
to do anything about it but anytime
there's an ello the picture that we're
looking at it's actually calling and a
lambda function to debug the application
and to fix it and anytime there's a red
alert it immediately notifies the owner
of the application about well the
service is down and here is the report
that i have here is the metrics that
i've collected about the service stuff
like that if the job role requires you
to manage the servers as well there are
certain job roles which are on the
system side there are certain job roles
which is development plus system side
now you're responsible for the
application and the server as well so if
that's the case you might be tested with
some basic questions like the different
types of virtualization and aws and what
are the difference between them all
right the three major types of
virtualization are
hvm which is hardware virtual machine
the other one is pv para virtualization
and the third one is pv on hvm para
virtualization on hardware virtual
module
all right the difference between them or
actually describing them is actually the
difference between them hvm it's
actually a fully virtualized hardware
you know the whole hardware is
virtualized and all virtual machines act
separate from each other and these vms
are booted by executing master boot
record in the root block and when we
talk about para virtualization para grub
is actually the special boot loader
which boots the pva mis and when we talk
about pv on hvm it's it's actually the
marriage between hvm and pv and this
para virtualization on hvm in other
words pv on hvm it actually helps
operating system take advantage in
storage and the network input output
available through the host another good
question is name some of the services
that are not region specific now
you've been thought that all services
are within a region and some services
are within an availability zone for
example ec2 is within an availability
zone ebs is within an availability zone
s3 is region specific dynamodb is region
specific stuff like that vpc is both
availability and
region specific meaning you know subnets
are availability zone specific and vpcs
region specific stuff like that so you
might have thought you might have
learned in that combination but there
could be some tricky questions that
tests you how well you have understood
the region non-region and availability
non-availability services i should say
there are services that are not region
specific that would be iam so we can't
have
for every availability zone and for
every region which means you know users
will have to use one username and
password for one region and anytime they
switch to another region they will have
to use another username and password
that that's more work and that's not a
good design as well authentication has
to be global so im is a global service
and which means it's not region specific
on the other hand route 53 is again a
regional specific so we can't have a
route 53 for every region route 53 is
not a region specific service it's a
global service and it's one application
users access from everywhere or from
every part of the world so we can't have
one url or one dns name for each region
if your application is a global
application and then web application
firewall works well with cloudfront then
cloudfront is a region based service so
the web application firewall it's not
region specific service it's a global
service and cloudfront is again a global
service though you can
you know cache content on a continent
and country basis it's still considered
a global service right it's not bound to
any region so when you activate cloud
front you're activating it away from
region or availability zone so when
you're activating a web application
firewall because it's not a
region-specific service you're
activating it away from availability
zone and regions
so a quick recap i am users groups roles
and accounts they are global services
they can be used globally all 53
services are offered at edge locations
and they are global as well web
application firewall a service that
protects our web application from common
web exploits they are global service as
well cloudfront cloudfront is global
content delivery network cdn and they
are offered at edge locations which are
a global service in other words
non-region specific service or beyond
region service all right this is another
good question as well in the project
that you are being interviewed if they
really want to secure their environment
using nat or if they are already
securing their environment using nat by
any of these two methods like nat
gateway or nat instances you can expect
this question what are the difference
between a nat gateway and that instances
now they both saw the same thing right
so they're not two different services
trying to achieve two different things
they both serve the same thing but still
they do have differences in them right
on a high level they both achieve
providing netting for the service behind
it but the difference comes when we talk
about
the availability of it that gateway is a
managed service by amazon whereas nat
instance is managed by us now i'm
talking about the third point
maintenance here nat gateway is managed
by amazon that instance is managed by us
and availability of nat gateway is very
high and availability of that instance
is
less compared to the nat gateway because
it's managed by us you know it's on an
ec2 instance which could actually fail
and if it fails we'll have to relaunch
it but if it is not gateway if something
happens to that service amazon would
take care of reprovisioning it and
talking about bandwidth it can burst up
to 75 gigabits now traffic through the
net gateway can burst up to 75 gigabits
but for that instance it actually
depends on the server that we launched
and if we are launching a t2 micro it
barely gets any bandwidth so there's a
difference there and the performance
because it's highly available because of
the bigger pipe 75 gigabits now the
performance of the nat gateway is very
high but the performance of the nat
instance is going to be average again it
depends on the size of the nat instance
that we pick and billing a billing for
nat gateway is the number of gateways
that we provision and the duration for
which we use the nat gateway but billing
for that instance is number of instance
and the type of instance that we use of
course number of instance duration and
the type of instance that we use
security in that gateway cannot be uh
assigned meaning it already comes with
full packed security but in that
instance security is a bit customizable
i can go and change the security because
such a server managed by me or managed
by us i can always change the security
well allow this allow don't allow this
stuff like that size and load of the
night gateway is uniform but the size
and the load of the uh that instance
changes as per an ad gateway is a fixed
product but not instance can be small
instance can be a big instance so the
size and the load through it varies
right the other question you could get
asked is what are the difference between
stopping and terminating an ec2 instance
now you'll be able to answer only if you
have worked on environments where you
have your instance stopped and where you
have your instance terminated if you
have only used lab
and are attending the interview chances
are that you might you always lost when
answering this question it might look
like both are the same well stopping and
terminating both are the same but there
is a difference in it so when you stop
an instance it actually performs a
normal shutdown on the instance and it
simply moves the instance to the stopped
state but when you actually terminate
the instance the instance is moved to
this stop state the ebs volumes that are
attached to it are deleted and removed
and we'll never be able to recover them
again so that's a big difference between
stopping and terminating an instance if
you're thinking of using the instance
again along with the data in it you
should only be thinking of stopping the
instance but you should be terminating
the instance only if you want to get rid
of that instance forever
if you are being interviewed for an
architect level position or a junior
architect level position or even a cloud
consultant level position or even in an
engineering position this is a very
common question that gets asked what are
the different types of easy two
instances based on their cost or based
on how we pay them all right they're all
compute capacity for example the
different types are on demand instances
spot instances and reserved instances it
kind of looks the same they all provide
the compute capacity they all provide
the same type of hardwares for us but if
you are looking at cost saving or
optimizing cost in our environment we
got to be very careful about which one
are we picking now we might think that
well i'll go with on demand instance
because i pay on a per hour basis which
is cheap you know i can use them anytime
i want and anytime i don't want i can
simply get rid of it by terminating it
you're right but if the requirement is
to use the service for one year the
requirement is to use the service for
three years then you'll be wasting a lot
of money buying on-demand instances
you'll be wasting a lot of money paying
on an hourly basis instead we should be
going for reserved instance where we can
reserve the capacity for the complete
one year or complete three years and
save huge amount in buying reserved
instances all right so on demand is
cheap to start with if you're only
planning to use it for a short while but
if you're planning to run it for a long
while then we should be going for
reserved instance that is what is cost
efficient so spot instance is cheaper
than on-demand instance and there are
different use cases for spot instance as
well so let's look at one after the
other the on-demand instance the
on-demand instance is purchased at a
fixed rate per r this is very short-term
and irregular workloads and for testing
for development on demand instance is a
very good use case we should be using
on-demand for production spot instance
spot instance allows users to purchase
ec2 at a reduced price and anytime we
have more instances we can always go and
sell it in spot instances i'm referring
to any time we have more reserved
instances we can always sell them in
spot instance catalog and the way we buy
spot instance is we actually put a
budget this is how much i'm willing to
pay all right would you be able to give
service within this cost so anytime the
price comes down and meets the cost that
we have put in will be assigned an
instance and anytime the price shoots up
the instance will be taken away from us
but in case of on-demand instances we
have bought that instance for that
particular r and it stays with us but
with spot instances it varies based on
the price if you meet the price you get
the instance if you don't meet the price
goes away to somebody else and the spot
instance availability is actually based
on supply and demand in the market
there's no guarantee that you will get
spot instance at all time all right so
that's a caveat there you should be
familiar with that's a caveat that you
should be aware when you are proposing
somebody that we can go for spot
instance and save money it's not always
going to be available if you want your
spot instance to be available to you
then we need to carefully watch the
history of the price of the spot
instance now how much was it last month
then how much was it how much is it this
month so how can i quote or how much can
i code stuff like that so you got to
look at those history before you propose
somebody that well we're going to save
money using spot instance on the other
hand reserved instance provide cost
savings for the company we can opt for
reserved instances for you know one year
or three years there are actually three
types of reserved instances light medium
and heavy reserved instances they are
based on the amount that we would be
paying and cost benefit also depends
with reserved instance the cost benefit
also depends based on are we doing all
upfront or no upfront or partial payment
then split the rest as monthly payments
so there are many purchase options
available but overall if you're looking
at using an application for the next one
year and three years you should not be
going for on-demand instance you should
be going for reserved instance and
that's what gives you the cost benefit
and in an adapter's interview sometimes
you might be asked you know how you
interact with the aws environment are
you using cli are you using console and
depending on your answer whether console
or a cli the panelist put a score okay
this person is cli specific this person
is console specific or this person has
used aws environment through the sdk
stuff like that so this question tests
whether you are a cli person or an
console person and the question goes
like this how do you set up ssh agent
forwarding so that you do not have to
copy the key every time you log in if
you have used puri anytime if you want
to log into an ec2 instance you will
have to put the ip and the port number
along with that you will have to map or
we will have to map the key in the puri
and this has to be done every time
that's what we would have done in our
lab environments right but in production
environment using the same key or
mapping the same key again and again
every time it's actually an hassle it's
considered as a blocker so you might
want to cache it you might want to
permanently add it in your putty session
so you can immediately log in and start
using it so here in the place where you
would actually map the private key
there's a quick button that actually
fixes or that actually binds your ssh to
your putty instance so we can enable ssh
agent forwarding that will actually bind
our key to the ssh and next time when we
try to log in you don't have to always
go through mapping the key and trying to
log in all right this question what are
solaris and ax operating systems are
they available with aws that question
generally gets asked to test how
familiar are you with the
amis available how familiar are you with
ec2 how familiar are you with the ec2
hardwares available that basically test
that now the first question or the first
thought that comes to your mind is well
everything is available with aws i've
seen windows i've seen ubuntu i've seen
red hat i've seen amazon amis and if i
don't see my operating system there i
can always go to marketplace and try
them if i don't find a marketplace i can
always go to community and try them so a
lot of amis available that lot of
operating systems available i will be
able to find solaris and ax but that's
not the case solaris and ax are not
available with aws that's because
solaris uses a different and solaris
does not support the architecture does
not support public cloud currently the
same goes for ax as well and they run on
power cpu and not on intel and as of now
amazon does not provide power machines
this should not be confused with the hpc
which is a high performance computing
should not be confused with that now
these are different hardwares different
cpu itself that the cloud providers did
do not provide yet another question you
could get asked in organizations that
would want to automate their
infrastructure using amazon native
services would be how do you actually
recover an ec2 instance or auto recover
an ec2 instance when it fails well we
know that ec2 instances are considered
as immutable meaning irreparable we
don't spend time fixing
bugs in an os stuff like that you know
once
an ec2 instance crashes like it goes on
a ospanic or there are various reasons
why it would fail so we don't have to
really worry about fixing it we can
always relaunch that instance and that
would fix it but what if it happens at
two o'clock in the night what if it
happens that during a weekend when
nobody's in office
looking or monitoring those instances so
you would want to automate that not only
on a weekend or during midnight but it's
general practice good to automate it so
you could face this question how do you
actually automate an ec2 instance once
it fails and the answer to that question
is using cloudwatch we can recover the
instance so as you see there is an alarm
threshold a set in cloud watch and once
the threshold is met meaning if there is
an error if there is a failure if the
ec2 instance is not responding for a
certain while we can set an alarm and
once the alarm is met let's say the cpu
utilization stayed high for five minutes
all right it's not taking any new
connections or the instance is not
pinging for five minutes or in this case
it's two minutes it's not pinging so
it's not going to respond connection so
in those cases you would want to
automatically recover that ec2 instance
by rebooting the instance all right now
look at this the take this action
section under the action so there we
have a bunch of options like recover
this instance meaning reboot the
instance so that's how we would recover
the other two options are beyond the
scope of the question but still you can
go ahead and apply just like i'm gonna
do it so the other option is stop the
instance that's very useful when you
want to stop instances that are having
low utilizations nobody's using the
system as of now you don't want them to
be running and wasting the cloud
expenditure so you can actually set an
alarm that stops the ec2 instance that's
having low utilization so somebody was
working in an instance and they left it
without or they forgot to shut down that
instance and it gets i mean they will
only use it again the next day morning
so in between there could be like 12
hours that the system is running idle
nobody's using it and you're paying for
it so you can identify such instances
and actually stop them when the cpu
utilization is low meaning nobody is
using it the other one is to terminate
let's say you want to give system to
somebody temporarily and you don't want
them to hand the system back to you
right this is actually an idea in other
words this is actually the scenario so
you hand over a system to somebody and
when they're done they're done we can
actually terminate the system so you
could instruct the other person to
terminate the system when they're done
and they could forget and the instance
could be running forever or you can
monitor the system after the specified
time is over and you can terminate the
system or best part you can automate the
system termination so you assign a
system to somebody and then turn on this
cloud watch action to terminate the
instance when the cpu is low for like
two hours meaning they've already left
or cpu is low for 30 minutes meaning
they've already left stuff like that so
that's possible and if you're getting
hired for an uh system side architect or
even on the sysop site you could face
this question what are the common and
different types of ami designs there are
a lot of ami designs the question is the
common ones and the difference between
them so the common ones are the full
back a mice and the other one is just
enough os ami j e os ami and the other
one is hybrid type amis so let's look at
the difference between them the full
backed ami just like the name says it's
fully baked it's uh ready to use ami and
this is the simplest ami to deploy can
be a bit expensive it can be a bit
cumbersome because you'll have to do a
lot of work beforehand you could use the
ami so a lot of planning a lot of
thought process will go into it and the
ami is ready to use right you hand over
the ami to somebody and it's ready to
use or if you want to reuse the ami it's
already ready for you to use so that's
full baked ami the other one is just
enough operating system ami just like
the name says
it has i mean as you can also see in the
diagram or in the picture it covers a
part of the os all bootstraps are
already packed properly and the security
monitoring logging and the other stuff
are configured at the time of deployment
or at the time you would be using it so
not much thought process will go in here
the only focus is on choosing the
operating system and what goes the
operating system specific agents or
bootstraps that goes into the operating
system that's all we worry about the
advantage of this is it's flexible
meaning you can choose to install
additional softwares at the time of
deploying but that's going to require an
additional expertise on the person who
will be using the ami so that's another
overhead there but the advantage is that
it's kind of flexible i can change the
configurations during the time of
deployment the other one is the hybrid
ami now the hybrid ami actually falls in
between the fully baked ami and just
enough operating system options so these
amis have some features of the big type
and some features of the just enough os
type so as you see the security
monitoring logging
are
packed in that ami and the runtime
environments are installed during the
time of a deployment so this is where
the strict company policies would go
into the ami company policies like you
got to lock this you got to monitor this
these are the ports that generally gets
open in all the systems stuff like that
so they strictly go into the ami and
sits in an ami format and during
deployment you have the flexibility of
choosing the different runtime and the
application that sits in an ec2 instance
another very famous question you would
face in an interview is how can you
recover login to an ec2 instance to
which you lost the key well we know that
if the key is lost we can't recover it
there are some organizations that
integrate their ec2 instances with an 80
that's different all right so you can go
and reset the password and the 80 and
you will be able to log into the new
password but here the specific tricky
question is you are using a key to log
in and how do you recover if you have
lost the key generally companies would
have made a backup of the key so we can
pick from the backup but here the
specific question is we have lost the
key literally no backups on the key at
all so how can we log in and we know
that we can't log into the instance
without the key present with us so the
steps to recover is that make the
instance use another key and use that
key to log in once the key is lost it's
lost forever we won't be able to recover
it you can't raise the ticket with
amazon not possible they're not going to
help it's beyond the scope so make the
instance use another key it's only the
key that's the problem you still have
valid data in it you got to recover the
data it's just the key that's having the
problem so we can actually focus on the
key part alone and change the key and
that will allow us to log in so how do
we do it step by step procedure so first
verify the ec2 config service is running
in that instance if you want you can
actually beforehand install the ec2
config in that service or you can
actually make the ec2 config run through
the console just a couple of button
clicks and that will make the easy to
configure run in that ec2 instance and
then detach the root volume for that
instance of course it's going to require
a stop and start to detach the root
volume from the instance attach the root
volume to another instance as a
temporary volume or it could be a
temporary instance that you've launched
only to fix this issue and then login to
that instance and to that particular
volume and modify the configuration file
configuration file modify it to use the
new key and then move the root volume
back to its original position and
restart the instance and now the
instance is going to have the new key
and you also have the new key with which
you can log in so that's how we go ahead
and fix it now let's move on to some
product specific or s3 product specific
questions a general perception is s3 and
ebs can be used interchangeably and the
interviewer would want to test your
knowledge on s3 and evs well ebs uses s3
that's true but they can't be
interchangeably used so you might face
this question what are some key
differences between aws s3 and ebs well
the differences are s3 is an object
store meaning you can't install anything
in it you can store drive files but you
can't actually install in it it's not a
file system but ebs is a file system you
can install services i mean install
applications in it and that's gonna run
stuff like that and talking about
performance s3 is much faster and ebs is
super faster when accessing from the
instance because from the instance if
you need to access s3 you'll actually
have to go out through the internet and
access the s3 or s3 is an external
service very external service you'll
have to go through or you'll have to go
outside of your vpc to access s3 s3 does
not come under a vpc but ebs comes under
a vpc it's on the same vpc so you would
be able to use it kind of locally
compared to s3 ebs is very local
so that way it's going to be faster and
redundancy talking about redundancy of
s3 and ebs s3 is replicated the data in
s3 is replicated across the data centers
but ebs is replicated within the data
center meaning s3 is replicated across
availability zones ebs is within an
availability zone so that way the
redundancy is a bit less in ebs in other
words bluetooth nc is higher in s3 than
eps and talking about security of s3 is3
can be made private as well as public
meaning anybody can access s3 from
anywhere in the internet that's possible
with s3 but ebs can only only be
accessed when attached to an ec2
instance right just one instance can
access it whereas s3 is publicly
directly accessible the other question
related to s3 security is how do you
allow access to a user to assert in a
user to a certain bucket which means
this user is not having access to s3 at
all but this user needs to be given
access to a certain bucket how do we do
it the same case applies to servers as
well in few cases there could be an
instance where a person is new to the
team and you actually don't want them to
access the production service now he is
in the production group and by default
he or she is granted access to that
server but you specifically want to deny
access to that production server till
the time he or she is matured enough to
access or understand the process
understand the do's and don'ts before
they can put their hands on the
production server so how do we go about
doing it so first we would categorize
our instances well these are critical
instances these are normal instances and
we would actually put a tag on them
that's how we categorize right so you
put attack on them put attack saying
well they are highly critical they are
medium critical and they are not
critical at all still there in
production stuff like that and then you
would pick the users who wants to or who
should be or should not be given access
to a certain server and you would
actually allow the user to access or not
access servers based on a specific tag
in other words you can use actually tags
in in the previous step we put tags on
the critical server right so you would
define that this user is not going to
use this tag all right this user is not
allowed to use the resources with this
stack so that's how you would make your
step forward so you would allow or deny
based on the tags that you have put so
in this case he or she will not be
allowed to servers which are tagged
critical servers so that's how you allow
deny access to them and the same goes
for bucket as well or if an organization
is excessively using s3 for their data
storage because of the benefit that it
provides the cost and the
durability you might get asked this
question which is organizations would
replicate the data from one region to
another region for additional data
durability and for having data
redundancy not only for that they would
also do that for dr purposes for
disaster recovery if the whole region is
down you still have the data available
somewhere else and you can pick and use
it some organizations would store data
in different regions for compliance
reasons to provide low latency access to
their users
who are local to that region stuff like
that so when companies do replication
how do you make sure that there is
consistency in the replication how do
you make sure that the replication is
not failing and the data gets
transferred for sure and there are logs
for that replication this is something
that the companies would use where
they're excessively using s3 and they're
fully relying on the replication in
running their business
and the way we could do it is we can set
up a replication monitor it's actually a
set of tools that we could use together
to make sure that the cloud replication
a region level replication is happening
properly so this is how it happens now
on this side on the left hand side we
have the region one and on the right
hand side we have region two and region
one is the source bucket and region two
is the destination bucket right so
object is put in the source bucket and
it has to go directly to the region to
bucket or or made a copy in the region
to bucket and the problem is sometimes
it fails and there is no consistency
between them so the way you would do it
is connect these services together and
create and cross replication or cross
region replication monitor that actually
monitors that actually monitors your
environment so there are cloud watts
that make sure that the data is uh moved
no data is failing again there's cloud
watch on the other end make sure that
the data is moving and then we have the
logs generated through cloudtrail and
that's actually written in dynamodb and
if there is an error if something is
failing you get notified through an sms
or you get notified through an email
using the sns service so that's how we
could leverage these tools and set up
and cross region replication monitor
that actually monitors your data
replication
some common issues that company
companies face in vpc is that we all
know that i can use route 53 to resolve
an ip address externally from the
internet but by default the servers
won't connect to the other servers using
our custom dns name that does not do
that by default so it's actually a
problem there are some additional things
that as an administrator or as an
architect or as a person who uses it you
will have to do and that's what we're
going to discuss so the question could
be a vpc is not resolving the server
through the dns you can access it
through the ip but not through the dns
name and what could be the issue and how
do you go about fixing it and you will
be able to answer this question only if
you have done it already it's a quick
and simple step by default vpc does not
allow that's the default feature and we
will have to enable the
dns hostname resolution before
now this is for the custom dns not for
the default dns that comes along this is
for the custom dns so we will have to
enable the dns host name resolution so
our will have to enable dns hostname
resolution so they actually resolve
let's say i want to connect to a
server1.simplylearn.com by default it's
not allowed but if i enable this option
then i will be able to connect to server
1 simplylearn.com
if a company has vpcs in different
regions and they have a head office in a
central place and the rest of them are
branch offices and they are connecting
to the head office for access or you
know for saving data or for accessing
certain files or certain data or storing
data
all right so they would actually mimic
the hubban spoke topology where you have
the vpc which is centrally in an
accessible region a centrally accessible
region and then you would have a local
vpcs or branch offices in different
other regions and they get connected to
the vpc in the central location and the
question is how do you actually connect
the multiple sites to a vpc and make
communication happen between them by
default it does not do that we know that
vpcs they need to be paired between them
in order to access the resources let's
look at this picture right so i have
like a customer network or branch
offices in different parts and they get
connected to a vpc that's fine so what
we have achieved is those different
offices
the remote offices they are connecting
to the vpc and they're talking but they
can't connect or they can't talk to each
other that's what we have built but the
requirement is the traffic
needs to or they should be able to talk
to each other but they should not have
direct connection between them which
means that they will have to come and
hit the vpc and then reach the other
customer network which is in los angeles
or which is in new york all right that's
the requirement so that's possible with
some architecting in the cloud so that's
using vpn cloud hub you look at this
dotted lines which actually allows
customers or which actually allows the
corporate networks to talk to each other
through the vpc again by default it
doesn't happen cloud hub is an
architecture that we should be using to
make this happen and what's the
advantage of it as a central office or
as the headquarters office which is in
the vpc or headquarters data center
which is in the vpc you have control or
the vpz has control on who talks to who
and what traffic can talk to i mean what
traffic can be routed to the other head
office stuff like that that centralized
control is on the vpc the other question
you could get asked is never explain
some security products and features
available in vpc well vpc itself is an
security service it provides security
service to the application but how do
you actually secure the vpc itself
that's the question and yes there are
products that can actually secure the
vpc or the vpc delivers those products
to secure the application
access to the vpc is restricted through
a network access control list all right
so that's and security product in vpc
and a vpc has security groups that
protects the instances from unwanted
inbound and outbound traffic and network
access control list protects the subnets
from unwanted inbound and outbound
access and there are flow logs we can
capture in vpc
that captures incoming and outgoing
traffic through a vpc which will be used
for later analysis as in what's the
traffic pattern what's the behavior of
the traffic pattern and stuff like that
so there are some security products and
features available in vpc now how do you
monitor vpc vpc is a very important
concept very important service as well
everything sits in a vpc most of the
service sits in a vpc except for lambda
and s3 and dynamodb and couple of other
services most of them sit in a vpc for
security reason so how do you monitor
your vpc how do you gain some visibility
on your vpc well we can gain visibility
on our vpc using vpc flow log that's the
basic service as you see it actually
captures what's allowed what's not
allowed stuff like that which ip's
allowed which ip is not allowed stuff
like that so we can gather it and we can
use that for analysis and the other one
is cloud watch and cloud watch logs the
data transfers that happen so this is
you know who gets allowed and who does
not get allowed i mean the flow logs is
who is allowed and who's not allowed
that kind of detail and cloud watch
gives information about the data
transfer how much data is getting
transferred we can actually
pick unusual data transfers if there is
a sudden hike in the graph there's a
sudden hike and something happens at 12
on a regular basis and you weren't
expecting it there's something
suspicious it could be valid backups it
could be a malicious activity as well so
that's how you know by looking at
cloudwatch logs and cloudwatch dashboard
now let's talk about multiple choice
questions when going for an interview
you might sometimes find yourself that
the company is conducting an online test
based on the score they can put you to a
panelist and then they would take it
forward so we thought we'll also include
multiple choice questions to help you
better handle such situation if you come
across all right when you find yourself
in such situation the key to clear them
is to understand the question properly
read between the lines that's what they
say you know there can be like a big
paragraph with three lines or ten lines
you really got to understand what the
question is about and then try to find
answer for that question so that's a
thumb rule number one and then the
second rule is try to compare and
contrast the services
mentioned or try to compare and contrast
the answers you can easily read out one
or two answers and then you will be left
with only two answers to decide from you
know so that also helps you with time
and that's all that also helps you with
some precision in your answer so number
one read between the lines number two
compare and contrast the services and
you'll be able to easily weed out the
wrong ones so let's try answering this
question suppose you are a game designer
and you want to develop a game with a
single digit millisecond latency which
of the following database services would
you choose so we know that the following
are database services are good enough
all right and it talks about millisecond
latency that's a key point and the third
thing is it's a game it could be a
mobile game it's a game that you are
trying to design and you need uh
millisecond latency and it has to be a
database all right so let's talk about
the options available rds rds is a
database for sure is it good for
game design we'll come back to that
neptune
neptune is a graph a database service in
amazon so that's kind of out of the
equation and snowball is actually a
storage right it's it's a transport
medium i would say so that's again out
of the equation so the tie is between
rds and dynamodb if we need to talk
about rds rds is an a platform as a
service it provides cost efficient
resizable capacity but it's an sql
database meaning the tables are kind of
strict you know it's good for banking
and other type of applications but not
really good for anything that has to do
with the gaming so the only option left
is dynamodb again it's the right answer
dynamodb is actually an fast and
flexible nosql database service and it
provides a single digit millisecond
latency at any scale and it's a database
at the same time it's a key value store
model database so the right answer is
dynamodb all right let's look at the
next question if you need to perform
real-time monitoring of aws services and
get actionable insights which service
would you use
all right let's list the services so
talks about real-time monitoring a
firewall manager what does it provide
now firewall manager is not really a
monitor just like the name says it's a
manager it manages multiple firewalls
and aws guard duty is an threat
detection service it does monitoring it
does continuously monitor our
environment but it monitors for threats
all right only threats now let's talk
about cloud watch a cloud watch is a
service that
helps to track metrics it's a service
that is used
to
monitor the environment and give us a
system-wide visibility and also it helps
us to store logs so at the moment it
kind of looks like that could be the
right answer we don't know that yet but
i mean we have one more option left
that's uh ebs so what's ebs ebs is a
block storage elastic block store if we
abbreviate ebs it's elastic block store
so all three of them are easily out of
the question the first one is to manage
second one is to find threads of course
it does monitoring so there's i mean if
there is one relation between cloud
watch and god duty that's monitoring so
easily we can actually find ourselves
slipped towards picking god duty but
know that god duty is only for gaining
security insight but not about gaining
aws service inside so cloudwatch is a
service that helps us to get a system
wide or an aws wide or an account wide
and it has number of metrics we can
monitor and get a very good insight of
how a service is performing be it cpu be
it ram beat network utilization beat
connection failures cloud watch is a
service that helps us perform a
real-time monitoring and get some
actionable insights on the services all
right let's talk about this 33rd
question as a web developer you are
developing an app especially for the
mobile platform all right there is a
mention that this is especially for the
mobile platform so a lot of services
gets filtered out mobile platform right
which of the following lets you add user
sign up sign in and access control to
your web and mobile app quickly and
easily alright so this is all about
signing in to your mobile app so if we
need to read between the lines that's
how we can read sign up or sign in into
a mobile platform all right so we have
like four options here shield aws massey
aws inspector amazon cognito so let's
try to weed out services which are not
relevant to it so what's aws shield aws
shield is actually a service that
provides a ddos mitigation or ddos
protection denial of service protection
it's a security feature let's talk about
the second option aws maxi is again a
security service that uses machine
learning to automatically discover and
classify the data it again talks about
security and this security is all about
encrypting or saving the data does not
come close with signing up and mobile
platform all right let's talk about the
other one aws inspector now aws
inspector has something to do with apps
it definitely has something to do with
apps so kind of looks like that's
relevant as of now so it actually helps
with
improving the security and compliance of
the apps that we deploy in the cloud so
kind of looks like it could be because
it has to do with apps the last one
cognito now cognito is a service that
actually lets the administrator to have
control access over web and mobile apps
and it's a service that helps us to sign
up and
sign in to an mobile and web app so that
very much looks like we found the answer
so cognito is a service that helps web
app and mobile app for sign up and
signing in and also gives the
administrator to have control over who
has i mean access control over the web
and the mobile app pretty much we found
it so it's cognito cognito is a service
that helps us to set up sign up sign in
and have access control over the users
who would be using our mobile and web
app all right how about this question
you are an ml engineer or a machine
learning engineer who is on the lookout
for a solution that will discover
sensitive information that your
enterprise stores in aws and then uses
nlp to classify that data and provide
business related insights which among
the following services would you choose
so we have a bunch of services that's
going to help us achieve or one of it is
going to help us achieve the about
requirement so it's a service that deals
with machine learning you're a machine
learning engineer who is looking for a
service that
will help you to discover information at
your enterprise store so we're talking
about storage discover information in
store and then classify uh the data
depending on severity the sensitivity
classify the data so which service is
that so firewall manager just like the
name says it's a manager and the aws iam
if we abbreviate it it's a identity and
access management so it's identity and
access management nothing to do with
identifying sensitive data and managing
it so the first two is already out of
the equation and then the aw is massey
we already had a quick
definition description for aws massey
that it's actually a security service
that uses machine learning it kind of
looks like it could be it it's a
security service that uses machine
learning and it discovers and classifies
the sensitive information not only that
it does not stop there it goes beyond
and protects the sensitive data aws
massey kind of looks like but we still
have one more option to look at which is
cloud hms cloud hms is also a security
service kind of looks like that could be
the answer as well and it enables us to
generate encryption keys and save the
data so kind of fifty percent of it it's
a security service it encrypts helps us
protect the data but aws maxi is right
on spot it's a machine learning service
it helps us to classify the data and
also to protect the data so the answer
for this question would be aws messy so
hope you kind of get it how this is
going so first we apply the thumb rule
identify the question that's being asked
read between the lines and then try to
find the service that meets your
requirement then finding the service is
by first weeding out the wrong ones
recollect everything that you've learned
about the service and see how well that
matches with those hints that you have
picked up and if that doesn't match weed
that out then you'll end up with two
just to to decide from at some point and
then it becomes easy for you to decide
click on the question submit it and then
move on to the other question in your
interview all right so how about this
one you are a system administrator in
your company which is running most of
its infrastructure on aws you are
required to
track your users and keep a look on how
your users are being authenticated all
right so this is where the problem
statement starts but you need to keep
track of how your users are being
authenticated and you wish to create and
manage aws users and use permissions to
allow and deny their access to the aws
resources right so you are to give them
permission number one and then i mean if
we put them in the right order first
giving them permissions and then
tracking their usage let's see which of
the service will help us achieve it iam
is a service that
helps us to
looking at the permissions we can
actually predict whether the user or the
group will have servers or not so that
helps us to get a track of who is able
to use who's not able to use certain
servers and all that stuff so it kind of
looks like but we have other three
options left let's look at aws firewall
manager just like the name says it's
actually a firewall manager it helps us
to manage multiple firewalls simple as
that and shield is a service it's a
service that's used to protect denial of
service or distributed denial of a
service an api gateway is a service that
makes it easy for developers to create
publish maintain and monitor and secure
api so i mean it's completely on the api
side very less on user and how you
authenticate your user we can get that
by looking at the name itself right if
you abbreviate it or if you if you try
to find a definition for the name api
gateway you would get it it has to do
with api but if we aggregate aws iam its
identity and access management pretty
much meets the requirement for the
problem statement about its aws identity
and access management that's the right
answer all right let's look at this one
if you want to allocate various private
and public ip address in order to make
them communicate
with
the internet and other instances you
will use this service which of the
following is this service so it talks
about using public and private ip
address so this service uses ip address
and then this service helps us to
allow and deny connections to the
internet and to the other instances so
you get the question is it let's pick
the service that helps us achieve it
route 53 route 53 is actually a dns
service right so it's not a service
that's used to allow or deny no it does
not do that vpc vpc uses public and
private ip address yes so kind of looks
like a vpc helps us
to allow i mean the security in vpc the
security group the network access
control list in a vpc that routing table
in a vpc that actually helps us to allow
or deny a connection to a particular ip
address or to a particular service
within the vpc or outside of the vpc so
as of now it kind of looks like it could
be but let's look at the other services
what if if we find a service that
closely matches to the above requirement
than the amazon vpc gateway api gateway
we know that it's a managed service that
makes it easy for developers to create
publish maintain and monitor apis and
secure api so that has completely do
with api not with iap cloudfront we know
about cloudfront that it's a content
delivery network and it provides global
distribution of
servers where our content can be cached
it could be video or bulk media or
anything else they can be cached locally
so users can easily access them and
download them easily right so that's
cloud front now at this point after
looking at all four it looks like vpc is
the right answer and in fact vpc is the
right answer vpc has public ip address
vpc can help us with a private ip
address vpc can be used to allow deny
connection based on the security group
access control list and routing table it
has so that's right answer is vpc all
right how about this one this platform
as a service or platform as a db service
provides us with the cost efficient and
resizable capacity while automating time
consuming administrative tasks so this
question is very clear it's a db service
we got to look for and it's a service
that can provide
automating some of the time consuming
tasks it has to be resizable at the same
time so let's talk about
amazon rational database it's a database
kind of matches the requirement we can
resize it as and when needed
all right looks like it's a fit as of
now it actually automates some of the
time consuming work looks like it's a
fit as of now let's move on to elastic
cache and then try to see if
that matches the definition that
we've figured out about elastic cache
it's actually a caching service it's
again an in-memory data store which
helps in achieving high throughput and
low latency in memory data store so it's
not a full-blown database and it does
not come with
any amazon provisioned automation in it
for automating any of the administration
tasks no it does not come up with
anything like that yeah we can resize
the capacity as and when needed but
automation
it's not there yet and moreover it's not
a database so that's out of the equation
vpc is
not a recessible one you know once we
have designed vpc it's fixed it can't be
resized so that's out of the equation
and uh amazon glacier glacier is a
storage but not a database all right so
that's again of the equation so that tie
is kind of between amazon rational
database service and amazon elastic
cache because they both aid the database
service but elastic cache is not a
full-blown database it actually helps
the database but it's not a full-blown
database so it's amazon relational
database so that's the one which is a
platform as a service it's the one which
can be resized it's the one which
can be used to automate the time
consuming administrative tasks all right
let's talk about this one which of the
following is a means for accessing human
researchers or consultants to help solve
a problem on a contractual or a
temporary basis all right let's read the
question again which of the following is
a means for accessing human researchers
or consultant to help solve problems on
a contractual or a temporary basis it's
like a signing task or hiring aws
experts for a temporary job so let's try
to find that kind of service in the four
services that are listed amazon elastic
mapreduce mapreduce is actually an
framework service that makes it easy and
cost effective to analyze large amount
of data but that has
nothing to do with accessing human
researchers all right let's talk about
mechanical term it's a web service that
provides a
human workforce that's the definition
for it for example automation is good
but not everything can be automated for
something to qualify for automation it
has to be and repeated tasks one-time
task can't be automated or the time and
money that you would be spending in
automation is not worth it instead you
could have done it manually so that does
not qualify for automation and anything
that requires intelligence right
anything that's a special case right
automation can do repetitive tasks
automation can do precise work but it
has to be repeated tasks the scenario
you know it should have been there
already only then that can be executed
but if it's a new scenario and it
requires uh appropriate addressing then
it requires human thought so we could
hire researchers and consultants who can
help solve a problem using amazon
mechanical turk the other two are
already out of the equation now dev pay
is actually a payment system through
amazon and multi-factor authentication
as it says it's an authentication system
so the right answer is amazon mechanical
turk all right this sounds interesting
let's look at this one this service is
used to
make it easy to deploy manage and scale
containerized applications using
kubernetes on aws which of the following
is this aws service so it's a service to
deploy manage and scale containerized
applications so it deals with containers
it also should have the ability to use
kubernetes which is and container
orchestration service all right the
first one amazon elastic container
service kind of looks like it's the one
the name itself has the word and the
relation we're looking for elastic
container service so this container
service is an highly scalable high
performance container orchestration
service let's look at the other one aws
batch it's a service that enables id
professionals to schedule and execute
batch processing i mean the name itself
says that that's meant for batch
processing elastic bean stock that's
another service that helps us to deploy
manage and scale but it helps us with
easy to instances
not with containerized
instances so that's again out of the
equation would light scale be a good
time for elastic container service
what's light sale now lightsail is a
service it's called as a virtual private
server without a vpc it's called as a
virtual private
server it comes with a predefined
compute storage networking capacity it's
actually a server not a container right
so at this point that also becomes out
of the equation so it's amazon elastic
container service that's the one that
helps us to easily deploy manage scale
container services and it helps us
orchestrate the containers using
kubernetes all right how about this one
right this service lets us to run code
without provisioning or managing servers
so no servers run code select the
correct service from the below option
all right so no servers but we should be
able to run code amazon easy to order
scaling easy to auto scaling ec2 is
elastic compute cloud which is a server
and auto scaling is a service that helps
us to achieve scaling the server so
that's the definition for it could be
that's out of the equation aw is lambda
now lambda is a service it's actually an
event driven serverless computing
platform and lambda runs code in
response to the event that it receives
and it automatically manages the compute
resource that's required for that code
as long as we have uploaded a code
that's correct and set up events
correctly to map to that code it's going
to run seamlessly so that's about lambda
it kind of looks like it could be the
answer because lambda runs code we don't
have to manage servers it manages
servers by itself but we can't conclude
as of now we have other two servers to
talk about aws batch all right batch is
service that
enables id professionals to run batch
job we know that and about inspector
amazon inspector it's actually a service
that helps us to increase and identify
any security issues and align our
application with compliance well that's
not the requirement of the question the
requirement and the question was run
code without provisioning your server
and without any more space for confusion
aws lambda is a service or is the
service that runs code without
provisioning and managing services right
the right one would be aws lambda second
part in aws interview questions if you
haven't watched the first part yet
please go back and watch the first part
we have a lot of interesting questions
there which will better prepare you for
the interview all right let's get
started so in an environment where
there's a lot of automation
infrastructure automation you'll be
posted with this question how can you
add an existing instance to a new auto
scaling group now this is when you are
taking an instance away from the auto
scaling group to
troubleshoot to fix a problem you know
to look at logs or if you have suspended
the auto scaling you know you might need
to re-add that instance to the auto
scaling group only then it's going to
take part in it right only then the auto
scaling is going to count it has part of
it it's not a straight uh procedure you
know when you remove them you know it
doesn't get automatically re-added i've
had worked with some clients so when
their developers were managing their own
environment they had problems adding the
instance back to the auto scaling group
you know irrespective of what they tried
the instance was not getting added to
the auto scaling group and whatever they
fix that they were provided or whatever
fix that they have provided we're not
you know getting encountered in the auto
scaling group so like i said it's not a
straight you know a click button
procedure there are ways we'll have to
do it so how can you add an existing
instance to the auto scaling group there
are a few steps that we need to follow
so the first one would be to under the
ec2 instance console right under the uh
instance under actions in specific you
know there's an option called attach to
auto skilling group right if you have
multiple auto scaling groups in your
account or in the region that you're
working in then you're going to be
posted with the different auto scaling
groups that you have in your account
let's say you have five auto scaling
groups for five different application
you know you're going to be posted with
five different auto scaling groups and
then you would select
the auto scaling the appropriate auto
scaling group and attach the instance to
that particular auto scaling group while
adding to the auto scaling group if you
want to change the instance type you
know that's possible as well sometimes
when you want to add the instance back
to the auto skilling group there would
be requirement that you change the
instance type to a better one to a
better family to the better instance
type you could do that at that time and
after that you are or you have
completely added the instance back to
the auto scaling group so it's actually
an seven step up process adding an
instance back to the auto scaling group
in an environment where they're dealing
with migrating the instance or migrating
an application or migrating an instance
migrating and vm into the cloud you know
if the project that you're going to work
with deals with a lot of migrations you
could be posted this question what are
the factors you will consider while
migrating to amazon web services the
first one is cost is it worth
moving the instance to the cloud given
the additional bills and results
features available in the cloud is this
application going to use all of them is
moving into the cloud beneficial to the
application in the first place you know
beneficial to the users who will be
using the application in the first place
so that's a factor to think of so this
actually includes
cost of the infrastructure and the
ability to match the demand and supply
transparency is this application and
high demand you know is it going to be a
big loss if the application becomes
unavailable for some time so there are a
few things that needs to be considered
before we move the application to the
cloud and then if uh the application
does the application needs to be
provisioned immediately is that an urge
is there an urge to provision the
application immediately that's something
that needs to be considered if the
application requires to go online if the
application needs to hit the market
immediately then we would need to move
it to the cloud because in on premises
procuring or buying an infrastructure
buying the bandwidth buying the
switchboard you know buying an instance
you know buying their softwares buying
the license related to it it's going to
take time at least like two weeks or so
before you can bring up an server and
launch an application in it right so the
application cannot wait you know waiting
means you know workforce productivity
loss is it so we would want to
immediately launch instances and put
application on top of it in those case
if if your application is of that type
if there is an urge in making the
application go online as soon as
possible then that's a candidate for
moving to the cloud and if the
application or if the
the software or if the product that
you're launching it requires hardware it
requires an updated hardware all the
time that's not going to be possible in
on premises we try to deal with legacy
infrastructure all the time in on
premises but in the cloud they're
constantly upgrading their hardwares
only then they can keep themselves up
going in the market so they constantly
the cloud providers are constantly
updating their hardwares and if you want
to be benefited of your application
wants to be benefited by the constant
upgrading of the hardwares making sure
the hardware is as latest as possible
the software version the licensing is as
latest as possible then that's a
candidate to be moved to the cloud and
if the application does not want to go
through any risk if the application is
very sensitive to failures if the
application is very much stacked to the
revenue of the company and you don't
want to take a chance in
you know seeing the application fail and
you know seeing the revenue drop then
that's a candidate for moving to the
cloud and business agility you know
moving to
the cloud at least half of the
responsibility is now taken care by the
provider in this case it's amazon at
least half of the responsibility is
taken care by them like if the hardware
fails amazon make sure that they're
fixing the hardware immediately and
notifications you know if something
happens you know there are immediate
notifications available that we can set
it up and make ourselves aware that
something has broken and we can
immediately jump in and fix it so you
see there are the responsibility is now
being shared between amazon and us so if
you want to get that benefit for your
application for your organization for
the product that you're launching then
it needs to be moved to the cloud so you
can get that benefit from the cloud the
other question you could get asked is
what is rto and rpo in aws they are
essentially disaster recovery terms when
you're planning for disaster recovery
you cannot avoid planning disaster
recovery without talking about rto and
rpo now what's the rto what's the rpo in
your environment or how do you define
rto how do you define rpo or some
general questions that get asked rto is
a recovery time objective rto stands for
the maximum time the company is willing
to wait for the recovery to happen or
for the recovery to finish
when and disaster strikes so rto is
in the future right how much time is it
going to take to fix and bring
everything to normal so that's rto on
the other hand rpo is recovery point
objective which is the maximum amount of
data laws your company is willing to
accept as measured in time rpo always
refers to the backups the number of
backups the the frequency of the backups
right because when an outage happens you
can always go back to the latest backup
right and if the latest backup was
before 12 hours you have lost the in
between 12 hours of
data data storage right so rpo is the
acceptable amount if the company wants
uh
less rpo rpo is 1r then you should be
planning on taking backups every one
hour if rpo is 12 hours then you should
be planning on taking backups every 12
hours so that's how rpo and rto you know
helps disaster recovery the fourth
question you could get asked is if you'd
like to transfer huge amount of data
which is the best option among a
snowball snowball edge and snowmobile
again this is a question that gets asked
if the company is dealing with a lot of
data transfer into the cloud or if the
company is dealing with uh migrating
data into the cloud i'm talking about a
huge amount of data data in petabytes
snowball and all of the snowball series
deals with the petabyte-sized data
migrations so there are three options
available as of now aws snowball is an
data transport solution for moving high
volume of data into and out of a
specified aws region on the other hand
aws snowball edge adds additional
computing functions snowball is simple
storage and movement of data and
snowball edge has a compute function
attached to it snow mobile on the other
hand is an exabyte scale migration
service that allows us to transfer data
up to 100 petabytes that's like 100 000
terabytes so depending on the size of
data that we want to transfer from our
data center to the cloud we can hire we
can rent any of these three services
let's talk about some cloud formation
questions this is a classic question how
is aws cloud formation different from
aws elastic beanstalk you know from the
surface they both look like the same you
know you don't go through the console
provisioning resources you don't you
know you don't go through cli and
provision resources both of them
provision resources through click button
right but underneath they are actually
different services they support they aid
different services so knowing that is
going to help you understand this
question a lot better let's talk about
the difference between them and this is
what you will be explaining to the
interviewer or the panelist so the cloud
formation the cloud formation service
helps you describe and provision all the
infrastructure resources in the cloud
environment on the other hand elastic
bean stock provides an simple
environment to which we can deploy and
run application cloud formation gives us
an infrastructure and elastic bean stock
gives us an small contained environment
in which we can run our application and
cloud formation supports the
infrastructure needs of many different
types of application like the
enterprise application the legacy
applications and any new modern
application that you want to have in the
cloud on the other hand the elastic bean
stock it's a combination of developer
tools they are tools that helps manage
the life cycle of a single application
so cloud formation in short is managing
the infrastructure as a whole and
elastic bean stock in short is managing
and running an application in the cloud
and if the company that you're getting
hired is using uh cloud formation to
manage their infrastructure using or if
they're using infrastructure or any of
the infrastructure as a code
services then you would definitely face
this question what are the elements of
an aws cloud formation template so it
has
four or five basic
elements right and the template is in
the form of json or in yaml format all
right so it has parameters it has
outputs it has data it has resources and
then the
format or the format version or the file
format version for the cloud formation
template so parameter is nothing but um
it actually lets you to specify the type
of ec2 instance uh that you want the
type of rds that you want all right so
ec2 is an umbrella rds is an umbrella
and parameters within that ec2 and
parameters within that rds are the
specific details of the ec2 or the
specific details of the rds service so
that's what parameters in a cloud
formation template and then the element
of the cloud formation template is
outputs for example if you want to
output the name of an s3 bucket that was
created if you want to output the name
of the ec2 instance if you want to
output the name of some resources that
have been created instead of looking
into the template instead of you know
navigating through in the console and
finding the name of the resource we can
actually have them outputted
in the result section so we can simply
go and look at all the resources created
through the template in the output
section and that's what output values or
output does in the cloud formation
template and then we have resources
resources are nothing but what defines
what are the cloud components or cloud
resources that will be created through
this cloud formation template now ec2 is
a resource rds is a resource and s3
bucket is a resource elastic load
balancer is a resource and nat gateway
is a resource vpc is a reserve so you
see all these components are the
resources and the resource section in
the cloud formation defines what are the
aws cloud resources that will be created
through this cloud formation template
and then we have a version a version
actually identifies the capabilities of
the template you know we just need to
make sure that it is of the latest
version type and the latest version is
0 9 0 9
2010 that's the latest version number
you'll be able to find that on the top
of the cloud formation template and that
version number defines the capabilities
of the cloud formation template so just
need to make sure that it's the latest
all the time still talking about cloud
formation this is another classic
question what happens when one of the
resource in a stack cannot be created
successfully well if
the resource in a stack cannot be
created the cloud formation
automatically rolls back and terminates
all the resources that was created using
the cloud formation template so whatever
resources that were created through the
cloud formation template from the
beginning let's say we have created like
10 resources and the 11th resource is
now failing cloud formation will roll
back and delete all the 10 resources
that were created previously and this is
very useful
when the cloud formation cannot you know
go forward cloud formation cannot create
additional resources because we have
reached the elastic
ip limits elastic ip limit per region is
five right and if you have already used
five ips and a cloud formation is trying
to buy three more ips you know we've hit
the soft limit till we fix that with
amazon cloud formation will not be able
to you know launch additional you know
resources and additional ips so it's
going to cancel and roll back everything
that's true with a missing ec2 ami as
well if an ami is included in the
template and but the ami is not actually
present then cloudformation is going to
search for the mi and because it's not
present it's going to roll back and
delete all the resources that it uh
created so that's what cloudformation
does it simply rolls back all the
resources that it created i mean if it
sees a failure it would simply roll back
all the resources that it created and
this feature actually simplifies the
system administration and layered
solutions built on top of aws cloud
formation so at any point we know that
there are no orphan resources in the in
in our environment you know because
something did not work or because there
was an you know cloud formation executed
some there are no orphan resources in
our account at any point we can be sure
that if cloudformation is launching a
resource and if it's going to fail and
it's going to come back and delete all
the resources it's created so there are
no orphan resources in our account now
let's talk about some questions in
elastic block store again if the
environment deals with a lot of
automation you could be thrown this
question how can you automate easy to
backup using ebs it's actually a six
step process to automate the ec2 backups
we'll need to write a script to automate
the below steps uh using aws api and
these are the steps that should be found
in the scripts first to get the list of
instances and then and then the script
that we are writing should be able to
connect to aws using the api and list
the amazon abs volumes that are attached
locally to the instance and then it
needs to list the snapshots of each
volume make sure the snapshots are
present and it needs to assign a
retention period for the snapshot
because over time the snapshots are
going to be
invalid right once you have some 10
latest
snapshots any snapshot that you have
taken before that 10 becomes invalid
because you have captured the latest and
10 snapshot coverage is enough for you
and then the fifth point is to create a
snapshot of each volume create a new
snapshot of each volume and then delete
the old snapshot anytime a new snapshot
gets created the oldest snapshot of the
list needs to go away so we need to
include options we need to include
scripts in our script lines in our
script that make sure that it's deleting
the older snapshots which are older than
the retention period that we are
mentioning another question that you
could see in the interview be it written
interview beat online interview or beat
and telephonic or face-to-face interview
is what's the difference between ebs and
instant store let's talk about ebs first
ebs is kind of permanent storage the
data in it can be restored at a later
point when we save data in ebs the data
lives even after the lifetime of the ec2
instance for example we can stop the
instance and the data is still going to
be present in ebs we can move the ebs
from one instance to another instance
and the data is simply going to be
present there so abs is kind of
permanent storage when compared to
instance on the other hand instance
store is a temporary storage and that
storage is actually physically attached
to the host of the machine ebs is an
external storage an instant store is
locally attached to the instance or
locally attached to the host of the
machine we cannot detach an instant
store from one instance and attach it to
another but we can do that with eba so
that's a big difference one is permanent
data and another one is ebs is permanent
instant store is a volatile data and
instant store with instant store we
won't be able to detach the storage and
attach it to another instance and
another feature of instant store is data
in an instant store is lost if the disk
fails or the instance is stopped or
terminated so instant store is only good
for storing cache data if you want to
store permanent data then we should
think of using ebs and not instant store
while talking about storage on the same
lines this is another classic question
how can you take backups of efs like ebs
and if you can take backup how do you
take that backup the answer is yes we
can take efs to efs backup solution efs
does not support snapshot like ebs efs
does not support snapshot snapshot is
not an option for efs elastic file
system right we can only take backup
from one efs to another efs and this
backup solution is to recover from
unintended changes or deletions of the
efs and this can be automated but any
data that we store in efs can be
automatically replicated to another efs
and once this efs goes down or gets
deleted or data gets deleted or you know
the whole ef is is for some reason
interrupted or deleted we can recover
the data from we can use the other efs
and bring the application to consistency
and to achieve this it's not an um one
step configuration it's a cycle there
are series of steps that's involved
before we can achieve efs to efs backup
the first thing is to sign in to the aws
management console and under efs or
click on efs to efs restore button from
the services list and from there we can
use the region selector in the console
navigation bar to select the actual
region in which we want to work on and
from there i'll ensure that we have
selected the
right template you know some of the
templates would be you know efs to efs
backup granular backups incremental
backups right so there are some
templates the kind of backups that you
want to take do you want to take grant
alert do you want to take increment
backups stuff like that and then create
a name to that solution the kind of
backup that we have created and finally
review all the configurations that you
have done and click on save and from
that point onwards the data is going to
be copied and from that point onwards
any additional data that you put is
going to copy it and replicate it now
you have an efs to efs backup this is
another classic question in companies
which deals with
a data management there are easy options
to create snapshots but deleting
snapshots is
not always an you know click button or
an single step configuration so you
might be facing a question like how do
you auto delete old snapshots and the
procedure is like this now as best
practice we will take snapshots of ebs
volume to s3 all snapshots get stored in
s3 we know that now and we can use aws
ops automator to automatically handle
all snapshots the ops automator service
it allows us to create copy delete ebs
snapshots so there are cloud formation
templates available for aws ops
automator and this automator template
will scan the environment and it would
take snapshots it would you know copy
the snapshot from one region to another
region if you want i know if you're
setting up a dr environment and not only
that based on the retention period that
we
create it's going to delete the
snapshots which are older than the
retention period so life or managing
snapshot is made a lot easier because of
this ops automator cloud formation
template moving into questions and
elastic load balancer this again could
be an
question in the interview what are the
different types of load balancers in aws
and what's their use case what's the
difference between them and as of now as
we speak there are three types of load
balancers which are available in aws the
first one being application
load balancer just like the name says
the application load balancer works on
the application layer and deals with the
http and https request and it also
supports part based routing for example
simplylearn.com slash some webpage
simplylearn.com slash another website so
it's going to direct the path based on
the slash value that you give in the
urls that's path based routing so it
supports that and not only that it can
support a port based colon 8080 colon
8081 or colon 8090 you know based on
that port also it can take a routing
decision and that's what application
load balancer does on the other hand we
have network load balancer and the
network load balancer makes routing
decisions at the transport level it's
faster because it has very less thing to
work on it works on lower osi layer it
works on a lower layer so it has very
less information to work with than
compared with application layer so
comparatively it's a lot faster and it
handles millions of requests per second
and after the load balancer receives a
connection it selects a target group for
the default rule using the flow hash
routing algorithm it does simple routing
right it does not do path based or port
based routing it does simple routing and
because of it it's faster and then we
have classic load balancer which is kind
of expiring as we speak amazon is
discouraging people using classic load
balancer but there are companies which
are still using classic load balancer
they are the ones who are the first one
to step into amazon when classic load
balancer was the first load balancer or
the only load balancer available at that
point so it supports http https tcp ssl
protocol and it has a fixed relationship
between a load balance report and the
container port so initially we only have
classic load balancer and then
at after some point amazon said instead
of having one load balancer address all
type of traffic we're going to have two
load balances called as the child from
the classic two load balancer and one is
going to specifically address the
application requirement and one is going
to specifically address the network
requirement and let's call it as
application load balancer and network
load balancer so that's how now we have
two different load balancers talking
about load balancer another classic
question could be what are the different
uses of the various load balancer in aws
elastic load balancing there are three
types of load balancer we just spoke
about it application load balancer is
used if we need flexible application
management and tls termination and
network load balancer if we require
extreme performance and the load
balancing should happen on based on
static ips for the application and
classic load balancer is an old load
balancer which is for people who are
still running their environment from
easy to classic network now this is an
older version of vpc or this is what was
present before vpc was created easy to
classic network is what was present
before ec2 was created so they are the
three types and they are the use cases
of it let's talk about some of the
security related questions you would
face in the interview when talking about
security and firewall in aws we cannot
avoid discussion talking about waff web
application firewall and you would
definitely see yourself in this
situation where you've been asked how
can you use aws waft in monitoring your
aws applications waff or web application
firewall protects our web application
from common web exploits and vaf helps
us control which traffic source your
application should be allowed or a block
which traffic from a certain source you
know which source or which traffic from
a certain source should be allowed or
blocked your application with waff we
can also create custom rules that blocks
common attack patterns you know if it is
a banking application it has a certain
type of attacks and if it is simple uh
data management data storage application
it has i mean content management
application it has a separate type of
attack so based on the application type
we can identify a pattern and create
rules that would actually block that
attack based on the rule that we create
and waff can be used for three cases you
know the first one is allow all requests
and then block all request and count all
requests for a new policy so it's also
an monitoring and management service
which actually counts all the policies
or counts all the requests that matches
a particular policy that we create and
some of the characteristics we can
mention in aws off are the origin ips
and the strings that appear in the
request we can allow block based on
origin ip allow block based on strings
that appear in the request we can allow
block or count based on the origin
country length of the request yeah we
can block and count the presence of
malicious scripts in an connection you
know we can count the request headers or
we can allow block a certain request
header and we can count the presence of
a malicious sql code in a connection
that we get and that want to reach our
application still talking about security
what are the different aws im categories
we can control using aws iam we can do
the following one is create and manage
im users and once the user database gets
bigger and bigger we can create and
manage them in groups and in im we can
use it to manage the security
credentials kind of setting the
complexity of the password you know
setting additional authentications you
know like mfa and uh you know rotating
the passwords no resetting the password
there are a few things we could do with
iam and finally we can create policies
that actually grants access to aw
services and resources another question
you will see is what are the policies
that you can set for your user's
password so some of the policies that we
can set for the user password is at the
minimum length or you know the
complexity of the password by at least
having one number or one special
characters in the password so that's one
and then the requirement of a specific
character types including you know
uppercase lowercase number and
non-alphabetic characters so it becomes
very hard for somebody else to guess
what the password uh would be and and
try to hack them so we can set
the length of the password we can set
the complexity in the password and then
we can set an automatic expiration of
the password so after a certain time the
user is forced to create a new password
so the password is not stale old and
easy to guess in the environment and we
can also set settings like the user
should contact the admin i mean when the
password is about to expire so you know
you can get a hold of how the user is
setting their password is it having good
complexity in it is it meeting company
standards or there are a few things that
we can control and set for the users
when the users are setting or recreating
the password another question that could
be posted in an interview so to
understand your understanding of iem is
what's the difference between an iem
role and an im user let's talk about iem
user let's start small and then go big
or let's start simple and then talk
about the complex one the iem user has a
permanent long-term credential and it's
used to interact directly with aws
services and on the other hand iem role
is an iem entity that defines a set of
permissions for making aws service
request so iem user is an permanent
credential and role are temporary
credentials and iem user has full access
to all aws iem functionalities and with
role trusted entities such as iem users
application or aws services uh assume of
the role so when an im user is given an
permission you know it sticks within the
im user but with the roles we can give
permissions to applications we can give
permissions to users in the same account
in a different account corporate id we
can give permissions to ec2 s3 rds vpc
and lot more role is wide and im user is
is not so wide you know it's very
constrained only for that im user let's
talk about managed policies in aws
managed policies there are two types you
know customer managed and amazon managed
so managed policies are im resources
that express permissions using the iam
policy language and we can create
policies edit them manage them manage
them separately from the iam user group
and roles which they are attached to so
they are something that we can do to
managed policies if it is customer
managed and we can now update policy in
one place and the permissions
automatically extend to all the attached
entries so i can have like three
services four services point to a
particular policy and if i edit that
particular policy it's going to reflect
on those three or four services so
anything that i allow is going to be
allowed for those four services anything
that i denied is going to be denied for
uh the four services imagine what would
be without the im managed policy will
have to go and specifically allow deny
on those different instances four or
five times depending on the number of
instances that we have so like i said
there are two types of managed policies
one is managed by us which is customer
managed policies and then the other is
managed by aws which is aws managed
policy this question can you give an
example of an iem policy and a policy
summary this is actually to test how
well worst are you with the aws console
the answer to that question is look at
the following policy this policy is used
to grant access to add update and delete
objects from a specific folder now in
this case name of the folder is example
folder and it's present in a bucket
called example bucket so this is an iam
policy on the other hand the policy
summary is a list of access level
resource and conditions for each service
defined in a policy so im policy is all
about one particular resource and the
policy summary is all about multiple
resources with im policy it was only
talking about s3 bucket and one
particular s3 bucket here it talks about
cloud formation template cloud watch
logs ec2 elastic bean stock services
summary summary of resources and the
permissions and policies attached to
them that's what policy summary is all
about another question could be like
this what's the use case of iam and how
does im help your business two important
or primary work of im is to help us
manage iam users and their access it
provides a secure access to multiple
users to their appropriate aws resources
so that's one it does and the second
thing it does is manage access for
federated users federated users or
non-iam users and through iam we can
actually allow and provide a secured
access to resources in our aws account
to our employees without the im user no
they could be authenticated using the
active directory they could be
authenticated using the facebook
credential google credential amazon
credential and a couple of other
credentials third party uh identity
management right so we could actually
trust them and we could give them access
to our account based on the trust
relationship that we have built with the
other identity of systems right so two
things one is manage users and their
access for manage iam user and their
access in our aws environment and second
is manage access for federated users who
are non-iam users and more importantly
im is a free service and with that
will only be charged for the use of the
resources not for the iam username and
password that we create all right let's
now talk about some of the questions in
route 53
one classic question that could be asked
in an interview is what is the
difference between latency based routing
and
geodns or jio based dns routing now the
geo-based dns routing takes routing
decisions on the basis of the geographic
location of the request and on the other
hand the latency based routing utilizes
latency measurements between
networks and
data centers now latency-based routing
is used where
you want to provide the customers the
lowest latency as possible so that's
when we would use latency based routing
and on the other hand the geo-based
routing is
when we want to direct customers to
different websites based on the country
they are browsing from you know you
could have you know two different or
three different websites for the same
url you know take amazon the shopping
website for example when we go to
amazon.com from in the us it directs us
to the us web page where the products
are different the currency is different
right and the flag and a couple of other
advertisements that shows up are
different and when we go to amazon.com
from india it gets directed to the
amazon.com indian site where again the
currency the product and the
advertisements they're all different
right so depending on the
country they're trying to browse if you
want to direct customers to two or three
different websites we would use a jio
based routing another use case of
geo-based routing is if you have a
compliance that you should handle all
the dns requires sorry if you should
handle all the uh requests you know from
a country within the country then you
would do jio based routing now you
wouldn't direct the customer to a server
which is in another country right you
would direct the customer to a server
which is very local to them that's
another use case of jio based routing
and like i said for latency based
routing the whole goal or aim is to
achieve minimum end user latency if you
are hired for the architect role and
if that requires working lot on the dns
then you could be posted with this
question what is the difference between
domain and a hosted zone a domain is
actually a collection of
data describing a self-contained
administrative and technical unit on the
internet right so for example you know
simplylearn.com is actually a domain on
the other hand hosted zone is actually
an container that holds information
about how you want to route traffic on
the internet to a specific domain for
example
lms.simplylearn.com is an hosted zone
whereas simplylearn.com is a domain so
in other words in hosted zone you would
see the domain name plus and a prefix to
it lms is a prefix here ftp is a prefix
mail.simplylearn.com is a prefix so
that's how you would see a prefix in
hosted zones another question from
another classic question from route 53
would be how does amazon drop 53 provide
high availability and low latency the
way amazon route 53 provides high
availability and low latency is by
globally distributed dns servers amazon
is a global service and they have dna
services globally any customer doing a
query from different parts of the world
they get to reach an dns server which is
very local to them and that's how it
provides low latency now this is not
true with all the dns providers there
are dns providers who are very local to
a country who are very local to a
continent so they don't they generally
don't provide low latency service right
it's always high latency it's low
latency for local users but anybody
browsing from a different country or a
different continent it's going to be
high latency for them but that's not
again true with amazon amazon is a
globally distributed dns provider it has
dns servers global wide and like i said
it has optimal locations it has got
global servers or in other words it has
got servers around the globe different
parts in the globe and that's how they
are able to provide high availability
and because it's not running on just one
server but on many servers they provide
high availability and low latency if the
environment that you're going to work on
is going to take a lot of configuration
backups environmental backups then you
can expect questions in aws config a
classic question would be how does aws
config work along with aws cloud trail
aws cloud trail actually records user
api activity on the account and you know
any http https access or any any sort of
access you know that's made to the cloud
environment that's recorded in the cloud
trail in other words any api calls the
time is recorded the type of call is
recorded and what was the response given
was it a failure was it successful they
also get recorded in cloud trail it's
actually a log it actually records the
activity in your cloud environment on
the other hand config is an uh point in
time configuration details of your
resources for example at a given point
what are all the resources that were
present in my environment what are all
the resources or what are the
configuration in those resources at a
given point they get captured in aws
conflict right so with that information
you can always answer the question what
did my aws resource look like at a given
point in time that question gets
answered when we use aws config on the
other hand with cloudtrail you can
answer the question i mean by looking at
the cloud trail or with the help of
cloudtrail you can easily answer the
question who made an apa call to modify
this resource that's answered by
cloudtrail and with the cloud trail we
can detect if a security group was
incorrectly configured and who did that
configuration let's say there happened
to be a downtime and you want to
identify let's say there happen to be a
downtime and you want to identify who
made that
change in the environment you can simply
look at cloudtrail and find out who made
the change and if you want to look at
how the environment looks like before
the change you can always look at aws
config can aws configure or aws config
aggregate data across different aws
accounts yes it can now this question is
actually to test whether you have used
aws config or not i know some of the
services are very local is it some of
these services are availability zone
specific some of them are regional
specific and some of them are
global services and amazon and though
some of the services are region services
you still can do some changes you know
add some configuration to it and collect
regional data in it for example s3 is a
regional service but still you can
collect logs from all other regions into
an s3 bucket in one particular region
that's possible and cloud trail is and
cloud watch is an regional service but
still you can with some changes to it
with some adding permissions to it you
can always monitor the cloud watch that
belongs to cloudwatch logs that belongs
to other regions you know they're not
global by default but you can do some
changes and make it global similarly aws
config is a service that's a region
based service but still you can make it
act globally you can aggregate data
across a different region and different
accounts in an aws config and deliver
the updates from different accounts to
one s3 bucket and can access it from
there aws config also works or
integrates seamlessly with sns topic so
you know anytime there is a change
anytime a new data gets collected you
can always notify yourself or notify a
group of people about the new log or the
new config or new edit that happened in
the environment let's look at some of
the database questions you know database
should be running on reserved instances
so whether you know that fact or not the
interviewer wants to understand how well
you know that fact by asking this
question how are reserved instances
different from on-demand db instances
reserved instances and on-demand
instances are exactly the same when it
comes to their function but they only
differ based on how they are
built reserved instances are purchased
for one year or three year reservation
and in return we get a very low uh per
hour pricing because we're paying
upfront it's generally said that
reserved instance is 75 percentage
cheaper than on-demand instance and
amazon gives you that benefit because
you know you're committing for one year
and sometimes you're paying in advance
for the whole year on the other hand
on demand instances are built on an
oddly early price talking about auto
scaling how will you understand the
different types of auto scaling the
interviewer might ask this question
which type of scaling would you
recommend for rds and y the two types of
scaling as you would know now are
vertical and horizontal and in vertical
scaling we can vertically scale up the
master database with a couple of clicks
all right so that's vertical scaling
vertical scaling is keeping the same
node and making it bigger and bigger if
previously it was running on t2 micro
now we would like to run it on m3 two
times large instance previously it had
one virtual cpu one gigabit now it's
going to have eight virtual cpu and 30
gigabit of ram so that's vertical
scaling on the other hand horizontal
scaling is adding more nodes to it
previously it was running on one vm now
it's going to run on 2 3 10 vms right
that's horizontal scaling so
database can only be scaled vertically
and there are 18 different types of
instances we can resize our rds too
right so this is true for rds mysql
postgres sql mariadb oracle microsoft
sql servers there are 18 type of
instances we can vertically scale up to
on the other hand horizontal scaling are
good for replicas so they are read only
replicas we're not going to touch the
master
database we're not going to touch the
primary database but i can do horizontal
scaling only with amazon aurora and i
can add additional read replicas i can
add up to 15 read replicas for amazon
aurora and up to five read replicas for
rds my mysql postgres sql and marie db
rds instances and when we add replica we
are horizontally scaling adding more
nodes right read only nodes so that's
horizontal scaling so how do you really
decide between vertical and horizontal
scaling if you're looking in to increase
the storage and the processing capacity
we'll have to do a vertical scaling if
you're looking at increasing the
performance or of the read heavy
database we need to be looking for
horizontal scaling or we need to be
implementing horizontal scaling in our
environment still talking about database
this is another good question you can
expect in the interview what is a
maintenance window in amazon rds will
your db instance be available during the
maintenance event all right so this is
really to test how well you have
understood the s delay how well you have
understood the amazon rdas the failover
mechanism of amazon ideas stuff like
that so
audio's maintenance window it lets you
decide
when a db instance modification a
database engine upgrades or software
patching has to occur and you you
actually get to decide should it happen
at 12 in the night or should it happen
at afternoon should it happen early in
the morning should it happen in the
evening you actually get to decide an
automatic scheduling by amazon is done
only for patches that are security and
durability related sometimes amazon
takes down and does automatic scheduling
if you know if there is a need for a
patch update that deals with security
and durability and by default the
maintenance window is is for 30 minutes
and the important point is the db
instance will be available during that
event because you're gonna have primary
and secondary right so when that upgrade
happens amazon would shift the
connection to the secondary do the
upgrade and then switch back to the
primary another classic question would
be what are the consistency models in
dynamodb in dynamodb there is eventual
consistency read this eventual
consistency model it actually maximizes
your read throughput and the best part
with eventual consistency is all copies
of data reach
consistency within a second and
sometimes when you write and when you're
you know trying to read immediately
chances that you would still be reading
the old data that's eventual consistency
on the other hand there is another
consistency model called the strong
consistency or strongly consistent read
where there is going to be a delay in
writing the data you know making sure
the data is written in all places but it
guarantees one thing that is once you
have done a write and then you're trying
to do a read it's going to make sure
that it's going to show you the updated
data not the old data and you can be
guaranteed of it that it is going to
show the updated data and not the old
data that's strongly consistent still
talking about database talking about
nosql dynamodb or nosql database which
is
dynamodb and amazon you could be asked
this question what kind of query
functionality does
dynamodb support dynamodb supports get
and put operation dynamodb supports or
dynamodb provides flexible querying by
letting you query on non-primary key
attributes using global secondary index
and local secondary indexes a primary
key can be either a single attribute
partition key or a composite
partition sort key in other words a
dynamodb indexes a composite partition
sort key as a partition key element and
a sort key element and by holding the
partition key you know when doing a
search or when doing a query by holding
the partition key element constant we
can search across the sort key element
to retrieve the other items in that
table and the composite partition sort
key should be a combination of a user id
partition and a timestamp so that's what
the composite partition sort key is made
of let's look at some of the multiple
choice questions you know sometimes some
companies would have an a written test
or an mcq type online test before they
call you for at the first level or
before they call you for the second
level so these are some classical
questions that companies asked or
companies ask in their multiple choice
online questions let's look at this
question as a developer using this
pay-per-use service you can send store
and receive messages between software
components which of the following is
being referred here let's look at it
right we have aws step functions uh
amazon mq amazon simple queue service
amazon simple notification service let's
read the question again as a developer
using this pay-per-use service so the
service that we are looking for is a
pay-per-view service you can send store
and retrieve messages between two
software components kind of like a queue
there so what would be the right answer
it would be amazon simple queue service
now amazon simple queue service is the
one that's used to decouple at the
environment it breaks the tight coupling
and then it introduces decoupling in
that environment by providing a cue or
by inserting a queue between two
software components let's look at this
other question if you would like to host
a real-time audio and video conferencing
application on aws it's an audio and
video conferencing application on aws
this service provides you with a secure
and easy to use application what is this
service let's look at the options they
are amazon
chime amazon workspace amazon mq amazon
app stream well you might tend to look
at
amazon app stream because it's real time
and a video conference but it's actually
for a different purpose is actually
amazon chime that lets you create chat
and create a chat board and then
collaborate with the security of the aws
services so it lets you do the audio
it's lets you do the video conference
all supported by aws security features
it's actually amazon chime let's look at
this question as your company's aws
solution architect you are in charge of
designing thousands of individual jobs
which are similar which of the following
service best serves your requirement in
earlier ec2 auto scaling aws snowball
aws
fargate aws batch let's read the
question again as your company's aws
solution architect you are in charge of
designing thousands of individual jobs
which are similar it looks like
it's batch service let's look at the
other options as well aw snowball is
actually an storage transport service
ec2 auto scaling is you know in
introducing scalability and elasticity
in the environment and aws fargate is
container services aws batch is the one
is being referred here that actually
runs thousands of individual jobs which
are similar aws batch it's the right
answer let's look at the other one you
are a machine learning engineer and
you're looking for a service that helps
you build and train mission learning
models in aws which among the following
are we referring to so we have amazon
sage maker aws deep lens amazon
comprehend aws device form let's read
the question again you are a machine
learning engineer and you're looking for
a service that helps you build and train
machine learning models in aws which
among the following are referred here
the answer is sage maker it provides
every developer and data scientist with
the ability to build train and deploy
machine learning models quickly that's
what sagemaker does now for you to be
familiar with you know the the products
i would recommend you to you know simply
go through the product description you
know there's one page available on
amazon that explains all the products a
quick neat and simple now that really
helps you to be very familiar with you
know what the product is all about and
what it is capable of you know is it a
db service is it a machine learning
service or is it a monitoring service is
it a developer service stuff like that
so get that information get that details
before you attend an interview and that
should really help to answer or face
such questions with great confidence so
the answer is amazon sage maker because
that's the one that provides developers
and a data scientist the ability to
build the train and deploy machine
learning models quickly as possible all
right let's look at this one let's say
that you are working for your company's
id team and you are designated to adjust
the capacity of the aws resource based
on the incoming application and network
traffic how do you do it so what's the
service that's actually helps us to
adjust the capacity of the aws resource
based on the incoming application let's
look at it amazon vpc amazon iam amazon
inspector amazon elastic load balancing
amazon vpc is a networking service
amazon iam is an username password
authentication amazon inspector is a
service that actually does security
audit in our environment and amazon
elastic load balancer is a service that
helps in scalability that's in one way
you know indirectly that helps in
increasing the availability of the
application right and monitoring it
monitoring you know how much requests
are coming in through the elastic load
balancer we can actually adjust the
environment that's running behind it so
the answer is going to be amazon elastic
load balancer all right let's look at
this question this cross-platform video
game development engine that supports pc
xbox playstation ios and android
platforms allows developers to build and
host their games on amazon's servers so
we have amazon game lift amazon green
grass amazon lumber yard amazon sumerian
let's read the question again this
cross-platform video game development
engine that supports pc xbox playstation
ios and android platforms allows
developers to build and host their games
on amazon servers the answer is amazon
lumberyard this lumberyard is an free
triple a gaming engine deeply integrated
with the aws and twitch with full source
this lumbar yard provides a growing set
of tools that helps you create and
highest
game quality applications and they
connect to a lot of games and vast
compute and storage in the cloud so it's
that service they are referring to let's
look at this question you are the
project manager of your company's cloud
architect team you are required to
visualize understand and manage your aws
cost and usage over time which of the
following service will be the best fit
for this we have aws budgets we have aws
cost explorer we have amazon work mail
we have amazon connect and the answer is
going to be cost explorer now cost
explorer is an option in the amazon
console that
helps you to visualize and understand
and even manage the aws cost over time
who's spending more who's spending less
and what is the trend what is the
projected cost for the coming month all
these can be visualized in aws cost
explorer let's look at this question you
are a chief cloud architect at your
company and how can you automatically
monitor and adjust computer resources to
ensure maximum performance and
efficiency of all scalable resources so
we have a cloud formation as a service
we have aws aurora as a solution we have
aws auto scaling and amazon api gateway
let's read the question again you're the
chief cloud architect at your company
how can you automatically monitor and
adjust computer resources how can you
automatically monitor and adjust
computer resources to ensure maximum
performance and efficiency of all
scalable resources this is an easy
question to answer the answer is
autoscaling right that's a basic service
and solution architect
course is it auto scaling is the service
that helps us to easily adjust monitor
and ensure the maximum performance and
efficiency of all scalable resources it
does that by automatically scaling the
environment to handle the inputs let's
look at this question as a database
administrator you will use a service
that is used to set up and manage
databases such as mysql maya db and
postgres sql which service are we
referring to amazon aurora amazon
elastic cache aws rds aws database
migration service amazon aurora is
amazon's flavor of
the rds service and elastic cache is is
the caching service provided by amazon
they are not full-fledged database and
database migration service just like the
name says it helps to migrate the
database from on-premises to the cloud
and from one database flavor to another
database flavor amazon rds is the
service is the console is the service is
the umbrella service that helps us to
set up manage databases like mysql money
db and postgres sql it's amazon rds
let's look at this last question a part
of your marketing work requires you to
push messages to onto google facebook
windows and apple through apis or aws
management console you will use the
following service so the options are aws
cloudtrail aws config amazon chime aws
simple notification service it says a
part of your marketing work requires you
to push messages it's dealing with
pushing messages to google facebook
windows and apple through apis or aws
management console you will use the
following service it's simple
notification service simple notification
service is an message pushing service
and sqs is pulling similarly sns is
pushing right here it talks about a
pushing system that pushes messages to
google facebook windows and apple
through api and it's going to be a
simple notification system or a simple
notification service microsoft azure
full course
in this full course we will learn
everything about azure in detail
we'll begin this full course video with
what microsoft azure is then we will
look into azure and its concepts in
detail then our experts will give you a
quick training on azure services then we
will see
what is azure machine learning and azure
active directory next we will see
azure virtual machine and azure virtual
network
after that we will be looking into a few
major difference between aws and gcp and
after that we will have a quick
understanding of how the famous cloud
providers aws azure and gcp are
different from each other
finally we will conclude this video by
discussing 25 important azure interview
questions and answers for beginners and
experienced level candidates
by the end of this video i can assure
you that all your azure related queries
would have been answered
for this training with me i have our
experience as your experts sam rahul and
alankar
together we will take you through the
various topics of azure
so let's start with an exciting video on
the microsoft azure cloud provider
before we begin make sure to subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update from simply
learn hi guys this is rahul from simply
learn and today we'll be talking about
one of the fastest growing and second
largest cloud computing platform in the
market right now i'm talking about
microsoft azure now before we begin
let's talk about what we'll be covering
in this video first we'll talk about why
you should be interested in cloud
computing what exactly is cloud
computing what is microsoft is your some
of its services and the uses of azure
now let's start with why you should be
interested in cloud computing now let's
say you have an idea for a revolutionary
application an idea that ticks both the
boxes when it comes to good applications
one it has great user experience and two
it'll be highly profitable now for it to
be successful you'll have to release it
on the internet people need to use it
they need to spread the word and then it
will become truly famous however for
that you're going to need servers
storage developers a dedicated network
and application security to ensure your
application works the way it does now
these are a lot of components
and that's where the problem lies there
are two major disadvantages to this
approach the initial setup is very
expensive and risky which means this
requires a huge amount of capital
upfront to ensure that it works properly
and the downside is if your application
does not become famous or it doesn't
return as much as you expect it to
you're probably not going to get the
money back which means it provides a
huge amount of risk and then on the flip
side if it does become famous your
number of users have increased which
means that you'll have to buy more
servers and storage systems to keep up
with your demand and this problem can be
solved with the help of cloud computing
now that you know why you should be
interested in cloud computing let's go
into the details of what exactly is
cloud computing now cloud computing is
basically a platform that gives you
access to a number of computing
resources and this is possible with the
help of the internet now as a user all
you need to do is go to a cloud service
provider through your laptop or your
computer through the internet of course
connect to that cloud service provider
and then there you go you have access to
computing resources now computing
resources may include you know
serverless computing virtual machines
storage and so much more now let's dig a
little deeper now basically these cloud
service providers actually have massive
data centers now in these data centers
what you have are hundreds of servers
also included are storage systems and
mainly several organizations critical
components so these are very secure safe
locations where a large amount of data
is stored hence the name data centers
now it is to these data centers that
users actually connect to collect their
data or use it so actually users can
access any service based on their
requirement now like i told you there's
a number of services the user can use
for example now if you want a
notification every time someone sends
you a message or perhaps once you get an
email you need a copy of it created now
for all of this there are services and
most importantly almost every cloud
service provider has this option where
users only pay for the service that they
use so there's no charge up front where
they tell you that you need to pay x
amount of money so that you can use our
services you're only paying for the
amount of time that you're using these
services now cloud computing is used for
a wide variety of reasons firstly
there's machine learning and data
analysis now basically there are
services that analyze your data and tell
you how you can work with this data
better then there's data storage in
backup streaming media content for
example did you know that the shows that
you watch on netflix actually all of
them are in the cloud so you're
connected to the internet and you browse
through netflix and you get access to
the videos these are possible with the
help of cloud service providers there's
creating and testing applications
automating software delivery which is a
component in devops and hosting blogs
and applications so now what is azure
what's the big cloud service provider
all about so azir is a cloud computing
platform provided by microsoft now it's
basically an online portal through which
you can access and manage resources and
services
now resources and services are nothing
but you know you can store your data and
you can transform the data using
services that microsoft provides again
all you need is the internet and being
able to connect to the azure portal then
you get access to all of the resources
and their services in case you want to
know more about how it's different from
its rival which is aws i suggest you
click on the top right corner and watch
the aws versus azure video so that you
can clearly tell how both these cloud
service providers are different from
each other now here are some things that
you need to know about this year it was
launched in february 1st 2010 which is
significantly later than when aws was
launched it's free to start and has a
pay-per-use model which means like i
said before you need to pay for the
services you use through azure and one
of their most important selling points
is that 80 of fortune 500 companies use
as your services which means that most
of the bigger companies of the world
actually recommend using azure and then
azure supports a wide variety of
programming languages the c-sharp
node.js java and so much more another
very important selling point of azir is
the amount of data centers it has across
the world now it's important for a cloud
service provider to have many data
centers around the world because it
means that they can provide their
services to a wider audience now azure
has 42 which is more than any cloud
service provider has at the moment it
expects to have 12 more in a period of
time which brings its total number of
regions it covers to 54. now let's talk
about azure services now azure services
have 18 categories and more than 200
services so we clearly can't go through
all of them it has services that cover
compute and machine learning integration
management tools identity devops web and
so much more you're going to have a hard
time trying to find a domain that azure
doesn't cover and if it doesn't cover it
now you can be certain they're working
on it as we speak so first let's start
with the compute services first virtual
machine with this service what you're
getting to do is to create a virtual
machine of linux or windows operating
system it's easily configurable you can
add ram you can decrease ram you can add
storage remove it all of it is possible
in a match of seconds now let's talk
about the second service cloud service
now with this you can create a
application within the cloud and all of
the work after you deploy it deploying
the application that is is taken care of
by azure which includes you know
provisioning the application load
balancing ensuring that the application
is in good health and all the other
things are handled by azure next up
let's talk about service fabric now with
service fabric the process of developing
a micro service is greatly simplified so
you might be wondering what exactly is a
micro service now a micro service is
basically an application that consists
of smaller applications coupled together
next up functions now with functions you
can create applications in any
programming language that you want
another very important part is that you
don't have to worry about any hardware
components you don't have to worry what
ram you require or how much storage you
require all of that is taken care of by
azure all you need is to provide the
code to azure and it will execute it and
you don't have to worry about anything
else now let's talk about some
networking services first up we have
azure cdn or the content delivery
network now the azure cdn service is
basically for delivering web content to
users now this content is of high
bandwidth and can be transferred or can
be delivered to any person across the
world now these are actually a network
of servers that are placed in strategic
positions across the world so that the
customers can obtain this data as fast
as possible next up we have express
route now with this you can actually
connect your on-premise network onto the
microsoft cloud or any of the services
that you want through a private
connection so the only communication
that happens is between your on-premise
network and the service that you want
then you have virtual network now with
virtual network you can have any of the
azure services communicate with each
other in a secure manner in a private
manner next we have azure dns so azure
dns is a hosting service which allows
you to host their dns or domain name
system domains in azure so you can host
your application using azure dns now for
the storage services first up we have
disk storage with this storage you are
given a cost effective option of
choosing hdd or solid state drives to go
along with your virtual machines based
on your requirements then you have blob
storage now this is actually optimized
to ensure that they can store massive
amounts of unstructured data which can
include text data or even binary data
next you have file storage which is a
managed file storage and can be
accessible via the smb protocol or the
server message block protocol and
finally you have queue storage now with
queue storage you can provide durable
message queuing for an extremely large
workload and the most important part is
that this can be accessed from anywhere
in the world now let's talk about how
azure can be used firstly for
application development it could be any
application mostly web applications then
you can test the application see how
well it works you can host the
application on the internet you can
create virtual machines like i mentioned
before with the service you can create
these virtual machines of any size or
ram that you want you can integrate in
sync features you can collect and store
matrices for example how the data works
how the current data is how you can
improve upon it all of that is possible
with these services and you have virtual
hard drives which is an extension of the
virtual machines where these services
are able to provide you a large amount
of storage where data can be stored i'm
sam an azure cloud architect working for
simply learn and i'm more than glad to
walk you through this session where
we're gonna talk about azure in great
length and breadth and if you're looking
for a video that talks and walks you
through all the services in azure then
this could be one of the best video you
could find in the internet and without
any further delay let's get started
everybody like story is it so let's get
started with the story in a city not so
far away a ceo had plans to expand his
company globally and called one of his
id personnel for an i.t opinion and this
guy has been in the company for a long
time and is very seasoned with the
company's infra and he nicely answered
the questions with what he foresaw and
he said i have a good news and a bad
news for us to go global and he starts
with the good news he said sir we're
well on our way to become one of the
world's largest shipping company and the
bad news is however our data centers
have almost run out of space and setting
up new ones around the world would be
too expensive and very time consuming
now the it personal let's call him mike
now he explains the situation from how
he saw it but the ceo had done some
homework about how he was going to do it
and he answered mike saying don't worry
about that mic i've come up with a
solution for a problem and it's called
microsoft azure well mike is an
hard-working and honest i.t professional
working for that company but he did not
spend time on learning the latest
technologies and he asked this question
very honestly oh how does it solve a
problem and the ceo begins to explain
azure to mike and he starts with what is
cloud computing and then he goes on and
talks about azure and the service is
offered by azure and why azure is better
than the other cloud providers and what
are the great companies that uses azure
and how they got benefited out of it and
then he winds it all up with the use
cases of azure so he begins his
explanation saying microsoft azure is
known as the cloud service provider and
it works on the basis of cloud computing
now microsoft azure is formerly known as
windows azure and it's a microsoft's
public cloud computing platform it
and scale our applications or even plan
on running existing applications in the
public cloud microsoft azure is both a
platform as a service and infrastructure
as a service let's now fit their
conversation out and let's talk about
what is cloud computing azure services
offered by azure how is azure leading
when compared to other cloud service
providers and what are the companies
that are using azure let's talk about
that in simple terms cloud computing is
being able to access compute services
like servers storage database networking
software analytics intelligence and lot
more over the internet which is the
cloud with the uh flexibility of the
resources that we use like anytime i
want a result i can use one and it
becomes available immediately and
anytime if i want to retire and results
i can simply retire as a service and not
pay for it and we also
typically pay only for the services that
we use and this helps greatly with our
operating cost to run our infrastructure
more efficiently and scale our
environment up or down depending on the
business needs and changes and all the
servers and storages and databases and
networking all that are accessed through
the network of remote systems or remote
computers hosted in the internet
typically in the provider's data center
which is azure in this case now we don't
use any physical server or an
on-premises server here well we still
use physical servers and vms you know
hosted on a hardware or a physical
server but they're all in the provider's
environment and none of them sit on
premises or in our data center we only
access them remotely it looks and feels
the same except for the fact that they
are in a remote location we access them
remotely do all the work remotely and
when we're done we can shut it down and
not pay for them so some of the use
cases
some of the use cases of cloud computing
are creating applications and services
the other use cases are storing or using
cloud for storage alone
if there is one thing that ever grows in
their organization is the storage every
new day there is a new storage
requirement and it's very dynamic it's
very hard to predict and if we go out
and buy a big storage capacity up front
until we use the storage capacity fully
the empty storages you know we're
wasting money on them so instead i can
go for a storage with scales dynamically
that's in the cloud put storage or put
data in the cloud and pay only for what
you're storing and for the next month if
you have deleted or flushed out some
files or data pay less for it so it's a
very dynamic storage in the cloud and a
lot of companies are getting benefited
from storing data in the cloud because
of its uh dynamic in nature and the cost
that comes along with it the cheap cost
that comes along with it and also they
give a lot of the providers like azure
they give a data replication for free
they promise an sla along with the data
we store in the cloud so there's an sla
attached to it and they also provide
data recoveries as well if in case
something goes wrong with the physical
disk where our data is stored azure
automatically makes our data available
from the redundant or
other places where it had stored our
data because of the sla they wanted to
keep the other use case for azure is
hosting websites and running blogs using
the compute service
be it storing music and letting your
users stream the music azure is a good
place to store music and stream the
music with the benefit of
cdn
content delivery network which allows us
to stream a video or audio files with
great speed you know with that with
azure our audio or video application
works seamlessly because they are
provided to the client with very low
latency and that improves the customer
experience for our application azure
compute service is a good place for
delivering software on demand there are
a lot of software's embedded softwares
that we can buy using azure and
everything on a pay pay-as-you-go
service model so anytime we need a
software we can go out and immediately
buy the software for the next one or two
hour let's say and use them and then
return it back
we're not bound to any
yearly licensing cost by that azure
computing services has analytic
available for us with which we can
analyze get a good visualization of
what's going on in a network be it logs
be the performance be the metrics you
know instead of looking at logs and
searching logs and trying to do manual
things over the heaps and heaps of logs
that we have saved azure analytics
services helps us to get a good visual
of what's going on in the network where
have we dropped where have we increased
or what's causing what's the major
driver what is the top 10 errors that we
get in the server in the application
stuff like that those can be easily
gathered from the azure analytic
services
now cloud is really a very cool term for
the internet a good analogy would be
looking back any time we look at a
diagram when we do not know how things
are transferred we simply draw a cloud
right for example a male gets sent from
a person in one country to a person in
the other country a lot of things
happening in between from the time you
hit the send button and the time the
other person hits the real button right
and we let the simple and the easiest
way of putting it in a picture is simply
draw a cloud and on the one end one
person will be sending the email and on
the other end the other person will be
reading the email so a cloud is a really
cool term for the internet now that's
some basics about cloud computing now
that we've understood about cloud
computing in general let's talk about
microsoft azure as a cloud service
now microsoft azure is a set of cloud
services to build
manage and deploy applications on a
network with the help of microsoft
azure's frameworks now microsoft azure
is a computing service created by
microsoft basically for building testing
deploying and managing applications and
services through a global network of
microsoft managed data centers now
microsoft azure provides sas which is
software as a service and pass which is
platform as a service and iaas
infrastructure as a service and they
support many different programming
languages tools and framework and those
tools and framework include both
microsoft specific and third-party
software
now let me pick and talk about a
specific service for example management
azure automation provides a way for us
to automate the manual long running and
frequently repeated tasks that are
commonly performed tasks both in cloud
and enterprise environment it saves a
lot of time and increases the
reliability and it kind of gives a good
administrative control and even
schedules the task automatically to be
performed on a regular basis
to give you a quick history of microsoft
azure it was launched on 1 february 2010
and it was awarded or it was called
an industry leader for infrastructure
and platform as a service by a gartner
now gartner is the world's leading
research and advisory company this
microsoft azure supports a number of
programming languages like c sharp java
and python all these cool services we
get to use and pay only for how much we
use for example if we use for an r we
only get to pay for an r even the
costliest system available if we use
them for an r we only pay for that
particular r and then we're done no more
billing on the resource that we have
used
microsoft azure has spread itself more
than 50 regions around the world so it's
quite easy for us to pick a region and
it will start provisioning and running
our applications probably from day one
because the infrastructure and the tools
and technologies needed to run our
application are already available all
that we have to do is commit the code in
that particular region or build an
application and launch it in that
particular region and they become live
starting day one now because we have 50
regions around the world we can very
carefully design our environment to
provide low latency services to our
customers all right instead of in
traditional data center let's say you
know customers will have to or their
request will have to travel all the way
around the globe to reach a data center
which lives in the other side of the
planet and this adds more latency to it
and it is really not feasible to build a
data center
near
each customer location because of the
cost involved but with azure it's
possible azure already has data centers
around the world and all that we have to
do is just pick a data center build an
environment there they are available
starting day one number one and also the
cost is considerably saved because we
are using a public cloud instead of an
physical infrastructure to serve those
customers from a very local location and
these services that azure is offering is
ever increasing as of now as we speak we
have like 200 plus services offered and
they span through different domain or
different platform or different
technologies available within the azure
console portal now we're going to talk
about that later in this section so hold
your breath till we talk about it but
for now just know that we have like 200
plus services offered by azure
let's now talk about different services
and azure starting with artificial
intelligence plus machine learning where
we have a lot of tools and technologies
so the wide variety of services
available on azure includes artificial
intelligence plus machine learning plus
analytic services to get and or to give
us a good visual of how the data or how
the application is performing or the
type of the category of data stored and
to read from the logs and variety of
compute services different vms with
different size and different operating
systems different containers available
different type of databases available a
lot of developer tools that are
available for us
an identity service to
manage our users in the azure cloud and
those users can be integrated or
federated with let's say google facebook
you know linkedin so there are some
external federation services they can be
used to integrate with our identity
system iots iot services iot tools and
technologies available and management
tools to manage the users you know
creating identity is one and then
managing them on top of it is an a
totally different thing and we have
tools technologies to manage the users
cool services for data migration data
migration is now made simple tools and
technologies available for mobile
application development and i can plan
my own network in the cloud with the
networking services i can implement my
own security both azure provider and
third-party security services on azure
cloud that's now possible and a lot of
storage options available in the cloud
so these are just a glimpse of the big
list of services available in azure
cloud so that was a glimpse of what's
available in the cloud let's talk about
the services in a specific let's take
compute for example you know whenever
we're building a new application or
deploying existing ones
the azure compute service provides the
infrastructure we need to run and
maintain our application we can easily
tap in the capacity that azure cloud
service has and we can scale our compute
requirement on demand we can also
containerize our application we have the
option of choosing windows or linux via
machine and take the advantage of the
flexible options azure provides for us
to migrate our vms to azure and lot more
and these compute services also include
a full-fledged identity solution meaning
integration with active directory in the
cloud or in on-premises and lot more
let's look at some of the services that
this compute domain provides
some of the services the compute domain
provides are virtual machines and this
azure virtual machines
gives us the ability to develop and
manage a virtual computer environment or
a virtualized environment inside azure's
cloud environment that too in a virtual
private network now we will talk about
virtual private network at a later point
but as of now just
know that there are a lot of services
available in azure compute servers that
we can get benefited from we can always
choose from a very wide range of compute
options
for example you know we have an option
to choose the operating system we have
the option to choose whether the system
should be in on premises or in the cloud
or do we want to maintain the
environment both in on premises and in
the cloud we have the option of choosing
the operating system whether we want to
use our own operating system with some
software attached to it or do we want to
go and buy the operating system from the
cloud from azure marketplace and these
are just a few of the options available
for us when we want to buy the compute
environment and these compute
environments are easily scalable meaning
we can easily scale our vm instances
from one instance to thousands of
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
or simply put in a couple of button
clicks and all these services are
available on a pay for what we use model
meaning there is no upfront cost we use
the service and then pay for the
services that we have used there is no
literal long-term commitment when it
comes to using virtual machines in the
cloud and these most of the services are
built on a
pay-per-minute billing basis all right
and at no point because of the
pay-per-minute billing model at no point
we will be overpaying for any of the
services that's that's attractive isn't
it now let's talk about batch service
now batch service is always independent
regardless of whether you choose windows
or linux it's going to run fairly well
and with batch servers we can take
advantage of the environment's unique
features and not only that in short the
batch service helps us to manage
the whole batch environment and also it
helps to schedule the jobs now this
azure batch services actually runs on a
large scale parallel and high
performance computing because of that
batch jobs are highly efficient in azure
and when we run bad services this azure
batch creates a pool of computer nodes
and installs the needed applications
that we want to run and then it
schedules jobs to those individual nodes
in those pools as a customer there is no
need for us to install a cluster or
there is no need for us to install a
software that actually can use the jobs
or even to manage or even to scale those
infrastructure or the software because
everything is managed by azure and this
batch service is a platform as a service
there is no additional charge for using
this batch service except for i mean the
only charges that will be paying is for
the virtual machines that the service
uses and the storage that we will be
using of course and
the networking services that we would be
using for this batch service let's
summarize this bad service we have a
choice of operating system that we can
pick and use and it scales by itself now
the alternative for the batch would be
queues but in queues we'll have to
pre-provision and pay for the
infrastructure even if we're not using
it but with a batch
we only pay for what we use and this bad
service helps us to manage the
application manage the scheduling as a
whole as if they are just one thing as
next thing in the compute domain let's
talk about this fabric service now this
fabric service is actually a distributed
system platform that helps us to package
deploy and manage a scalable and a very
reliable microservice and containers and
what does it help this azure fabric
service helps us or it helps the
developers and administrators so they
can avoid the complex infrastructure
problems and they can focus only on
implementing workloads or taking care of
their development taking care of their
application instead of spending time on
infrastructure so what service fabric
service fabric it provides runtime
capabilities and life cycle management
two applications that are composed of
microservices no infrastructure
management at all and with service
fabric we can easily scale the
application to tens or hundreds or even
to thousands of machines here machines
represent containers as next thing in
compute domain let's talk about virtual
machine scale set now this virtual
machine scales that it lets us to create
a group of identical load balanced vms i
just want to mention it again it helps
us to manage a group identical and load
balanced vms the number of instances or
the number of vm instances in an in a
skill set can increase or decrease in
response to
the demand or in response to a schedule
that we define you know the resources
needed on a monday morning is not the
same as that would be required on a
saturday or a sunday morning all right
and even within the day the resources
that would be needed in the beginning of
the business hour is not the resources
that would be needed at noon or you know
after eight or nine in the evening so
the demands could actually vary in the
environment and this scale set helps us
to take care of the varying demand or
take care of the different
infrastructure requirement at a
different schedule throughout the day
throughout the week throughout the month
or could be throughout the year as well
the skill set also allows us to provide
high availability to our applications
and it helps us to centrally manage
configure and update a large number of
vms as if they they are just one thing
now you might ask well virtual machines
are enough why would we need a virtual
machine scale set just like i said this
virtual machine skill set helps us with
a greater redundancy and improved
performance for our applications and
those applications can be accessed
through a load balancer that actually
distributes the request to the
application instances so in a nutshell
this virtual machine scale set it helps
us to create a large number of identical
virtual machines number one and with
skill set we can increase or decrease
the virtual machines with virtual
machine scale set we can centrally
manage and configure and update a big
group of vms and it's a great use case
when it comes to big data or container
workloads as next thing in compute
domain let's talk about cloud services
now this azure cloud service is actually
a platform as a service and it's very
friendly in fact it is designed for
applications that support scalability or
an application that requires scalability
or reliability and and on top of it you
want them to be very inexpensive to
operate so azure cloud service provides
all these so where would this cloud
service run well it runs on a vm but
it's a platform as a service vms are
infrastructure as a service and when we
run applications on vm through cloud
service it becomes platform as a service
so here is how you got to be thinking
with infrastructure as a service like
vms we first create and configure the
environment and then we run applications
on top of it let's look at the
responsibility the responsibility for us
in vm is that we manage everything end
to end like
you know deploying new patches picking
the versions of the operating system and
making sure they are intact and all that
stuff it's all managed by us but on the
contrary with platform as a service it's
i mean it's as if the environment is
already ready all that you have to do is
deploy your application in it and manage
the platform i mean manage the platform
not as an administrator because all the
administration is taken care by azure
like uh deploying new versions of the
operating system it's all handled by the
azure so we deploy the application and
we manage the application that's it
infrastructure management is handled by
azure so what does cloud service provide
this cloud service provides a platform
where we can
write the
application code and we don't have to
worry about hardware simply hand over
the code and cloud service takes care of
it so no worry on the hardware at all so
responsibilities like patching what do
we do if something
crashes how do i update the
infrastructure how do i manage
the maintenance or the downtime in the
underlying infrastructure all that is
handled by azure it also provides a good
testing environment for us you know we
can simply run the code test it before
it's actually released to the production
i want to expand a bit on these testing
applications so this azure cloud service
it actually gives us an staging
environment for testing a new release
without it affecting the existing
release which actually reduces the
customer downtime so we can run the
application test it and anytime that's
ready for production all that's needed
for us to do to move it to production is
simply to swap the staging environment
into the production environment and the
old production environment will now
become the new staging environment where
we can
add more to it and then swap it back at
a later point so it kind of gives us a
swappable environment for testing our
applications and not only that it gives
us health monitoring alerts it helps us
to monitor the health and availability
of our application and there is a
dashboard we can benefit from when we
use azure cloud services and that shows
the key statistics all in one place and
we can also set up real-time alerts to
one when a service availability or a
certain metrics that we are concerned
about degrades as next thing in compute
domain let's talk about functions now
functions are serverless computing many
times if you heard about azure being
serverless a lot of time they are
referencing or the person who's talking
to you is referencing to serverless
computing or azure functions which is a
serverless computing service hosted on
microsoft azure the main motive of
a function is to accelerate and simplify
application development functions helps
us to run code on demand without
we need to pre-provision or manage any
azure infrastructure so azure functions
are script or
a piece of code that gets run in
response to an event that you want to
handle so in short we can just write a
code that you need for a problem at hand
without actually worrying about the
whole application or the infrastructure
that will be running
that code and the best of all the best
is when we use functions we only pay for
the time
that our code runs
so what does functions provide or what
does azure functions provide azure
functions allow users to build
applications using serverless
simple functions with the programming
language of our choice so the current
programming languages that are supported
is c sharp f sharp node.js java and php
so here we really don't have to worry
about provisioning or maintaining
servers if a code requires more resource
yes azure functions handles or it
provides the additional resources needed
by the court and the best part is we
only pay for the amount of time the
functions are running not the resources
but the amount of time the function is
running as next thing and moving to the
new domain let's talk about the
container domain in azure now the
container domain or the container
service it allows us to quickly deploy a
production ready kubernetes or a docker
swamp cluster now what's a container a
container is a standard unit of software
that packages of code and all its
dependencies so the applications run
quickly and reliably from one computing
environment to another it could be a
testing uh to staging to developing
development environment to staging to
production or from one production to
another production or on-premises to
cloud or one cloud to another cloud vice
versa now imagine we had an option not
to worry about the vm and just focus on
the application well that's exactly
what containers helps us achieve so
these container instances enable us to
focus on applications and not worrying
about managing vms or not worrying about
the learning the new tools required to
manage the vms or even the deployment
and our applications that we create they
run in a container running in a
container is what helps us to achieve
all these not being able to manage or
not needing to manage the virtual
machines so these containers
they can be deployed into the cloud
using a single command if you're using
command line interface and
a couple of button clicks if we are
using the azure portal and these
containers are kept lightweight but they
are equally secure as virtual machines
let's talk about container services next
thing the container service or
sometimes called as azure kubernetes
service it helps us to manage the
containers container is one thing and a
service that's used to manage the
container is another thing now this
kubernetes service or acs it helps us to
manage the containers so let's expand on
this a bit so this azure container
service or acs it it actually provides a
way to simplify
the creation configuration and
management of a cluster of virtual
machines that are pre-configured to run
containerized applications on top of
them and deploying them deploying these
containers might take like 15 to 20
minutes or deploying the virtual
machines that run containers in it might
take 15 to 20 minutes and once they are
provisioned we can actually manage them
by using simple ssh tunnel into them and
this acs when it runs application it
runs applications from docker images
what does that mean a docker images
makes sure that the applications the
container runs are fully portable images
are portable and acs also helps us to
orchestrate the container environment
not only that it also helps us to ensure
that these applications that we run in
containers can be scaled to thousands or
even tens of thousands of containers so
in a nutshell managing an existing
application into a container and running
it using aks or acs is really easy or
that's what it is all about to make the
application management or migration easy
now managing the container based
architecture and we discussed that
containers could be tens or even tens of
thousands of containers so managing them
is made
simple using this container services and
even training of model using a large
data set in a complex and resource
intensive environment this aks helps us
to simplify that environment all right
as next thing in container domain let's
talk about container registry we spoke
about registry a little bit when we
spoke about docker images so container
registry is a single place where we can
store our images which are docker images
when we use when we use containers it's
it's docker images that we use for our
image purposes so these container images
are a central registry that can be used
to ease container development by easing
the storage and management of container
images so there we can store all kinds
of images like
docker swamp or the images used in
docker swamp are in kubernetes
everything can be stored in container
registry in azure now anytime we store a
container image it provides us an option
for geo replication what that means is
that we can efficiently manage a single
registry replicated across multiple
regions now these jio replication it
actually enables us to manage global
deployments assuming we are having an
environment that requires a global
deployment so it helps us to manage
global deployments as one entity because
we are geo replicating we would be
updating we would be editing one image
and that image gets replicated
throughout
the global
replication centers we would have set up
and so just one editing would have
actually edited the global images and
those global images would have
provisioned at the global application so
one edit replication and then
provisioning of the applications
global wide and this replication also
helps us to
helps us network latency because you
know anytime an application needs to
deploy it does not have to rely on a
single source which which can be reached
only through high latency network
because we have global replications
around the world anytime the application
wants to check back it would check back
the application which is in a very
nearby location for the application
itself global replication means that we
are managing it as a single entity
that's being replicated across the
multiple regions in the globe as next
thing in our learning let's talk about
azure databases now this azure databases
are rational in fact they have many
flavors in them we're going to look at
different
flavors or sql nosql cache type of
database that azure offers so we're
going to learn one at a time or are we
going to learn one by one so this azure
sql database is a relational database in
fact it's a rational database as a
service it's managed by azure we don't
get to do a lot of management in it so
it's a regional database as a service
based on microsoft
sql server database engine and this
database is a high performance database
it's very reliable and
it's very secure as well and this high
reliability high performance and for
this high security really don't have to
do anything it comes along with it and
it's managed by azure and there are two
things that i definitely need to mention
about azure sql database that is it's an
intelligent service number one it's
fully managed by azure and it also has
this one good thing which is it has
built-in intelligence that learns app
patterns and adapts to maximize
performance and reliability and data
protection of the application that's
something that's not found in
many of the other cloud providers that
i'm aware of so i thought i'll mention
it so it uses built-in intelligence to
learn about the user's database patterns
and helps improve performance and
protection and migration or importing
data is very easy when it comes to azure
sql database so it can be readily or
immediately used for analytic reporting
and
intelligent applications in azure as
next thing let's talk about azure
cosmodb now azure cosmodb is a database
service that is for nosql type and it's
it's created to provide low latency and
an application that scales dynamically
or that scales rapidly
now this azure cosmodb is an
a globally distributed service and it's
a multi-model
database this can be provisioned in a
click of a button that's all we got to
do if we need to provision and azure
cosmodb in the azure it helps with
scaling the database now we can
elastically and independently scale
throughput and storage across this
database and in any of the azure
geographic regions it provides a good
throughput it provides good latency it
provides good availability and
it provides or
azure promises a comprehensive sla that
no other database can offer that's the
best part about cosmodb so this cosmodb
was built with global distribution in
mind and it's built
with the horizontal scale in mind and
all this we can use by only paying for
what we have used and remember the
difference between azure cosmodb and the
sql database is that azure cosmodb
supports nosql whereas sql doesn't all
right few other things about azure
cosmodb is it allows users to use key
value graph a column family and document
data it also gives users a number of ap
options like sql javascript mongodb and
and few others that you might want to
check in the document at the time of
reading and the best part here is that
all that we mentioned we get to use only
by paying for the amount of storage and
throughput that are required and the
storage and the throughput can be
elastically scaled based on the
requirement of that r all right let's
talk about
redis cash discussion about azure
database won't be complete without we
talking about redis cache now redis
cache is a secure data cache it's also
called it's also sometimes called as
messaging broker that provides high
throughput and low latency access to
data for the applications now that is
cash is based on an a popular open
source caching product which is redis
sometimes called as that is cash now
what's the use case it's typically used
to cash to improve the performance and
scalability of a system that rely
heavily on backend data stores now
performance when we use zs cache is
improved by temporarily copying the
frequently accessed data to a fast
storage located very close to the
application now with redis cache this
fast storage is located in memory with
redis cache instead of being loaded from
the actual disk in the database itself
now this redis cache can also be used as
an in-memory data structure store not
only that it can be used as a
distributed non-relational database and
a message broker so there are a variety
of use cases for this redis cache and by
using redis cache the application
performance is improved by taking
advantage of the low latency and the
high throughput performance that this
redis cache engine provides so to
summarize this redis cache when we use
redis cache data is stored in the memory
instead of the disk to ensure that there
is high throughput and low latency when
the application needs to read the data
it provides various levels of scaling
without any downtime or interference now
this redis cache is actually backed by
reduce server and it supports
a string hashes linked list and various
other data structures now let's talk
about security and identity services now
identity management in specific is a
process of authenticating first and then
authorizing using security principles
and not only that identity management
involves controlling information about
those principle identities you might ask
now what's a principle identity now
identity or principle identity are
services applications users groups and a
lot more the speciality about this
identity management is that it not only
helps authenticate and authorize
principles in cloud it also helps
authenticate and authorize principles or
resources on premises especially when
you run an hybrid cloud environment so
all these services and features that
this identity management helps us to get
additional level of validation like
identity management can provide
multi-factor authentication it can
provide access policies based on
condition a permit or deny based on
condition it can also monitor suspicious
activity and not only that it can also
report it it can also help generate
alerts for potential security issues and
in a way to mitigate it can send us an
alert so we can get involved and prevent
and a security accident from happening
so let's talk more about identity
management so some of the services under
security and identity management are
azure security center now this azure
security center provides
security management and threat
protection across the workloads in both
cloud and in the hybrid environment it
helps control user access and
application control to stop any
malicious activity if present it helps
us to find and fix vulnerabilities
before they can be even exploited it
integrates very well with analytic
methods that helps us to identify or it
gives us the intelligent to identify or
detect attacks and prevent them before
it can actually happen
and it also works seamlessly with hybrid
environments so you don't have to have
one policy for on-premises and one
policy for the cloud it's now a unified
service both for on-premises and the
cloud the next service and security and
identity would be key vault now a key
vault is a service or a feature that
helps safeguard the cryptographic keys
and any other secrets used by the cloud
applications and the services in other
words this azure keyword is a tool for
securely storing and accessing the
secrets of the environment i mean the
secret keys now a secret is anything
that you really want to have a very
tight control access like the
certificates like the passwords stuff
like that now if i tell you what keyword
actually
solves that would actually explain what
keyword is now key vault is used in
secrets management it's helped in
securely storing the tokens the
passwords the certificates it helps in
key management and it really helps in
creating and controlling the encryption
keys that we would use to encrypt data
it helps in certificate management
talking about certification management
it helps us to easily provision manage
and deploy public and private ssl tls
certificates in azure and lot more so in
a nutshell this keyword it provides
users the ability to provision new walls
and keys in just a matter of minutes all
that in a single command or all that in
a couple of button clicks it also helps
users to centrally manage their keys
secrets and policies
next in the list let's talk about azure
active directory now azure active
directory it helps us to create
intelligent driven access policies to
limit resource usage and manage user
identities but what does that mean now
this azure active directory is a cloud
based active directory and identity
management service now azure active
directory combines and it's actually a
combination of the core directory
services plus application access
management plus identity protection and
one good thing about this azure in fact
there are a lot of good things but
especially when you're running hybrid
environments you might wonder well how
this azure active directory is going to
behave now this azure active directory
is built to work on on-premises and
cloud environment as well not only that
it also works seamlessly with mobile
applications as well so in a nutshell
this azure active directory it acts as
an central point of identity and access
management for our cloud environment it
also provides good security solutions
that protect against unauthorized access
of our app and the data
now that we've discussed about security
and identity let's talk about the
management tools that azure has to offer
azure provides built-in management and
account governance tools that helps
administrators and
developers that helps them to keep their
resources secure and very compliant and
again it helps both in on premises and
in the cloud environment and these
management tools help us to monitor the
infrastructure monitor the applications
it also helps in provisioning and
configuring resources it also helps in
updating apps it helps in analyzing
threats taking backup of the resources
build disaster recoveries
it also helps in applying policies and
conditions to automate our environment
we use azure management tools and it's
also used in cost control methods so
this azure management plays a wide role
across the azure services
and in the management tools first comes
the azure advisor now this azure advisor
it acts as a guide to educate us about
azure best practices it throws
recommendations that we can select on
the basis of the category of servers and
it also provides the impact it can have
or the impact that would happen in our
environment if we follow the
recommendations given and
recommendations are
first one is the recommendations are
kind of templatized and it throws the
templatized recommendations not only
that it also provides customized
recommendations on the basis of the
configuration on the basis of our usage
patents and these recommendations are
not hard it's not like something that it
recommends and then just leaves us
hanging there these recommendations
provided are very easy to follow very
easy to implement and see results you
can think of as advisor as an very
personalized cloud consultant that helps
you to follow best practices to optimize
our deployments it kind of analyzes our
resources our configurations our usage
and then it recommends a solution for us
that really helps in improving the cost
effectiveness improving the performance
improving high availability and
improving security in our azure
environment so with this azure advisor
we can get a proactive
actionable and personalized best
practice recommendations now you don't
have to be an expert just follow the
azure advisor and your environment is
going to be good it also helps in
improve the performance security high
availability of our environment and also
it helps in bringing down the overall
azure spend and the best part is it's a
free service that analyzes our azure
usage and provides recommendations how
we can optimize our azure resource to
reduce cost and reduce cost at the same
time boost the performance helps in
strengthening the security and improve
the overall reliability of our
environment
next in the list would be network
watcher now this network watcher helps
users identify and gain insights in the
overall network performance and the
health of the overall environment now
these azure watchers provides enough
tools to monitor to diagnose to view the
metrics and to enable or disable logs
which means regenerate and collect the
logs for resources in the azure virtual
network so with network watcher you can
monitor and diagnose issues in
networking without even logging into the
virtual machines with just the logs
which are real time we can actually come
to a conclusion what could be wrong in a
certain resource in a vm or in a
database you know by just looking at the
logs and not only that it's used for
analytic or to gain some intelligence of
what's happening in our network we can
gain a lot of insight to the current
network traffic pattern using the
security group flow logs that this
network watcher offers it also helps in
investigating vpn connectivity issues
using detailed logs now you might or
might not know that you know vpn
troubleshooting requires both parties or
it involves two parties another person
the network administrator on this side
and the network administrator on the
other side and they will have to check
logs in their end and we'll have to
check logs and hour and stuff like that
but with the network watcher it kind of
takes it to the next level the logs
itself we could easily identify which
side is having the issue and suggest an
appropriate fix
and the next in the list would be
microsoft azure portal now this
microsoft azure portal it provides a
single unified console to perform
various number of activities like
building not only building managing and
monitoring the web applications that we
build now this portal can be used to
organize our environment or the
appearance of the environment or the
visual of the environment based on our
work style and using azure portal users
can control who gets to manage or access
the resources all from the azure portal
and this azure portal gives a very good
visibility on the spends that happen on
each resource right and if we can
customize it we can also identify spends
based on team spends based on days
spends based on department stuff like
that so it kind of gives us a good
visual of
where the money is spending or where is
the bill consumed within the azure
environment
next in the list would be azure resource
manager now azure resource manager
enables us to manage
the usage of the application resources
now we use resource manager to deploy
monitor and manage solution resources as
a group as if it's one single entity now
the infrastructure of our application is
typically made of various components
which includes virtual machine storage
virtual network web app database servers
some other third-party services that we
might use in our environment and they
are by nature separate services but with
azure resource manager we don't see them
as different components or different
entities instead we see them as related
services in a group that supports an
application now we kind of get the
relation between them instead of you
know letting them spread azure resource
manager identifies the relation between
them and helps us to visually see them
all as one or single entity not only
that azure resource manager helps or it
ensures that the resources that we
provision are deployed at a constant
rate along with the other application
it also helps users to visually see
their resources and how they are
connected and that helps in managing the
resources lot better
resource group also is used to control
who can access the resources within the
user's organization kind of gives you
the fine grained control over who gets
to access and who does not get access
and the last one in the management tools
would be automation and this automation
gives us the ability to automate
configure and install upgrades across
hybrid environments
it provides a cloud-based automation and
configuration service not only that this
can be applied for non-azure
environments as well which is
on-premises so some of the automation we
could do is process automation update
management automation configuration
features automation stuff like that and
this azure automation provides complete
control during the deployment operation
and also during the decommissioning of
the workloads and resources
with automation we can actually automate
a time consuming or
mundane or any task that's error prone
because of human errors those things can
be automated so irrespective of how many
times you run it it's going to run the
same way and that really helps in
reducing the overall time and also the
overhead cost because a lot of the
things are automated which means it's
human error-free which means the
application is not going to break and
keep running for a longer time with
automation we can actually build a good
inventory of operating system resources
and configuration items all in one place
with ease and this really helps in
tracking the changes and investigating
the issue let's say something happened
because we have automation because it's
logging the configuration changes it's
easy to track easy to identify easy to
identify what has changed lately that
has broken the environment go back and
fix it or kind of roll it back that
solves the problem and that actually
summarizes the azure management tools or
management services now let's talk about
the networking tools or the networking
services available in azure there are
variety of services especially
networking services that azure offers
and i'm sure it's going to be an
interesting one let's begin our
discussion with content delivery network
now the content delivery network in
short cdn it allows us to perform secure
and a very reliable content delivery not
only that it also helps in accelerating
the delivery time or in other words
reducing the delivery time also called
as low times it also helps in saving
bandwidth and increases in
responsiveness to the application let's
expand on this the content delivery
network is actually a distributed
network of servers that can efficiently
deliver web content to users now cdns
we're going to use the word cdn here
cdns store cached content on global edge
servers also called as
pops point of presence locations that
are very close to the end users so the
latency is minimized it's like taking a
copy of the data or taking a multiple
copy of the data and storing it in
different parts of the world and whoever
is requesting it the data gets delivered
to them from a server which is very
locally to them so this cdn offers
developers a global solution for rapidly
delivering high bandwidth content to
users by caching the content in a
strategically placed location which is
very near to them so these content
delivery networks it really helps in
handling that's one advantage you get
for content delivery network that's we
can handle spikes and heavy loads very
efficiently and we can also run analytic
against the locks that gets generated in
content delivery network which helps in
gaining good insight on the workflow and
what would be the future business need
for that application and this just like
a lot of other services this is on a pay
as you go type so you use the results
first and then you only pay for what you
have used
the next one in networking would be
express route now express route is
actually a circuit or a link that
provides an a direct private connection
to azure and because it's direct it
gives low latency link to azure it gives
good speed and reliability for the azure
data transfer it could be on premises to
azure so it gives very good speed it
gives increased reliability and low
latency for that connection let's expand
on this a bit
now this express route is an service
that actually provides and private
connection between microsoft data center
and infrastructure in our premises or in
a different co-location facility that we
might have now these express routes do
not go over the public internet and
because they don't go over the public
internet they offer a high security
reliability and speed and low latency
compared to the connections which are in
the internet because it's fast because
it's reliable because it has low latency
it can be used as an extension of our
existing data center you know users are
not going to feel the difference whether
they are accessing services from an
on-premises or in the cloud environment
because latency is minimized as much as
possible users are really not going to
see the difference
and because it's a private line and not
an public internet line it can be used
to build hybrid applications without
compromising a privacy or at the
performance
now these virtual private cloud these
express routes can be used for taking
backups if assume a backup going through
the internet that would be a nightmare
if you use express route for backups
that's going to be
fast and imagine recovering a data
through the internet from the cloud
through the internet to the on premises
in a time of disaster that would be the
worst nightmare so these express routes
can be used not only to backup but also
to recover the data because it provides
good speed low latency recovering the
data is going to be a lot sooner the
next product or service we're going to
discuss in networking is azure dns now
azure dns allows us to host domain name
in azure and these domain names come
with an exceptional performance and
availability now azure dns is used to
set up and manage dns zones and records
for our domain name in the cloud now
this azure dns is a service for dns just
like the name says and it provides name
resolution by using azures
infrastructure and by using this domain
we can actually manage the dns ourselves
through the azure portal with the same
credential imagine having a dns provider
which does not even belong in our it
imagine that environment you know we
would have a separate portal to manage
the dns environment now those are gone
and now we can actually manage the dns
in the very same azure portal where we
use the rest of the other services and
this azure dns very much integrates with
other dns service providers it uses a
global network of name servers to
provide fast response to dns queries
and these domains are having additional
availability compared to the other
domain service providers availability
promises these are going to have more
availability than the rest because
most of the servers are maintained by a
microsoft and it helps resolve sooner it
helps re-syncing let's say a server
fails it kind of helps resyncing with
the rest of the servers so all the
microsoft's environment all the
microsoft global network of name servers
kind of ensures that our domain names
are resolved properly not only properly
but also are available most of the time
right next in the list in networking
services is virtual network i'm sure
this is going to be very interesting and
i'm sure you're going to like it so this
networking or virtual networking in
azure it actually allows us to set up
our own private cloud
in the public cloud it gives us an
isolated and highly secure environment
for our application let's expand on this
so this azure virtual network helps us
to provision azure virtual machines and
it helps us to securely communicate with
other on-premises and internet networks
it also helps in controlling the traffic
that flows through or flows in and out
of this virtual network to other virtual
networks and to the internet now this
azure a virtual network sometimes called
as v-net is actually a representation of
our own network in the cloud it's
actually a logical isolation of the
azure cloud dedicated to our
subscription all our environments are
provisioned in a v-net that is separate
from another customer's units that way
we have that logical separation there so
this virtual network can also be used to
provision uh vpns in the cloud so we can
connect the cloud and the on-premises
infrastructure and lot more especially
in a environment where we have hybrid
environment surely we will be using
virtual network because that's going to
require a vpn for secure data transfer
in and out of the cloud and in and out
of the on-premises environment
all right so it kind of gives us an
boundary for all the resources so all
the traffic between the azure resources
they kind of logically stay in between
or logically stay within the azure
virtual network and here we can design
the network it's given over to us you
know you can pick the ip you can pick
the routing you can pick the subnet and
a lot of freedom is given or i would say
a lot of control on how the network is
designed it's not like something that's
already cooked and we only get to use it
now we can actually build the network
from the scratch we can pick the ip
address that we like we can pick you
know which subnet needs to communicate
with the other subnets stuff like that
and like i said if you are using hybrid
environment you definitely would be
requiring a virtual network because it
helps connect the on-premises and the
cloud in a secure fashion using vpn the
last product we're going to discuss in
networking is a load balancer this load
balancer actually provides application a
good availability and a good network
performance so how does it work it
actually works by load balancing the
traffic to and from the virtual machine
and the cloud resources not only that it
also load balances between cloud and
across premises which virtual networks
with azure load balancer we can actually
scale our application and create high
availability for our services which
means our application will be available
most of the time if any of the server
goes dead the server does not get
traffic what happens if the server gets
traffic user is going to experience
downtime what happens if the server does
not get traffic user won't experience
any downtime the connection is shifted
to an healthy service so the user
experiences uptime all the time so this
load balancer supports inbound and
outbound scenarios and it provides low
latency it gives high throughput of the
data transfer and we can actually scale
up the flow of the tcp and udp
connections from hundreds to thousands
to even millions because we have a load
balancer now in between the user and the
application so how does it operate this
load balancer actually receives the
traffic and it load balances the traffic
to the backend pool of instances
connected to it according to the rule
and the health probe that we set that's
how it maintains high availability so
what does load balancer help it helps in
creation of high available scalable
application in the cloud in minutes it
can be used to automatically scale the
environment with the increasing
application traffic and one feature of
load balancer is to check the health of
the user's application instance and it
removes or it stops sending the request
to the unhealthy instance and kind of
shifts that connection to the healthy
instance that way a user or a connection
does not get stuck with an instance
that's not healthy that's all that you
need to know about the networking
services now let's talk about the
storage services or the storage domain
in azure now azure storage in general is
a microsoft manage service providing
cloud storage which basically is highly
available secure durable scalable and
redundant because it's all managed by
azure we don't get to manage a lot of it
and these azure storages are a group of
storage services they cater different
needs and the storage products include
azure blobs which is actually an object
storage it includes
azure data lake it includes azure files
as you see it in it includes azure
queues it includes azure tables and lot
more but let's start our discussion with
azure store simple azure store simple is
an hybrid cloud storage solution that
actually lowers the cost of storage to
nearly 60 percent of how much you'd be
actually spending without using it so
azure simple storage or store simple is
an integrated storage solution that
manages the storage task between
on-premises and the cloud storage what i
really like about azure is that it's
built around a hybrid environment in
mind there are a lot of other cloud
providers that are there where running
and hybrid environment is a big
challenge you know it has some
compatibility you won't be able to find
an hybrid or a on-premises and cloud
solution for your need stuff like that
but with the azure especially when it
comes to storage a lot of the things
that we're going to see it clearly is
designed with hybrid environment in mind
all right so let's come back and talk
about store simple so store simple is an
very efficient cost effective and a very
easily manageable san storage area
networking solution in the cloud i
thought i'll throw in this information
the reason why it got store simple is
really because it uses store simple 8000
series devices which are used in azure
data center and this stores simple or
simple storage it comes along with
storage steering to manage the stored
data across the various storage media so
the current the very current data is
actually stored in on-premises on
solid-state drives and data that is used
less frequently is stored in hdds or
hard disk drives and the data that
requires archived or that needs to be
archived very old data let's say less
frequently used data candidate for
archive they are actually pushed to the
cloud so you see how this storage
steering automatically happens in store
simple and one another cool feature of
store simple is that it enables us to
create an on-demand and scheduled
backups of data and and then store the
data locally or in the cloud and these
backups are actually taken in the form
of incremental snapshot which means that
they can be created and restored quickly
it's not a complete backup it's an
incremental backup and these cloud
snapshots they can be critically
important when there is a disaster and
when there is a disaster recovery
scenario because these snapshots can be
called in and they can be put on storage
systems and then they become the actual
data so recovering is faster if you have
proper scheduled backups or if you have
frequent backups and this storage simple
it really helps in easing our backup
mechanism which means it kind of eases
our disaster recovery steps or
procedures as well so this store simple
it can be used to automate data
management data migration data movement
data turing across the enterprise both
in cloud and on-premises it actually
improves the compliance and accelerates
the disaster recovery for our
environment and if there is one thing
that's increasing every new day in our
environment that would be storage and
this store simple addresses that need
and we really don't have to pre-plan or
think in deep or having a proper storage
because now we have a simple storage
available in the cloud and moreover it's
on a pay-as-you-go type so not much
pre-planning on storage is needed yes
there will be a need but not as much as
i would without the cloud or without the
simple storage and the next service
under storage that we would like to
discuss is the data lake store this data
lake store or storage it's a cost
effective solution for big data
analytics in specific so let's expand
this so this data lake storage is an
enterprise-wide repository for big data
analytic workload that's the major
service that's dependent on this data
lake store and this data lake enables us
to capture data of any size of any type
and of any injection speed and it kind
of collects them in one single space or
in one single place for operational
efficiency i mean operational efficiency
and for analytic purpose hadoop in azure
is very dependent on this data lake
storage and this
data like store is designed with
performance for analytics in mind so
anytime you think of or anytime you're
using analytic in the cloud or anytime
you're using hadoop in the cloud in
azure we are definitely using or we will
be to the most part or the normal
procedure or the right storage to pick
would be data lake store in azure it's
designed with security in mind so
anytime we use azure storage we can be
rest assured that we are using storage
from within a data center which has or
which was built with security in mind so
this data store also uses azure blob
storage behind the scenes for global
scale durability and for performance
let's talk about blob storage now blob
storage provides large amount of storage
and scalability now this blob storage is
the object storage solution for azure
cloud let's expand a bit on blob storage
azure blob storage is microsoft offering
for object storage now this blob storage
is optimized for storing massive amount
of unstructured data which could be text
or binary data it's designed and it's
optimized for rapid reads if i explain
to you on what scenarios we would be
using blob storage that might help you
get a good understanding of what blob
storage is so it's help or its design as
of now it's being used in many idea
environments to serve images or
documents directly to the browser it
helps in storing files for distributed
access a lot of features can fetch data
from azure blob storage and it currently
helping users stream video and audio
it's currently being used for writing
log files it's currently being used to
store data as backup and restore at a
later point in times of disaster
recovery it also is used as an archiving
storage in a lot of cloud id
environments it's widely used in storing
analytic data not only storing but also
running analytic query against the data
stored in it so that's a wide use case
for blob storage not only that in
addition to all that we mentioned it
also supports versioning so anytime
somebody updates and data a new version
gets created which means at any point i
can roll back as in when needed and it
provides a lot of flexibility on
optimizing the user's storage need it
also supports tiering of the data so
based on need when i actually explore i
would find a lot of options i can pick
from that uh you know suits to my unique
storage environment or unique storage
need and like i said it stores
unstructured data and this unstructured
data is available for customers through
rest based object storage environment
the next product and storage service
would be queue storage now queue storage
provides durable cues for large volume
cloud services it's a very simple and
cost effective durable
messaging queue for large workloads
let's expand this queue storage for a
moment now this queue storage is a
service for storing large amount of
messages that can be accessed from
anywhere in the world through http and
https calls a single queue or a single
cube message can be up to like 24 kb in
size and a single queue can contain
millions of such 24 kb in size messages
and how much can it hold it can hold up
to the total capacity of the storage
account itself so that's kind of easy to
translate how much would it hold and
this azure queue storage it provides an
messaging solution between applications
and components in the cloud what does it
help it helps in designing an
application for scale it helps in
decoupling the application so you know
it's not very dependent or sometimes
it's not at all dependent on the other
application because now we have a queue
in between which kind of translates or
which kind of connects or which kind of
decouples both the environment now we
have a queue in between both the
environment can scale up or scale down
independently the next in the storage
service would be file storage let's talk
about file storage now these azure files
provide secure simple and managed cloud
file shares now with file share in the
cloud it actually extends the user
servers on premises performance and
capacity and lot of familiar tools for
the cloud file share management can be
used along with the file storage that
we're talking about so let's expand a
bit on file storage now this azure files
or azure file storage offers a fully
managed file shares in the cloud that
can be accessed via the
smb protocol server message block
protocol now this azure file shares can
be mounted concurrently by cloud or in
on-premises deployments a lot of
operating systems are compatible with it
windows are compatible linux is
compatible mac os is compatible in
addition to all this being able to run
on on-premises and on the cloud or being
able to access from premises and on the
cloud it can also offer cash for caching
the data and keeping it locally so it's
immediately available when needed so
that's some additional feature i would
say that some advanced feature that it
offers compared to the other file shares
available in the market let's talk about
table storage let's talk about table
storage now table storage is a no sql
key value pair storage for quick
deployments with the large
semi-structured data sets the difference
between one important thing to note with
table storage is that it has a flexible
data schema and also it's highly
available let's expand a bit on table
storage so anytime you want to pick a
schema less a nosql type table storage
is the one we'll end up picking it
provides an key pair attribute storage
with a schema-less design this table
storage is very fast and very cost
effective for many of the applications
and for the same amount of
data it's a lot cheaper when you compare
it with the traditional sql data or data
storage so some of the things that we
can store in the table storage are of
course they're going to be flexible data
sheets such as user data for web
application address books device
information and other types of metadata
for our service requirements and it can
have any number of tables up to the
capacity limit of the storage account
now this is not possible with sql this
is only possible with nosql especially
with table storage in azure explanation
of storage really concluded the length
and breadth of the explanation this ceo
was giving his id personal but this id
personal is not done with it yet he
still has a question even after this
lengthy discussion and his question was
well there are a lot of other cloud
providers available what made you
specifically choose azure i mean from
the kind of question that he asked we
can say that he is very curious and he
definitely had asked and very thoughtful
question so his ceo went on and started
to explain about the uh other
capabilities of azure or how it kind of
outruns the rest of the cloud providers
so he started or he again started his
discussion but from different angle now
so he started to explain what are the
capabilities or how azure is better than
the competitors so he started with
explaining the platform as a service
capabilities and i'm going to tell you
what the ceo told his id person so this
platform as a service or in platform as
a service the infrastructure management
is completely taken care by
microsoft allowing users to focus
completely on the innovation no more
infrastructure management
responsibilities go and focus on
innovation that's that's a fancy way of
saying it when we buy platform as a
service that's what we get we can
contribute our time on innovation and
not just maintaining the infrastructure
and azure especially is uh dotnet
friendly azure supports the.net
programming language and it has or it is
built or designed or it is optimized to
work with old and the new applications
deployed using net programming framework
so if your application is a.net most of
the time you would end up picking azure
i mean if you try to compare most of the
time you would end up picking azure as
your cloud service provider and the
security offerings that azure offers is
it's designed based on the security
development life cycle which is an
industry leading assurance process when
we buy services from azure it assures
that the environment is designed based
on security development life cycle and
like i mentioned many times in the past
and i would like to mention it again
azure has well thought about the hybrid
environments which a lot of other cloud
providers have failed so it's very easy
to set up and hybrid environment to
migrate the data or not to migrate the
data and still run a hybrid environment
they work seamlessly with
azure because azure provides seamless
connection across on-premises data
centers and the public cloud it also has
a very gentle
learning curve if you look at the
documentation it's picture rich and the
documentations are neat and clear would
really it would encourage you to learn
more it would encourage you to think and
imagine and try easily get a grasp of
how services work so it has a very
gentle learning curve azure allows the
utilization of technologies that several
businesses have used for years so there
is a big history behind it it has a very
gentle learning curve the certifications
the documentations the stage by stage
certification levels it's all very
gentle learning curve which is generally
missing in other cloud service providers
now this would really impress the ctos
or people working in finance and
budgeting if an organization is already
using microsoft software they can
definitely go and avail or be bold and
ask for a discount that can reduce the
overall azure spending in other words
overall a pricing of the azure so that's
what helped or they are the information
that helped the ceo pick azure as his
cloud service provider and then the ceo
goes on and talks about the different
companies that are currently using azure
and they are definitely using azure for
a reason like pixar boeing samsung
easyjet xerox bmw 3m they are major
multinational multi-billion companies
they rely
run operate their id in azure and this
ceo has a thought that his i.t person is
still not very convinced unless and
until he shows him a visual of how easy
things are in azure so he goes on and
explains about a practical application
of azure which is what exactly i'm going
to show you as well all right a quick
project on building an azure app using
or building a dotnet application in
azure web app and making it connect to
an sql database will solidify all the
knowledge that we have gained so far so
this is what we're gonna do i have an
azure account open as you see logged in
and everything is fresh here let me go
to resource group there's nothing in
there it's it's kind of fresh all right
i'm logged in and this is what we're
going to do so we're going to create an
application like this which is nothing
but an to-do application
to do list application which is going to
run from the web app get information
from us and save it in the database
that's connected to it so you can
already see it's a two-tiered
application web
and db all right so let me go back to my
azure account the first thing is to
create an resource group let's give it
an a meaningful name let's call it azure
simply learn all right and it's going to
be a free trial and the location
pick one that's nearest to you or you
know wherever you want to launch your
application now for this use case i'm
going to pick central us and
create it's going to take a while to get
created there you go it's created it's
called azure simply learn now what do we
need we need an web app and and a
separate sql database let's first get
our web app running so go to app
services and then click on add
it's not the web app plus sql that we
want we want web app alone for this
example so let's create and web app
give it a quick name let's call it uh
azure
simply learn
the subscription is free trial and i'm
gonna use my existing resource group a
resource group that we created some time
back it's gonna run out of windows and
we're gonna publish the code all set we
can create it all right while this is
running uh let me create my database
right sql database
create a database
give it a name let's call it azure
simply learn db
put it in our existing resource group
that we created it's going to be a blank
database all right and it's going to
require some
settings like
the name of the server
and the admin login the password that
goes along and in which location this is
going to be created the server name is
going to be azure simply learn db that's
the server name and the admin login can
be
what can be the admin login name let's
see
so let's call it simply learn that's my
admin login name
and let me pick a password
click on create so what have we done so
far we have created an web app and we
have created and
a database in the resource group that we
have created so if i go to resource
group it's going to take some time
before things show up so if i go to my
resource group i only have one resource
group as of now
azure simply learn and there i have a
bunch of resources
being created and that's still being
created all right in the meantime
i have my application right here that's
running out of
or that's in visual studio as of now
right so once
the infrastructure is set and ready
in the azure console we're going to go
back to visual studio feed these inputs
in the visual studio so the code knows
what the database is the the credentials
to log into the database and stuff like
that so we're going to feed those
information in visual studio by that
we're actually feeding it into the
application and then we're going to run
it from there
deploying this application takes quite a
while
we really got to be patient right now we
have all the resources that we need for
the application to run here's my
database and here is my app service
there's one more thing we need to do
that is
create and firewall exception rule so
one more thing needed is to create and
firewall exception uh rule right so the
application is going to run from my
local desktop and it's going to connect
to the
database right so let's add an exception
rule by simply adding the client ip it's
going to pick my ip the ipf laptop i'm
using as of now and it's going to create
an exception to access the
database so that's done now we can go
back to our visual studio i already have
a couple of
apps running or a couple of
configurations pushed from
a visual studio i'm going to clean that
up if you're doing it for the first time
you you may not need to do this
all right so let's start from the
scratch this is very similar to
how you would be doing
in your environment right so we're going
to
select an existing azure app service now
before that i have logged in as you can
see i have logged in
with my credentials so it's gonna pull
few things automatically from my azure
account so
in this case i'm gonna use an existing
azure app so select existing and then
click on publish
all right if you recall these are the
very
same resources that we created a while
back
all right we have clicked on save and
it's
running kind of validating the code
and it's going to come up with an url
now initially the url is
not going to work because we haven't
mapped the application to the database
so that would be the next thing
all right so the app has been
published and it's running from my
web app as of now
it's going to throw an error
like you see
it's throwing an error that's because we
haven't mapped
the app and the db together so let's do
that
all right let's do that so let's go to
server explorer
this is where we're going to see our
databases that we have created now let's
quickly verify that
go back to
the resource group
right appropriate resource group which
is right here
and here i have my
database azure
simply learn
database
all right it has some issues connecting
to my database give me a quick moment
let's fix it
all right so
we'll have to map
the database into this application
all right so let's go to the solution
explorer click on publish
and a page like this gets shown and from
here we can go to configure
here is our web app all right with all
its credentials let's validate the
connection number one
all right and then click on next
this is my db connection string right
which the app is going to use to connect
to my db
now if you recall rdb was a
azure simply learn db and that's not
being shown here
so let's fix that
right so let's fix that
click on configure
and here
uh let's put our db servers
url now before that let's change this to
sql server
all right and then in here
put the
db's
url so go back to azure
here is my
db or
server's name
put that here
right
the username to connect to the server
that's
right here
put that in
and the password
to connect to the server let's put that
in
all right it's trying to connect to our
azure
portal or the azure infrastructure and
here is my
database if you recall it's azure
sldb that's the name of the database
let's test the connection connection is
good click on ok
so now it's showing up correctly azure
simply learn db that's the name of the
database
that we created
now it's configured
all right let's modify the data
connections
right let's map it to the appropriate
database again
all right so our name of the database is
azure simply learn db
and then
it's going to be
sql
server that's the data source
the
username is simply learn and the
password is
what
we have given in the beginning
all right let's validate
the connection
it's good click ok
now we're all set
and ready to publish our application
again now the application knows how to
connect
to the database we have educated it with
the
the correct connection strings the dns
name
the username and the password for the
application to connect to the database
so visual studio is building this
project and once it is up and running
will be prompted with an url
to connect and
anytime
we put or we give inputs to the url
that's going to
receive the input and save it in the
database
all right so here is my to-do list app
and i can start
creating to-do list for
myself all right so i have items already
listed
i can create an entry and these entries
get stored in
the
in the database i can create another
entry
you know take the doc for a walk that's
gonna get stored i can create another
entry
book tickets for
scientific
exhibition
and that's going to receive and put that
in the database and that concludes our
session so through this session we saw
how i can use azure services to create a
web app and
connect that to the db instance and how
those two services which are
decoupled by default which are separate
by default how i can you know use the
connection strings to make connection
between the app server and the database
and be able to create and working app i
strongly believe you enjoyed me walking
you through this session today i'd like
to welcome all of you to this training
video on azure so here we have two
friends having a conversation with each
other one of them says that her company
is moving all of its physical data and
migrating it onto the cloud she says
that they're using a cloud service
provider known as azure now here's the
problem she doesn't really understand
how cloud service providers work or even
how the cloud does her friend decides to
help her out so in this video here's
what we're going to talk about first
we'll talk about what is cloud computing
what is microsoft azure what are the
services that does your offers and then
we'll have a look at a use case where
we'll be applying one of these services
to get a particular job done now for the
first question what is cloud computing
so cloud computing actually provides a
platform through which you can access
resources now these resources include
servers storage application security and
other ways you can transform your data
or get some use out of it now at the
same time you can also store manage and
process your data now anything related
to cloud computing is made possible only
with the help of the internet now along
with these things there are several
other things that you can do with cloud
computing now let's have a look at some
of the ways cloud computing is making
our lives better firstly you have
services for just about every
requirement that you have then you get
access to the newest and most innovative
technologies in the market right now
cloud computing provides cost-effective
solutions with flexible pricing now most
cloud service providers work in such a
way that you only pay for the amount of
time you use that particular resource
then you have one of the most important
selling points when it comes to cloud
computing which is that data and
applications are accessible from any
part of the world as long as you have
access to the internet and finally you
have increased protection for your data
and applications now you should know
that there are several cloud service
providers in the market right now be it
amazon web services adobe creative cloud
google cloud platform and so much more
now among all these platforms there's
one that's growing really really fast
and that is microsoft azure now let's
ask the question what is microsoft azure
microsoft azure is actually a cloud
service platform that allows users to
build manage scale and deploy
applications by giving them access to
cloud services now these cloud services
range from creating virtual machines to
creating functions that run themselves
without having to worry about hardware
now all of this is made possible only
through the internet now here are some
things that you need to know about azure
firstly it was launched on the 1st of
february 2010 it has data centers in
more than 42 regions across the world
they also say that 12 more data centers
are in the making which helps them say
they're the only cloud service provider
that covers these many regions next
azure is preferred by 80 of the fortune
500 companies which means that the best
of the best in the market only choose to
work with us europe and finally azure is
the second largest cloud service
provider in the market right now let's
talk about azure services as i told you
azure provides services for a wide range
of domains now let's have a look at some
of these domains there's ai and machine
learning compute containers database
identity management tools networking
security storage and so much more now
let's have a look at some of the
individual services within these domains
firstly you have azure virtual machines
with azure virtual machines what you get
is the opportunity to create windows or
linux virtual machines now all of this
is possible in a matter of seconds with
a large amount of customization now
let's have a look at some of its
features firstly you can choose from a
wide variety of virtual machine options
then you have a large amount of
optimization available to you for
example what size of operating system do
you want how much size do you want
allocated to it what version of the
system is it and so much more then it
provides low cost and permanent billing
now azure provides you permanent billing
which means that you're only charged for
how much time you use the service and
finally you have enhanced security and
protection for your virtual machines
next we have service fabric now with
service fabric you have platform which
enables you to create micro services now
this also makes the process of
application life cycle management a
whole lot easier as a direct result you
can create applications with a faster
time to market it supports windows linux
on-premises or other clouds and it
enables you to do a tremendous amount of
scaling up depending on your requirement
and finally we have functions now with
functions you can build applications
with the help of serverless computing
here the users only pay for the amount
of resources that they've used you can
create applications in any language that
you want and the only thing you need to
worry about is the code of the
application everything other than that
that is the hardware requirements are
taken care of by azure now let's have a
look at the networking services firstly
we have the azure cdn or the content
delivery network with azure cdn what you
get is the ability to deliver your
content with reduced load times fast
responsiveness and less bandwidth now
cdn can be integrated with several other
azure services so that the process can
move at a faster rate it can handle
heavy loads and traffic spikes with ease
it also provides a robust security
system now with the content that's
delivered you can get advanced analytic
data with which you can understand how
customers are using your content next we
have express route with express route
you can connect your on-premises network
to azure through a private network now
by default this lowers latency it
increases the emphasis on reliability
and speed and it can be of great use
when you have to transfer large amounts
of data between networks now another way
this can be useful is if it's used to
add compute or storage capacity to data
centers next we have azure dns domain
name service or azure dns can be used to
host your domains on azure this provides
high availability and great performance
it provides fast responses to dns
queries by taking advantage of
microsoft's global network it also
provides high availability next we have
virtual network azure virtual network
allows the azure resources to
communicate with each other or other
on-premise networks via the internet and
all of this is kept extremely secure now
with this users can create their own
private network for communication it
provides users with an isolated and
extremely secure environment for their
applications to run now all of the
traffic stays entirely within the azure
network and it also allows users to
design their own networks
next we have traffic manager now with
traffic manager you can route incoming
traffic to improve your performance and
availability now one thing it provides
is multiple failover options so if a
particular situation goes wrong there's
always an option to consider to salvage
the situation it helps reduce
application runtime and enables the
distribution of user traffic across
multiple locations it also helps the
people who are using it to know where
the customers connecting from across the
world next we have load balancer with
this you are provided the ability to
instantly scale applications at the same
time providing high availability and
improved network performance for users
applications it can be integrated into
virtual machines and cloud services it
provides highly reliable applications it
also allows users to secure and
integrate security groups finally we
have azure vpn gateway now this allows
users to connect their on-premise
networks to azure using a site-to-site
vpn now this allows users to connect
their virtual machine to anywhere in the
world through a point-to-site vpn and
also it's very easy to manage and is
highly available
now let's talk about the storage
services first we have data lake storage
now with this what you get is a scalable
data storage with an emphasis on cost
effectiveness and scalability now it
comes of maximum use when you integrate
it with other services so that you can
get analytics on how the data is being
used it is also integrated with other
services like the azure blob storage now
it is also optimized for big data
analysis tools like battery spark and
hadoop next up we have blob storage now
blob storage provides a storage capacity
for data now depending on how often a
particular data is used it is classified
into different tiers now all the data
that is within the blob storage is
unstructured data now it has a way of
ensuring that the data integrity is
maintained every time a particular
object is being changed or the data has
been accessed and it also helps improve
app performance and reduces bandwidth
consumption next we have queue storage
now with this you have a message queuing
system for large workloads this allows
users to build flexible applications and
separate functions not to mention with
this you can be sure that your
individual components will not fail it
also makes sure that your application is
scalable
queue storage provides queue monitoring
which helps ensure that the customer's
demands are met then we have file stored
now with file storage you can perform
file sharing with the help of the smb
protocol or the server message block
protocol now this data is protected by
smb 3.0 and the https protocol in this
case like we mentioned in functions
azure takes care of all the hardware
needs and the operating system
deployments on its own it also improves
on-premises performance and other
capabilities lastly we have table
storage with table storage you can
deploy semi-structured data sets and
nosql key value store now this is used
for creating applications which have a
flexible data schema and also
considering how it has a very strong
consistency model it's mainly aimed for
enterprises next let's have a look at
some web and mobile services
first we have the azure search now with
azure search you get a cloud search
service which is powered by artificial
intelligence with this you can develop
web applications as well as mobile
applications now one big advantage is
that you don't have to set up or manage
your search indices azure takes care of
that and by extension it increases your
development speed the artificial
intelligence also will provide insights
and structured information that you can
use to improve the search and structured
information next we have logic apps now
with this you can create integration
solutions which can connect applications
that are important to your business now
with this you can visually create
business processes and workflows you can
integrate sas or software as a service
applications and enterprise applications
and more importantly it allows you to
unlock data within a firewall and
securely connect to services next we
have web applications now with web apps
you can create deploy and scale web
applications according to business
requirements now it supports both
windows and linux platforms and it helps
with continuous integration or
deployment abilities another very
important aspect of this is that the
data can be deployed and hosted across
multiple locations in the world and
finally we have mobile apps with mobile
apps you can create applications for ios
android and windows platforms one
advantage is that it automatically
scales up and down based on your
requirements now in situations where you
have network issues offline data syncing
ensures that your applications work
anyway and you can create cross-platform
applications or native applications for
ios android and windows
next let's have a look at some container
services first let's talk about acs or
azure container services it is also
known as the azure kubernetes services
as it's a fully managed kubernetes
container orchestration service now what
this means is that it eases the process
of container integration and deployment
it also can be used with other resources
from security like virtual networks
cryptographic keys and so much more to
ensure that your container is kept
secure next we have container instances
now this is similar to functions in a
way just that in this we're using
containers without having to manage
servers now applications can be
developed here without managing virtual
machines or learning new tools all that
is azure's problem to take care of and
it enables building applications without
having to manage the infrastructure that
is all you need to worry about is
running the container next let's have a
look at some database services first we
have the sql database now with sql
database what you get is a relational
cloud database service now this means
that it helps accelerate your app
development and makes it easier for you
to maintain your application now sql
database is also used extensively in
migrating workloads to the cloud and
hence saves time and cost it also helps
improve your performance by integrating
machine learning and adaptive
technologies into your database next we
have azure cosmos db now this is a
globally distributed multi-model
database service now what this means is
that with this you can create
application with support nosql it
provides a high grade security system
has high availability and low latency
now this is usually used in situations
where you have a diverse and highly
unpredictable workload now let's have a
look at some security and identity
services firstly we have the azure
active directory now if you want to know
more about azure active directory i
suggest you click on the top right
corner and watch our video on the azure
active directory this is just an
introduction so with this you can manage
user identities and you can make sure
the resources are kept safe with the
help of access policies most of these
are intelligence driven now one of the
main features is that you can have
access to your applications from any
location or device it helps increase
your efficiency and helps down cutting
costs when it comes to having a help
desk it can also help improve security
and can respond to advanced threads in
real time next you have azure active
directory b2c it helps provide customer
identity and access management in the
cloud now protecting customer identity
is extremely important for an
organization and that's what azure adb2c
does now it also enables the application
to be scaled to great amounts even
billions of customers next we have the
azure security center this is basically
like a command post with which you get a
complete view of the security across
users on your on-premises and cloud
workloads so with this you are given
threat protection method that adapts to
situations and helps reduce exposing you
to threats it also has rapid threat
response and makes the process of
finding and fixing vulnerabilities a
whole lot easier next up let's talk
about monitoring and management services
so first let's have a look at azure
advisor now azir advisor is basically a
guide for the best practices when it
comes to azure now when you follow these
it improves performance security cost
and increases availability now it also
learns from how you use the services on
your configuration and usage pattern and
the adjustments that it suggests can be
implemented very quickly and easily next
we have network watcher now with this
you can monitor diagnose and understand
the working of your network now you can
monitor your network without actually
having to log in to your virtual machine
now you can also use something known as
network security flow logs to understand
the traffic pattern how much traffic is
coming towards you how much you're
giving and so much more it also helps
diagnose vpn problems that you might
have with detailed logs and finally you
have the azure resource manager now with
this you can ensure that the resources
that you have are managed and deployed
at a consistent rate now this makes it
extremely easy for you to manage and
visualize your resources that are used
in your applications or some other
requirements and you can control who can
access your resources as well as perform
actions on it and now let's have a look
at how we can use one of these services
to satisfy a particular requirement so
the friend asks that she needs one last
bit of help she wants a friend's help to
host the website on his yaw and here's
how we can do it so now we're going to
put one of these services into action so
this is the azure dashboard so from here
we are going to create a virtual machine
within which we are going to create a
website a very simple html website
nonetheless
so let's get started so first what we're
going to do is create a resource a
resource group so what a resource group
is is actually a repository of all the
resources like virtual machines or
storage that you're going to use in your
project so in this we need a virtual
machine so let's get that created so
first we'll name it
demo
ecus and we'll create it now this will
take a few seconds
and that's it
so now that that's done we go on add
so we're going to be using a windows
operating system so we'll just search
for a virtual machine
we select this
and create
okay so here we are going to set up
we're going to select the resource group
the one just that we just created
a virtual machine name
okay
so
storage
and name
[Music]
passwords
and then
just breeze through the rest of it
we can
reduce the size we need this big
and create
now that the validation is done the next
step is to
create
now this will take a few minutes so
we'll wait
and as you can see here the virtual
machine has been created we'll go to the
source
so here all we need to do is connect and
download the rdp file
let's see if we run this file and see
what happens
now this error shows up in a whole lot
of systems that i've used
so there's a very easy way to
troubleshoot this problem so here's what
you need to do now so these are the
problems as remote access to the server
is not enabled the remote computer is
turned off the remote computer is not
available on the network
so what we're going to do is go to
networking
and add an inbound port rule now we're
trying to access a computer remotely
right so to remotely access the computer
we would need to add an inbound port
rule so that's what we're going to do
right now
so we can keep the source as any port
ranges any and our destination port as
eight nine if you've noticed there we'd
actually have used the three three eight
nine as the inbound port
and then we change the name as three
three eight nine
and this rule is added
now after this is done all we need to do
you can see here that we refresh the
page this would be here
a new rule has been added now so we'll
go to overview
and try to connect
again do the same thing again
and this time it worked so here we'll
input the name
and our password
and that's it now we just press yes
and there you go the system has started
now your virtual machine is started now
in a while the server manager will pop
up
so there's some things that we need to
do so that we can host the website so
the first thing is to create an inbound
port so we'll turn off the virtual
machine for now
come back to that later first we'll go
to
a resource group
check the name of our resource
and then we'll look at all its resources
here
so here we need to find at the network
security group and add an inbound
security rule
press add we take any source any source
port range
and then we add port 80 which is the one
that we're going to use and we'll put
name as port
80
we'll add the security rule
which will take a few seconds
and that's that now it's a lot now let's
go back to our virtual machine
here you go
and let's get it started
login again
and there you have it it's on again now
we'll go to server manager so we need to
add roles and features so most of this
we can just run through we'll leave them
at the default values
same and here we need to add a web
server which is the iis so we'll select
this
we add the features
next so we can add the net 3.5 features
as well
next
and
we'll install now
now we'll wait for the installation to
finish
and now the installation is done so now
what we're going to see is if the
website can be reached i will go to the
public address which is given here so
we've come back to our original system
click
and you can see that the is page has
been created
now we need to work more to create the
html page
here's what we'll need to do to run our
website so right now what we're getting
is this the is page now let's make it
our own html page a very simple html
page from there on we can create the
website so go back to the virtual
machine and then we go to
c drive
so the is is located in a location which
is in c drive in it pub
and www root so if you click on this
actually what you'll get is the page i
showed you earlier which is this one so
now we'll go to the server manager
click on tools
and find the iis manager
so we click on this
and sites
now there's a default website
we can now add a new one
site name
demo
we need a physical path we'll put it
inside the
folder we just saw which is
right here c drive
init pub
wwe root within which we'll create a new
folder
for simply learn demo
we save it
and port 80
and
okay
now this is assigned to another site so
we'll change that but we'll wait for
that okay
now for this we'll just change it
we click on this
so since both of them have the same port
we'll change that go here edit binding
we change this
to something else
okay and close
so now both are different and now we can
start our website
it's already started now
now we'll start the website right click
this
manage website
and start
and that's it now we will go to the
to the init pub www root and we have
simply learn demo so here we will create
the
html website or the html
the document
so
next dot html
okay
open this
it's a very simple website now so
we keep it save it
so here what we're going to do is save
as
an html file but for all
all files
we close this
now to make sure this is recognized as a
dot html file
it go to view
options
here we'll hide extensions for known
file types
we'll just rename this
[Music]
and there you have it it's a dot html
file
now let's go back
to our
original computer
and run this page
and there you have it now this is just
the initial version more work has to be
done on it but your first step is
already done
and today we will be talking about
machine learning in azure before we move
on let me tell you what azure is so
azure is microsoft's public cloud
computing platform it provides you with
various services like compute analytics
networking and storage so you can pick
from these services to develop and scale
new applications or run existing
applications in the public cloud
okay so once you log into your azure
portal and select machine learning as
your service you'll be redirected to
this page now on the right hand side you
can see there's an option called my
workspace so once you click on my
workspace it will take you to a new
window which is machine learning studio
but before that let me give you a small
idea of what my workspace is so any data
that we get into our machine learning
studio we analyze it and that is
presented under my workspace now on the
left hand side you can see there are a
few options under machine learning
studio page so let me go through those
options one so the first option is
projects so project basically gives you
a list of all the experiments that we
have worked on then comes experiments so
experiments are all the programs that
you work on to create a model after that
it's web services so since azure is a
cloud computing platform we know that
all the data needs to be uploaded over
the cloud by data i mean all the
experiments that we have needs to be
uploaded over the cloud
so web services gives you a list of all
the experiments that we have and is over
the cloud so that you can access it from
anywhere then comes notebooks so
notebooks are basically space where you
can explore analytics you can create
your own code you can visualize it and
at the last you can share it with your
peers then it's data sets so the data
set gives you a list of all the data set
that you have in your azure portal now
when you click on sample these are all
the sample data set that azure has
provided as to the users
now comes trained models so while
working in an experiment you'll come to
a point where you need to train your
model so this gives you a list of all
the models that you have trained in your
azure program
then at the last you have settings so
any changes that you make is done under
settings so now that we are done with
this let's go to the next half of our
azure tutorial so on the left hand side
you can see there's an option called new
when you click on new it will open a
window so this window gives you a list
of all the templates that we have in our
azure machine learning studio okay so
since we are working from the scratch we
will be working on blank experiment so
once you click on blank experiment a new
window appears
okay so let me go through the component
that we have here so on the left hand
side you have the components at the
center you have the canvas where your
experiments will take place and on the
right hand side you have properties so
today we'll be working on problem
statement which says that we need to
find out the income of an individual
whose data we don't have in our system
now let's go on to the component part
and find the best data set that can suit
our problem statement okay so we see
that we have list of data set in our
samples so the very first data set adobe
senses income binary classification so
we'll select the data set and drag it
over to the canvas
but before that let me give a name to
our experiment so we'll give the name as
income prediction
[Music]
now once you click on adult census
income you can see there is a circle
press right click and four options
appears in front of you the first one is
download the second is visualize third
is generate access code and the last one
is notebook since we need to visualize
the data set we'll click on visualize
so once you click on visualize a new
window appears
on the left hand side you can see there
are 32 000 nodes and 15 columns that we
have in our data set but before that let
me go through all the columns that we
have here so the first one is age which
gives you a which sense about the age of
a person
then is work class so this gives you an
idea whether he's a government employee
is he working in a private sector or is
he a self-employed then is fnl wjt which
is the sample weight of the field then
is the education so education is
basically telling us about his highest
degree whether is it bachelors is it
high school grad or is he a masters
then comes education number so this
gives you an idea of the number of years
he took to complete his education
then his marital status so this is
telling about a person's is he married
or whether he has never married then his
occupation so occupation is actually
important while finding out the income
so if a person is a manager then a
chance he will be earning more as
compared to others then his relationship
whether he is a husband is she a wife or
has he never married then comes sex
whether he's a male or the female then
his capital gain capital loss hours per
week so this gives you an idea of number
of hours a person is working in a week
then is native country so income varies
from country to country so getting to
know about the country is also very
important while predicting our model and
at the last we have income we see that
the income column is divided into two
halves which is above 50 and below 50.
so there are two distinct values in
income group and in cases like these we
make use of classification algorithm
now let's go to the next part which is
where we will define the fields that we
need to have for our prediction so what
we do here is we select the column
so on the search bar when you type
column under manipulation you get a list
of options from that you select column
in data set and drag it over to the
canvas now connect your data set with
select column in data set now under this
you can see there's a question which
says that value required so you go under
properties and select launch column
selector so once you select launch
column selector window appears
so this gives you a list of all the
columns that we have in a data set
so the very first column that we have
here is age so age is actually important
in understanding the income of a person
then comes work class so the background
of a person whether he's working in a
government employee or is he a private
employee is also important for
prediction of income then comes
education
a person who has a master's degree has
more chances of earning than a person
who has a graduation degree so education
is also an important field when
predicting our income then what comes
next is occupation
after that you have country
and at the last we will work on incur
now when you press next you get back to
the same window so now that we know the
fields that we're working on our next
step is to find the algorithm that best
suits our model
okay so now that we know the fields that
we have to work on our next step is to
find the best with algorithm for our
model so what we do here is we look at
the list of algorithms that we have but
before that we know that our data our
target value is divided into two classes
so the algorithm that we'll be working
on is a classification algorithm now
azure provides few
classification algorithm like logistic
and decision tree two class booster
decision tree so we'll be working on two
class boosted decision tree because this
gives you a high accuracy rate now let
me give you an idea of why two class
booster decision tree is taken over all
the other classification algorithm so
what happens in two class booster
decision tree is for every node that we
have here the accuracy is calculated and
once the accuracy is above our required
accuracy then only it moves on to the
next nodes so this gives you a height so
the prediction value here becomes more
and more towards the higher side
so that the overall model will give us a
very high accuracy okay so our next step
here is to train the model so on the
search bar again just
type train and under train you can see
there's an option called train model so
drag the train model over the canvas and
connect the two cloud boosted decision
tree with this now you can see that it
says that it requires a value or a data
which is obvious because it's not it
does not have any data to work on so our
next step here is to split the data so
on the search bar when you
find split it gives you an option called
split data when you drag the split data
over your canvas and connect it with
your column data
it asks you for the split percentage so
you split the data into training and
testing so 80 of data gets into the
training model and twenty percent goes
into the testing model so what we do
next is we connect eighty percent of
training data with the trained model but
you see there's a value required this is
because the model is not aware of the
column it needs to train on so what we
do here is we go on launch column
selector
and select the column so we need to work
on income column
so when we select column and press enter
we see that the question mark is gone
now our next step is to find the score
of the model
so what score does is it gives you the
prediction value of the model
okay so when you connect your trade
model with the score model you again see
a caution sign here this is because it
does not have idea of what it needs to
test on so you collect your testing data
with your score model
so our last step here is to evaluate the
model so on the search bar when you type
evaluate
you get an option called evaluate model
you drag the model here on the canvas
and connect it with the score model so
your model is now complete now our next
step is to save the model and run it
now once our program is executed click
on evaluate model once you click on
evaluate model and press visualize
a window will appear this shows you the
performance of the model you see that
the accuracy is 79 which is considered
to be good
now let me go through all the other
options you see there is an option
called positive label
and negative level which has been
assigned values of above 50k and below
50 kids respectively now let me tell you
what these values are so this part is
known as a confusion matrix so of all
the values above 50k true positive give
me value that are predicted correctly
and false positive give me values that
are not predicted correctly which means
that six out of all the value that we
have in positive label 666 667 have been
predicted right that is they have their
salary above 50k and 422 have been
predicted wrong similarly they're out of
all the people that we have 840 have
been predicted wrongly that if they have
salary of above 50k but have been
predicted below 50k and 4091 have been
predicted correctly now this is used to
find the accuracy of the model so what
you do here is you sum the true positive
with two negative and divide it by false
positive false negative true positive
and two negative and then you multiply
it by 100 and that's how you get your
accuracy now let us go back
and run this service over the net so
when you click on setup web service you
see predictive experiments click on
predictive experiment
now our next step is to connect the web
service input that is the entry point
with the score model so what it does is
once the program is over the cloud it
directly connects to the score model and
shows us the output so you don't have to
go through all the processes now because
the machine is automatically learning
now you save this
and press run this will execute the
entire model
so once this is done all that is left
with you is to deploy web service so
once you click on deploy web service
it will take you to the dashboard
so you see an option called test once
you click on test
it will take you to a window where it
will ask you for values so let's just
say that i have a value of percent age
35
let's say he's working
in a government
his education is
bachelor's
then his occupation is manager
this country is us
so once i press next
it will give me the predicted value
telling me that he will be earning 50k
with the precision rate of 0.12
so this is how you make use of machine
learning in azure the service as your
active directory so firstly let's ask
the most important question what is
azure active directory now here we're in
a situation where we have two colleagues
having a conversation with each other so
one of them complains that he is finding
a hard time managing multiple user
logins at the same time his friend
suggests that he has a solution that the
company start using as your active
directory he says that with azure ad
they'll be able to handle multiple user
logins without any issue so just like
the question in all our minds the friend
asks how is azure active directory going
to help us so to help you understand
let's think about a scenario you're an
employee working for an organization and
you want to use a particular service in
this case sql database so you are
assigned a set of username and password
then you want to use another service a
machine learning service again you are
assigned a different username and
password and likewise for any number of
services that you want to use so for
every service that you're going to
choose you need to be assigned a new
username and password but this becomes a
huge issue for the administrator as they
have to handle a large number of
username and passwords now if you think
about a large organization where there's
more than thousand people working you
can understand how much of a hassle it's
going to be for the administrator at the
same time it's also a really difficult
thing for you to remember that many
numbers of username and passwords it's
difficult on the user as well and that's
where azure active directory helps now
here's a scenario where we're applying
azure active directory now you're an
employee you want to use a particular
service and you're assigned a single
username and password and with this
username and password you can access all
the services that you want so there's
only one set of username and passwords
that you need to remember you can use
any of the services that you want as
long as the administrator has given you
access to it so what is your active
directory now azure active directory is
a service that falls under the identity
domain it allows multiple users and is a
cloud-based directory and identity
management service now here's an ideal
scenario you're joining an office newly
the admin helps you sign up to whatever
services you want and you can access
these services anywhere over the cloud
so now let's talk about something
different windows 80 and azure ad now
windows 80 was the previous version of
azure 80. so now we'll talk about why we
needed to change from windows active
directory to azure active directory so
what is windows active directory now
it's an os directory service which
allows you to work with multiple systems
multiple network resources in a unified
manner now the biggest draw when it came
to windows 80 was that it had many
layers now different layers that did
different bits of work so now let's talk
about each of these layers the first
layer is adds or the windows active
directory domain services now each layer
as i said before has a different role to
perform adds allows admin to manage
information relating to user logins and
other details like when they signed up
how much they're using and things like
that the next layer is adls or the azure
data lake storage services this layer is
for allowing you to store any amounts of
data of any type or size then you have
the adfs or the active directory
federation services where you're given a
single option for sign up with which you
get access to all systems and
applications then we have the fourth
layer the adcs or the active directory
and certification services this enables
administrators to customize services and
then be able to manage and issue public
certificates and the final layer is
adrms or the active directory rights
management service and this is used for
data protection now here's where azure
active directory changed the whole game
this means that there's a large number
of layers that administrators need to
take care of now how about there was a
solution for this and as your ad is that
solution as your active directory
integrates all these five layers into
two and these are the windows azure
active directory or the waad where it
combines all the problems when it comes
to identification management which is
almost all file layers taken into one
and the windows as your access control
service enables the federation or the
division of all these services of an
organization and by division i mean
assigning each of these services to
these users so that is taken care of by
the windows as your access control
service hence as your active directory
is able to simplify a lot of the
problems that windows as your active
directory had for example the
application office 365 uses as your
active directory to manage user
identities here's how now you're an
employee who wants to access one of the
office 365 services which could be excel
powerpoint microsoft word or something
like that so you go talk to the
administrator and he gives you access to
these services with the help of a single
username and password
now as long as you have this username
and password and the administrator has
given you access to it you can use any
of these services so who's the service
audience who is using the active
directory service now there are three
types of audience when it comes to azure
active directory the first one is id
administrator the second one application
developers and online customers so the
idea administrators their main emphasis
is to ensure that the sign-in takes
place they take care of all the sign-in
procedures they also solve issues when
it comes to authentication for example
to authenticate a particular user the
problem is solved by the id
administrators then you have application
developers who use these services to
develop applications and with this they
have an easier time developing
applications as all these resources are
easily available you have online
customers who make use of services like
office 365 and other crm services and
have all their demands catered
immediately so now let's have a look at
how we can use azure active directory to
provide access to a particular
individual
so if you log into the azure account
this is what you see or you go into
active directory a list of all the
people who are using or have been given
permission to use resources from azure
okay now we're going to create a profile
we need to set up his name which is john
and second name jacob
now for properties we need to determine
the source of authority which is already
active directory so that's fine
we can select a group or add them to a
particular group if we feel like it
now if we add them to a particular group
it means that they have access to all
the resources that everyone in the group
has access to earlier so we'll do that
later we'll select their directory role
or we can select it here if we need to
it could be user administrator or
limited administrator and now we'll set
up a password we already got one and
we'll create
and that's it we have created a user now
we'll go to their profile
so what we can see here is that you have
access to every bit of detail related to
this account so you have the name your
first name the username the object id
job info everything you can even have
other details like how often they've
signed in when did they sign up you can
check their password you can reset the
password
delete their account and so much more
now we can even add a directory role
which we saw earlier and now let's add
this person to the admin group so you
know he gets access to all the services
those people have access to and select
that's it we've added them now the other
things that you can see here there are
applications licenses devices these are
all restrictions you can add or remove
like which device he can use the system
through or with and stuff like that so
that's it and with that we have created
a user and given him access to certain
services we are going to talk about
another important as your service as
your data factory now why should you be
interested in data factory now let's
consider a scenario so here we have two
colleagues having a conversation with
each other and they say that the data
that they're generating from their
applications or products is increasing
exponentially now considering that this
data is coming from a number of
different products it'll be a bit of a
task to analyze and store all of this
data so he wonders how they're going to
manage that his friend suggests that
they use azure's data factory now what
does azure's data factory actually do
first it stores data with the help of
the data link storage now any kind of
data can be stored in the data lake
storage then you can analyze the data
you can transform the data with the help
of pipelines and you can publish the
organized data you can visualize the
data with third-party applications like
apache spark or hadoop as well now what
exactly is data factory so now let's
have a look at what exactly is data
factory now data factory falls under the
identity domain of services in the azure
catalog and is a cloud-based integration
service basically what it does is it
works on your data it stores your data
it orchestrates and automates the
movement or transformation of data it
works heavily on the data that you store
now let's see how it actually works or
how the flow of its processes are
firstly we have the input data set which
is nothing but the data that you have
within your data store the one that you
need processed then you pass this data
through a pipeline now what does a
pipeline do a pipeline basically
performs an operation on the data that
transforms it which could be anything
from just data movement or some data
transformation now data transformation
is possible with the help of usql some
stored procedures are hype now after
this is done you get an output data set
now this output data set will contain
data that is in a structured form
because it's already been transformed
and made structured in the pipeline
stage then it is given into linked
services like azure data lake block
storage or sql now what it does is these
store information that is very important
when it comes to connecting to an
external source now this is you know if
you wanted an example you know how in an
sql server you need to mention the
source and destination of your data now
for example consider an sql server so
you need a connection string so that you
can connect to an external device you
need to mention the stores and the
destination of your data this is how the
link services work and finally you need
a gateway now a gateway basically
connects your on-premises data to the
cloud so you do need a client installed
on your on-premises system so that you
can connect to the azure cloud and
finally you have the cloud here what
happens is your data can be analyzed or
visualized with a number of different
analytical softwares like apache spark r
hadoop and so on so all this time i've
been mentioning that data lake is a very
important part when it comes to azure
data factory's proper functioning so now
let's talk about what exactly is data
lake now data lake is a data storage or
a file system which is highly scalable
and distributed it is located in the
cloud and works with multiple analytics
frameworks which is external frameworks
like hadoop apache and so on so now
let's have a look at it so first you
have your output data set which is data
from the mobile video web social media
so much more it is sent into the azure
data lake store and then it is provided
to external frameworks like r apache and
spark so that they can be worked on now
there are two main concepts when it
comes to data lake storage so one of
them is storage and the other one is
analytics now storage is of unlimited
size it can be petabytes terabytes
gigabytes and so much more it shows a
wide variety of data it could be
unstructured or structured data and it
can store really large files and another
concept when it comes to data lake is
analytics now how it works now here are
two examples of how analytics works when
it comes to data lake now when it comes
to analytics you can monitor and
diagnose real-time data for example data
that you're getting from vehicles or
buildings these can be used to optimize
how they work respond to certain events
or generate alerts in case something
goes wrong then you can also identify
fraudulent transactions on your credit
card or you can identify the current the
geographical position of your card
perhaps monitor how many transactions
have been taking place on that card and
so on so now we're going to have a look
at how we can use the azure data factory
to move data from an sql database to a
blob storage on the cloud so here's what
we're going to do so first off to make a
database what you're going to need a
software known as ssms so you can find
it on google it's called you just need
to google it ssms the first thing you
can take here
and there you have it so you just need
to click here and download the file so
we i've already downloaded the file so
basically this is used to create a
database which we'll be transferring to
the blob storage so this will take about
depending on your computer speed pretty
long or little to no time i've already
downloaded it the process is very simple
just directly go on saying yes yes and
finally once the installation is done
here's what we're going to do we should
go into the dashboard of microsoft azure
we need to create a data warehouse so
we'll go into all resources create a
source
go to database
and select sql data warehouse there we
have it now it's very important that you
remember the names of the service of
everything that you're going to write
here because each of these become very
important later on so i've already set
up a possible set of names
youtube it's free trial the source is
already created
a blank database the server we need to
create a new one so
that we'll name it as youtube server
youtube
admin as the server admin login
the password as
all right the location does not matter
okay that's done now here the server is
done
and here we need to change how much you
want the lowest i mean how much
computation you want how much did
workload how important your workload is
so we'll put it at the lowest since we
don't require much we'll apply the rest
is normal and great
so now we're creating an sql data
warehouse so we'll wait so now the
deployment is done so we'll go to the
notification and go to the resource here
now this is done so we'll go to the ssms
which i've already opened here and then
go here
and copy this paste it here seo
authentication login which details we
have already stored here which is add
when youtube admin and the password
which is also given there
right go to options we go to the
database name which is youtube
everything else is there
you need to change it to tcp
and connect
we sign in
we'll add the password
again we're going to sign in now
right
so now that that's completed you can see
that this is what will pop up so this is
the name of the server we've given as
you saw earlier you go to databases and
here you have the youtube database that
we just created right click this and add
a new query
i already have a code for this program
it's a very simple program so
copying and pasting this
now if you need the code for this
program let us know in the comments
below it's very simple what we're doing
is creating a table called demo tab with
first name clark kent and last name is
bruce wayne and the table that's created
will have these two rows so now we're
going to execute this there you have it
two rows have been affected so now let's
have a look at our table
execute this line and there you go the
table's here so now that this is done
we're going back into azure
back and we need to create a storage
account so that's where the storage
where the blob storage is going to
happen so we're going to storage
accounts and click on add so here it's a
free trial resource group is youtube
storage account name is
the
store
that's all okay us performance is
standard
general purpose
you can do locally since we don't need
to be very reliable at least for this
one advance this fine
view and create
that's done and we create now we'll wait
for the deployment to finish
and that's it the deployment is done so
we'll go to the resource
and go to blobs so this is where the
storage is happening we need to create a
blob
simply
blob
which does not exist and okay
it has been created
now for the next bit we need to create
the data factory now so
we go to
all services
search for data factory
we press add
so here we
free trial use existing
which we have youtube each us and create
so now we've created a new data factory
now we'll wait while it's being deployed
so now it's created so we'll go here and
here we click on copy data and this
opens up
we'll name it
now description run once now
once now okay
right so we press next so we need to
connect to a data source so
so what you need to do is select a
secure as your sql data warehouse so
once again go to previous
here we select zero skill data warehouse
go here
search for
source
is your subscription free trial here
youtube server
and the database is youtube you also
need to provide your username and
password i've saved it here
youtube admin
[Music]
right
okay now we can select the table which
is demo tab
next
next
and now for our destination so where are
we going to connect this to we're going
to assure blob storage next
destination
job subscription free trial
and simply start
now we need to name our
name our storage path
next all of this can be
passed on
so
here's what we're doing it copying
whatever is inside this to the azure
blob storage that's what's happening
right now
all of that is set
and
next
it's validating and we'll wait now
it's registering connections creating
database and in the end it's creating a
pipeline
so you can monitor the pipeline from
here if you feel like it
now here's what we're going to find so
here's the here's a visual
representation of what's happening
it's being copied into the blob storage
now let's have a look if it's actually
worked out we go to our database we'll
go into
storage accounts simply store
go to blobs
you've created a new one
and there you have it
so based on the container that you've
named there it's created a new one here
so actually i earlier created the name
called simply blob but as you can see
here as long as you name a container
you'll create a folder inside which
you'll find your particular thing that
you copied
and that's it you've copied data
similarly you can do a number of
multiple operations on this container on
the on the pipeline you just created
with the data factory and that's that
and with that we've reached the end of
another video i hope you guys found this
informative and helpful we are going to
learn about the azure virtual machine so
without further ado let's get started
before getting in depth let me tell you
what's in store for today first i'll be
talking a little about azure next i'll
start off by explaining the azir virtual
machine
then i'll be focusing on few benefits of
azir virtual machine moving forward i'll
be going in depth with the azure virtual
machine components and finally we will
be looking into a demo on azure virtual
machine all of us may have heard of
azure at one point of time but what is
azir let me explain
azir is a cloud service created by
microsoft for building testing and
managing applications and many services
through the microsoft data centers the
azure hosts web applications over the
internet with the help of these data
centers
azir is very flexible it gives an option
to have the functionality as required
you can pay as you consume switch to
azure and accommodate the business
fluctuations there's no need to worry
about the infrastructure all the time
azir is very reliable and has 24 7 tech
support
azure offers pay-as-you-go pricing and
hence it is very cost effective
staying online all the time ensures
customers or users trust azure supports
backup and disaster recovery tools
now we know what azure is and its key
benefits let's now move on to azure
virtual machine
before that let's consider a scenario
rachel had to host 10 virtual machines
at once for a project there was an issue
when her computer ram was not compatible
with the instances
the computer ram was only 8 gb and the
instances that required were 10 gb
then she says i wish there is a service
that's cost effective and also provides
extra ram memory one of a colleague
heard this and he comes up with an idea
he says can we use azure virtual machine
it has a pay-as-you-go pricing and has
discs for storage you can pay for what
you use and create any number of
instances with high storage capacity
also if any technical difficulty arises
you can easily retrieve the files
through the backup server
so now she's happy and she wants to know
more about azure washing machine
azure virtual machine is one of the wide
range of services that azir offers to
create your instance a virtual machine
is a computer file typically called an
image which behaves like an actual
computer it runs in a window giving the
user the same experience on a virtual
machine as they have on the host
operating system itself
multiple virtual machines can run
simultaneously on the same physical
computer each virtual machine provides
its own hardware like cpus memories and
other devices
as your virtual machine offers a high
range of flexibility and it maintains
the physical hardware that runs on it
let me explain some of the benefits of
azure virtual machine
first we have easy development and test
azure virtual machine has a quick and
easy way to configure the computer that
is required to code and test an
application
next agility and scale as your virtual
machine is agile and the ability to
clone and spin up multiple instances of
the same virtual machine allows us to
scale services and applications rapidly
efficiently and very cost effectively
azure virtual machine provides enhanced
performance demands for applications can
fluctuate so you pay for the virtual
machines you need and shut down the
unnecessary ones to save the cost
azir virtual machines provide extended
data center and can be easily connected
to an organization's network it is easy
to set up your redundant infrastructure
in azure and azure provides a full
disaster recovery site at a fraction of
the cost furthermore let me explain azir
virtual machine components in details
virtual machine comes under the compute
domain of azio it also offers various
services like availability sets
snapshots disks images and many other
services like hosts
virtual machine can be clubbed with
other services like disks images
availability sets hosts and many more so
the first component and the most
important component is the operating
system the operating system creates
connections to the remote desktop
session host there are many operating
systems available like ubuntu red hat
linux windows server sent os you can
also set the operating disk size so that
the memory is not wasted the next
component is disks azure virtual
machines use attached virtual hard disks
for storage there are two types of
virtual hard disks first is an image it
is a template for creation of new azure
virtual machine then we have disks it is
a bootable virtual hard disk all durable
disks are backed up by page blobs in
azure storage therefore the disks
inherit the benefits of blob storage
high availability durability and many
more the disks are mounted as drives on
the vm the next component is virtual
network
many components operate the virtual
machines in a scalable and secure manner
virtual networks could include equipment
such as separate network spaces for
internet facing and backend servers load
balancers firewalls and more many of
these components are deployed into an
azure virtual network azure virtual
network provides many features such as
subnet ip address load balancer and
network security group
another important component of azure
virtual machine is availability sets if
in case there's a slight chance there
could be a failure in physical servers
then these come into picture so in case
of such failure the azure platform will
migrate the failed virtual machine to a
healthy host to reconstitute the vm it
is highly recommended to deploy at least
two instances of the virtual machine and
virtual machines placed on an
availability set perform identical set
of functionalities
now that we know what azir virtual
machine is let's look into the demo in
this demo first we are going to create a
virtual machine connect it and then
create a web server and modify the web
server and finally launch the web
application so let's go ahead into the
demo now so the first step is to log
into microsoft azure with your
credentials
now let's click on virtual machines and
create a new one
so i can put add
and
you can use the subscription you want
either pay as you go pricing or free
tire your sales group will create a new
one that is payroll
one
okay
virtual machine we can create i'm gonna
use vm
web
zero zero one
and then region i'll be using east us
then image i'll be using windows server
r2 data center
size i'll be using b1 ms
select
username
[Music]
and then password of your choice
and then i'm going to allow selected
ports and choose rdp 3389
and next
so ost step i'll be using standard hdd
and then
yeah next
so i can see a default virtual network
and a default submit in public ip as
well as default
then next
you can allow for auto shutdown but
again it's entirely your choice
i'm going to select an extension to
install and i'm going to install
microsoft anti-malware
create okay
i'm going to create a few tags now let's
go ahead with it
so i have created five tags now review
plus create
okay so everything seems good let's
create now
so the deployment is going to take a few
minutes let's wait for it
okay so that's done now let's go to
virtual machine and see our watching
machine
okay so it's been deployed
now let's get into the virtual machine
and copy the ip address
then hit windows plus r
and open mstsc
and
paste the ip address and connect
let's use a different account
you have to use the administrator
account that we've created before with
the same password
click ok
now the remote desktop session host
opens
the next step is to click on server
manager
and add rules and features
click on next
select role base of feature based
installation and click on next
then select the watching machine you've
created and next
and then we are going to select
web server iis next
sorry
next okay so it's already installed my
computer but you have to install this
then let's close this
and open internet explorer
let's type in
http
localhost
yeah so now you can see the default was
opening
let's minimize this
and let's try it here
here we have just put the ip address
i think there's an issue
so let's add an input port networking
select networking and add inbound port
let's move 480
and add
okay so it's added now let's go and
refresh it
now we can see the default web browser
opening
so the next step is to modify the web
browser let's go ahead with that go back
to your remote session host
let's go to file explorer
so certain folders are created in the c
drive let's open that
it would be
under
i needed pub
so this is where the default bros is
coming from now let's make a new text
document
open that and put
hello
welcome
to this
demo
by
simply
learn
save it
[Music]
close it let's rename this as
index
dot ht
so this is a text document
so we need to change that
okay let's remove this
okay
that's done
now let's go back to our internet
explorer and hit f5
let's refresh this
that's trying
okay so let's
yeah so it's done
now let's go back to the previous
browser and try let's refresh
yeah that's done assure virtual network
tutorial
let's look into what's in it for you
so we will be covering why is azure
virtual network important
what is azure virtual network is
benefits of using the azure virtual
network
components of a show virtual network
that includes the subnet routing network
security group why these components are
required to be created in the virtual
network and how to launch an instance
within the
azure vnet or the virtual network
and then we will be seeing one demo in
which we'll create azure virtual network
subnets and network security groups
so first of all let's look into why is
azure virtual network important
so why azure virtual network is required
so somewhere far away at an office a
company was struggling with few
challenges
the company got a bigger projects which
lead to the following challenges that
includes poor network connectivity
time consuming process in building
network topologies could not divert
network traffic to its destination on
time so these were a couple of
challenges the company was facing so
the employees thought that what could be
the possible solution to these
challenges
and then we require the azure virtual
network in that case
so first of all let's understand what is
azure virtual network is
an azure vnet or a virtual network
represents your network or environment
to run vms and applications in the cloud
when it is created the services and
virtual machines within the network
interact securely with each over the
internet so virtual network you can
consider it as a virtual cloud which is
basically kind of a cloud
space virtually assigned
to the users or or to the organization
which they can dedicatedly use for their
purpose
so for example if you have to create
some
instances or virtual machines onto the
azure cloud
and you want to connect it
with the on-prem servers for example
then you might require the virtual
network in that case let's assume that
those instances that are created in the
virtual network require the
range of ip addresses that you want to
allocate to them and that is something
you can customize using the azure
virtual network
how do you want that the traffic should
be routed to your instances in the
virtual network how the firewall
securities should be applied everything
the end user can control in the virtual
network so it seems like that you are
working in your own data center ideally
you would be working on to the azure
cloud using the virtual network
now what are the advantages of using the
azure virtual network so couple of them
are it provides an isolated environment
for your application so as i said that
it feels like it seems like
that you are working in your on-prem
environment that means within your data
center
but ideally it is a virtual space that
is allocated to you
which is a kind of an isolated
environment and that is specifically
designed
for your task and the activities
a generally a subnet in a v-net can
access the public internet by default so
we create a subnet inside the virtual
network which can access
the public internet so there is a public
network connectivity that is enabled in
the virtual net so that a subnet which
will be created in the vnet can be
accessed
traffic can be easily filtered from
different resources so you can have some
control lists defined you can have some
security groups created and how do you
want to allow the traffic onto the
servers or the application that is
something which you can control it is a
highly secure network and the security
groups and the policies are basically
implemented by the end user so you can
design how the security should be
implemented high network connectivity so
you have a higher bandwidth as compared
to the normal internet connection you
might be having in the data center
compared to that you use the azure
network only which gives you the higher
network connectivity
it builds sophisticated network
topologies in a simple
manner and which is easily manageable as
well as there are less
troubleshooting issues that we would
encounter
now what are the components of azure
virtual network
one of them is the subnets
then you have
routing
then you have network security groups
now what do we mean by subnets
the subnet is one of the
major or a prime important component in
the virtual network so what you have to
do is first obviously you would be
creating a virtual network
inside that you can create the subnets
subnets you can consider it a logical
partitioning
a virtual partitioning inside the
virtual network
subnet lets user segment the virtual
network into one or more
sub networks
for example let's assume that you're
working in an organization and in the
organization there are different
departments for every department there
should be some set of ip addresses that
you want to allocate to
the machines that the employees are
using
or
all the department should be isolated
that means they should have their own
network ids
and the network addresses allocated to
their machines
and in that case what you would do is
you would create the subnets and the
subnet ids that would be allocated to
those departments
these sub networks can be separated
logically and each subnet consists of a
server so what you do is when you create
a subnet you can you can create a server
or an instance inside that subnet and
how do you want to give an access to
that instance depends on criteria or the
requirement
hence a subnet can further be divided
into two parts one as the public subnet
and the other one as the private subnet
these are the naming conventions of the
subnet then how do you want to give the
internet connectivity depends on how the
public subnet should be interacting with
the internet and for the private subnet
as the name suggests that the internet
is blocked so that means it is
completely isolated in the virtual
network
the private instances though if you want
that any instance created in the private
subnet should have the internet
connectivity or an access you can
primarily go with the nat gateways in
that case which is a network address
translation or kind of a translator
which converts the private to public and
vice versa
and that would actually enable the
internet connectivity to your subnets
then in the public instances they can
directly access the instance as the name
suggests public instances that public
subnets that means
they have the direct internet
connectivity
next component is routing and
the routing is primarily a routing rules
you can say that are applied
and those are actually applied to
the routers only so since on the cloud
we cannot have a direct router access
and hence using the routing as a
component we can define some routing
rules which are directly applied to the
router and the infrastructure
it delivers the data by choosing a
suitable path from source to destination
for each subnet azure virtual network
automatically routes traffic and creates
a route table when you create a virtual
network
automatically a route table is created
and that
basically
is required to route the traffic
and that can be used by every subnet
that doesn't mean that you only have to
create a single route table in the
virtual network you can have multiple
route tables also created which can be
associated with different subnets as
well then you have the network security
groups
it is kind of a firewall that protects
the virtual machine by limiting the
network traffic
it restricts inbound and outbound
network traffic depending upon the
destination ipa transport
and the protocol so it is basically
the network security group sits on the
instances
and
or virtual machines and
they basically
define that how the traffic should be
reaching to the ports onto the virtual
machine so how do you want to open up
the ports and for which ip addresses you
want to open up the ports that is
something
the end user or the administrator has to
specify your design so they act as a
kind of a firewall rules only that
protects the virtual machines
so how to launch an instance using azure
vnet
so first of all you have to create a
virtual network so virtual network act
as a container for subnets so first
thing is that you would be creating a
virtual network then you would be
creating
subnets which are considered as a subset
within the virtual network
so cloud instance is included in the
subnet so first vnets are created then
the subnets are created and then you
configure the properties in the security
group
have a look at this in detail
now with respect to the virtual network
what you need to do is you have to
create a virtual network in the azure
cloud
then you have to create subnets into
each virtual network which is kind of a
subset of a virtual network so you can
create one as a public subnet the other
one as a private subnet for example
now you have to assign instances so when
you create an instance you have to
specify that what is the virtual network
for which virtual network you are
creating an instance within that virtual
network you have to select that on which
particular subnet the instance should be
created
and then connect instance to a relevant
network security group so attach your
network security group to the instances
and based on the properties or the rules
that are defined in the network security
group that will be applied to the
instances within the subnets finally
configure the properties in the network
security and set the policies
as a result you will be able to launch
your instance on azure within
the virtual network
now we will be seeing one demo that how
we can create azure virtual network
subnets and the network security group
so just be there
to watch our demo on
the azure virtual network in today's
session i would be showing how you can
create the virtual networks onto the
azure
and for that you require the credentials
on microsoft azure and here you can see
on my screen that i have already logged
in into
the azure console
now what you need to do is in order to
search virtual network you can
type
and search in the dashboard
in the search bar uh with respect to the
virtual networks
and here you can find
uh the virtual network and the gateways
so what you need to do is you just have
to click on the virtual networks and
then it will give you the options
to add the components inside the virtual
networks
so let me first
open up
the virtual network
right now
in theory we discussed that the virtual
network comprises of multiple components
and sub components so primarily is that
first you have to create a virtual
network
then you have to assign the ipv4 cidr
block to the virtual network
and then you create the subnets inside
the network which is a subset of the
virtual network along with that you
define the routing rules
and
likewise you create
the instances inside the subnets that
will be part of the virtual networks
so that's what we are going to do uh in
this demo so i would be adding up a new
virtual network so you can see here
there are already two virtual networks
that have been added one is the demo
v-net which is by default so when you
created the azure credentials
the demo virtual network was already
created by the azure so that it can
provide you the
default settings
and then the test one has been created
by me and that's the customized one or
you can say a non-default virtual
network
so i'll i'm going to add another
v-net and
would define
the name to it
so let's wait for
the details to appear so here
you have to define the virtual network
to create uh obviously we will be going
with the free trial only
and then you have to create a resource
group so
what is a resource group it is primarily
a collection of resources that share the
same life cycle permissions and the
policies so if you have a resource group
created you can use it otherwise you can
create a new resource group so i already
have one
that is the demo one i would be using
that
in the instance details you have to
specify the name of the virtual network
so
these are certain
uh parameters that you have to go with
while defining the name so let's say i
put something like
test
v-net
as the virtual network that i want to
create and that is you have to select a
region where you want to get that
created
so these are the available regions that
you can select i would go with
newest east
east us only and then we have to define
the ip addresses also
see so in the ip addresses uh the cidr
blocks are allocated to the virtual
networks and that becomes a fixed ip
address for that we net
so what you can do is you can specify a
range of ip addresses now whenever we
talk about a virtual network and the ip
addresses we primarily focus on the
private ips only so this is the private
ip that we are actually
talking about so i can reserve some
ip address cidr
for our vnet and that is the range of
40.0.0.0.16
i'm going to resolve so now we'll create
one subnet and we'll name that subnet so
as we discussed that subnets are the sub
components of
the vnet
so here you can see we have already
created one
subnet with the name public subnet so
likewise we can add another subnet also
and
let's name it to something like demo
subnet right and the subnet should have
the ip address range and that ip address
range should be part of the v-net only
in vte
so same subnet address range you would
be defining in the subnet as well so
that will be 40.0.1.
or we can select 2.0
24.
the rest of the things would be default
we are not attaching any route table as
of now so just click on ok
and here you can see
that the subnet is created
now once the subnet is created now we
are going to create a virtual machine
inside that subnet and for that we'll go
to the search bar
and here we'll type
virtual machines
now we'll create a virtual machine in
the same v-net that is the test v-net
and inside the demo subnet
so that our virtual machine gets the
private ip address from
the subnet that has been created in the
vnet itself so what you need to do is
you have to open up the virtual machines
click on add and here
you should add a new virtual machine
so you should select the name of the
virtual machine and
the network details
where we would be defining
the v-net as well as the subnet where
the virtual machine should be created
so in the subscription we'll go with the
free tail and in the resource group
we'll go with the demo that has already
been created we'll put a virtual machine
name something like
test
vm
and the rest of the things will be
default
so we'll quickly skip the disk check
also
now in the networking
we would be selecting
the test v-net as
our virtual network
and in the subnet we would be selecting
the demo subnet
so that is the recently one added in the
test v-net and we want that our virtual
machine should be part of that subnet
only
now obviously since we are creating a
virtual machine so it should be part of
it should have the public ip also
assigned since from the public network
we need to access those virtual machines
so we'll keep it enabled right and the
next
would be the default settings that we
are going to proceed with
so let's review all the configurations
and then
create your virtual machine
so here you can see that our virtual
machine has been created validation has
been passed and it takes couple of
minutes to get that updated so let's
wait for a few more minutes so that our
virtual machine is ready and primarily
what we want to look into is that our
virtual machine is created in a correct
we net and it gets
the private ip address from the subnet
that has been part of the
v-net
which has been defined in the creation
of a virtual machine so let's wait for a
couple of more minutes and we'll look
into the status of the main
now you can see here our test virtual
machine has been created now what we
wanted to look into is that our virtual
machine is created in a correct
subnet or not and that is something
which we can validate
by checking the private ip address so it
got the private ip from the range of
the ip address that we have specified in
the subnet
now in order to access this particular
virtual machine you have to use the
public ip since
since we have to access it from the
internet so
from the private ip this virtual machine
will not be accessible
so that's the reason that when we
created a virtual machine we allocated
the public ip address also for this
instance
so that is with respect to
the virtual network and the
demonstration on it and how we can
create a v-net and the sub-components of
the v-net how they are associated or
interlinked with each other
and that actually creates a kind of an
isolated environment on the public cloud
which gives you
the understanding that you can work into
just like an on-prem environment only
today we will discuss what should an
individual learn in the year 2021
let's wait for an ample amount of time
so that few more people can tune in
by the time please allow me to tell you
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you are the tech geek
in a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and hit the bell icon so that
you can never miss an update from our
end
so we have a few more people now hi
everyone welcome to simply learn
so without further ado let's get started
back in the 2000s organizations were
utterly dependent on purchase servers
for their id infrastructure
these servers not only came with limited
functionality but were also very
expensive
the traditional way of storing and
managing data was costly and complicated
it required a massive amount of hardware
and complex software to run all these
issues were resolved using cloud
computing rather than owning their
computing infrastructures organizations
were able to scale up or scale down
resources based on the requirement
companies providing these computing
services are called as cloud providers
according to c-sharp corner the two
popular cloud providers in the cloud
market are amazon aws and microsoft
azure now let's take a step back and
talk about a question
what should an individual learn in the
year 2021
amazon web services or microsoft azure
though this question is tricky we need
to understand which cloud provider is
the best option to choose
now let's take a brief look at both of
these cloud providers
amazon web services is an evolving cloud
computing platform that offers various
services such as compute power storage
database content delivery and other
resources to help business scale and
grow
aws services are provided based on a
subscription basis similarly microsoft
azure provides a set of cloud services
to design create and monitor
applications on a network
talking about the general features
amazon web services was established in
the year 2006. today it holds a market
share of 31.7
whereas microsoft azure was started in
the year 2010 and now has a market share
up to
16.8 percent
amazon aws is the world's most broadly
adopted cloud platform it offers up to
165 services globally
these services are used by millions of
companies like spotify netflix facebook
bbc etc
talking about netflix the company moved
its id operations to aws in the year
2009. aws was able to solve the
company's scalability and data
management issues
azure offers several services in various
categories including artificial
intelligence analytics containers iot
and many more
these services are used by many famous
companies like accenture linkedin stack
ebay and samsung
accenture chose microsoft azure to boost
productivity and provide better security
to its employees
the aws pricing model is based on an
hourly basis with aws every individual
pays only for the services that are
required for his work every person only
pays for the services he consumes
azure pricing is charged on a per minute
basis the payment system is very simple
and doesn't involve any long-term
contracts
microsoft azure is free of upfront cost
and cancellation fees and only users pay
for the resources they consume
with azure and amazon aws there are no
additional costs or termination fees
moving on to the next factor let's talk
about availability zones
availability zones are isolated data
centers with independent power and
networking these zones protect
applications and files from data center
failures
in total
aws has nearly 77 availability zones
within 24 geographic regions around the
world
the company plans to establish nine more
aws availability zones and three more
aws regions in indonesia japan and spain
on the other hand microsoft azure has
many isolated availability zones these
zones are located within an azure region
and they provide fast network
connectivity azure has 44 availability
zones around the world the company is
planning to launch 12 more zones
now after discussing the availability
zones let's talk about the services the
services that i am going to compare here
come under the following domains compute
storage
database
security and finally networking
aws and azure provide a wide variety of
services with low migration costs so
that every individual can shift his or
her current traditional infrastructure
to cloud platform very easily
aws ec2 is a suitable example of compute
services
ec2 is a web service that aims to make
life easier for developers by providing
secure and resizable compute capacity in
the cloud it can be integrated to
several other services like s3 iam cloud
formation etc
azure has a small service called as your
virtual machine image it helps the
developers to develop and design
identical virtual machines in the matter
of minutes
azure virtual machines are becoming more
popular among id infrastructures these
machines let an individual create and
use virtual machines in the cloud as ias
or infrastructure as a service
virtual machines can be created using
azure portal as your powershell and arm
templates as your cli or client software
development kits
next comes amazon s3 it is the best
example for storage service
simple storage service is an object
storage service designed to store and
recover any information from anywhere
via the internet
amazon s3 facilitates storage through a
web service interface the service
provides 99.9 percent durability and
99.9 availability of objects
it has the capacity of storing computer
files up to five terabytes in size
on the other hand azure provides a
similar service called blob storage
service
this service provides a large amount of
storage and is highly scalable
it stores an object in the tires
depending on how often the data is being
accessed
blob storage supports widely used
frameworks like java dot net pyson and
node.js
it is the only cloud storage service in
microsoft azure that offers a premium
ssd based object storage tire for low
latency networks
aws provides a secure cloud platform
where every individual can manage and
deploy their applications
compared to the on-premises environment
aws security offers a high level of data
protection at a lower cost for security
purposes iam is a suitable service
aws identity and access management is a
cloud service that controls and manages
aws resources securely it has no upfront
cost also gives a facility to create and
maintain services within a specific set
of users on your aws resources
in microsoft azure as your active
directory or in short also called as
azure ad is a web service which provides
mfa multi-factor authentication features
to users in order to protect their data
from cyber attacks
next is amazon rds it is a web service
designed to simplify the setup operation
and scaling of a relational database
it is simple to set up use and scale
when required by users
it provides inexpensive and resizable
capacity and automates several tasks
such as hardware provisioning database
setup patching and backups on the other
side the azure sql database
automatically updates and backups data
in order to focus on the development of
applications
not just that it also manages database
services and responds to client
requirements
client requirements such as scalability
of a service data backup and high
availability of database
similarly these cloud providers have
plenty of services that help users build
and deploy their applications
effectively
moving on to the next topic let us focus
on integrating aws and azure with open
source tools
now we will explain how to build a
pipeline using jenkins along with one of
the services of amazon web services that
is the ec2 in this integration process
we have a sample pyson application
called as a docker file
this dockerfile will consist of a python
based image the docker file builds a
pipeline in order to create a docker
image upon pushing the code to the
repository
later the new image is used to start a
new aws service on an ecs cluster now
let's have a look at how the integration
of open source tools happen in azure in
your azure cloud application devops
tools like docker maven and jenkins can
be integrated in case you want to
integrate the jenkins pipeline go to
project and create a subscription
followed by jenkins you can specify the
required filters based on your
requirement then choose your endpoint
for azure devops to communicate with
jenkins
so that was all about amazon aws and
microsoft azure both aws and azure are
honored to be on top of all other cloud
providers
both provide all necessary features like
scalability high availability and
security but the moment i hear about
choosing the best one i have to say that
all that depends upon the individual
business needs
both cloud providers are the certified
ones that hold immense value in the
current cloud service market
hey guys i'm rahul and i'll be
representing amazon web services i'm
chinmayi and i'll be representing
microsoft azure and i am shruti and i'll
be representing google cloud platform so
welcome to this video on aws versus
azure versus gcp talking about market
share amazon web services leads with
around 32 percent of the worldwide
public cloud share azure owns up to 16
of the worldwide market share and gcp
owns around 9 of the world's market
share let's talk about each of these
service providers in detail aws provides
services that enable users to create and
deploy applications over the cloud these
services are accessible via the internet
aws being the oldest of the lot was
launched in the year 2006. azure
launched in 2010 is a computing platform
that offers a wide range of services to
build manage and deploy applications on
the network using tools and frameworks
launched in the year 2008 gcp offers
application development and integration
services for its end users in addition
to cloud management it also offers
services for big data machine learning
and iot now let's talk about
availability zones these are isolated
locations within data center regions
from which public cloud services
originate and operate talking about aws
they have 69 availability zones within
22 geographical regions this includes
regions in the united states south
america europe and asia pacific they are
also predicted to have 12 more editions
in the future azure available in 140
countries has over 54 regions worldwide
grouped into six geographies these
geographical locations have more than
100 data centers gcp is available in 200
plus countries across the world as of
today gcp is present in 61 zones and 20
regions with osaka and zurich being the
newly added regions now let's talk about
pricing these services follow the pay as
you go approach you pay only for the
individual services you need for as long
as you use them without requiring
long-term contracts or complex licensing
now on screen you can see the pricing
for each of these cloud service
providers with respect to various
instances like general purpose compute
optimized memory optimized and gpu now
let's talk about the compute services
offered first off we have virtual
servers for aws we have ec2 it is a web
service which eliminates the need to
invest in hardware so that you can
develop and deploy applications in a
faster manner it provides virtual
machines in which you can run your
applications azure's virtual machines is
one of the several types of computing
resources that azure offers azure gives
the user the flexibility to deploy and
manage a virtual environment inside a
virtual network gcp's vm service enables
users to build deploy and manage virtual
machines to run workloads on the cloud
now let's talk about the pricing of each
of these services aw cc2 is free to try
it is packaged as part of aws's free
tier that lasts for 12 months and
provides 750 hours per month of both
linux and windows virtual machines azure
virtual machine service is a part of the
free tier that offers this service for
about 750 hours per month for a year the
user gets access to windows and linux
virtual machines gcp's vm service is a
part of a free tier that includes micro
instance per month for up to 12 months
now let's talk about platform as a
service or pass services for aws elastic
beanstalk is an easy to use service for
deploying and scaling web applications
and services developed with java.net
node.js python and much more it is used
for maintaining capacity provisioning
load balancing auto scaling and
application health monitoring the pass
backbone utilizes virtualization
techniques where the virtual machine is
independent of the actual hardware that
hosts it hence the user can write
application code without worrying about
the underlying hardware google app
engine is a cloud computing platform as
a service which is used by developers
for hosting and building apps in google
data centers the app engine requires the
apps to be written in java or python and
store data in google bigtable and use
the google query language for this next
let's talk about virtual private server
services aws provides light sale it
provides everything you need to build an
application or a website along with the
cost effective monthly plan and minimum
number of configurations in simple words
vm image is a more comprehensive image
for microsoft azure virtual machines it
helps the user create many identical
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
unfortunately gcp does not offer any
similar service next up we have
serverless computing services aws has
lambda it is a serverless compute
service that lets you run your code
without facilitating and managing
servers you only pay for the compute
time you use it is used to execute
backend code and scales automatically
when required azure functions is a
serverless compute service that lets you
run even triggered code without having
to explicitly provision or manage
infrastructure this allows the users to
build applications using serverless
simple functions with the programming
language of their choice gcp cloud
functions make it easy for developers to
run and scale code in the cloud and
build image driven serverless
applications it is highly available and
fault tolerant now let's talk about
storage services offered by each of
these service providers
first off we have object storage aws
provides s3 it is an object storage that
provides industry standard scalability
data availability and performance it is
extremely durable and can be used for
storing as well as recovering
information or data from anywhere over
the internet blob storage is an azure
feature that lets developers store
unstructured data in microsoft's cloud
platform along with storage it also
offers scalability it stores the data in
the form of tears depending on how often
data is being accessed google cloud
storage is an online storage web service
for storing and accessing data on google
cloud platform infrastructure unlike the
google drive google cloud storage is
more suitable for enterprises it also
stores objects that are organized into
buckets amazon provides ebs or elastic
block store it provides high performance
block storage and is used along with ec2
instances for workloads that are
transaction or throughput intensive
azure managed disk is a virtual hard
disk you can think of it like a physical
disk in an on-premises server but
virtualized these managed disks allow
the users to create up to 10 000 vm
disks in a single subscription
persistent storage is a data storage
device that retains data after power to
the device is shut off google persistent
disk is durable and high performance
block storage for gcp persistent disk
provides storage which can be attached
to instances running in either google
compute engine or kubernetes engine next
up we have disaster recovery services
aws provides a cloud-based recovery
service that ensures that your it
infrastructure and data are recovered
while minimizing the amount of downtime
that could be experienced site recovery
helps ensure business continuity by
keeping business apps and workloads
running during outages it allows
recovery by orchestrating and automating
the replication process of azure virtual
machines between regions unfortunately
gcp has no disaster recovery service
next let's talk about database services
first off for aws we have rds or
relational database service it is web
service that's cost effective and
automates administration tasks basically
it simplifies the setup operation and
scaling of a relational database
microsoft azure sql database is a
software as a service platform that
includes built-in intelligence that
learns app patterns and adapts to
maximize performance reliability and
data protection it also eases the
migration of sql server databases
without changing the user's applications
cloud sql is a fully managed database
service which is easy to set up maintain
and administer relational postgresql
mysql and sql server databases in the
cloud hosted on gcp cloud sql provides a
database infrastructure for applications
running anywhere next we have nosql
database services aws provides dynamodb
which is a managed durable database that
provides security backup and restore and
in-memory caching for applications it is
well known for its low latency and
scalable performance azure cosmos db is
microsoft's globally distributed
multi-model database service it natively
supports nosql it natively supports
nosql created for low latency and
scalable applications gcp cloud data
store is a nosql database service
offered by google on the gcp it handles
replication and scales automatically to
your application's load with cloud data
stores interface data can easily be
accessed by any deployment target now
let's talk about the key cloud tools for
each of these service providers for aws
in networking and content delivery we
have aws route 53 and aws cloud front
for management we have aws cloud watch
and aws cloud formation for development
we have aws code start and aws code
build for security we have iam and key
management service for microsoft azure
networking and content delivery we have
content delivery network and express
root for management tools we have azure
advisor and network watcher for
development tools for management we have
azure advisor and network watcher for
development we have visual studio ide
and azure blob studio for security we
have azure security center and azure
active directory for gcp we have the
following tools for networking and
content delivery we have cloud cdn and
cloud dns for management we have stack
driver and gcp monitoring for
development we have cloud build and
cloud sdk and finally for security we
have google cloud im and google and
cloud security scanner now let's talk
about the companies using these cloud
providers for aws we have netflix
unilever kellogg's nasa nokia and adobe
pixar samsung ebay fujitsu emc and bmw
among others use microsoft azure so as
seen on your screens the companies that
use gcp are spotify hsbc snapchat
twitter paypal and 20th century fox
let's talk about the advantages of each
of these services amazon provides
enterprise friendly services you can
leverage amazon's 15 years of experience
delivering large-scale global
infrastructure and it still continues to
hone and innovate its infrastructure
management skills and capabilities
secondly it provides instant access to
resources aws is designed to allow
application providers isvs and vendors
to quickly and securely host your
applications whether an existing
application or a new sas based
application speed and agility aws
provides you access to its services
within minutes all you need to select is
what you require and you can proceed you
can access each of these applications
anytime you need them and finally it's
secure and reliable amazon enables you
to innovate and scale your application
in a secure environment it secures and
hardens your infrastructure more
importantly it provides security at a
cheaper cost than on-premise
environments now talking about some of
the advantages of azure microsoft azure
offers better development operations it
also provides strong security profile
azure has a strong focus on security
following the standard security model of
detect assess diagnose stabilize and
close azure also provides a
cost-effective solution the cloud
environment allows businesses to launch
both customer applications and internal
apps in the cloud which saves an it
infrastructure costs hence it's opex
friendly let's now look at the
advantages of gcp google builds in
minute level increments so you only pay
for the compute time you use they also
provide discounted prices for long
running workloads for example you use
the vm for a month and get a discount
gcp also provides live migration of
virtual machines live migration is the
process of moving a running vm from one
physical server to another without
disrupting its availability to the users
this is a very important differentiator
for google cloud compared to other cloud
providers gcp provides automatic
scalability this allows a site's
container scale to as many cpus as
needed google cloud storage is designed
for 99.9 durability it creates server
backup and stores them in an user
configured location let's talk about the
disadvantages of each of these services
for aws there's a limitation of the ec2
service aws provides limitations on
resources that vary from region to
region there may be a limit to the
number of instances that can be created
however you can request for these limits
to be increased secondly they have a
technical support fee aws charges you
for immediate support and you can opt
for any of these packages developer
which costs 29 per month business which
costs more than hundred dollars an
enterprise that costs more than fifteen
thousand dollars it has certain network
connectivity issues it also has general
issues when you move to the cloud like
downtime limited control backup
protection and so on however most of
these are temporary issues and can be
handled over time talking about some of
the disadvantages of microsoft azure
code base is different when working
offline and it requires modification
when working on the cloud pass echo
system is not as efficient as iaas azure
management console is frustrating to
work with it is slow to respond and
update and requires far too many clicks
to achieve simple tasks azure backup is
intended for backing up and restoring
data located on your on-premises servers
to the cloud that's a great feature but
it's not really useful for doing bare
metal restores of servers in a remote
data center let's now look into the
disadvantages of gcp so when it comes to
cloud providers the support fee is very
minimal but in the case of gcp it is
quite costly it is around 150 dollars
per month for the most basic service
similar to aws s3 gcp has a complex
pricing schema also it is not very
budget friendly when it comes to
downloading data from google cloud
storage azure interview preparation
session knowing azure is one thing
having worked on azure is another thing
and being able to answer interview
questions in azure is a totally
different thing although one helps the
other it's still different skills and
our aim through this video is to prepare
you with common product and scenario
based interview questions so why wait
let's get started a common cloud
interview question is what's the
difference between sas pass and is we
all know that
software as a service is thin client
model of software provisioning where
client in this case usually is simply a
web browser providing the point of
access to software's running on the
servers now sas is the most familiar
form of cloud service for customers sas
moves the task of managing software and
its deployment to third-party services
meaning the vendor actually gets to
manage all that so
sas is software as a service involving
applications being consumed and used by
organization so it's generally using an
application and usually organizations
pay for their use of this particular
application now some examples of sas
would include office 365. salesforce is
another very good example of sas and a
lot of google apps and storage solutions
like box and dropbox are a very good
example of software as a service talking
about platform as a service or pass it
actually functions at the lower level
than sas now typically it provides a
platform on which software can be
developed and deployed now here we
develop the software we deploy the
software now pass actually provides an
abstract of much of the work dealing
with servers and giving client an
environment in which the operating
system and the server software and the
hardwares the network are managed and
taken care in other words with a
platform as a service all the things
that i've mentioned like the servers the
server software the hardware everything
is managed by the provider and we can
focus on business side of the
scalability and we can focus on
application development of our product
or the service so in short platform as a
service is a service that enables
developers to build and work with
applications without even having to
worry about the infrastructure or
management of the underlying hosting
environments and some examples of
pass in azure is
sql and azure storage talking about
infrastructure as a service i as now
this is moving down the stack even
further now we get to the fundamental
building block of the cloud service
which is infrastructure as a service is
now is is fully of highly automated
scalable computer resources is full of
storage is full of the network
capability that's what is is now is
clients have direct access to the
servers and storage just as they would
to do traditional servers but in this
case it's going to be in the cloud in
this case it's going to be more scalable
so is is very similar to what you would
do in your on-premises physical data
center but when we talk about is we get
to do everything but it's stored in the
cloud so if we need to build a
definition around is is or
infrastructure as a service provides
users with components it provides
components it does not give us a built
environment it simply provides a
component such as operating system
networking capabilities and a lot more
now this is a paid for based on the
usage and can be used to host
applications in other words this is pay
as you go type the more you use the more
you pay the less you use the less you
pay and some of the examples of is in
azure is a virtual machine that's a
great example for is and v-nets for
networking that's another good example
for is in azure another common question
in azure interview is what are the
instant types offered by azure the main
intention of this question is how well
have you understood the different
offerings in azure and how well are you
trained to pick the right
offering for the right service now one
size does not fit all and thereof there
are a lot of services in azure that
under the carpet it does the same thing
but depending on how different your
requirement is we'll have to pick the
appropriate server so this actually this
question what are the different instant
types offered by azure it's to test how
well have you used the product and
services available in azure and how well
have you applied them for the given
requirement you shouldn't be
provisioning more you should be
provisioning less at the same time so
it's kind of matching the right service
to the right requirement so what are the
instant types offered by azure as you
see in the list we have general purpose
compute optimized memory optimized
storage optimized gpu virtual machines
and high performance compute virtual
machines now answering just the names
won't be enough in an interview you'll
have to go further and explain why and
in what scenario you would use general
purpose and what are the use cases what
type of servers is a good fit for a
general purpose and what type is a good
fit for compute optimized so on and so
forth and that's exactly what we're
going to do now so the general purpose
vms you know they provide a balanced cpu
to memory ratio and it's very good for
testing very good for a development
environment very good for small and
medium databases and also for low to
medium traffic web servers and some of
the use cases are like we said test
servers low traffic web servers
small to medium databases some
enterprise great applications it's also
good for relational database it's also
good for
servers used for in-memory caching it's
also good for some small analytic
database very good for micro services
and if you're trying to build a proof of
concept for an idea that you just have
or just parked this is another good
server for doing proof of concepts
because you're not going to send actual
traffic to it i just want to show that
you know your idea works so general
purpose server is a very good use case
for those scenarios and the largest
instance size we can get in general
purpose is standard d64 v3 which comes
with 256 gigabit of memory and 1600
gigabit of ssd temporary storage on the
other hand compute optimized vms have an
a high cpu to memory ratio and are very
good for medium traffic web servers very
good for batch processing servers very
good for application servers now because
it's computer optimized and compute
means a cpu it's an excellent choice for
workloads that demand faster cpu but
does not need as much memory or
temporary storage virtual cpu some of
the workloads that run very well on
computer optimized are analytic
workloads gaming servers require more
cpu they run really well batch
processing are some of the applications
that can be placed in compute optimized
and by doing that we get the actual
benefit of the compute optimized
instance and the largest instance size
or the largest instant size type is
standard f72s v2 and here we get
144 gigabit of memory and
576 gigabit of ssd temporary storage in
compute optimized vms in the same lines
memory optimized to vm they offer high
memory to cpu ratio and that are great
for databases databases require more
memory so it's a great fit for database
and it's a great fit for medium to
large scale caches applications that
require in-memory analytics so this
memory optimized memory is more so it's
very good for in-memory analytics
applications and the largest instant
size we get here is standard
m128m and look at the
gigabit of memory it's 3892
gigabit of memory and
look at the temporary storage it's uh
1400
336 a gigabit of temporary storage on
the same lines storage optimized now i
guess i don't have to explain to you
what storage optimized is used for you
might have easily guessed looking at the
flow
yes storage optimized vm offer high disk
throughput and io and are very ideal for
big data
sql nosql databases data warehousing
servers large transactional databases
and lot more and some of the examples of
the applications that can be launched on
storage optimized are cassandra mongodb
cloudera redis these are some familiar
applications that can get benefited when
we run them on storage optimized and one
difference between storage optimized and
the other servers are they are generally
optimized to use the local disk on the
node attached directly to the vm rather
than using an durable disk which is
actually in a remote
disk space now what does this allow this
allows for greater input outputs per
second or throughput for the workload so
that's what we get a greater throughput
at greater input outputs per second is
what we get and when we use storage
optimized and the largest instance size
available in storage optimized is a
standard l32s and
the memory is 256 gigabit and look at
the temporary storage it's a
5630 gigabit of temporary storage
gpu type vms easy to guess gpu optimized
vms are specialized virtual machines
available with
multiple gpus attached to them now these
sizes are designed for or these vms are
designed for compute intensive graphic
intensive visualization workloads that
require a lot of
graphical processing unit attached to it
so in short these are virtual machines
that specialize in heavy graphic
rendering and video editing it also
helps with model training and
interferencing with the standard nd 24
rs which has a 448 gigabit of memory and
2948
gigabit of temporary storage and the
last but not the least but the best last
but the best is high performance compute
or azure head series virtual machines
now they are the latest in high
performance computing vms and are aimed
to handle workloads like batch
processing analytic molecular modeling
and fluid dynamics a lot of complicated
applications in this vm and this is the
fastest and powerful cpu virtual machine
with the optional high throughput
interfaces and the largest instance size
that's available is a standard l32s
which comes with the 224 gigabit of
memory and 200 gigabit of ssd temporary
storage and a third common question is
what are the deployment environments
offered by azure there are two main
deployment environments one is the
staging environment and the other one is
the production environment now in
staging environment let's talk about
staging first so when you are deploying
your web app or web app on linux you can
deploy them to a separate slot instead
of the default production slot when
running them in standard premium or
isolated app service plan tiers now the
deployments slots are actually live app
with their own host name and at a later
point that the staging environment can
be swapped with the production
environment so why do we need and
staging environment what are the benefit
of it so the benefit of deploying our
application to a non-production or
staging environment it provides a
platform to validate changes to our
application before it can be made live
in the production environment and in the
staging environment the app can be
identified using the azure's global
unique identifier also called as the
guid url and it's very very similar to
the production url except that it has a
custom name in front of it that
identifies it as the staging environment
and for production environment this is
the live
production environment that's serving
customers request that serving the
customer content now it can be slightly
different from the staging environment
in a way that the url that's used to
identify the production environment
that's more often dns friendly name like
the name of the actual service dot cloud
app.net that way it differs in case of
staging environment you have and custom
name right before it so the custom name
and then the cloudapp.net but in this
case you get the direct service name as
the name of the url so this is live
production environment which receives
and handles and serves customer traffic
another commonly asked question in azure
is what are the advantages of scaling in
azure the actual thought behind the
question is to see
how much have you understood scaling how
much have you seen and how much have you
applied the scaling effect in the
production environment and have received
benefits in return so let's talk about
it advantages of scaling in azure some
of the advantages are we get the maximum
application performance now auto scaling
is a built-in feature for the cloud
services be it
aws azure uh google and couple of other
cloud service providers it's a built-in
feature for a cloud service a cloud
service should be auto scalable and that
includes mobile services virtual
machines and
when we run our applications uh on
mobile services or virtual machines the
website actually gets the best
performance uh during the change in the
demand again different applications
might require different performance
needs for examples for some apps the
performance measured based on memory and
another a good example is the
fluctuating demand for example you could
have a web app that handles millions of
requests during the day and literally
nothing at the night and auto scaling
this environment auto scaling any of
these environment will automatically
scale or fatten your environment so to
receive the all the incoming traffic and
during lean period it actually gets
slimmer and slimmer so to help you with
the cost so it actually maximizes the
performance that's what auto scaling
does and like we said auto scaling
scales up and scales down based on
demand it not only scales up but also
scales down so to help you with the cost
and if you know the particular pattern
in which the application is going to
receive traffic then we can very well go
ahead and schedule scaling to our
application or schedule scaling that
infrastructure based on time if we
already know that monday to friday
that's the traffic that i would get and
it's a constant one it's not a public
facing but you know it's an internal
application so i know all the 500 users
or the thousand or the 5000 users who
will be using it so at any given point
it's just 5000 users it's not going to
go beyond that and during saturday and
sunday literally nobody's going to be in
office so no load at all so in that case
i pretty much know how the pattern is
going to be i can go for scheduled
scaling if i know at the pattern and
auto scaling like i said not only helps
with keeping the application highly
available it also helps with the cost
effectiveness of our infrastructure so
anytime there's a vm or a group of vms
running on less cpu auto scaling is
going to actually get the environment
slimmer and slimmer so we're not
unnecessarily running any resources and
paying for it if you're being
interviewed for the infrasight in azure
this is another common question that
gets asked how are windows active
directory and azure active directory
different let's talk about the windows
active directory first the non-cloud
windows active directory was the service
was released along with windows 2000
server edition and this active directory
is essentially a database that helps
organizations to organize the users
organize the computers and lot more it
provides authentication and
authorization to the applications not
only to the applications but also to
file servers to printers and a lot of
other on-premises resources that's what
the basic non-cloud active directory
does on the other hand the azure active
directory is not designed to manage
web-based services the azure active
directory on the other hand was designed
to support web-based services that use
rest api interfaces for office
365 salesforce.com etc unlike the plain
active directory this uses a completely
different protocol so protocol wise it's
different and the services that it
support is quite different now besides
that it also has couple of other
differences as well and let's look at
them so the actual active directory or
the windows actual directory is a
directory service that facilitates
working with interconnected complex and
different network resources in a very
unified manner on the other hand azure
active directory is microsoft's
multi-tenant cloud-based directory and
identity management service and the
windows active directory has five layers
to store data to store user details and
to issue the management certifications
on the other hand azure active directory
integrates or compresses the five layers
into just two layers here windows active
directory works with on-premises servers
like applications file servers and
printers etc on the other hand azure
active directory it works on web-based
services that use restful interfaces if
you're being hired for the development
environment or for the cloud devops
support environment or even for the
production support environment you might
find yourself being asked this question
what are the types of queues offered by
azure now azure supports two types of
queue mechanisms the storage cube and
the service bus queue let's talk about
storage queue first now the storage
queue which are part of azure storage
infrastructure it provides a simple rest
based uh interface simple rest based get
put and peak interface it provides
reliable persistent messaging within and
between other services it follows the
pub sub model or pub sub messaging
infrastructure and it's best suited for
users that need to store more than 80
gigabit of messages in the queue it can
provide a logs for all the transactions
executed against the user's queue so
that's what we get with storage queue
and on the other hand service bus cube
the service bus cues are built on top of
broader messaging infrastructure and
they are designed to integrate
applications and applications component
that can span multiple communication
protocols so that way it differs so this
is good for applications and components
that may span multiple communication
protocols and even different totally
different network environments so in
short these service buses or the service
bus cues in azure are part of azure's
messaging infrastructure and they
integrate applications or application
components that can actually span
multiple different protocols and
multiple different network environments
it also provides and first and first out
style for delivery and the user's queue
size has to remain under 80 gigabit
another familiar question is what are
the advantages of azure resource manager
now the resource manager helps us to
manage at the usage of the application
resources this question is actually to
test how well have you tested how well
have you used resource manager and have
gotten the benefit of it this question
actually tests how easy it has become
after the introduction of resource
manager compared to
when doing deployments or when
provisioning resources without the
resource manager so let's get into the
answers for the question what are the
advantages of azure resource manager the
in chart resource manager is called arm
so the arm helps deploy manage and
monitor all the resources for an
application a solution or a group so all
the interconnected application all the
interconnected services can be monitored
as group using resource manager and
users can be granted to access to
resources that they require within a
resource manager so in an account i can
have like 10 different resources created
by a resource manager or a resource
group created by resource managers and i
can allow deny connection to those
services or only to those services based
on whether the user should be accessing
one and not accessing the other so that
way it becomes easy to give access to a
group of application it helps in getting
billing details for the group of
resources now which group is using more
which group is using less and which
group has contributed more to this
month's bill stuff like that so those
details can be obtained using azure zoos
manager and provisioning resources is
made much easier with the help of this
resource manager another question is how
has integrating hybrid cloud been useful
for azure well with the use of hybrid
cloud we get the best of both the worlds
so with hybrid cloud it's nothing but
combining the public cloud and the
private cloud and allowing data and
applications to be shared between them
so whenever the compute or the
processing demand fluctuates hybrid
cloud computing gives businesses the
ability to seamlessly scale their
on-premises infrastructure in the public
cloud and handle any kind of
overflow in the requirement or overflow
in handling the application so it really
helps it helps it boost the productivity
of our on-premises application so with
the hybrid cloud we get a greater
efficiency with combination of azure
services devops processes and tools for
the application running in on premises
and by having an hybrid cloud
environment users can take advantage of
a constantly updated azure service and
other aws marketplace
applications for their on-premises
environment and the other benefit is
with hybrid cloud environment we can
simply deploy applications regardless of
its locations in case of on-premises
we'll have to worry about the location
but when we expand our on-premises
environment in the cloud and they can or
we can pick any of the locations and
simply deploy it in them and this
enables the applications to be created
at a greater
speed what's federating in azure sql now
this question is very specific about sql
how can we scale the sql database now
this is a very good question or a valid
question or an important question in the
interview because
many customers or companies have
not been able to meet the user demand
because they could not scale out the
databases the theory of scaling out or
adding servers to accommodate the
increased workloads and traffic is not
hard to understand but the implications
can be very complicated the implications
can be very expensive we're well aware
of scaling the web servers that's very
common but how do we scale the database
so microsoft provides the tools and
technologies so we can scale out the
database in the cloud and that's what is
called sql or federation in azure sql so
the way we scale out the sql database is
by sharing sharding the database so
sharding actually enables users to take
advantages of the resources in the cloud
not only that it allows users to have
their own database or a shared database
amongst each other because we're
creating a highly available database
because we're having shards in a
database it actually reduces the
possibility of a single point of failure
for our database and more importantly
because we're starting because we're
using federation and azure sql it
provides an cost effective scaling of
our databases by using cloud resources
or by using billing only for the cloud
resources that we have used so no
pre-provisioning no over provisioning it
provisions the right amount and we pay
the right amount let's talk about this
one what are the different types of
storage offered by azure now the
different types of storage offered by
azure are as you already know and as you
can see they are azure blob storages
table storages file storage and queue
storage so let's expand one after the
other now blob storage are nothing but a
massive scalable object storage and
that's very good for storing text and
binary data and as your blob storage is
a microsoft's object storage solution
for the cloud a lot of storage is
optimized for storing massive massive
amount of unstructured data that can be
in form of text or
or in form of binary data so in short
blob storage enables users to store
unstructured data and those data can be
in the form of pictures music video
files and lot more and it stores them
along with their metadata and another
advantage or another feature benefit
that we get from blob storage is when
object is changed it is verified to
ensure it is of the latest version
number one and number two it provides
maximum flexibility to optimize the
user's storage needs and this
unstructured data is available to
customers through an url or an rest
based object storage so they are the
benefits that come along with the blob
storage table storage on the other hand
is an a nosql store for schema-less
storage of secured data now this azure
table storage is a service that stores
uh structured no sql data in the cloud
and because this table is schema-less
it's very easy to save your data it's
very easy to adapt your data as the need
for your application grows and this
table storage is very fast and cost
effective for many type of applications
so some of the some of the type of data
that we can store is uh table storage is
good for flexible databases like user
data for web applications address book
storage device information storage and
if you want to store metadata this is a
very good use case to store them in
azure table storage azure files is
another storage uh here it's an managed
file share for cloud or on-premises
deployment so file storage provides the
file sharing capabilities accessible by
the server messaging block protocol and
this can be accessed from the cloud and
this can be accessed from on premises as
well here in file storage the data is
protected by smb 3.0 and https protocols
and the more important thing is azure
takes care of managing hardware and the
operating system deployments for azure
file storage so this additional file
storage can be used when we want to
burst the storage capacity in
on-premises so on-premises the primary
and cloud is the secondary or the
extended on-premises storage so it
actually improves the on-premises
performance and capabilities for our
on-premises data center and then we have
queues azure queues it's a messaging
store for reliable messaging between the
application components so we spoke a
little about this in the previous
question so the azure queue storage is a
service for storing a large amount of
messages that can be accessed from
anywhere in the world via http or https
protocol in here
the a single message can be up to 64
kilobits in size and in a queue we can
have millions of messages and the limit
can actually go up if we have not
reached the limit of the storage account
so it's millions and millions of
requests that can be stored in the
storage tube or the queue storage so the
queue storage in short provides message
queuing for large workloads and it
enables users to build flexible
applications and separate the functions
one from another so one failing doesn't
affect the other application which is
running healthy and this q storage it
ensures the application is scalable and
less prone to individual component
failures because they are decoupled
separate now it also helps in monitoring
the queue which ensures the customer's
demands are met so q is a great place to
monitor or a great component to monitor
so we understand um how much peak have
we reached for a particular application
service or a container what is text
analysis api in azure machine learning
now a text analysis is actually an cloud
based analytics api and it provides an
advanced natural language processing
over the raw text and it has got
four main functions like the sentiment
analysis or and the key phrase analysis
language
deduction and few other things now what
do you mean by sentiment analysis now
sentiment analysis is from the logs from
the comments from the text comments that
we receive do an analysis and find out
whether that's a positive or a negative
statement now if it is a the api the api
returns and sentiment score between 0
and 1 and 1 is positive and 0 is
negative and then in text analysis we
have a key phrase extraction which is it
will automatically extract the key
phrase to uh quickly identify the main
points in that
key phrase for example if you're
analyzing and text which says the food
was delicious and there were wonderful
stuff then the api returns the main
talking points of that phrase like food
food is the main talking point and
wonderful stuffs that was a main talking
point so that's another feature that
this text analysis has and then we have
language deduction in text analysis but
irrespective of what you paste it can
try to gauge and try to align it to the
120 or up to 120 languages that it
supports so i can simply take text from
the internet and i can paste it and text
analysis software is going to identify
the language and then can run phrase and
sentiment analysis on those texts right
so in short text analysis is an api a
set of web services that can be used for
text analysis it can be used to analyze
unstructured statement sentiment
analysis key phrase extraction and lot
more and the results are generally
between 0 and 1 and 1 being positive and
0 being the negative sentiment there is
no much training or in other words this
is not as complicated as couple of other
text analysis softwares are available in
the market we can simply paste we can
simply upload the text and we can call
the service and it runs a sentiment
analysis on it all by itself let's look
at this question what are the advantages
of azure queue storage if you're going
to work in a development environment if
you're going to work in an environment
that
embraces devops this could be a question
what are the advantages of azure queue
storage now azure queue storage is built
to flexibly operate the applications and
separate the functions between the
applications that run large workloads so
when we design applications for scale
these applications can be decoupled so
that they can scale independently you
know and thing happening on an
application is not dependent on another
application and anything happens to an
section of the application will not
affect the other application because
they are now decoupled and connected
through the queue storage so the queue
storage gives us asynchronous message
queuing for communication between the
applications irrespective of whether
they are running in the cloud or whether
they are running in desktop or whether
they are running on premises or on
mobile devices so in short this queue
storage enables message queueing for
large workloads in a simple and cost
effective and a durable manner talking
about the advantages advantages is it
provides rich client libraries for java
android c plus plus php ruby and lot
other services getting added during
every new release from azure and the
main advantage again is it enables users
to build flexible apps and separate the
functions for
bigger or greater durability again
introduction of cues into our
application it ensures our users
applications are scalable and less prone
to individual component failures meaning
one component failing is not going to
take the whole application down right if
one component fails it's just that
component that stays fails the rest are
healthy and the rest are going to
function it also helps us to monitor the
queues and ensure the servers aren't
overhelmed by sudden traffic bursts so
how much do i have in the cube
kind of determines uh the traffic for my
application and if the
queue is more i can always go and auto
scale my environment and the queue is
less i can always go and shrink or make
my environment thinner so we can save
cost and anytime there is more data in
the queue i can auto scale monitor the
metric and do auto scaling based on that
metric so the environment knows that
there are more data's coming in i need
to expand myself to handle that much
amount of data this is a very common
question what are the two kinds of azure
web service roles now a service role is
a set of managed and load balanced
virtual machines that work to perform
some tasks and based on
what it's going to run on top of it is
it going to run a web service or is it
going to run a worker service defines
what kind of roles that gets attached or
that goes on this virtual machines so we
have two types web role and worker roles
the web role is a cloud service role
that's configured to run web
applications developed on programming
languages technologies and majorly they
support iis internet information service
and they support asp.net php windows
communication foundation and so on so
that's web roles and these web roles it
automatically deploys and hosts
application through the users iis
internet
information service on the other hand
worker roles are roles that
runs applications and service level
tasks which generally do not require iis
so iis is actually the different shading
factor so in worker roles is is not
installed by default the worker roles
are mainly used to perform supporting
background process along with web roles
and do tasks automatically compressing
or uploading the images running scripts
and
or doing some changes in the database
getting new messages from the queue and
processing a lot more you know the work
the applications are the work that does
not require ies that's what this
worker role does again the main
difference between the web role and the
worker role is that the web role
automatically deploys and hosts your
application through is whereas the
worker role does not use iis and runs
our application as standalone this is
another classic question what is azure
service fabric so azure service fabric
is actually a distributed system
platform that makes it easy to pack
deploy and manage scalable and reliable
microservices and containers now service
fabric also addresses some of the
significant challenges in developing and
managing cloud native applications and
the problem that it addresses and fixes
is now developers and administrators can
avoid complex infrastructure problems
and focus on implementing
mission-critical and demanding workloads
that can be scaled and that can be
managed through the console or from the
single place in short service fabric
provides a platform that makes the
process of developing microservices and
managing application life cycle lot
easier and the advantages of service
fabric is that now we can produce
application with faster time to market
because all the worry about the
infrastructure is taken away from us we
don't have to design an infrastructure
all that we need to worry about is
simply the application and the
application life cycle again the
advantage is it supports
windows it supports linux not only that
it supports servers on-premises and in
the cloud with service fabric we can
scale up our environment to even
thousand machines in just a single
command or if there is a immediate need
for thousand machines i can immediately
scale them up two thousand machines
that's possible with service fabric now
let's look at this question you can
expect this question if the customer is
running hybrid environment meaning
having some of the applications and
on-premises and running some of the
applications from the cloud and for some
reason when classifying the application
that goes to the cloud and that stays on
premises they have decided to keep the
database in-house so in that environment
a lot of customers do that so in that
environment this is a classic and a
scenario based question a client wants
the front end of their application to be
hosted on azure in the cloud and wants
the database to be hosted in on-premises
for security reasons or to have full
control on their databases how do we go
about suggesting a solution for this
customer the ideal solution in this
scenario is to use
the v-net based point-to-site vpn
solution so all the front-end
applications will be in the cloud and
they'll be hosted in a v-net and from
the we net they'll be connecting to the
database through and point to site vpn
so the traffic and the writings and the
reads are not coming through the
internet but through a point to site vpn
link that's connecting the azure vnet
and on-premises environment and this
model or this approach or this solution
is best suited for scenarios where there
are only a limited number of resource
that needs to be connected between
on-premises and the cloud this is a very
common question what's azure traffic
manager of course we no more running
applications on a single server we no
more running applications on or or from
a single environment the same
application is being run from multiple
environments within azure and it can be
running from azure and on-premise as
well so multiple environments between
azure and on-premises a lot of customers
have such environment and if you are
facing an interview with such customer
this could be an ideal question what is
azure traffic manager now the azure
traffic manager is a dns based traffic
load balancer that actually enables us
to distribute traffic between services
across azure global regions and by doing
this it provides a good availability and
a good responsiveness to the application
and this traffic manager it uses dns to
direct client requests to the most
appropriate service endpoint based on
the traffic routing logic and the health
of the endpoints that it maintains so in
short this traffic manager is a load
balancer that enables users to provide
high availability and responsiveness by
distributing traffic in an optimal
manner across the azure when we run the
same application in different regions so
some of the advantages or some of the
use cases of using azure traffic manager
is it provides multiple automatic
failover options it also helps with
reduced downtime it also helps with the
distribution of user traffic across
multiple locations so one location is
not overloaded and then it helps with
users knowing from where our customers
are getting connected from that's
another big use case with azure traffic
manager let's look at this question
right this is an ideal question now
there are group of servers connected
together within an virtual network and
now we need to move them or create a
separation between them how do you go
about achieving it so the question goes
like this you need to isolate network
traffic among vms in a subnet which is
part of a virtual network with little
downtime and impact on the user so
that's the given scenario and the best
way we can do it is uh create a new
virtual network and move all the vms in
that subnet to the new virtual network
now this feature is not possible with a
lot of other cloud service providers
like aws and a lot of other providers
now in those environments we might need
to shut down we might need to stop the
vm create a new vm based on the image
and it's an hefty process but here in
azure i can simply move the vms from one
subnet to another virtual network
without needing for any additional
security like the network security group
i can simply isolate them if i need to
by creating a simple new virtual network
and moving the servers to the new
virtual network look at this one this is
another common question with respect to
azure what is public private and hybrid
cloud so this is really to test how well
have you understood the different cloud
offerings in the market public private
and hybrid or at least the three basic
offerings in the market public private
and hybrid cloud now the public cloud is
the most common way of deploying cloud
computing applications and it has
resources like servers storage and are
owned and operated by third-party cloud
service providers like microsoft azure
microsoft azure is a very good example
of public cloud so here every component
that the user is using is running only
on azure that's public cloud let me talk
to you about some of the advantages of
public cloud some of the advantages is
low cost because there's no need to
purchase hardware or software and we pay
only for the services that we use in
public cloud and there is literally no
maintenance because
the service provider maintains the
environment for us and with public cloud
we have nearly unlimited scalability
meaning we can get resources on demand
and can meet our business requirements
on demand and the public clouds are very
highly reliable because they have a vast
network of servers and they ensure that
our application does not fail so there
are some advantages of public cloud
let's talk about private cloud now
private cloud consists of compute
resources used extensively by one
business or one organization now this
private cloud can be physically located
at our organization's on-site data
center or it can be hosted by a
third-party service provider whichever
the case the private cloud services and
infrastructure are always maintained on
a private network and they maintained on
hardware and software that are dedicated
solely for one organization or solely
for your organization so in short
private cloud in azure is azure services
being run within an on-premises data
center or on-premises data center used
by the user to host systems or
applications and some of the advantages
some of the advantages is it gives more
security resources are not shared with
others so a higher level of control and
security over our resource and
application is possible and then we have
hybrid cloud now hybrid cloud is the
best of both worlds so it combines the
features of both public and private
cloud and some of the user components
are being run on azure and others within
on-premises data center so they kind of
share the resources in other words they
kind of share the application half of
the application would be running in on
premises and a half of them would be in
the cloud and they would be working in
harmony to support the application and
the business need so that's hybrid cloud
this is one another good example
question that wants to test how well you
pick services or how well have you
understood the azure products and
services and are picking the right
service for the need so the question
would go like this what kind of storage
is best suited to handle unstructured
data
there are a lot of storage options
available and the requirement here is
what or which one would you choose for
unstructured data the answer for that
question is blob storage because blob
storage is designed to support
unstructured data it works in this way
it places the data into different tiers
based on how often they are accessed
different tier means different
performance different performance means
different cost associated with it so a
lot of add-on advantages will be get
when we use blob storage for
unstructured data in addition to it any
type of unstructured data can be stored
in blob storage this is not true with
couple of other storage options that we
have in azure only with blob storage we
can store any type of unstructured data
and the data integrity is maintained
every time an object is changed in the
blob storage and the best part is the
blob storage helps increase applications
performance and reduces the bandwidth
consumption
and reduces the bandwidth consumption
for that application so they are the
benefits that we get for block storage
and block storage are the ones that are
well suited for unstructured data and
that's what your answer should be it's
really an five-step process and if
you're worked and if we have done some
labs some basic labs with azure you can
easily answer this question so it's a
five-step process first step is to log
into the azure the second one is to
create an
resource resource or a resource manager
and within the resource manager you will
be selecting the resource and then pick
the
offering system do you want windows or
linux and within windows what's the
flavor you want or within linux what's
the flavor you want so decide on it and
then
entering the relevant information
relevant information like the
name of the
instance or the vm that we're going to
launch and the password the url that
goes with it and couple of other
relevant information that goes gets
itself attached with the
vm and then select the size of the
virtual machine different size different
uh
types available for the kind of
application and for the intensity of the
application that will be running on top
of it so select the virtual select the
size of the virtual machine review
everything whether they're good or not
if there are any changes required go
back and edit them and then come back
and launch and your vm is there for you
to start working within like three or
four minutes not even five minutes
within three or four minutes it gets
ready and you can start working on it so
it's a quick and it's a five step
process and you should be able to answer
it easily if you have done a few labs
in azure let's now look at some
scenario-based question you've been
posted with a scenario so we thought
through it and we picked some common
scenario based question that are being
asked in interview and i thought we'll
present it for you with the answers with
explanation so you can get benefited
through it so let's look at this
question you're asked to make sure your
virtual machines are able to communicate
securely with each other to ensure
security or to have good amount of
security what would you do and the
correct and the best answer for this
would be using virtual network in azure
which enables us to communicate with the
internet securely which enables us to
communicate with the on-premises data
center in a secure fashion so the
advantage of using virtual
network is users can create their own
private network users can pick their own
private ip ranges users can create their
own subnet users can create their own
routing between those two subnets lot
more goes into that virtual network so
it's very customizable and the users are
provided with an isolated and highly
secure environment for applications it's
completely isolated from other customers
it's completely isolated from other
applications that are running in other
virtual network that we own so within
our account we can have multiple virtual
networks and one application running on
a virtual machine is completely isolated
from other applications running on other
virtual machines and of course all
traffic stays within the azure network
as your virtual machine or within the
azure network depending on how you set
up the routing if you have set up a
routing to go or reach the internet it's
going to go otherwise it's going to stay
within azure if you have set up routing
to reach on-premises then it's going to
go and reach on-premises otherwise it's
not going to go and reach on premises
it's going to stay within the azure and
it also allows users to design their own
network like we already discussed
picking up ips picking routing you know
picking subnets you know how many
servers should be present in that
particular subnet or how many servers
should that subnet accommodate the size
of the subnet the ip ranges the netting
the masking of ips creating of vpn all
that's possible with the virtual network
so it really allows users to design
their own network and using virtual
machine is how we secure applications in
the cloud let's look at this other
scenario how do you ensure that every
time a user logs in they are not asked
to re-enter the password as part of
authentication so you really don't want
your users to re-enter the password
every time they log in to a different
application well all the applications
have their authentication mechanism in
place all of them wants to authenticate
the user before they log in ensuring the
user does not log in every time does not
mean that wiping away all the
authentication and authorization that's
present in that application you still
need that in place but how do you make
the user hassle free so they're not
asked to re-enter the password or the
same password again and again let's look
at the options available the first one
is to enable microsoft account
authentication well it's not going to
fix because with that the user will
still need to re-enter the username and
password deploy express route it's not
going to fix either because express
route is a network level service that
connects on-premises to the cloud so
that has got nothing to do with
prompting or not prompting for password
and then we have set up vpn between
on-premises data center and azure set up
80 domain controller in vm and implement
integrated windows authentication well
you can use the same username and
password for on-premises and the cloud
but this setup that the vpn and the ad
controller set up it's not going to stop
you asking for repetitive passwords so
this is all about
using the same password in on premises
and in the cloud and this has got
nothing to do with
not prompting the user to re-enter the
password all right so that's same
password is different from not prompting
the user to re-enter the password they
are two different scenarios so uh that
is also out of the equation and the last
one is configure ad sync to use single
sign on that's the right one so when we
configure the id to use a single sign on
then
it's going it's not going to ask for the
username and password every time we
access an application because we have
logged in and that login is going to
stay active for like 24 hours or so
depending on how you configure it and
within that time you can access a lot of
other applications and it's not going to
ask for the username and password
because you already have a single signed
on and you have signed in using the
right credentials let's look at this one
you need to ensure that virtual machines
remain available while migrating to
azure what would be the appropriate
service to use right let's look at the
options traffic manager traffic manager
is um is literally an dna service and
then let's look at the other one update
domains it again has to do with traffic
manager updating the url so now the
traffic manager gets updated and then
starts sending request to that
particular url it's going to take some
downtime because when we update the url
they will have to be populated to all
different places and it takes time so
within that time any user trying to
access it's going to fail and then we
have express route and cloud services
express route could be the in fact it's
the right answer because express route
it's an extension of our on-premises and
cloud environment and in this question
it really comes out from a customer
who's having an hybrid environment so
they have applications running in
on-premises they have applications
running in the cloud and they want to
have a way to migrate applications from
on-premises to the cloud in other words
kind of do a cut over between
on-premises and the cloud and this
express route is a service that connects
between on-premises and the cloud so
when you do the cut over the traffic is
now sent to the cloud instead of being
handled in on-premises in fact the
services and the application is getting
down are getting shut down in
on-premises so the request will come in
the same pattern instead of they being
handled in on-premises they are now
routed to the cloud using express route
and the api calls get addressed or the
the queries gets answered in the cloud
through the express route service look
at this question you are an
administrator for a website called web
game and you are required to validate
and deploy changes made to your website
by your development team with minimum
downtime so the real question is how do
you validate the deployment changes
that's made by the development team
let's look at the options create a new
linked resource create a staging
environment for the site enable remote
debugging on the website and then create
a new website well why would you want to
create a new website just to validate
the changes and doing a remote debugging
is not going to help because debugging
only captures logs of the changes
happening it does not do anything with
validating the changes create a staging
environment could be or is the right
answer because when we have staging
environments anything that we run on
production can be run on staging
environment and any failures that would
happen in production if we simply run it
in production can be captured when we
run the application in the staging
environment so that way staging
environment is a very helpful and useful
service and that way i can catch
any errors in other words i can validate
the changes that were done by my
development team before i move it to
production and that reduces
the downtime in the production
environment look at this one last
question that we have for you it's
a standard tier application is used
across the world and uses azure website
standard tier it uses large amount of
image files so you can get it this could
be an ecommerce website which has a lot
of pictures in it and this is causing
the application to load slow how can we
handle this situation let's look at the
options given configure blob storage
with custom domain well this application
has pictures but the pictures only the
pictures is not all that the application
has all right so configuring blob
storage might not help this could be an
very interactive website and that can't
be run from blob storage let's look at
the other options configure azure
website auto scaling to increase
instances at high loads now it's the
picture that's causing issues for the
website it's not the cpu or it's not the
memory unavailable memory not enough
that's causing the application to be
slow so we need to identify what's
causing the application to be slow so
it's not the cpu it's not the memory so
configure azure for auto scaling is not
gonna help and then what are the other
options let's see configure azure cdn to
cache all responses from the
applications web endpoint a cdn could be
the right answer but look at that it
says a cdn to cache all responses from
the applications web endpoint cdn is not
designed for that though it can do it
that's not the best way to use cdn to
capture all responses from the
application's web endpoint the proper
design for cdn would be to cache the
frequently used ones in other words
cache the static content which are
photos videos logos and pictures and lot
more static content that never changes
let's look at the last option configure
azure cdn to cache site images and
content stored in azure blob storage
absolutely correct so here we will have
to redesign the application to store the
pictures high quality lazy loading or
slow loading pictures because of the
high quality and the bigger size so
store them in cdn and then the content
let it be stored in azure blob storage
that's the right way of designing the
application and if we do it this
application is going to run faster or
the application is going to respond
faster to the users
and with that we have come to the end of
this video i hope it was informative and
interesting
if you have any questions about the
topics covered in this video please ask
away in the comment section below
our team will help you solve your
queries
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you